GONNA STARTED THIS MORNING IS
SUBCOMMITTEE OF LONELY -- ONE
GIVEN THE COMPETING DEMANDS ON
MEMBERS SCHEDULES WERE GONNA
ALLOW MEMBERS TO PRESENT AND
THEN WE WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
AT A AT A LATER POINT WE HAVE
CRITICAL MASS HERE BUT FOR NOW I
SEE WE'VE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
OF THE MON WITH US SO WOULD YOU
LIKE.
TO COME PRESENT.
THE YOU'VE GOT THREE MEASURES
BEFORE US TODAY IF THAT'S
CORRECT I DO I DON'T WELCOME TO
MY VICE CHAIR [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible] ONE MOMENT.
WELCOME CENTER JONES.
WE'RE GONNA HERE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
SUMMON THE MOANS BILLS AND THEN --
SEE IF ANY OTHER MEMBERS ARE
HERE TO PRESENT SO.
PLEASE I AND WHATEVER ORDER YOU
YOU CHOOSE HERE I THINK YOU
THREE AT ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE
GONNA START WITH EIGHTY TWO OH
NINE THE OUTDOOR AXIS GRANT VERY
GOOD.
ED THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS I WANT
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AB TWO OH
NINE ESTABLISHES THE OUTDOOR
EQUITY GRANT FUNDING PROGRAM AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION IN ORDER TO INCREASE
THE ABILITY OF UNDERSERVED IN AT
RISK POPULATIONS TO PARTICIPATE
IN OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
CALIFORNIA HAS TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY STATE PARKS AND MILLIONS
OF ACRES OF PUBLIC LAND BUT
ACCESS TO SUCH OUTDOOR
EXPERIENCES IS OFTEN OUT OF
REACH FOR COMMUNITIES AND
STUDENTS IN LOW INCOME OR
OTHERWISE.
MARGINALIZE AREA OF THE STATE I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WILL SAY
ONE SILENCE FROM LET ME KNOW HOW
DOORS AND ONE AS THEY MEET ON
ALL FOUR AUDUBON CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AN CHAIR STERN AND
WITH ONE OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AS A
WHOLE -- YES THERE IN BY SEN
THANK YOU -- SOMEONE IN
SWITZERLAND SALAS -- THE FOUNDER
OF THAT THE NOT DOORS WHICH CAN
BE TO BASED ORGANIZATION -- HERE
IN CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE --
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES FOR FAMILIES
AS BEST WE FOCUS ON AT THE NEXT
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE AND
NATION WIDE.
IN THE THREE THINGS I WANT TO
ADD WITH YOU IS FIRST OF ALL
THIS AGAIN AS HE HEARD ME.
SAY BEFORE IS IN CALIFORNIA OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES ARE JUST PART
NINE AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
KNOW THAT FIRST HAND EXPERIENCES
TO OUTDOOR -- TO THE OUTDOORS.
IS A KEY COMPONENT TO AND
SUPPORTING KIND OF THE
GENERATIONS STORIES THAT WE NEED
TO CONTINUE THIS TRADITION
THAT'S WHAT WORKED FOR ME.
AND IT WOULD TWO NINE DOES
THAT'S CRITICAL IS THAT KNOWING
THAT IN ADDITION TO SCHOOLS AND
OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES IS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
PROVIDE A KEY LINK TO PROVIDE
SOME SUPPORT AND SOME WITHOUT
TRICKS APPEARANCES SUCH AS THE
TEAM OF DOORS -- AND I WOULD
LIKE TO INSURE THAT AS OUR
DEMOGRAPHICS CONTINUE TO REFLECT
THE DIVERSITY OF THE ECOLOGICAL
CALIFORNIA -- THAT WE PROVIDE
THIS FOR ALL COMMUNITIES SOME OF
THAT I HIGH COMPANY ASKED THE
POLICE AT SUPPORT I WAS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ONE OF THE
MEAT ON A WITHOUT ON CALIFORNIA
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A A.
B..
TWO OH NINE REALLY STATED --
MANY ASSEMBLYMEMBER THIS BILL IS
INSTRUMENTAL IN MAKING SURE THAT
KIDS HAVE ACCESS TO GOOD QUALITY
IN OUTDOOR -- EDUCATION WE KNOW
THAT MANY KIDS AROUND THE STATE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS.
OR HAVE THE ABILITY TO
EXPERIENCE NATURE -- THE WAY
OTHER FOLKS -- TO IT IS A
BARRIER THAT WE NEED TO BE TO BE
ABLE TO HELP TEAR DOWN.
THIS BILL HELPS US GET US A STEP
CLOSER TO THAT REALITY -- WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT -- ALL
CALIFORNIA KIDS HAVE ACCESS TO
THE OUTDOORS IN THAT'S WHY WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CAP THE
CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT.
MORNINGMR CHAIR MEMBERS I LOOK
AT FACTS ABOUT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT THANKS
MUCH.
GOOD MORNING JAMIE GO ON BEHALF
OF A SCHOOL CALIFORNIA RELIEF
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY AS WELL AS THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MATTEO CHROME HAVE
THE MOUNTAINS RECORD
CONSERVATION RECREATION
AUTHORITY HINES FROM SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING HOLLY MARTINEZ
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT AND I WAS ALSO ASKED TO
PASS ALONG THE SUPPORT OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA.
THANKS SO MUCH.
HERE TOO SO ON BEHALF OF THE
CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER FEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUSEUMS AND APART
AND THE DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN
SUPPORT.
THANKS SO MUCH.
WATER LAMBERT WELL AS LAND TRUST
IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
NEED TO COMMITTEE NATURE
CONNECTION AND FRIENDS OF THE LA
RIVER AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SEEN ORDERS IN SUPPORT TO
HAVE ANY IN OPPOSITION.
TING NINE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DIS MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
WE ARE A CENTER ALLEN WELCOME TO
WE ARE ON A. B. TWO OH NINE
ABOUT OUTDOOR ACCESS GRANTS.
THE PUT APARTMENT PARKS AND
RECREATION I'LL JUST SAY THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
A LOT OF UNMET PROMISES STILL
WHEN IT COMES TO ACCESS AND I
THINK IS A CRITICAL STEP FOR
THAT I DO WANT TO SAY FOR ANYONE
LISTENING YOU KNOW WE
DISAPPOINTED ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
ACCESS.
LOSSES WE TOOK IN THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR WE STILL THINK THERE'S
GOT TO PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTH IS I'M ADDING THIS
INVOLVES THE FRAMEWORK TO
ACTUALLY HAVE A WORKABLE PROGRAM
A TV ARE BUT I WE I I STILL
BELIEVE BOND FUNDS CAN BE USED.
ON DEALING WITH A LOT OF THESE
ACCESS ISSUES.
INCLUDING TRANSPORTATION -- AND
FRANKLY THERE'S NOT ENOUGH RIGHT
NOW WE WE SEE CUTS IN THIS AREA
ALL ALL THE TIME SO.
SHE THIS AFTER EQUITY ACCOUNT
AND LOOKING A KIDS FACE WHEN.
THEY SHOW UP IN TOUCH THE OCEAN
FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME AND THEN
THEY DON'T JUST TOUCH IT THEY
JUMP IN START SURFING YOU'RE
LIKE HOW DID YOU HAVE THAT KIND
OF COURAGE IN YOU. TO STEP OUT
FROM FORTY MINUTES AWAY FROM THE
BEACH OF FEELING LIKE YOU'RE A
STRANGER TO TO OWNING THE PLACE
AND I'VE SEEN WITH MY OWN EYES --
I'M COMMITTEES LIKE MALIBU IN
THESE BEAUTIFUL STRETCH OF COAST
THAT WE HAVE UP UP SO IN
CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO SHARE --
SAID IS A BIG PART OF THAT SAID
THANK YOU SO MEMBER.
MISTER VICE AREA [inaudible]
COMMENTATOR.
ALL UP ON THAT IS ALWAYS
SUPPORTING THE BILL AS WELL
THANK YOU FOR BRING IN AS A
PARTNERSHIP FOR ME AS WELL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALL I TO CLOSE MY SEARCH FOR THE
COMING OF THIS MOVIE WHEN
APPROPRIATE VERY GOOD -- MOTION
FROM CENTER ALLEN SO WILL ALLOW
YOU TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I THANK YOU SO MUCH --
CERTAIN THE MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS BUT WE
DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM SO WE
WILL.
POLL ACTUALLY WE CAN'T ENTERTAIN
THAT MOTION AT THIS POINT
BECAUSE WE DO NOT HAVE COR ME TO
STEP IN WHEN APPROPRIATE WE WILL
WHEN APPROPRIATE -- WHY DON'T
MOVE ON?
NEXT WE HAVE AB.
TEN FIFTY SEVEN VERY GOOD FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN MEMBERS.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON ASSEMBLY
BILL.
TEN FIFTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND OIL
WELL OIL AND GAS WELLS THIS
FIGURE INCLUDES APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY THOUSAND IDOLS MANY OF
WHICH HAVE BEEN IDLE FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
AND POSE A HIGH RISK FOR
DESERTION.
AS OIL PRODUCTION CONTINUES TO
DECLINE IN CALIFORNIA THERE IS A
GROWING CONCERN OVER THE IMPACT
THAT DESERTED OIL AND GAS
INFRASTRUCTURES COULD HAVE
LEADING TAXPAYERS TO ADDRESS THE
RISK.
AND COVER THE COST BASED ON
CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATES COSTS TO
TAXPAYERS COULD BE AS HIGH AS
TWO HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT MILLION
PER TEN THOUSAND OIL WELLS.
IN MY DISTRICT ALONE THE RECENT
BACK RIGHT BANKRUPTCIES OF TWO
OIL COMPANIES WILL COST
TAXPAYERS OVER A HUNDRED MILLION.
OIL AND GAS PRODUCERS ALREADY
ACCEPT THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
PLUG WELLS WHEN THEY ENTER INTO
LEASES WITH THE STATE TO DRILL.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE FULFILL
THIS OBLIGATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN FIFTY SEVEN WILL STRENGTHEN
THE STATE'S AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL SECURITY
FOR ONSHORE OIL AND GAS WELLS.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
TAXPAYERS ARE PROTECTED FROM THE
FINANCIAL LIABILITIES IN THE
EVENT OF THAT A COMPANY FAILS TO
FILL THEIR LEGAL OBLIGATION TO
DECOMMISSION OIL PRODUCTION
SITES.
I'M COMMITTED TO HOLDING
ADDITIONAL STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
AND INCLUDING COMMITTEE STAFF AS
WELL.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY AT VICTORIA
ROME AND I FILL OUT AN AD IN THE
LITTLE AYE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M VICTORIA
AROUND WHAT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TEN FIFTY SEVEN L. TAKES
PROACTIVE STEPS TO HELP INSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S TAXPAYERS ARE
NOT LEFT HOLDING THE BAG FOR
REMEDIATION AND DECOMMISSIONING.
OF ON SHORE IDLE OIL WELLS.
WE KNOW FROM RECENT EXAMPLES IN
THE OFFICE OR CONTEXT WHERE WELL
OPERATORS WENT BANKRUPT.
THAT COSTS CAN QUICKLY BALLOON
INTO THE TENS OR HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AS CALIFORNIA'S OIL PRODUCTION
DECLINES IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE
INDUSTRY SAFELY PLUG WELLS AND
CLEAN UP THE SITES.
AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN MAKE SURE BUT
THE COSTFOR THESE ACTIVITIES
ARE APPROPRIATELY BORN BY THE
OIL INDUSTRY AND OUR DC REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON FEDERAL ON THEM WE
HAVE TO VOTE ON CALIFORNIA --
I'LL BE BRIEF AND JUST REALLY
POINT OUT A COUPLE OF OF DATA
POINTS THAT I THINK MAY BE
USEFUL FOR THE COMMITTEE -- TO
TO HEAR ONE IS THAT RECENTLY IN
CONVERSATIONS -- AMONG
STAKEHOLDERS AND AND FOLKS
REPRESENTING DR THEY MENTIONED
THAT OF THE SIXTY SIX
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS ARE
CURRENTLY EXIST ON ORPHANED AND
ABANDONED WELLS. THIRTY FOUR OF
THOSE -- THE THE OWNER IS IS NOT
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO FIND THE
OWNER -- THEY'RE NOWHERE TO BE
FOUND SO IT'S MORE THAN 50%.
THIS BEING THE CASE -- SO THIS
BILL IS REALLY IMPORTANT FROM
THAT PERSPECTIVE ONE A IN BEING
ABLE TO SETTING CONTROLS AND
MECHANISMS BY WHICH YOU CAN
PROPERLY TRACK AND TRACE -- THE
ACTUAL OWNERS ARE TO HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE IN THE EVENT OF
ALLEN AND SECOND IS REALLY --
KIND OF ADDRESSING THE WHAT'S
BEEN ARTICULATED ABOUT.
THE RECENT EXAMPLE OF THE
OFFSHORE SPACE -- YOU KNOW ONE
EXAMPLE THAT -- HAS HAPPENED
RECENTLY IN HAS BEEN IN THE NEWS
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS IS
THE PLUGGING IN AND AN
ABANDONMENT OF TWO IDLE WELLS IN
ECHO PARK IN THE LOS ANGELES
AREA -- WHERE WE HAVE SEEN THE
COST TO DO THAT HAS BEEN IN THE
AND THE ORDER MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS?
AND WE EXPECT THERE WILL BE MORE
EXAMPLES LIKE THAT TO COME -- AS
THE THE DIVISION CONTINUES TO DO
ITS WORK AND AND AND KIND OF
IDENTIFYING WERE THESE -- THESE
SITES EXIST THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA -- AND CALIFORNIA
WRIT LARGE -- WE ARE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE THE KIND OF
MECHANISM THE THE CONTROLS ARE
IN PLACE HERE SO THAT THE
DIVISION SUPERVISOR HAS TO BE
ABLE.
TO PROVIDE SORT OF RISK FACTORS
TO BE ABLE TO EVALUATE WHAT THE
ACTUAL COSTS COULD BE AND AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE IN URBAN AREAS LIKE
IN ECHO PARK NEAR DODGER STADIUM
WHERE YOU HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF
POPULATION OUT THERE AND YOU
KNOW AND THOSE COSTS.
SHOULD BE EVALUATED AND BE TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
A BETTER LEVEL OF CERTAINTY --
ON BOTH ENDS -- WITH THAT --
CLOTHES AND RESPECTFULLY ABLE
QUESTIONER AND I I THANK YOU SO
MUCH -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT. ONE
OF THE MEAT ON THE WITHOUT AMONG
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
JAMIE ON BEHALF OF THE OF A SOUL
IN SUPPORT.
IS INJURED HER DIRECTOR THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL PROTECTION
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
WE'LL BRING HER THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
OKAY -- SEEN NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT -- THOSE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
I MAKE A COUPLE SEATS FORM HERE.
MORNING WELL LEARNING SEARCHER
MEMBERS.
ARE NOT LOSE CENTERS WITH THE
WESTERN SEAS PATROLMEN'S
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON AB --
TEN FIFTY SEVEN BUT FIRST WE'D
LIKE TO THINK -- THE AUTHOR AND
SPECIFICALLY -- STAFFER
CONVENING -- YOU KNOW THE
APPROPRIATE STAKEHOLDERS TO
DISCUSS.
A LAUNDRY LIST OF CONCERNS WE
HAVE SHARED WITH -- WITH THAT WE
HAVE WITH THE CURRENT BILL IN
PRINT -- AS OUR LETTER STATES
OUR BIGGEST ISSUE RIGHT NOW IS
THE FACT THAT THERE IS REALLY NO --
UNILATERAL AUTHORITY FOR DOCTOR
TO INSTITUTE A MONEY REQUIREMENT
WITHOUT A CAP SO WE WE
DEFINITELY NEED A CAP.
THAT HAS WITHOUT A CAP THAT HAS
THE POTENTIAL POWER TO BASICALLY
PUT OPERATORS OUT OF BUSINESS SO --
IN IN DISCUSSION WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE WAS SUPPOSED
MEMBERS NEED A CAP AGAIN TO
ENSURE STABILITY IN THE ABILITY
TO MOVE CAPITAL TOWARDS
INVESTMENTS -- IN WORK FORCING
CONTINUE OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA
UNDER THE MOST STRINGENT LABOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SAFETY STATE.
STANDARDS.
IN ADDITION WE LIKED INCLUSION
OF SELF INSURANCE TO BE.
AS ONE OF THE INSTRUMENTS --
THAT CAN BE USED IN THE
TERMINATIONS AND PROVIDING
CLARITY AS TO HOW THE BOND
SUPPLY DIRECTLY TO A COMPANY
WITH SUBSIDIARIES AS WELL AS
ISSUES RELATING TO PROTECTING.
CONFIDENTIAL BUSINESS
INFORMATION ON ADDITIONAL
DOCUMENTS THAT DAUGHTER CAN
COLLECT I THINK THAT GOES TO THE
POINT.
FROM ONE OF THE THE GENTLEMAN IN
SUPPORT ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
DOCTOR HAS THE ABILITY TO HAVE
THE INFORMATION AS TO HOW --
ASSETS WHICH ARE TRANSFERRED IN
AND THEY CAN APPROPRIATELY GO
AFTER -- THE THE APPROPRIATE
STAKEHOLDER.
TO TO PLUG IN ABANDONED OR
PROVIDE THE FINANCIAL -- MONIES
TO TO COVER THAT COST SO --
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO
OBVIOUSLY THANK YOU -- AND AND
CATHERINE IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
BEING PART OF THE THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP AND WE LOOK
FOR TO HAVING -- CONTINUE
DIALOGUE WITH THE AUTHOR
HOPEFULLY DURING THE SUMMER
RECESS BUT FOR THESE REASONS WE
WE WE MUST REPENT OF LOS.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF P.
ANTHONY THOMAS RIBS IN THE
CALIFORNIA.
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION -- LET ME START BY
SAYING WE APPRECIATE.
THE MEETING THAT WE HAD -- WITH
THE CONSULTANT AS WELL AS THE
AUTHOR AND STAKEHOLDERS -- BUT
HE SENT TO THE BILL ITSELF.
NOT TO BE AS HARSH AS POSSIBLE
BUT WE THINK ANOTHER ATTEMPT TO
SOLVE.
A PROBLEM THAT REALLY DOES NOT
EXIST.
MAINLY THE THREAT OF THE STATE
HAVING MILLIONS OR BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
IN UNFUNDED ROOF REPAIR
MEDIATION COSTS. FOR FROM WELLS.
OVER THE PAST ONE HUNDRED YEARS
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
DRILLING AND PRODUCTION AND
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY IN OUR ESTIMATE AND WE
ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION TO YOU THERE ARE
SIXTEEN OFTEN WELL AS AN ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- SIXTEEN
AND INDUSTRY PROVIDES THE
FUNDING AS YOU WELL KNOW TO PLUG
IN A BANDING CALLED ORPHAN WELLS.
THE FUND IT PAYS FOR PLUGGING AN
ABANDONMENT OF THESE REMAINING
FROM WELLS IS AT AN ALL TIME
RECORD HIGH.
AN ALL TIME RECORD HIGH.
ALL THE OLD AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY NINE WHICH WAS CHAPLAIN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN ESTARá TO RECORD
PROCESS OF PLUGGING IN
ABANDONING IDA WELLS IN THE
STATE.
THE SPONSOR OF THE BE -- FEAR
THIS ARMAGEDDON.
ARMAGEDDON OF THE INDUSTRY AND
AN OVER ABUNDANCE OF WAR FROM
WELLS SUDDENLY BECOMING THE
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
STATE.
NOW THE POSSIBILITY MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF ALL PRODUCERS
SIMULTANEOUSLY DISAPPEARING
DISAPPEARING IT'S HIGHLY
UNLIKELY.
UCES HAVE INVESTED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN THEIR OPERATIONS AS
AN AS DIFFICULT SOMETIMES IT IS
TO DO BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THEY CONTINUE TO INVEST IN OUR
GOLDEN STATE.
SUPPORT CAN WHISPER HAS MET BUT
THE AUTHOR AS YOU WELL KNOWN.
AS WELL THIS DOG AND A PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS ON THAT WE PROVIDED
IN LIEU OF GIVING THE SUPERVISOR
UNLIMITED AUTHORITY.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT UNLIMITED
AUTHORITY IS APPROPRIATE IN THIS
DAY AND TIME.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE DID OFFER
WOULD LIMIT THE BONDING
AUTHORITY TO TWENTY MILLION FOR
OPERATORS BUT MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND WELLS.
IT WOULD ALSO HAVE FORMING FOR
THOSE AT 500-211-0000 WELLS HE
PROPOSED EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
FOR THE HOLES WITH FIFTY TO FIVE
HUNDRED WELLS AND FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND THE BILL'S WITH LESS
THAN FIFTY WELLS.
CURRENTLY INDEPENDENT OPERATORS
IN THE PUT UP A BLANKET BOND.
FOR THE WELLS OR TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN CASH. FOR
THE ENTIRETY OF THE WILL WHICH
IS TWENTY TO THIRTY YEARS.
AS AN ALTERNATIVE UNDER THE
AMENDMENTS OPERATORS COULD ELECT.
AS WE PROPOSED A FINANCIAL
ALTERNATIVE.
FINANCIAL TURN OF THAT A SINGLE
WELL SUCH AS A SECURED FUND THAT
SET ASIDE REVENUE GENERATED BY
THAT WELL OVER ITS ENTIRE LIFE.
RATHER THAN ONE UP FRONT SOME OF
DOLLARS THE PHONE WOULD BE
DEEMED ADEQUATE BY DAGR TO COVER
THE FUTURE ABANDONMENT COSTS OF
THAT PARTICULAR WELL.
AND WITHDRAWAL OF THOSE PHONE TO
ONLY BE BY MUTUAL CONSENT OF DOG --
AND THE OPERATOR YUP THE AUTHOR
HAS NOT ACCEPTED HI INDUSTRY
SUGGESTED A MAN'S AND INSTEAD
OFFERED A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
CAP.
A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR CAP TO
WHAT TO SUPERVISOR COULD REQUIRE
FROM AN OPERATOR.
OBVIOUSLY MISTER CHAIRMAN SMALL
TO MEDIUM SIZE OPERATORS WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO BOND ATFIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IT WOULD PUT MY
MEMBERS OUT OF BUSINESS.
THAT MIGHT BE THE GOAL OF SOME
ON THE OPPOSITION.
BUT THAT'S TRUE IF IN FACT YOU
PUT THE SMALL TO MEDIUM SIZE
OPERATORS OUT OF BUSINESS TEN
FIFTY SEVEN FOR NOW EXACERBATE
THE PROBLEM THAT IT ATTEMPTS TO
EXIST. TO FALL OFF.
AS I CLOSE -- INDUSTRY AS A
POLICY SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM.
WE HAVE A POLICY SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM IF IN FACT YOU
PROCEED DOWN THIS PATH HERE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU'LL COME BACK
IN ANOTHER YEAR OR TWO OR YEAR
OR THREE WHAT THE SAME
EXACERBATED PROBLEMS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SAY IS WE CAN IN THIS
NOW PUT APPEARED AT THE END OF
THIS SENTENCE.
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM SO THE TEN
FIFTY SEVEN TO THE WORLD I NO
LONGER NEEDED.
NOW I'VE BEEN IN FRONT OF YOU ON
MANY OCCASIONS ASKING FOR YOU TO
HOLD BILLS IN COMMITTEE I THINK
THE TEN FIFTY SEVEN IS A PRIME
CANDIDATE TO BE HELD IN
COMMITTEE.
WORKED ON PUT A TIME LIMIT IF
YOU IF IF YOU SO DESIRE BUT THIS
BILL SHOULD NOT BE PASSED OUT IF
IT'S PASSED OUT MISTER CHAIRMAN
IT RUNS THE CLOCK AUDI SINCE YOU
WE ARE NOT ABLE TO COME TO AN
AGREEMENT.
HOLD IT IN COMMITTEE ALLOW US TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ANY
OPPOSITION PUT A TIME LIMIT ON
IT WE DON'T GET PASSED TO TOM
AND THEN MOVE THE BILL TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
UNTIL THEN SUPER STANDS OPPOSED
TO YOUR BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE TESTIMONY.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A PAUSE
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED QUORUM HERE
NOW THAT WE HAVE CRITICAL MASS
MEMBERS SO -- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL IN A STERN STERN HERE JONES
JONES HERE ALLEN.
ELLEN HERE BOARD JUST COVER EURO
CAREER -- HERE HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO HERE JACKSON MONEY.
OKAY VERY GOOD NOW WE HAVE A
QUORUM -- WE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DICE MEMBERS COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE -- SEEN ONE SECOND
HERE.
CONTROVERSIAL QUESTION I WISH I
HAD ONE BUT I DON'T I I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT -- THAT I I
SUPPORT THE THE THE BILL IS
ATTEMPTING TO DO I THINK WE DO
NEED TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT --
MAKING SURE THAT THE TAXPAYERS
ARE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR FOR
CLEAN UP I DO I AM SENSITIVE
HOWEVER TO THE WHOLE ISSUE OF
THE UNILATERAL AUTHORITY TO
INCREASE THE SECURITY BOND AND I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S DISCUSSIONS
ON LANGUAGE AND SO -- WITH THAT
IN MIND I I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY.
AND I'M SORRY I I DIDN'T.
SCRIPT THE PROCEDURE A LITTLE
BIT HERE -- ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION I DID WHAT I IN A
OFTEN OPPORTUNE I APOLOGIZE. TO
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION YOUR
DAY.
ON THE BILL.
OKAY SEE.
NINE THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENT
CENTER CABALLERO -- PRECIADO THE
AUTHOR'S WORK ON THIS AND I YOU
KNOW I'VE HAD SOME OF THESE
SIMILAR MEETINGS.
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
ALTERNATIVES PROPOSED I'M I
WOULD I WOULD NOTED.
ED THE REASONABLENESS STANDARD.
IN THE BILL -- WILD I RECOGNIZE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT I I I
I I WOULD AT OFFER YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY IS TO CLARIFY.
BUT I DIDN'T GET A SENSE OF THE
INTENT WAS.
TO SHUT DOWN -- LARGE SECTORS OF
THE INDUSTRY BUT MORE SO TO TRY
TO FIND SOME WAY.
TO IS NOT LEAVE US IN THE SAME
PLACE THAT SOME OF THOSE IN COAL
COUNTRY HAVE BEEN LEFT WHERE YOU
SORT OF RELYING TO SELF
INSURANCE MARKET AND WE'VE SEEN
SOME OF THE FALL OUT OF THAT
BANKRUPTCY.
GERMAN PROCESS HERE SO --
SENSITIVE TO SOME OF THE ISSUES
RAISED BUT I JUST WANT TO GIVE
YOU A CHANCE TO COMMENT BACK ON
THEN YOU CAN YOU CAN COMBINE
THAT YOUR CLOSES OKAY AS WELL
HERE THE SERBS HAVE SO YES THE
INTENT OF THE BILL IS.
NOT TO LEAVE TAXPAYERS WITH.
A HUGE AMOUNT OF PUBLIC DOLLARS
THAT NEED TO GO INTO CLEANING UP
THAT'S WHAT IT IS AND THE
CONVERSATIONS I A DO WE HAVE
BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION WAS BUT IT HAS
PROVIDED LANGUAGE AND RETAIN --
WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
SEPTA AND WE'VE YET TO SEE
ANYTHING IN WRITING -- IN TERMS
OF THE AMENDMENTS UP FROM STEP
UP BUT WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS
BECAUSE THE INTENTION IS TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY. TO DEAL
WITH THESE ORPHANED WELLS THERE
WAS A STATEMENT MADE THAT
THERE'S ONLY SIXTEEN THERE'S
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED WELLS AT
THAT OUR CANDIDATES TO BE OR FAN.
AND ANOTHER THIRTY THOUSAND
WELLS AT HAVING PRODUCED OIL IN
TWENTY FIVE YEARS SO.
OUR PROBLEM IS BIGGER -- IT THEN
IT'S BEEN A NUMBER OF SIXTEEN
AND WHEN.
THE COMMUNITY DOESN'T HAVE A WAY
TO PAY FOR IT THEY HAVE TO PAY
FOR THE CLEANUP AND AS IS BEING
GIVEN AN EXAMPLE -- YOU KNOW
IT'S JUST A IN IN THE DISTRICT
ALONE THERE'S ONE THAT COST A
HUNDRED MILLION SO WHERE DO YOU
WHERE DOES THAT COME FROM WHAT
WHAT DOLLARS THAT TAKE AWAY FROM
AND SO.
OUR HOPE IS TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATIONS TO IDENTIFY WHAT
ELEMENTS -- OF THIS COULD BE
ADOPTED IN A WAY.
THAT DOESN'T HAVE A MASTER GOAL
OF SETTING ANYTHING DOWN BUT
DOES HAVE THE GOAL OF PROTECTING
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT.
LIABLE -- FOR THE COST TO CLEAN
THEM UP IT'S VERY COSTLY AND SO
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GOING AND
WE'VE COMMITTED TO WORK I THINK
BOTH SIDES ACTUALLY ARE
COMMITTED TO WORK THROUGH THE
SUMMER I'M TRYING TO FIND
LANGUAGE THERE'S BEEN AND SOME
OPPOSITION LANGUAGES BEEN
PRESENTED TO US WE COUNTERED
IMMIGRANT.
REALLY KIND OF IN THE BACK AND
FORTH PROCESS.
WHEN THEY -- JUST ASK IS YOUR IS
YOUR ENGAGING IN THIS PROCESS
PLEASE.
KEEP THE COMEDIAN FORM I WOULD
SAY MY BIGGEST CONCERN.
ABOUT THE MAKING OF THE NUMBER
PROCESS IS.
HOW HOW FORTY STRAIGHT FROM THE
REASONABLENESS STANDARD BECAUSE
IN SOME CASES YOU'RE SAYING
THERE'S ACTUALLY VERY LIMITED?
LIABILITY SO SEE WITH A CERTAIN
FORMATION AND IT WOULD BE VERY
LOW BUT IN SOME YOU'RE AT A
HUNDRED MILLION AND SO HOW TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE AND ALLOW
THIS SORT OF STATE SPECIFIC
FACTORS TO WEIGH IN AYE.
IT'S GOING TO BE AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO TAYLOR I DON'T I ALSO
DON'T IF THE THE BILL MOVES
THROUGH TODAY I DON'T CONSIDER
THIS -- RUNNING THE CLOCK I I
THINK THERE'S A I'VE HEARD A
PRETTY GOOD FAITH.
INTENT TO ENGAGE IN A PROCESS
HERE AND I I'M COMMITTED TO THE
SAME.
ON BEHALF OF THIS COMMITTEE SO --
IS A TERM YOU YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN
BALANCE LET ME BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT THAT SHE HAD.
PERSONAL AND PRIVATE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS.
BUT I WOULD JUST SAY THIS.
DOES TEN FIFTY SEVEN PUT A
PERIOD AT THE END THE DISSENTERS
DOES THIS SOLVED THE PROBLEM.
IN ITS CURRENT FATE DOES NOT
WITH YOU IT IS NOT THAT OLD SOUL
SO WE CAN.
OUR CAR POINT IS ACTUALLY MORE
TO DO THOUGH THAT THAT'S THERE'S
NO THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO OIL AND AND THE
ISSUES THAT FACE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ACTUALLY DON'T.
I WOULD JUST SAY IT'S PROBABLY
TOO AMBITIOUS TO FINALLY PUT TO
PUT A PERIOD AT THE END OF THE
SENSE AROUND ISSUES OF OIL IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THIS IS WE
ARE A PETRO.
STATE RIGHT NOW AND WE WE DRIVE
MORE THAN ANYONE ELSE ON THE
PLANET AND THERE'S DEMAND SIDE
ISSUES AND SUPPLY SIDE ISSUE SO.
I I RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR THAT
CERTAINTY IN THE INDUSTRY BUT I
ALSO -- I DON'T WANNA PUT TOO
MUCH ON THIS ONE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION HERE TO SOLVE THE
ENTIRE OIL ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA
AND I KNOW THERE'S OTHER OUTSIDE
STUDIES GOING ON AS WELL SO --
WE'RE GONNA KEEP DOING A
DILIGENT WORK HERE -- I
APPRECIATE BOTH THE INPUT AND
THE AUTHOR'S WORK AND I I'D BE
OPEN ENTERTAINING A MOTION AT
THIS TIME WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
SO YES THIS IS YOUR THIS IS NOT
LEAVE OUT THE OPPORTUNITY FILL
THESE WELLS WITH NATURAL GAS.
I'M JOKING THAT WAS A JOKE.
FOR BUT ANYWAY I'M AT THE PIER
YOU ALMOST YOU WANT YOU ALMOST
PAGE TO THE SEMI COLON NOSES --
I MOVE THE BILL MISTER -- OKAY --
OR DO YOU. FOR THAT --
INTERESTING MOTION. TO
APPROPRIATIONS IS THEM.
I DON'T DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS IS THE MOTION --
WE TREATED THAT IS YOUR CLOTHES --
SO THIS FIRST.
ALLOW YOU TO CALL THE ROLL
SENATE STERN AYE AYE STERN HIGH
JONES NO JONES NO ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE PORGES CUBBY ERRO
COMING YEAR -- AYE HERTZBERG
HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY IS ON
CALL FOR THAT OKAY WILL LEAVE
THEM IS WRONG CALL THANK YOU
MEMBERS -- OF COURSE YOU ONE
MORE BILL VERY GOOD [inaudible]
AB.
SIXTEEN EIGHTY I WANTED TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WITH THE COPY AT THAT
I AM WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FINALIZE
DEADLINES TO ENSURE THIS BILL
GIVES THE STATE THE TOOLS TO
FINALLY ACHIEVE.
PUBLIC ACCESS AT HOLLISTER RANCH
HOLLISTER RANCHES OF FOURTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED ACRE
SUBDIVISION THAT INCLUDES EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILES OF PUBLICLY
OWNED SHORELINE OVER THIRTY
SEVEN YEARS AGO IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION ADOPTED A HOLLISTER
RANCH PUBLIC ACCESS PROGRAM.
THE NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO AXES
PROGRAM HAS NEVER BEEN
IMPLEMENTED CONTRADICTING THE
CLEAR LEGISLATIVE INTENT.
THAT AN AXIS PROGRAM BE
IMPLEMENTED AS EXPEDIENT WE AS
POSSIBLE.
OVER. FOR OVER THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC HAS
BEEN CUT OFF FROM ENJOYING THE
NATURAL TREASURES OFFERED BY A
CALIFORNIA COASTLINE WHICH ARE
OWNED BY THE PUBLIC.
THE GOAL OF ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN EIGHTY IS TO SET UP A
CLEAR FAINT FRAMEWORK TO ACHIEVE
PUBLIC ACCESS AT HOLLISTER RANCH.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO ME THAT WE
THAT AS WE PROCEED A. B. C.
NINETY SIXTEEN EIGHTY REMAIN
STRONG AND WILL ACTUALLY RESULT
IN FULL FULLY IMPLEMENTED ACCESS
PROGRAM.
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE RANCH
OWNERS TODAY AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY
RESULT IN A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN
THAT BUILDS ON THE FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE THAT ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIA BEACHES SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR EVERYONE TO ENJOY.
REGARDLESS OF THERE'S A CODE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU WELCOME
WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE ON FEDERAL ON THE
HERE ON BEHALF OF US SOON --
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO TO
ELEVATING LETTING LEADERSHIP
INVOICES ON COASTAL ACCESS AND
COASTAL PROTECTION -- ISSUES IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR ME TO
I THINK THIS MORNING TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
BILL FROM THE STATEWIDE
PERSPECTIVE -- AS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS DEDICATED
ON TO TO ENCOURAGING AND
FOMENTING -- COMMUNITIES THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
THE COAST TO GET OUT THERE AND
WE WE INTIMATELY ARE.
AWARE OF HOW YEARS FOR ACCESS --
WHEN YOU HAVE LIKE IN IN THE
CASE OF A LOT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES -- THE
ADJACENT PROPERTY OWNERS TO THE
BEACH -- LIMITING THE ACCESS
DONE THROUGH DIFFERENT
MECHANISMS WHETHER IT'S PUTTING
UP A FAKE WITH SIGNS SAYING NO
PARKING OR THAT THERE IS NO
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE BEACH --
WRIT LARGE WE HAVE EXAMPLES UP
AND DOWN THE COAST IN CALIFORNIA.
IN THREE PARTICULAR ONES AND AND
HOLLISTER RANCH BEING I THINK
ONE OF THOSE THOSE MAJOR
EXAMPLES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING DEBATED NOW -- FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF US SOON.
THIS BILL IS GOING TO BE LOOKED
UPON AS A SETTING A REALLY GOOD
PRESIDENT ABOUT WHETHER OR
CALIFORNIA CAN REALLY MAINTAIN
ITS PROMISE AND THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL ACT. TO ITS
RESIDENTS -- TO ENSURE ACCESS
FOR EVERYBODY -- FOR THESE
REASONS -- WE'RE VERY PROUD TO
SUPPORT AB AND TEN SIXTY EIGHT
OR SIXTEEN EIGHTY EXCUSE ME --
THEN VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
AUTHOR'S CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR
COASTAL ACCESS WRIT LARGE AND IN
HER DRIVER THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU WELCOMES
TRYING SEASON JORDAN CALIFORNIA
COASTAL PROTECTION NETWORK WILL
TODAY'S NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
HAS TRIED TO CRAFT REQUIREMENTS
THAT WOULD OPEN UP PUBLIC ACCESS
AND HOLLISTER RANCH.
AND EIGHT IN HAVE STRETCH OF
SPECTACULAR COASTLINE IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY WHICH HAPPENS TO
BE WHERE I LIVE.
THE LEGISLATURE'S FIRST EVER TO
BEGIN IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE
FORTY YEARS AGO WHEN IT CRAFTED
A PATH FOR HOLLISTER OWNERS TO
BUILD THEIR HOMES IN EXCHANGE
FOR PROVIDING SUBDIVISION WIDE
ALL I IN HALF MILES.
OF PUBLIC ACCESS HOWEVER WHEN
HOLLISTER RANCH CONTINUE TO
REFUSE TO COOPERATE A FRUSTRATED
LEGISLATURE FOUND IT NECESSARY
TO AGAIN TAKE ACTION SO THREE
YEARS LATER IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE LEGISLATURE GAVE
HOLLISTER RANCHES ON SPECIAL
COASTAL ACT SECTION. THREE OH
SIX ONE OH POINT EIGHT THAT
ALLOWED HOLLISTER PARCEL OWNERS
TO BUILD THEIR HOMES AND OTHER
AMENITIES UNDER THE CONDITION
THAT SUBDIVISION WIDE PUBLIC
ACCESS WOULD BE PROVIDED.
IN THE INTERVENING THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS THE LUXURY HOMES THE GUEST
HOUSES THE POOLS OVERLOOKING THE
OCEAN WERE BUILT BUT PUBLIC
ACCESS WAS NEVER PROVIDED
INSTEAD THE PUBLIC WAS BLOCKED
FROM ENTERING BY A GATE AND A
GUARD HOUSE.
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE CRAFTED THE
HOLLISTER RANCH REQUIREMENTS
BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO IT
HAD THE BEST OF INTENTIONS AND
IT FULLY EXPECTED THAT ACCESS
WOULD FINALLY BE PROVIDED?
SWIFTLY EXPEDITIOUSLY AND IN A
TIMELY MANNER AS A LEGISLATION
STATED REPEATEDLY YET HERE WE
ARE THIRTY SEVEN YEARS LATER AN
ACCESS IS STILL BLOCKED WERE YOU
YOUR CHILDREN OR ANY OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS TO GO THERE TODAY.
EVERY ONE OF YOU WOULD BE TURNED
AWAY WHICH IS WHY IT'S SO
CRITICAL THAT THIS BILL THE
FINAL TERMS OF WHICH ARE STILL
UNDER NEGOTIATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION BE AIRTIGHT.
FULLY ENFORCEABLE WAS STRONG
CONSEQUENCES IN PENALTIES IF
PUBLIC ACCESS IS NOT PROVIDED
WITHIN A REASONABLE BUT SWIFT
TIME CERTAIN DEADLINE.
IN THE WEEK OF EXT IN THE WAKE
OF EXTENSIVE MEDIAN TENSION AND
PUBLIC SCRUTINY THAT HAS BEEN
BROUGHT TO BEAR ON THIS ISSUE
OVER THE LAST YEAR I BELIEVE
THERE ARE NOW SOME.
HOLLISTER RANCH HOMEOWNERS THAT
BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE A LEGAL
RESPONSIBILITY UNDER THE LAW TO
PROVIDE SUBDIVISION WHY PUBLIC
ACCESS AT HOLLISTER RANCH BUT I
ALSO BELIEVE THERE ARE OTHERS
FOR HIM TO LAY AN OBSTRUCTION
HAVE WORKED IN THE PAST.
AND WHO WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
PERSISTENTLY TO DO EVERYTHING IN
THEIR POWER TO BLOCK ACCESS WHY
WOULDN'T DAY IT'S WORKED FOR
FORTY YEARS.
AND JUST YESTERDAY A HOMEOWNER
FILED LEGAL SUIT ON THE PREMISE
THAT THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO ADD ADDITIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WITHOUT PROVIDING
THE PUBLIC ACTS AS THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRED.
THIS IS THE TIME TO PUT A STOP
TO HOLLISTER RANCHES EGREGIOUS
VIOLATION OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
ORIGINAL AND EXPLICIT INTENT AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
AS THIS BILL CONTINUES TO
INVOLVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I DO HAVE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
VICTORIA AROUND WITH NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ONE OF THE
MEAT ON A WITHOUT A ONE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JON DRAKE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION DOES HAVE A SUPPORT
POSITION ON THIS BILL WE HAVE
SOME POTENTIAL CONCERNS WITH
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
HAVEN'T HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PREFER COMMISSION ON THEM.
ULTIMATELY HOWEVER WERE
COMMITTED AND ENJOYING THE
AUTHOR AND WORKING WITH AGENCIES
IN THE ADMINISTRATION PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL LASTING PUBLIC ACCESS
TO HOLLISTER RANCH LIKE MINE.
TO JUST ANYONE MORE COLOR THAT
COMMENTARY WHAT WHAT ONE
PARTICULAR -- OF CAN OF
CONCERNED JUST AS AN INITIAL
MATTER.
I THINK.
THE IDEA IS -- HER EYES ALREADY
BEEN ECHOED BY THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS JUST MAKING SURE THAT
THE BILL IS STRUCTURED IN A WAY
TO PROVIDE MEANINGFUL PUBLIC
ACCESS FINALLY.
I KNOW THAT ALL THE PARTIES ARE
INVOLVED ARE COMMITTED TO THAT
AND THE WERE WORKING IN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO PROVIDE THAT.
AND SO WE JUST MERELY MEAN TO
ECHO THAT SENTIMENT [inaudible]
SEEK FINALLY.
IS THAT IS THIS YES SEVEN THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HERE TOO SO ON BEHALF OF THE
CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SEEN ORDERS.
AT HEAD FAKE BANNER -- ANY
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING.
NINE OUT WE CAN BRING BACK TO
THE DICE MEMBERS.
I HAVE A YEAH I'M HAVING
EIGHTEEN EMOTIONALLY PROBABLY
TIME I DID I DID WANT TO JUST
GET A BRIEF UPDATE.
AS IN THE AUTHOR OR FROM THE
BUT WE ARE TRYING.
TO CATCH US UP HERE AND WHAT
HAPPENED SINCE LAST YEAR JUST
VERY BRIEFLY IF YOU COULD
BECAUSE I KNOW WE HEARD A
SIMILAR MEASURE THAT AT A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
THE ISSUE ESTABLISH AN ACCOUNT.
I BELIEE WILL SETTLEMENT.
NEGOTIATIONS ARE STILL UNDER WAY
SO JUST CAN YOU CATCH UP LAST
YEAR'S EFFORT WAS ABOUT
ESTABLISHING AN ACCOUNT -- IN
WHERE THAT ACCOUNT WOULD BE USED
TO BEGIN THE PROCESS TO GAIN
PUBLIC ACCESS AND THAT BILL GOT
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND AND THE GOVERNOR VETOED IT
SAYING THAT THAT TRUE NEED WAS
TO UPDATE THE ACCESS PLAN AND
THE BILL YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF
YOU -- IS A BILL WHERE WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN AMMO YOU
WITH FOR A DEPARTMENTS AT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
WHO ARE HAVING CONVERSATIONS THE
RANCH OWNERS ARE ALSO AT THE
TABLE HAVING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
HOW WE GET TO THE PLAN -- AND
THE IDEA IS THAT THE GOAL.
IS THE KERRY IS WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER WE COME UP WITH A PLAN
TO PROVIDE MEANINGFUL ACCESS --
AND THAT PLAN INVOLVES THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS THE
THE RANCH OWNERS AND THE PUBLIC.
AND IF THAT IS NOT -- TO IN%
PLACE THE BILL AS YOU SEE
AMENDED -- EIGHTIES NOW THE
STICK IS WELL WE'RE GONNA PUT
THE OLD PLAN IN AND SO WE ARE
HOPING WE WHAT THE BILL ALSO
DOES NOW IS THAT THE BILL
EXTENDS THAT DEADLINE FOR US TO
CREATE THIS PLAN.
UNDERSTOOD OKAY AND THE I
APPRECIATE THE EMPHASIS ON
MEANINGFUL WHEN IT COMES TO
ACCESS AND WE TALKED WE JUST
TALKED AND THE PREVIOUS BILL BUT
ACCESS WITHOUT.
SERVICES TO ACTUALLY MAKE IT
WORK THOUGH IT DOESN'T WORK AND
AND SO IN ALL THOSE.
THIS IS WHERE WE GOT THAT --
ORNERY HOMEOWNER WHO WANTS TO BE
A NAME BE AND PUT UP THE NO
PARKING SIGN -- THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE AND AGAINST THE LAW.
THE QUESTION IS WHEN YOU OPEN IT
UP.
WHAT DO YOU DO THAT RIGHT AND IS
IT DOES IT STILL HAVE THAT SENSE
OF YOU CAN'T COME HERE --
BECAUSE HOW ARE YOU EVER GOING
TO GET THERE A AND ONCE YOU GET
THERE.
IF YOU DON'T IF YOU DON'T HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN THE OCEAN OR SORT
OF DON'T IF YOU FEEL OUT OF YOUR
ELEMENT WHAT ARE THOSE SORT OF
SERVICES.
AND OPERATIONAL -- OPPORTUNITIES
TO ACTUALLY MAKE IT WORK SO -- I
I JUST WANTED PLEDGE OUR OUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK -- THROUGH
THIS ESPECIALLY AS WE LOOK AT
DEADLINES I KNOW THIS IS SORT OF
JUST THE SHOT CLOCK BILL TO SAY
LIKE LET'S GET EVERYONE TGETHER.
EVEN COME UP WITH SOMETHING HERE --
SO I APPRECIATE THE INTENT I'M
JUST AS TO KEEP WORKING WITH
COMMITTEE AS WE SORT OF ROUND
THAT OUT -- BUT I THINK THERE'S
A GOOD PATH FOR HERE HOPEFULLY
TO SETTLING THIS ISSUE IN A WAY
THAT.
THAT WORKS FOR ALL THE PARTIES --
WITH THAT I'D ENTERTAIN A MOTION
OR QUESTIONS CENTER CAREER.
I WILL MOVE THE BELL -- ALSO --
HE STARTED TALKING ABOUT IT ONE
OF THEM THE MORE DIFFICULT.
ISSUES THAT I HAD IN THE
THIRTIETH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WAS
THAT -- HIGHWAY ONE IN -- BIG
SUR APART FROM THE LANDSLIDES
AND ALL OF THAT.
THE DEVASTATION IT HAPPENS --
KINDA NATURALLY.
BUT BUT THE ISSUE OF
ACCESSIBILITY OF THE BEACH IS
REALLY IMPORTANT BUT THERE'S
ALSO A REAL NEED -- TO HAVE
RESTROOMS AND SO I'M GOING TO
PUT THAT ON THE RADAR SCREEN --
THE FEDERAL FOREST SERVICE
REFUSED TO CHANGE THE SIGNAGE SO
THAT YOU CAN SEE WHERE THE
RESTROOMS WERE ON FEDERAL
PROPERTY BECAUSE THEY REALLY
DON'T HAVE TO CLEAN OUT THE
TOILETS.
AND THE RESIDENTS WERE
COMPLAINING BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE
THEN DOING THEIR BUSINESS ON THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD NEAR THERE.
SPOCK'S BOXES WHICH WAS KIND OF
DISGUSTING.
SO -- SO SO ACT AXIS IS THE
FIRST POINT AND THEN IT THEN IT
THEN THE WHOLE ISSUE OF HOW DO
YOU.
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT -- WHERE
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT THE RULES ARE
AND CAN FIND THE RESTROOMS AND --
AND WE'RE PARKING IS APPROPRIATE
AS WELL BECAUSE IF YOU DRIVE
DOWN HIGHWAY ONE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE TAKING PICTURES
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE HIGHWAY.
OUR OR ARE JUST DOUBLE OR TRIPLE
PARK IS REALLY INCREDIBLE AND SO
WE HAVE THIS BEAUTIFUL COAST ON
BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF
RESTRICTIONS ON SIGNAGE.
AND WHAT YOU CAN POST OUT NEAR
THE ROADWAYS AND SO WE ME THIS
MAY BE A BIGGER ISSUE BUT I JUST
WANT TO IDENTIFY IT AS THERE ARE.
THERE WERE FOR PEOPLE WHO LIVED
IN THE IN THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS
WHO DIDN'T WANT ANY TOURISTS
COMING THROUGH -- AND WE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE DO WHEN WE
HAVE INTERNATIONAL VISITORS THAT
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE RULES ARE
AND ARE YOU ARE DOING THEIR BEST
TO ENJOY OUR BEAUTIFUL LANDSCAPE.
AND TO THAT POINT IF I IF I
LEAST -- WE ABSOLUTELY THAT THE
GREAT ACCESS IT IS ONE PART OF
IT BUT ALSO -- THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN HAPPENING AND
INCLUDE THE BIGGER.
PIECES ABOUT WHAT IS FULL AXES
MEAN IS IT PARKING IN IS IT
TRANSPORTATION IS AT THE
RESTAURANT PIECE ALL OF THAT SO
I A WANT TO NOTE THAT THE FOR
AGENCIES THAT HAVE SIGNED AN
AMMO YOU TO WORK TOGETHER OUR
STATE LANDS.
THE COASTAL COMMISSION OUR
COASTAL CONSERVANCY AND PARKS --
IT TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE VERY
ISSUES AND THAT YOU'RE
DISCUSSING I THINK THERE'S A
BROAD COMMITMENT TO IDENTIFY.
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE AND HOW WE
GET FULL ACCESS?
VERY GOOD -- WAS THAT IT WAS AN
EMOTION OKAY SO.
THERE'S A MOTION.
ALL I TO CLOSE.
COMPLETELY AGREE ON THE GOAL
KEEP US INFORMED AS THINGS MOVE
FORWARD AND LET US WORK WITH YOU
ON THIS.
QUESTION AND DEADLINES AND YOU
KNOW I I THINK.
WE TALK ABOUT IT -- AUTHORIZING
AN ADJUSTMENT OF A
RECOMMENDATION DRAINAGE ESSENCE
OF IN LIEU FEES.
THERE ARE OTHERS SORT OF REVENUE
CONVERSATION I THINK WE JUST
NEED TO BE HONEST WITH OURSELVES
AND HAVE ON A BROADER SCALE HERE
WHAT BOND DOLLARS CAN'T DO.
AND THERE'S CERTAIN THINGS AMONG
OTHERS CAN DO AND I THINK
FRANKLY WE DO NEED MORE.
THAN AROUND JUST LEFT BUT WE
NEED TO MOVE A RESILIENCY BOND --
THIS YEAR I BELIEVE THAT BUT
IT'S ONLY GONNA GO SO FAR SO
MAYBE IN THE MODEL HERE WE CAN
ALSO START TO LOOK AT HOW TO
GENERATE THAT KIND OF ACCESS.
MEANINGFUL ACCESS REVENUE THAT
IT'S GOING TO MAKE PEOPLE FEEL
SAFER IN THEIR COMMUNITY SO
THEY'RE GOING TO BE MORE OPEN
ABOUT IT NOT TO FEEL THAT IT'S
OPEN ENDED BUT THE SAME TIME
PEOPLE ARE GONNA ACTUALLY OF A
MEANINGFUL EXPERIENCE WHEN THEY
GET THERE SO.
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
VERY GOOD OTHER MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER STERN HIGH STERN I'D
JONES ALLEN FORGES CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE HERTZBERG HUESO
JACKSON MONNING ON CALL THERE
USUALLY THE MEASURE ON CALL
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT.
HE DIDN'T KNOW IT AT SENECA BEER
WE HAD SHE PRESENTED HER FIRST
BILL -- OUTDOOR ACCESS GRANTS A.
B. TWO OH NINE BUT WE DID NOT
HAVE A QUORUM AT THAT POINT.
I DO IN ENTERTAIN A MOTION IF.
OKAY SO MOVED.
HE'S CALDERON A. B. TWO OH NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR STERN
HI STERN AYE JONES ALAN FORGES
CABALLERO.
I HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON MONEY
ON CALL IT TOO OKAY VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON A DOCTOR
QUIRK -- THE MORNING IS YOUR SIR
.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND CENTER
CABALLERO -- EIGHTY TO NINETY
TWO WOULD CHANGE THE TERMS USED
FOR RECYCLED WATER.
WEEKLY AB TWO NINETY TWO WITH
THE LEAD TO TERMS DIRECT
POSSIBLE RE USE AN INDIRECT
POSSIBLE REVIEWS FOR GROUND
WATER RECHARGE CHARGE.
AND USE THE FOLLOWING TERMS
RALPH WATER AUGMENTATION
TREATING TREATED DRINKING WATER
AUGMENTATION GROUNDWATER
AUGMENTATION.
AND WORSE OF OUR LETTER
THE VAST MAJORITY PEOPLE DO NOT
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE TERM
POSSIBLE MEANS -- I DIDN'T UNTIL
I GOT HERE.
MUCH LESS WHAT DIRECTOR INDIRECT
WOULD ACTUALLY MEAN.
THE WATER AGENCIES THAT
IMPLEMENT THESE RECYCLED WATER
PROJECTS BELIEVE THAT THIS
CHANGE IN TERMS.
WOULD HELP THEM PROMOTE WHETHER
RECYCLING.
THE BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
ADEQUATE MANY WATER AGENCIES AND
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION.
WITH ME TODAY IS CYRUS FEVERS
WITHOUT.
LOS VIRGINIS JOINT POWER
AUTHORITY AND JENNIFER WEST WITH
Y. TO RE USE THANK YOU.
MORNING GOOD MORNING -- I AM
JENNIFER WEST AND THE MANAGING
DIRECTOR OF WATER USE CALIFORNIA
IN CALIFORNIA IS THE NATION AND
WORLD LEADER FOR POTABLE RIOS.
AND EDUCATION AND RIGOROUS
PUBLIC OUTRAGE IS A CORNERSTONE
OF ALL OF THESE PROJECTS.
WE SEE THIS IS ESSENTIAL TO GAIN
LOCAL SUPPORT CONFIDENCE AND TO
OVERCOME THE EVER PRESENT TOILET
TO TAP MONIKER.
SO WE KNOW THAT IN FACT WORDS
MATTER AND CAN BREAK MAKE OR
BREAK A PROJECT.
WE HAVE LOCAL SURVEY INFORMATION
ANECDOTAL STORIES AND
INFORMATION FROM PR
PROFESSIONALS THAT WORK ON THESE
PROJECTS ALL OVER THEIR STATE.
AND THEIR INPUT SHOW THAT THE
TERMS INDIRECT AND DIRECT JUST
ADD TO CONSUMER CONFUSION ABOUT
PORTABLE RADIOS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF TERMINOLOGY IS
ACKNOWLEDGED IN A TWENTY
EIGHTEEN EPA REPORT
MAINSTREAMING POTABLE REUSE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
ON PAGE TWENTY ONE OF THIS
REPORT IT DISCUSSES THAT WE NEED
TO NAME AND IDENTIFY DIFFERENT
TYPES OF POTABLE REUSE WATER AND
SPECIFICALLY STATES THAT.
CALIFORNIA'S AB FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR BY SOME WOMEN QUIRK
REPRESENTS A USEFUL STARTING
POINT FOR THE NATION.
AB TWO NINE TWO IS  SIMPLE BILL
THAT ELIMINATES THESE TERMS
INDIRECT AND DIRECT AND ALLOWS
US TO MORE CLEARLY COMMUNICATE
WITH THE PUBLIC USING
TERMINOLOGY ESTABLISHED IN AB.
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER THAN SUPPORT.
FOR MEMBERS ARE STEAMERS
REPRESENTING A LOS REGION AS
WATER DISTRICT.
AS THE ANALYSIS MAKES CLEAR THAT
IT FROM A DISTANCE BETWEEN
DIRECT AND INDIRECT IS THE
CONCEPT OF AN ENVIRONMENTAL
BUFFER.
WHICH IS THERE IS SOMETHING IN
BETWEEN RECYCLED WATER AND THE
CUSTOMER TO SHOW HOW OUTDATED
THIS TERM IS BECOME THE PROJECT
FROM YOUR DISTRICT APPEAR ONE
SYSTEM.
IN THAT CASE THE QUOTE UNQUOTE
ENVIRONMENTAL BUFFER THE
RESERVOIR THAT THE RECYCLE WATER
WILL GOING.
TO IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
CONTAMINATE THE RECYCLED WATER.
THE RECYCLED WATER IS COMING OUT
TO DRINKING WATER STANDARDS IT'S
GONNA BE CONTAMINATED BY THE
RESERVOIR AND THEN HAS TO BE
TREATED AGAIN BEFORE PEOPLE CAN
DRINK.
SO IN OTHER WORDS.
IN THE AREA WHERE WE CAN DEL THE
TECHNOLOGY TO DEVELOP RECYCLED
WATER DRINKING WATER STANDARDS
THESE TERMS HAVE BECOME AN ACTOR
DISTRICT AND IT'S REALLY.
A DISSERVICE TO THE PUBLIC TO
KEEP USING THEM THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
VERY HELPFUL -- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BABRI BOMB
BEHALF OF DESERT WATER AGENCY
ELDORADO IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND
WATER REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU SIR.
THIS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL
BOCA DORAL ON BEHALF OF THE
INLAND EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY
AND WATER USE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SIR.
EMILY PAPPAS ON BEHALF OF
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
IT'S PART.
THANKS.
I KNOW SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TO THE HOLE WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT.
THANKS.
JENNIFER WILLIAMS OF THE EAST
BAY MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ROSIE THOMPSON WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT IS
IN CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THE MORNING JOE BOSCO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES AND SUPPORT.
THE MORNING GENOCIDE TODAY FOR
THE GROUND WATER RESOURCES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WATER THIRTEEN SUPPORT.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD -- THERE'S IN SUPPORT
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
HAVE ME BACK.
TO PRETTY EMPTY DíAS.
HE WAS WOULD YOU MIND COMING
BACK UP I JUST A QUICK QUESTION
FOR YOU TO CLARIFY [inaudible]
SO.
IN THE SPIRIT OF OF THIS MEASURE
WHICH IS THAT WORDS MATTER.
I APPRECIATE WITH THE AUTHORS
TRYING TO DO HERE SO I SEE
YOU'RE SAYING.
BY VIRTUE OF THE NOMENCLATURE
USING EXISTING LAW.
THE THE PURE PROJECT SORT OF
NECESSARILY HAS TO BE REGARDED
AS A CONTAMINATION OF DRINKING
WATER RESOURCE EVEN THOUGH IT'S
ACTUALLY.
CLEANING THE WATER AND THE
SOURCE OF THE CONTAMINATION
BEING THE RESERVOIR UNDER THE
CURRENT TERMINOLOGY WOULD BE
REFERRED TO AS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
BUFFER.
SO A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING THAT TERM IS GONNA THINK
BUFFER MEANS SOME LETTER OF
PROTECTION.
THE FACT IN THE PIER ONE SYSTEM
THIS RESERVOIR THIS BEEN
AUGMENTED IS ACTUALLY SOURCE OF
CONTAMINATION OF THE RECYCLED
WATER IT REALLY FLIP THAT ON ITS
HEAD THAT'S WHY THESE TERMS ONCE
WE CAN DEVELOP THIS TO DRINKING
WATER STANDARDS.
THESE TERMS REALLY HAVE BECOME
OUTDATED.
INTERESTING YOU KNOW I I CAME
INTO TO BE FRANK WITH THE DOCTOR
QUIRK I I CAME INTO A LITTLE
SKEPTICAL -- IN TERMS OF JUST
THE AMOUNT OF SCHOLARLY RESEARCH
THAT HAS OCCURRED IN THE AREA
AND AND THIS SORT OF WEIGHT OF
PRECEDENT -- IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW NOT WANTING.
TO TINKER ARBITRARILY.
IF YOU WILL -- BUT IF I FIND IT
NOT IS ARBITRARY ANYMORE DID YOU
I MEAN DID YOU HAVE A A QUICK
RESPONSE -- IN TERMS OF THIS
THIS CONCERN THOUGH RAISING THE
ANALYSIS INTERNAL THE THE THE
SORT OF HOW THIS WILL IMPACT
SCHOLARLY RESEARCH AND AND
WHETHER WE'RE GONNA GET SOME
CONFUSION BRED OUT OF THIS OR
WHETHER WE THINK WE CAN ACTUALLY
CHANGE I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT THE
SCHOLARS THEY'LL FIGURE IT.
OUT I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE
GENERAL PUBLIC.
THEY'VE DONE SURVEYS THEY'VE
TALKED TO PEOPLE.
FRANKLY I COULDN'T TELL YOU WHAT
THE BEST WAY TO TALK ABOUT THIS
IS I'M RELYING ON THEIR RESEARCH
AND IS THAT AND BELIEVE ME I'VE
BEEN THE SCHOLAR.
THEY'LL FIGURE IT OUT SO TO THAT.
TO THAT PLAIN TALK FROM A
SCHOLAR DID YOU CAN YOU CAN YOU
WALK US TROUGH JUST VERY
BRIEFLY THAT THE WITH THE
RESEARCH DRIVING THIS AND AND
SORT OF HOW YOU ARRIVED AT THIS
DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
HOW ABOUT IF I TAKEN A SHOT AT
THAT PLEASE THEM YET THANK YOU
SO?
YOU KNOW THESE THAT INTERACT IN
DIRECT POTABLE REUSE TERMS -- I
THINK I THINK THAT THE EVOLUTION
OF POTABLE REUSE AND AS I SAID
AT THE BEGINNING WE ARE IN THE
NATION THEY ARE THE NATION AND
THE WORLD LEADER FOR PEREA SO.
THIS NATION IS LOOKING TO US ON
WHAT MAKES THE MOST SENSE I GO
TO CONFERENCES WHERE THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT HOW IS THE BEST
WAY TO COMMUNICATE ABOUT THESE
PROJECTS.
AND THE TERMS INDIRECT AND
DIRECT HAVE REALLY CREATED.
LIKE I SAID THIS THIS KIND OF
CONFUSION SO THERE HAS BEEN A
NATIONAL DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
NEED TO CHANGE THESE TERMS.
AND TO FIND MORE.
UNDERSTANDABLE TERMINOLOGY --
YOU KNOW WITH WITH FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR WE HAD TO LEAVE THOSE TERMS
IN THERE THERE WAS ANOTHER
PURPOSE FOR THAT BILL TO DEVELOP
THE RAW WATER AUGMENTATION
REGULATIONS.
THE TERMINOLOGY WAS A PART THAT
WE SET FOR LATER THAT WAS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR OUR
ORGANIZATION AND FOR THE PR
PROFESSIONALS THAT I WORK ON
THIS AND I AND I GUESS I JUST
LIKE TO SAY THAT I MEAN OF ALL
THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF WATER
PROJECTS THAT THEY'RE ON THE
STATE.
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION AND
CONSUMER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
PROJECT IS PROBABLY MORE
IMPORTANT INPUT ARRAY OF CINEMAS
ANYTHING ELSE WERE DRINKING
WATER.
RECYCLED WATER WERE EXPLAINING
THIS SO THAT WOULD BE MY URGING
ON THE IMPORTANCE OF TERMINOLOGY
PARTICULARLY FOR THIS TYPE OF
RECYCLED WATER.
AND WATER SOURCE AND SO AND IS
THE PUBLIC RESPONDING TO THE
TERM I MEAN EVERYONE LOVES LIKE.
RAW VEGETABLES AND RAW YOU KNOW
EVERY FANCY HEALTH FOOD STORE
YOU GO TO SO IT MEANS THAT PART
OF THE YEAH I MEAN LOGIC IS IT
IT DOESN'T.
SO WHEN ORINDA STILL WORKS
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT WHO'S THAT
WHO HAVE DID IT DONE TOWARDS
FIVE THOUSAND PLUS PER -- THEY
HAVE TOWARDS COME THE OF PEOPLE
COME TO TOWARD THEIR FACILITY.
THE INDIRECT AND DIRECT THEY
THEY SURVEYED THEM AFTERWARDS
AND THAT THAT'S NOT HELPFUL IN
TERMS OF UNDERSTANDING THE
DIRECT.
IMPLIES THAT THERE'S LESS
TREATMENT I MEAN THAT'S JUST
NATURAL -- SO WE SO I BELIEVE
THAT THAT THEY ARE THEY USE THE
SURVEY INFORMATION AND THAT
THAT'S BEEN VERY HELPFUL -- TO
TO ASCERTAIN THAT'S ONE PLACE
WHERE WE GET THE INFORMATION BUT
AS I SAID P. R. PROFESSIONALS
ARE WORKING ON THESE PROJECTS
ALL OVER THE STATE.
THEY HAVE LITTLE FOCUS GROUPS
AND THEY TALK ABOUT WHAT MAKES
SENSE TO PEOPLE YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY TALKING ABOUT POTABLE
RE ISN'T WHAT IS ACCURATE.
AND IN THE CONTEXT THE TERMS ON
AB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR MAKE THE
MOST SENSE UNDERSTOOD.
OKAY WELL -- THERE IS NO
OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE A MOTION
BUT I WOULD ENTERTAINMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME SO I'LL LET YOU
TO CLOSE DR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
LOOK FORWARD TO THE DAY WHEN
PEOPLE DON'T EVEN THINK ABOUT
THIS.
AND WE HAVE WHAT IS CALLED FLY
AND TO **** MEANING.
THE WATER GOES DIRECT FROM THE
READ TREATMENT PROGRAM TO CLEAN
UP THE THE SO CALLED WAR BRAWL
WATER WHICH IS COMING IN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND AND YOUR
ATTEMPTED THE P. R..
MOVE BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU -- OKAY WE
WE WILL -- WAIT FOR MEMBERS TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THAT
MEASURE IT BUT AT PRESENT LET ME
JUST LOOK IN OUR WE HAVE A
SIMILAR MCCARTY HERE I BELIEVE A
FILE ITEM NUMBER. FOUR THE ME
SEES THAT IT.
VERY GOOD YES WELCOME GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING.
BRING MY WITNESSES UP.
OKAY GOOD MORNING FIRST I WANT.
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US FOR A COUPLE WEEKS AND
WE PUT THIS BILL OVER TO MAKE
SURE WE GOT A RIGHT I THINK WE
DO SO. FOR THIS BILLS RELATED TO
OUR COURTS ARE GREAT CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS.
THAT CREATED BY OUR FORMER
GOVERNOR BROWN WITH A GREAT
SLOGAN CRUMMY CONDITIONS AND LOW
PAY WHO WOULD WANT THAT BUT IT'S
REALLY.
A PHENOMENAL PROGRAM MODERN UP
TO MODERN AFTER THIS CIVILIAN
CONSERVATION CORPS CREATED
DURING THE GREAT.
DEPRESSION.
COR MEMBERS LEARN SKILLS SUCH AS
FORESTRY MANAGEMENT ENERGY
AUDITING INSULATION EMERGENCY AT
A CAN ALSO EARN THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA SAID ALSO IS A
CRITICAL ROLE.
IN HELPING INDIVIDUALS WHO
FRANKLY WERE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM GET GET THEIR AND
GET THEIR YOU KNOW ON THE RIGHT
FOOT IN THAT IT HAD A KID START
IN THEIR CAREER.
SO WHAT THIS WOULD DO THIS WOULD
BUILD UPON A LOT COUPLE YEARS
AGO WHICH I WORKED ON WHICH
ALLOWS PEOPLE ON PROBATION TO BE
ELIGIBLE TO SERVE NOT
AUTOMATICALLY TO BE ELIGIBLE SO
THIS WILL NOT PEOPLE ON
PROBATION.
AND PAROLE THAT'S THE CHANGE SO
THEY WOULD BE CERTAINLY OPS --
OPTIONAL THIS WOULD ALLOW BUT
NOT REQUIRED.
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CORE AND ALSO LOCAL COURSE TO
CONSIDERS INDIVIDUALS -- WITH
THE WITH OF COURSE THE INPUT
FROM THE PEOPLE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM THE PAROLE AGENTS
AND SO FORTH -- SO THIS IS NO
OPPOSITION WITH ME IS AN
INDIVIDUAL FROM OUR LOCAL COR
JORDAN ROBERSON AS WELL AS READ
ADDIS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL COURSE.
JORDAN GOOD THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING WELCOME JOINT MORNING.
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JORDAN
ROBERSON.
I WAS BORN IN MAY THE CALIFORNIA
I GRADUATED FROM COULD OVER HIGH
SCHOOL.
I WAS THE ACADEMIC SCHOLAR I
LIVE IN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN
COOLEY DISTRICT.
A FEW MONTHS AGO I GRADUATED
FROM CONSUME THIS RIVER COLLEGE
TO RECEIVE MY A A DEGREE IN
SOCIOLOGY.
I HAVE ACCEPTED.
BEEN ACCEPTED TO CAST A
SACRAMENTO AND WILL ENTER AS A
JUNIOR IN AUGUST.
I REALLY GOT IN TROUBLE IN
AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AND I TRIED TO BREAK IN
SOMEONE'S HOUSE AND I GOT BILLED
OUT IN SERVE THREE MONTHS --
ANKLE MONITOR.
AND I GOT IN TROUBLE AGAIN FOR
THE SECOND TIME.
TRYING TO SELL NARCOTICS TO EARN
SOME EXTRA MONEY TO SURVIVE.
I MET A DEPUTY BY THE NAME OF
SHARE OF BAKER.
WHO WAS ASSIGNED TO MY CASE? TO
KEEP TRACK TO ME MAKE SURE I WAS
STAYING ON TRACK INTO WHEN I WAS
SUPPOSED.
TO AND I SEEN A FIRE -- FOR
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL CONSERVATION
CORPS HANG IN IN HIS OFFICE MY
LIFE AND HELP SUPPORT OF ME GIVE
ME THE GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT TO
GET BACK ON MY FEET AND NOW
BEING DIFFICULT TO HAVE A
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND AND GET A
JOB AND BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
YOURSELF.
AND THEY HAVE GIVEN ME A LOT OF
MENTOR SHIP.
WITH THE BEST OF THE BEST IN
THEIR JOB FILLED IN THE STAFF.
HELPS YOU GET DEEP INTO YOUR
PERSONAL LIFE AND HOW YOU WANT
TO IMPROVE.
AND IT REALLY HAS CHANGED MY
LIFE BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE I'VE
LEARNED.
THAT THINGS YOU SHOULDN'T TAKE
FOR GRANTED AND YOU KNOW THINGS
THAT ARE HARDER ARE PRETTY MUCH
THE THINGS THAT YOU SHOULD
PROBABLY CHIU FOR BECAUSE IT
GAVE YOU.
A BETTER FEELING OF GETTING
SOMETHING THE RIGHT WAY
[inaudible]
ENOUGH SAID.
THANK YOU WELCOME THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS READ OUT US ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL CONSERVATION
CORPS IS HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING WITH PEOPLE LIKE JORDAN.
ON A DAILY BASIS.
THE REASON WE'RE HERE IN TODAY
TODAY IN SUPPORT IS BECAUSE MANY
OF THE LOCAL CORES ALREADY HAVE
THE ABILITY. TO WORK WITH PEOPLE
LIKE JORDAN.
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE ONE CORD THAT
IS NOT ALLOWED TO DO THAT AND AS
HE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS POINTED OUT
THE STATE CORES ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO DO THAT.
WE'RE OBVIOUSLY ALWAYS TRYING TO
BREAK DOWN BARRIERS FOR
INDIVIDUALS ESPECIALLY THOSE IN
THIS POPULATION TO ENTER THE
WORKFORCE THE LOCAL COURTS DO
THAT BY BOTH PROVIDING EDUCATION
AND JOB TRAINING.
WHEN IT COMES TO PAROLEES IT'S
SOMETIMES DIFFICULT TO PLACE
THEM IN JOBS ONE OF YOUR MEMBERS
SENATOR WAY SAYS WORKING ON AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM FOR THAT?
WHAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY'S
BILL DOES IS IT BREAKS IT TAKES
DOWN THE BARRIER OF A LEGAL
ISSUE WHICH IS A STATE CORPS AND
AGAIN ONE OF OUR LOCAL COURSES
NOT ABLE TO ACTUALLY BRING THESE
FOR A LEE?
THE IT MEMBERS INTO THE PROGRAM
IN THE FIRST PLACE THEREFORE
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT TODAY
THANK YOU GOOD THANK YOU OTHERS
IN SUPPORT HERE.
SEEING NINE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING BACK TO
THE DíAS FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
I I JUST HAD A QUICK QUESTION OR
WELL.
JUST TO NOTIFY HOPEFUL
CONGRADULATIONS.
FOR SITTING HERE IN THE CAPITAL
TODAY.
BACK FROM WHERE YOU WERE TWO
YEARS AGO.
QUITE A PATH.
TELL ME.
IF YOU COULD WHAT KIND OF WORK
YOU DOING OUT THERE WHAT WHAT I
CONSTRUCTION WORK GENERAL LABOR.
HE SAID THE INTERESTING THING IN
YOUR CLOTHES AS I TELL YOU WHEN
HE READ THE NOTES ANYMORE WE
SAID DOING.
DOING THE HARD THINGS IS WHAT
YOU'RE SEEKING NOW IS OPPOSE THE
EASY THINGS HE CONNELL MORE ON
THE LIKE.
SELLIN DRUGS OR TRYING TO GET A
EASY MONEY.
RATHER THAN GOING TO WORK YOU
KNOW.
PLAN IN EIGHT HOURS A DAY.
YOU KNOW WAITING FOR YOUR MONEY
WHICH COMES LIFE REALLY TO
YOURSELF AND IT'S YOURS.
THE CLAIM.
PRETTY MUCH LIKE.
WORKING IN A STABLE SYSTEM WHERE
YOU'RE DOING THINGS TO SUPPORT
YOURSELF THE RIGHT WAY.
AND IT YEAH IT'S IT'S A
DIFFERENT SPEED OF OF YOU KNOW
RWARD RIGHT DOESN'T COME AS
FAST BUT I MEAN THAT THE HOPE
HERE IS THAT THIS PROGRAM.
JUDGES BASED ON CHARACTER.
AND WORK ETHIC AND NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF SOME DECISIONS YOU
MADE I APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AND TO IN THAT WORK IS.
BELIEVE IN A LOT OF TALENT ON
THE TABLE TO IN THIS STATE IN
TERMS PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY
IMPROVE OUR CONSERVATION
OUTCOMES AND ALL KINDS OF OTHER
PROFESSIONS [inaudible]
TO CHARACTER COUNTS.
A GUIDE YOU WITH THE MISTAKES
YOU MADE THAT'S HOW THE SYSTEM
WORKS BUT I APPRECIATE IS TRYING
TO BUST THROUGH SOME OF THESE
BARRIERS AND GIVE A LITTLE BIT
AT DAYLIGHT HERE -- THANKS FOR
DOING THAT AND WORK FOR WORKING
WITH A COMMITTEE TO JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
THAT THAT DISCRETION IS CLEAR.
AND THAT IS DIRECTLY TO BE
RIGOROUS AND JUST FIND THE BEST
THE BEST AND THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
WE WANT TO DRIVE THE PROCESS
APPRECIATE THAT.
UNDERMINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COLLEGES
WASN'T HERE TO HEAR THE AUTHORS
OPENING THAT.
SHE DID THE TESTIMONY OF OF BOTH
THE WITNESSES.
I ASSUME YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENT THAT INNING AND
ANALYSIS.
CORRECT AND SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION RELATES TO THAT.
ARE THERE ANY SPECIFIED CRIMES
THAT WOULD DISQUALIFY.
APPROVAL ONLY UNDER THE AMENDED
BILL FROM BEING CONSIDERED OR
SIT ALL.
NOW UP TO THE DISCRETION OF THE
DIRECTOR.
I THINK HOW WE HOW WE HOW WE
WROTE THE ON THE AMENDMENT AND
MAYBE.
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT COULD
CORRECT IF I'M WRONG.
IS THAT -- THEY WOULD ALL BE
UNDER DISCRETION THAT THE WEED
WE DO LIST -- ONE ONE ONE
INCIDENT IN THE PENAL CODE TO
NINETY IN THOSE OFFENSES TO BE.
LOOKED INTO TOTAL CONSIDERATION
WITH THE DIRECTOR AND OF COURSE
THE INDIVIDUALS FROM THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
EVALUATE EACH CANDIDATE.
I'M GONNA BE SUPPORTIVE TODAY I
I REALLY SUPPORT.
THE OBJECTIVE HERE I AM A LITTLE
CONCERNED THAT.
CERTAIN SPECIFIED CRIMES.
CHILD MOLESTATION -- OTHER
CRIMES THAT.
EVEN IF PERSONS DONE THEIR TIME
THERE MAY BE A PROPENSITY THERE
THAT ISN'T GOING TO BE A GOOD
MIX WORKING.
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
CONSERVATION CORPS AND WELL IN
THIS.
THE AUTHORITY IN THE DIRECTOR IT
SEEMS IT INVESTS ALL THAT
DISCRETION.
WITH THE DIRECTOR SO I JUST HAVE
SOME CONCERNS I THINK WE WANT TO
FIND A BALANCE THAT PROVIDES A
PATHWAY FOR PEOPLE LIKE IS IT
JORDAN THE SENTENCING YOU KNOW A
PATHWAY FOR PEOPLE WHO.
WHO WERE LOOKING TO GET THEIR
FEET ON THE GROUND IN BUILD
FUTURE?
BUT I JUST DON'T WANT TO SEE THE
GOOD WORK -- OF THE CONSERVATION
CORPS POTENTIALLY COMPROMISED BY
SOME.
OVERZEALOUS EFFORT. TO TO FILL
POSITIONS OR GRANT PAROLEES
SLOTS THAT MAY TAKE A SLICE FROM
A THE YOUNG PERSON.
WHO HASN'T HAD ANY ENGAGEMENT
WITH THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
SO THOSE ARE JUST MY CONCERNS I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ANY
REASSURANCE FROM THE CHAIR OR
THE AUTHOR?
I'M AND I'M HAPPY TO WIN BECAUSE
WE WE WRESTLED WITH THAT EXACT
ISSUE I THINK THAT I APPRECIATE
ACTUALLY SO MEMBER GIVEN US A
LITTLE TIME TO WORK ON THIS
THAT'S WHY WE HELD IT OVER AND
SORT OF WORKED ON IT FOR A
COUPLE WEEKS -- THE THE IT'S A
MANDATORY CONSIDERATION NOW IN
THE PROCESS THINGS LIKE -- PENAL
CODE TO NINETY WHICH YOU
MENTIONED.
AND LIFETIME PAROLE -- ISSUES.
THE I THINK THE WAY THIS BILL IS
STRUCTURED [inaudible]
DEMANDS -- A SORT OF COMMITMENTS
OVERSEEING THE PROGRAM'S
IMPLEMENTATION ON OUR END AND I
THINK I'VE HEARD FROM THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND YOU CAN
CHIME IN IF YOU LIKE BUT AS THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I KNOW WE'RE COMMITTED TO
CLOSELY MONITORING
IMPLEMENTATION.
HEY I THINK THE RESOURCE ARE
STILL STRIPPED SO THERE WILL BE
LIMITED SLOTS AND FORTUNE I
THINK THERE'S MORE WORK TO DO.
AND MORE WORK FORCE EXPANSION
FRANKLY IT'S NEEDED IF YOU DON'T
HAVE TO MAKE THAT'S A LIMITED
SET OF CHOICES BUT I ALSO OUR
SENSE FROM.
THE THE CCC AS WELL AS THE
AUTHOR IS THAT -- THERE'S NOT
GOING TO BE A SORT OF WAITING OF
THIS SCALE -- OUT YOU KNOW A
PENDING.
OTHER QUALIFIED CANDIDATES AS
WELL WHO DON'T HAVE THIS PAST
THIS SIMPLE POINT IS IF YOU DO
QUALIFY -- ON ON CHARACTER ON
HARD WORK AND TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION IS YOUR FITNESS TO
JOIN THE COR PUBLIC SAFETY ALL
THESE OTHER ISSUES.
YOU MAKE IT THROUGH THAT
RIGOROUS TEST I THINK JORDAN
SAID THE BEST THE BEST -- YOU
MAKE IT THROUGH THE TEST.
YOU'RE YOU'RE STILL GOING TO BE
ELIGIBLE BUT WE HAVE EVERY
EXPECTATION THAT THE DIRECTOR
GOING TO WAIVE THESE FACTORS
HEAVILY THAT WE'VE OUTLINED HERE --
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD ON THAT BUT YEAH
THAT I THINK THAT WAS THE THE
THE GOAL WE'VE SEEN THIS DURING
THE PROBATION CHANGE THAT WE
VOTED ON AND AN ACTIVE. THREE
YEARS AGO.
BUT IT'S NOT AUTOMATIC
ACCEPTANCE THIS IS A VERY
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM IT SOUGHT
AFTER.
FRANKLY WE SHOULD BE GROWING THE
THE CORE WE WE HAVE BEEN WITH
SOME OF THE CAP AND TRADE MONEY
LAST FOR YEARS FOCUSING ON OUR
STATE PRIORITIES AND IT HELPS
WITH ISSUES THEY WERE TRYING TO
DEAL WITH LIKE THEIR RECIDIVISM
ISSUE TRYING TO GET PEOPLE BACK.
INTO THE MAINSTREAM AND THE
IRONY IS YOU YOU CAN AS YOU KNOW
YOU COULD BE.
IN STATE PRISON RIGHT NOW AND BE
ABLE TO GO WORK ON THE FIRES
THREE YEAR PRISON SENTENCE.
AND THEN WHEN YOU'RE RELEASED ON
PAROLE YOU WANT TO JOIN A
PROGRAM LIKE THE COR DO THE SAME
TYPE OF WORK AND MAYBE KERN YOUR
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA -- GET SOME
EXPERIENCE GET A PIPELINE TO
CAREER LIKE NO YOU CAN'T DO THAT
YOU CAN DO ONE WHEN YOU'RE
INCARCERATED BUT NOT WHEN YOU'RE
OUT SO.
IT'S JUST - SOME
INCONSISTENCIES IN THIS WOULD
ALLOW -- FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
DIRECTORS TO DETERMINE WHAT
APPLICANTS AND MEET THAT HIGHER
THRESHOLD.
THANK YOU AGAIN I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I'LL JUST FINISH WITH A SHOUT
OUT TO THE CORE THAT PROVIDED.
TREMENDOUS SUPPORT IN OUR BIG
SUR AREA WHEN WE LOST TO BRIDGE
FOLLOWING THE STORMS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN IN.
THE CORPS CONSTRUCTED AN
EMERGENCY.
TRAIL IN SIX WEEKS WE ORIGINALLY
TOLD IT WOULD BE A SEVEN YEAR
PLANNING PROCESS THROUGH STATE
PARKS.
THEY GET IT DONE IN SIX WEEKS IN
THE CORE MOVE SOME TEAMS AROUND
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE.
FULL TIME SUPPORT SO -- I'M WELL
AWARE OF THE TREMENDOUS WORK.
THE CORE DOES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
HOW ARE YOU TO CLOSE NO I THINK
IT WOULD HIT ALL'S DURING THAT
BACK AND FORTH TO SENATOR MONEY --
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK TRAVEL
[inaudible]
GOOD.
SO HAVING AID EXCEPT TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE MOTION
WOULD BE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS I WON
ENTERTAINMENT OR WE CAN WAIT
UNTIL WE HAVE A I WE DO HAVE A
CORE.
YEAH BUT OKAY VERY GOOD -- VERY
GOOD THANK YOU CENTER MORNINGS
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
KALRA SENATOR STERN HI STERN AYE
JONES ALAN ORANGES CABALLERO
HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON MONNING.
MONEY NINE THE BILLS ON CALL.
OKAY WILL LEAVE THE MEASURE CALL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
TODAY GOOD LUCK OUT THERE.
DOESN'T TAKE A LOT THOUGH JUST
GO SWEAT. NINETY WORK THANK YOU
SIR.
ALL RIGHT -- LET'S SEE FILE
ORDER HERE [inaudible]
FOR OBERNOLTE AND WINS THE WINS
THE PRIZE -- I'M SORRY IT WILL
COVER KNOWN OVERNIGHT YES
MISERABLE.
NINETY FILE ITEM.
SIX EIGHTY THREE NINETY FOUR AND
THEN MISTER KALRA NAY MISTER
GRAY.
MY APOLOGIES. THREE NINETY FOUR
IS THAT CORRECT YES OKAY VERY
GOOD I LIGHT A PRESENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I'M
SURE EVERYONE IN THE ROOM IS
AWARE OF THE INCREDIBLY
DESTRUCTIVE CAMPFIRES OF LAST
YEAR.
THAT WAS THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
FIRE IN CALIFORNIA STATE HISTORY
ALSO THE DEADLIEST WILDFIRE IN
CALIFORNIA STATE HISTORY
EARLIER THIS YEAR -- I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TOUR THE
DEVASTATED TOWN OF PARADISE AND
IT WAS INCREDIBLY POIGNANT
EXPERIENCE FOR ME. TO SEE THE
DEVASTATION THAT WAS WROUGHT IN
THAT COMMUNITY. TO ME THE MOST
SURPRISING FACT OF THAT ENTIRE
VISIT WAS TESTIMONY THAT WE
RECEIVED FROM THE FIRST
RESPONDERS THAT WERE THERE IN
PARADISE.
THE DAY OF THE FIRE.
AND THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT HOW
ALL OF THE EGRESS ROUTES OUT OF
PARADISE WERE COMPLETELY CLOGGED
BECAUSE THE WILDFIRE HAD MOVED
SO RAPIDLY IN FACT THEY TOLD US
ABOUT PEOPLE SHELTERING IN PLACE
IN THEIR CARS.
IN INTERSECTIONS BECAUSE THAT
WAS THE WIDEST PLACE THOSE
PEOPLE COULD FIND TO GET AWAY
FROM THE FLAMES UNFORTUNATELY
MOST OF THOSE PEOPLE SURVIVED
BUT WE WILL NOT BE THAT LUCKY.
AGAIN.
PARADISE HAS FOR EGRESS ROUTES
AND ALL FOUR OF THOSE WERE
COMPLETELY CLOGGED THE DAY OF
THE FIRE.
I REPRESENT A LOT OF PLACES IN
OF MY DISTRICT THAT HAVE EVEN
WORSE EGRESS THE GROUCH THAN
THAT IN FACT WHERE I LIVE IN THE
CITY OF BIG BEAR LAKE WE ONLY
HAVE THREE EGRESS ROUTES.
SOME PLACES HAVE EVEN TWO OR ONE
THE COMMUNITY OF IDYLLWILD WHICH
I'M SURE PEOPLE ARE FAMILIAR
WITH HAS ONLY ONE EGRESS ROUTE
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
DEVASTATION THAT WOULD BE
WROUGHT.
IF A SIMILAR WILDFIRE WITH
THROUGH THERE THIS BILL AB THREE
NINETY FOUR CREATES A VERY
NARROWLY CRAFTED EXEMPTION TO
SEEK WORK FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION.
OF EGRESS PROJECTS IDENTIFIED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY.
WE'VE GONE THROUGH A NUMBER OF
COMMITTEES HERE TAKING
AMENDMENTS AT EACH STAGE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE CRAFTING A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT STRIKES AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN THE
NEED TO PROTECT.
THE ENVIRONMENT TO BE DELIBERATE
ABOUT PROJECTS ON THE ONE HAND
AND THE NEED TO CREATE THESE
BADLY NEEDED.
HE CHRIS ROUTES ON THE OTHER SO
WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALL YOU KNOW WHAT AND I I MIGHT
SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
MISTER CHAIR.
FOR BY YOUR WORK ON THIS -- BILL
WE CERTAINLY WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
SO MUCH -- PLEASE WRITE AT JOHN
KENNEDY WITH RC RC ON BEHALF OF
THE WORLD COUNTIES ARE COUNTIES
CONTAINED THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE STATE'S FOREST LANDS AND
WE'VE SEEN.
A LOT OF THE MOST RECENT
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN OUR
JURISDICTION.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT'S A MODEST STEP FORWARD TO
IMPROVING IGRE S. FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE A
SECONDARY EGRESS ROUTE.
IT'S BUILT UPON AB TWENTY NINE
ELEVEN FROM LAST YEAR THAT WAS A
FRIEDMAN BUILDER REQUIRES THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY TO GO OUT AND
IDENTIFY THOSE COMMUNITIES
LACKING A SECOND EGRESS ROUTE --
AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON
PROJECTS TO IMPROVE SAFETY FOR
THOSE COMMUNITIES SO THIS BILL
PROVIDES AN ERA SEQUEL EXEMPTION
IT DOES PROVIDE A NUMBER OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFEGUARDS
PROTECTING SPECIES PROTECTING
HABITATS -- PROTECTING WATER
COURSES RIPARIAN AREAS --
REQUIRES COMPLIANCE WITH THE
FORCE PRACTICES ACT -- PROTECTS
HISTORICAL AND ARCHAEOLOGICAL
RESOURCES AND DOESN'T EXEMPT ANY
OF THESE PROJECTS FROM ANY OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS THAT ARE ON
THE BOOKS TODAY -- SO WE THINK
THIS IS NARROWLY TAILORED BUT
WILL PROVIDE A NUMBER OF
BENEFITS TO THESE COMMUNITIES
AND SUBDIVISIONS.
YES ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
YOUR SINGLE PARTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RESEARCHER CHRIS MY KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF MENDOCINO AND HUMBLED
REDWOOD COMPANIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANKS SO
MUCH.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
STILL HERE FOR ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION THE CIVIL JUSTICE
CESSATION CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JOHNSON CLAIMED AFTER THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WELL YOU NEVER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DOLLARS BILL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANKS SO MUCH.
I WAS IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
TING.
NINE DO ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING.
NINE CAN BRING IT BACK TO THE
DíAS ALTHOUGH WAS CURIOUS ABOUT
THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO -- DO YOU
MIND I DON'T NEED TO CALL YEAH
BUT I DID HAVE A QUICK QUESTION
MAYBE THE AUTHOR CAN HELP
CLARIFY TO I KNOW WE WRESTLED.
WITH THIS ISSUE A BIT ANY CUSA
SOME OF IT IS GERMANE AND SOME
NOT TO THIS COMMITTEE BUT JUST
IN TERMS OF THAT.
THE LOCAL APPROVAL PROCESS AND
HOW IT WAS SORT OF STAGE ITSELF
OUT BOTH IN SAN DIEGO AND RURAL
COUNTIES CAN YOU GUYS CAN YOU
WALK US THROUGH -- PROCESS SAFE.
CENTER ALLEN ARE BOTH IN LA
COUNTY I THINK WE'VE GOT -- ON A
REYES AND BARBARA -- HOW HOW DID
HOW OLD IS ACTUALLY FUNCTION --
SO NO SEQUEL PROCESS BUT THERE
IS A PROVISION TALK ABOUT
LEADING AGENCY DETERMINATION OF
OF IT AVAILABILITY OF FUNDING
BUT ALSO ALL LOCAL APPROVAL SO
WHAT WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE
THOSE LOCAL APPROVALS BEING AND
JUST.
WATER SO WHAT THE PROCESS ADAM
WE ARE INCLUDING -- PUBLIC
NOTIFICATION AND A HEARING ON
THIS WHERE COMMENTS ARE RECEIVED
AND RESPONDED TO BY THE LOCAL
AGENCY -- SO THE PROCESS REALLY
STARTS AND BOARD OF FORESTRY
THEY IDENTIFY THE COMMUNITIES
THEY RECOMMEND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT SHOULD
BE DONE -- FROM THAT POINT
FORWARD IT WOULD BE UP TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO CHOOSE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE PROJECT OR
NOT -- I'M SURE SOME LOCALS WILL
NEED SOME RESOURCES SOME MAY
HAVE THE RESOURCES IN PLACE SOME
MAY BE SEEKING MORE RESOURCES
FROM THE STATE -- SO FROM THAT
DECISION POINT I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT YOU BUT NOT THAT LOCAL
DID WHEN THEY CHOOSE OR NOT IS
THAT THAT'S ABOUT OF SOME KIND
OF CONDITIONAL USE PERMIT DOES
IT IT SORT OF DEPENDS ON THE
EXISTING USE OF THAT.
THAT EGRESS THROUGH LIKE IF
THERE'S ALREADY EXISTING FIRE
ROAD SAY RIGHT AND SO THERE
COULD BE AN EXISTING FIRE ROAD --
THAT IS EITHER CLOSED OFF ITS
UNPAVED ON IMPROVED -- IT'S
CLOSED SO PEOPLE CAN'T USE IT --
SO THERE COULD BE A MINOR
PROCESS TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THOSE TYPES OF PROJECTS IS THAT
A MINISTERIAL DECISION THERE OR
WOULD THAT BE A DISCRETIONARY
ONE FOR A LOCAL GOVERNMENT JUST
USE FOR EXAMPLE I MEAN IN THE
SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS WITH FIRE
ROADS GOING ALL THROUGHOUT.
AND THAT THAT WAS MY CENTRAL
CONCERN IN ANY QUEUE TO TRY TO
WORK THROUGH THIS.
IT WAS LIVES ON THE LINE.
WE GET THAT THIS IS SERIOUS
STUFF MEAN GO SOMEWHERE LIKE TO
PAY A CANYON AND YOU KNOW THAT
FIRE HITS WRONG DESPITE ALL THE
PREPARATIONS DONE.
WE MAY LOSE LIFE.
THERE'S A V. ARE VERY REAL
OPPORTUNITY BUT THERE'S ALSO ALL
THESE WINDING FIRE ROADS ALL
THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITY -- BOTH
IN ANY CORPORATION DâN
INCORPORATED AREAS SO JUST
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF THAT
THIS IS.
YEAH IT'S IT'S PROBABLY TRUE IN
OTHER JURISDICTIONS AS WELL BUT
IS THERE A DISCRETIONARY
DECISION THAT THAT THAT THAT
COUNTY.
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE MAKING IN
THAT CIRCUMSTANCE AND AND WHAT
WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE WITHOUT
SEEK HUESO THERE VERY WELL COULD
BE -- AND WOULD GO THROUGH THE
NORMAL PLANNING PROCESSES FROM
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO NORMAL
APPROVAL PROCESSES -- THE ONLY
THING THAT WE'RE DOING AS
EXEMPTING THESE PROJECTS FROM
SEEK WAS SO -- THAT'S A BIT OF
INSULATION FROM POTENTIAL
LITIGATION AND IT'S ALSO SAVING
RESOURCES FOR THESE TYPES OF
PROJECTS -- AND DELAYS THAT MAY
BE ASSOCIATED WITH PREPARING
DOCUMENTS AND LITIGATION -- SO
YOU'D STILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH
AND OBTAIN ANY OTHER PERMITS
THAT ARE REQUIRED FOR THE S. R.
THE IT DEPENDS ON THE PROJECT SO.
SO I'M SAYING TAKE A THE IF
THERE'S GOING TO BE ANY IMPACT
TO A WATER CORES -- YOU MIGHT
HAVE TO LOOK AT STRING THAT
ALTERATION PERMITS AND
MITIGATING ANY IMPACT.
WE'VE TRIED TO BUILD AND BUFFERS
AND TO THE BILL THAT BASICALLY
SAY THE PROJECT CAN'T CONTAIN A
WETLANDS ARE RIPARIAN AREA -- SO
WITH RESPECT TO ESSAYS AND
PERMITS UNDER THE ESSAY -- FOR
THOSE SPECIES THE PROJECTS CAN'T
IMPACTS THOSE SPECIES SO IT
DEPENDS ON STATE PERMITS OR
TALKING TO STREAM THAT
ALTERATION PERMITS AND SO THOSE
WOULD BE STATE PERMITS ESA AT
YEAH AND I MENTIONED YESTERDAY I
MENTIONED.
YOU SEE SO -- YEAH SURE -- SO
THERE COULD BE STATE PERMITS ANY
LOCAL PERMITS THAT MIGHT APPLY --
MAYBE SENATOR CAN SPEAK MORE TO
ENSURE MORE URBAN KIND OF COUNTY
JUST GIVE GIVE A SENSE OF WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT HERE SO JOHN
THE CAN DOWN THE COUNTY SAN
DIEGO MORE URBAN BUT WE HAVE A
HUGE BACK COUNTRY ARE IN.
FACT WE ACTUALLY WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE A DECADE AGO ON A
HOLLINGSWORTH TO CHENEY BILL
WERE.
LOOK AT SIMILAR CONCEPT OF
TRYING -- TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
DO BRUSH CLEARANCE AND OTHER
THINGS AROUND EGRESS IDENTIFIED
EGRESS AND FIRE SAFETY ROUTES
FOR COMMUNITIES -- SO FROM THAT
AGAIN IT WAS A GOOD LOOKING AT
SEA CA TRYING TO SPEED UP THE
PROCESSAT THAT POINT IS BECAUSE
WE HAD OUR OF FUNDS COMING FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR BRUSH
CLEARANCE -- AND WE'D EXPORTED
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
WEEKS AGO OUT THIS HETHER YOU
DO A MASTERY AYE ARE.
AND THEN TEAR PROJECTS OFF OF
THAT BUT I THINK THAT'S WHY
WE'RE SUPPORTINGTHIS WE THINK
THIS IT'S BEEN SOMETHING AS THE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO WE STRUGGLED
WITH AND WE THINK THIS MAKES AS
IS A GOOD BALANCE AND MAKES IT --
SENSE BUT THERE ARE I'M NOT A
BELIEVER SO ALL THE LOCAL
PERMITS BUT I THINK -- MISTER
KENNEDY REALLY HAD ON IT THAT
THERE'S A WHOLE NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT WE HAVE TO DO.
THIS FROM THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO'S
PERSPECTIVE WE ALSO WOULD
IDENTIFY THESE THERE ARE FIRE
IT'S ALREADY -- THERE BE THE
PUBLIC NOTICING THE PUBLIC --
HEARINGS THAT I'D SAY THAT
IDENTIFICATION BY THAT'S
ACTUALLY VERY IMPORTS OF THE
COUNTY ITSELF HAS ALREADY.
IDENTIFIED BY THE I DON'T KNOW I
I DON'T I HAVE TO FIND OUT AND
GET BACK TO THE COMMITTEE BUT I
THINK OUR FIRE RESTORED HE DOES
IDENTIFY WHAT ARE THE CRITICAL
EGRESS ROUTES FOR COMMUNITIES.
BUT I CAN BE I CAN VERIFY THAT
AND GET BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
DID YOU WANNA MAKE A COMMENT ON
THAT I I I'M TRYING TO BE
SENSITIVE TO THIS ISSUE AROUND --
USING EGRESS AS A PROXY FOR
DEVELOPMENT -- AND AND TRYING TO
SORT OF PREVENT.
THAT BACK DURING ESSENTIALLY OF
NEW DEVELOPMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
GOING IN.
WHEN WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO WITH
HIS CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE
AND IT'S HARD TO SAY OKAY NOW
YOUR BILL TO ROAD?
YOU CAN'T USE IT FOR ANYTHING
ELSE BUT LEAVING DURING A FIRE
THAT'S JUST PROBABLY NOT HOW
IT'S GOING TO BE I THINK THAT
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT THAT
YOU BROUGHT UP AND I THINK. TO
BE CLEAR.
THESE PROJECTS DO NOT PERCOLATE
UP FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL IT'S THE
OPPOSITE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY IDENTIFIES.
THE AYE COMMUNITIES IN PROJECTS
THAT HAVE INSUFFICIENT EGRESS
AND THOSE ARE THE ONLY PROJECTS
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
LIMITED SEQUEL EXEMPTION THAT
THIS BILL -- THAT THIS BILL
OFFERS AND THEN IT WOULD REQUIRE.
PARTICIPATION AND BY AND FROM
THE LOCAL AGENCIES TO SAY FROM
THEIR POINT OF VIEW YES WE'RE
GOING TO UNDERTAKE THIS PROJECT
SO IT'S DEFINITELY GOING TO BE A
COLLABORATION AND BOTH PARTIES
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO AGREE AND
AS WAS TESTIFIED -- THERE'S
PUBLIC INPUT IN THIS PROCESS TO
THE BILL REQUIRES PUBLIC
HEARINGS BEFORE THAT WOMEN
EXEMPTION IS GRANTED.
UNDERSTOOD.
YEAH THAT'S THAT'S HELPFUL I
MEAN I THE MAIN THING IS I WANT
I WANT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE MAINTAIN
DISCRETION FOR COUNTY OR CITY TO
SAY YOU KNOW.
UP TO THE BOARD OF FORESTRY THIS
MAY MAKE SENSE BUT FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE HERE.
THERE'S TOO MANY RISKS IN THIS
PARTICULAR REGION TO HAVE THAT
DISCRETION TO SAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
WHERE WHERE IT'S APPROPRIATE AND
WE'RE NOT -- I THINK WE'LL
MATTER I'M I'M STILL OPEN THOUGH
HERE BUT I DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
DIES AT I THINK THAT THE REASON
I I YOU KNOW I SHARE YOUR
CONCERN AYE AYE I CERTAINLY
THINK [inaudible]
I'M.
AYE AYE AYE IT'S NOT WHAT I I
GUESS IS THERE HAVE YOU LOOKED
INTO TRYING TO TIGHTEN UP THE
LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE INTENT AS STATED BY THE
AUTHOR.
IS REALLY GONNA BE AFFECTION
WAITED HERE BECAUSE I I SHARE
YOUR CONCERN.
I THINK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
VERY LIMITED AND SPECIAL SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES YOUR THAT'S WHY
DON'T HAVE OPPOSITION FROM RIGHT
ARMENIANS IN THE REMOTE
COMMUNITY.
YEAH NOT NOT TO FLIP IT BACK --
BUT THE AS THE CHAIR VQ I THINK
YOUR JURISDICTION ALL OVER THIS
SEQUEL ISSUES IS SORT OF THE THE
AT LEAST JURISDICTION ONLY THE
THE APPROPRIATE VENUE TO TO PUT
THAT CHECK -- I WAS AND I I
DON'T WE WOULDN'T BE UPSET IF
YOU.
AYE AYE.
YEAH.
YEAH WELL WE CAN WORK TOGETHER
YOU -- TO ONE ROAD PLAY TOO MUCH.
FROM THE DIS HERE BUT I I DIDN'T
WANT TO HAVE YOU GIVEN THOUGHT
TO THIS AND SORT OF HOW TO MAKE
CLEAR WHAT THE LIMITS ARE THE
CONSTRAINTS ARE SO THAT WE CAN.
SORT OF MAINTAIN THAT DICRETION
AND I'M THINKING A MULTI ROADS
RECOMMENDATIONS COMING IN.
TO THIS IS IN AMOUNTS SANTA
MONICA MOUNTAINS REDUCE GO I
MEAN THERE'S IT'S GOING TO KEEP
COMING UP WITH MEMBERS TO JUST
HOW TO GET THAT REASSURANCE
BUILT INTO THIS FRAMEWORK -- YOU
GIVEN ANY THOUGHT TO THAT ANY
BUILT IN SUSPENDERS FOR INSTANCE
SAY.
TO THAT -- THE B. B. TWELVE
SEEMS LIKE THE MOST -- RIGOROUS
PORTION IN TERMS OF WHERE THE
LEAD AGENCY DETERMINES THE
PROJECT IS A PAIN THERE IS ABLE
TO OBTAIN ALL NECESSARY FUNDING
AND ANY STATE FEDERAL OR LOCAL
APPROVAL AND LOCAL APPROVALS
WITHIN ONE YEAR THE FILING.
IT IS YOURS IS THERE ANYTHING IN
THERE THAT WE CAN SORT OF DUE.
TO MAKE CLEAR THEY'RE STILL
DISCRETION FOR LOCAL STATUS SAY
NO PROBLEM IN LOOK IS SOMEONE
WHO CAME UP FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AS A LOT OF US DID I
CERTAINLY BELIEVE THE AND THAT
FORMER LOCAL CONTROL.
AND WE TOOK WE CRAFTED THE BILL
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE LOCAL
BY AND AND HONESTLY I CAN'T
IMAGINE.
HOW A PROJECT LIKE THIS WOULD
EVER BE DONE AND ACCOMPLISHED
WITHOUT?
THE ACTIVE ADVOCACY NOT JUST THE
DAHLE TACIT APPROVAL BUT THE
ACTIVE ADVOCACY OF THE LOCAL
AGENCIES INVOLVED SO I'M
CERTAINLY OPEN TO ANYTHING THAT
THAT WOULD ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS I THINK THAT THE BILL
AS WRITTEN.
ALREADY MAKES IT CLEAR THAT THE
LEAD AGENCY IS A LOCAL AGENCIES
THIS ISN'T THE STATE COMING AND
SAYING YOU MUST DO THIS -- BUT A
I'M OPEN TO SUGGESTIONS.
I GUESS THAT'S THAT'S THE
CRITICAL POINT FROM A FROM A
SEQUEL PERSPECTIVE LEAD AGENCY
IS STILL LOCAL -- SELECTION
PROCESS IN ELIGIBILITY PROCESS
COMES ON BOARD OF FORESTRY.
BUT THAT DISCRETION STILL
ESSENTIALLY LIES WITH THE LEAD
AGENCY TO SAY.
YES IN THE FIRST PLACE -- OKAY
ABSOLUTELY -- THANK YOU THAT'S
VERY HELPFUL YES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR.
BRINGING THIS FORWARD YOU MADE
THE REFERENCE TO SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES IN PARADISE.
I'D ALSO HEARD THAT THERE HAD
BEEN SOME PLANNING. TO HAVE A
BUFFER ZONES ALONG AT LEAST ONE
ESCAPE GROUP WHERE THEY TURNED.
TWO LANES INTO BOTH EXIT LANE
SENATE THAT ADVANCE PLANNING
ACTUALLY DID RESULT IN SAVING
LIVES IN PARADISE AND WELL.
IT OBVIOUSLY WASN'T ENOUGH TO
SAVE.
THE LIVES THAT PERISHED FROM.
IT DOES PROVIDE AN EXAMPLE OF
THE IMPORTANCE -- IT COULD HAVE
BEEN A MUCH HIGHER.
DEATH TOLL.
I JUST THINK GIVEN OUR CURRENT
CRISIS IN THIS STATE AND
HOPEFULLY.
WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE MORE.
DAY STORIES THIS FIRE SEASON.
WE NEED TO GET MOVING ON THIS IN
FAMILIES NEED TO BE EDUCATED IN
THE PROCESS IS WELL.
YOU KNOW WE IN EARTHQUAKE
PREPAREDNESS.
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE SUPPLIES.
COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS WITH
FAMILY ETCETERA WELL WE NEED TO
UP THAT.
VIGILANCE IN.
IN FAMILIES REALLY NEED TO BE
EDUCATED S. THESE.
GRASSROOTS ARE DEVELOPED SO I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD READY TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY.
ARM THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENT I
WOULD JUST ASK.
THE BILL MOVES FOR TODAY.
pWITH THE COMMITTEE IF THERE ARE
ANY AYE AYE I KNOW IT'S A BIG
COMMITMENT IT AFTER MAKING BUT
TO LOOK AT WHETHER THERE'S ANY
BELT AND SUSPENDERS WE NEED TO
PUT ON THIS.
AND ESPECIALLY PENDING SOME OF
THAT FEEDBACK I THINK FROM
COUNTY SAN DIEGO I'D LIKE TO
KNOW FROM LA COUNTY.
WHERE THEY SIT WITH THIS?
BEFORE WE BRING THIS THING ALL
THE WAY TO THE FLOOR AND GO FOR
IT.
SO I DID I THINK THE DILIGENCE
WILL BE IMPORTANT SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO MEET SO MANY ANTICIPATED
BACKLASH AND MAKE CLEAR.
WHAT THIS BILL IS AND WHAT IT
ISN'T?
RIGHT AND I APPRECIATE THE INPUT
FROM REALTORS AN APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION BUILDING INDUSTRY
BUT THAT SENDS A CERTAIN SIGNAL
IT SAYS LIKE.
YOUR BILL THIS IS ABOUT BUILDING
AND WHAT I'M HEARING YOU SAYING
THIS ABOUT FORCE YOU TO
TERMINATION ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO -- ARE YOU OPEN TO TO THAT
SHOULD THE BILL FOR JUST TRYING
TO THINK THROUGH SOME.
WAIT IS SIR TO SHORE UP THIS
THIS LEADING.
ZERO IF THE CONCERN IS THAT.
THE BOARD WOULD FORCE ONE OF
THESE IGRICE PROJECTS ON A
COMMUNITY AND A LEAD AGENCY THAT
DID NOT WANT IT.
THAT.
THAT THIS IS ONLY INTENDED TO BE
DONE WHEN THERE'S A COOPERATION
BETWEEN THE BOARD AND THE LOCAL
AGENCIES SO I'M HAPPY TO WORK
WITH I THINK YOU ARE.
I THINK YOU YOU JUST THAT
INTENSE CLARIFYING THAT INTENT I
THINK WOULD BE EVERYTHING THAT
CONCISE STATEMENT YOU MADE THERE
SO MAYBE WE CAN EVEN JUST WORK
ON THAT FINDING AT THE DOOR.
OKAY VERY GOOD.
WELL -- I WOULD ENTERTAIN THEM I
THINK THERE WAS A MOTION CENTER
MINING OR FROM THE VICE CHAIR.
AND THE VICE -- ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
WAS THERE ANY FURTHER COMMENTS
OR PLEASE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
ROBUST BEROSSUS CASH IN ON THIS.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW POIGNANT
EXPERIENCE WAS TO TO BE IN
PARADISE AND HEAR THE TESTIMONY
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SHELTERING IN
INTERSECTIONS IN FIELDS BECAUSE
ALL OF THE EGRESS ROUTES WERE
CLOGGED.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN AT THE
STATE LEVEL TO ENSURE THAT THAT
DOES NOT HAPPEN.
AGAIN AND OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE EVEN WORSE YOU KRISTIN
PARADISE IN THIS IS JUST A SMALL
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION SO I'D
URGE ON AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MANY NUMBER AND LET
ME SAY I'LL I'LL BE SUPPORTER
TODAY -- RESERVING THE RIGHT UP
FOR THE FLOOR DILIGENCE DONE. TO
TO TO CHANGE THAT BUT I THINK
FOR FOR PURPOSES OF GOOD FAITH
HERE YOU MADE QUITE AN EFFORT
SAYS THANK YOU FOR THAT -- THE
MOTION IS BEFORE US -- AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- SO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL UNDERSTAND HI STERN AYE
JONES JONES I ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE FORGES CABALLERO
COMING ERA AYE HERTZBERG PLEASE
SO JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY NINE TO HIS.
OKAY A PHONE CALL LEAVE A
MEASURE OF CALL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
I THINK MISTER KALRA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN MEMBERS FOR THOSE FALLING
ON TV.
FOR FIFTY FOUR DEGREES SHERIFF
DOT TO PRESENT IT SENATE BILL
FORTY FOUR WHICH ADDRESS THE
DANGERS LOOPHOLE IN CALIFORNIA'S
WILDLIFE PROTECTION LAW.
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS. TO
THE BILL REMOVE OPPOSITION FROM
GROUPS OF SENDING OUT CULTURE ON
TIMBER INTERESTS AS WELL AS A
SORT INDUSTRY IN THE WESTERN
STATES.
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION.
AS WE SEE WITH OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES OF GREAT
IMPORTANCE CLEAN WATER CLEAN AIR
AND DANGEROUS SPECIES OFFER ALL
OIL DRILLING.
ATTEMPTS TO DISMANTLE FEDERAL
LAWS AND STANDARDS BUT
CALIFORNIAN THE CHALLENGING
POSITION OF HAVING TO SECURE
PROTECTION FOR OUR RESOURCES AND
ENVIRONMENT.
AB FOR FIFTY FOUR WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO
PROTECT BIRDS WHILE PROVIDING
CERTAINTY FOR INDUSTRIES WITHOUT
STARVING ECONOMIC GROWTH OR
RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS AVOIDING
THE CONFLICTS AND LITIGATION
THAT SURROUND.
EARLY IN THE MIGRATORY BIRD
TREATY ACT TODAY.
BY TERRY BIRDS HAVE BEEN
RECOGNIZING CALIFORNIA LAW IN
OUR COURTS AND IMPORTANT NATURAL
RESOURCE TO INTRINSIC VALUE FOR
THE STATE BUT ALSO PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT ECOLOGICAL ECONOMIC
RECREATIONAL BENEFITS.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO HUMAN
ACTIVITIES MANY MIGRATORY BIRD
POPULATIONS OF DECLINE
SIGNIFICANTLY FROM THE HISTORIC
NUMBERS AND THE STATE MUST BE
ABLE TO RESPONSIBLY MANAGE.
AND PROTECT PROTECT THEM TO
ENSURE THEIR NUMBERS NOT%
NEEDLESSLY DECLINED FURTHER.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY FOUR OF
FOUR SIMPLY MAKE SURE THE
CALIFORNIA THAT CALIFORNIA
RETAINS AUTHORITY TO MAKE ITS
OWN RULES REGARDING MIGRATORY
BIRD PROTECTIONS.
OF ALL IT WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA
TO MANAGE THIS CONSTITUTIONAL
PUBLIC TRUST AS POSSIBILITY TO
PROTECT PALMER WILDLIFE IN
BATTLE HABITATS AND WILL NOT
UNNECESSARILY TO FOR THEM TO THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT
WITH ME AS ONE MARRANO ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF POLICY THE ITEM ON
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ARE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE QUALIFY ME DONE
WITHOUT ABOUT CALIFORNIA -- AS
YOU ALL KNOW I'VE IS A BIRD
CONSERVATION OR ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO PROTECTING.
MIGRATORY BIRDS AND JUST BIRDS
IN GENERAL -- ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY -- AUDUBON UNDERSTAND
THAT MIGRATORY BIRD PROTECTIONS
MUST BE APPLIED IN A WAY THAT
BALANCES THE NEED OF SOCIETY
INCLUDING ECONOMIC DRIVERS.
AND THE ENVIRONMENT -- TO WE
HAVE LONG WORKED WITH OUR
CULTURE THE AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY
RENEWABLE ENERGY DEVELOPERS --
AND TO THAT END WE KNOW THAT WE
WILL ALWAYS CONTINUE WORKING --
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
SENSIBLE SOLUTIONS TO ANY ISSUES
THAT WE ARE COME ACROSS.
WE ARE SPONSORING BABY FOR FIFTY
FOUR BECAUSE IT WILL ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN CONTINUE TO
PROTECT MIGRATORY BIRDS.
AS IT HAS DONE FOR DECADES THE
BILL IS NOT INTENDED TO CREATE
ANY NEW LEGAL.
LIABILITIES AND IT WILL NOT STAY
ME RENEWABLE ENERGY DEVELOPMENT
OR OTHER ECONOMIC ACTIVITIES.
IT IS ABOUT ENSURING THAT THE
FEDERAL ROLL BACKS IN IT
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS DO NOT
UNDERMINE THE STATE LAW AND ITS
AUTHORITY.
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
MIGRATORY BIRDS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE INSIGNIFICANT DECLINE DUE TO
HABITAT LOSS DISTURBANCE OR
DIRECT TAKE OR KILLING FROM
HUMAN ACTIVITIES BIRDS PROVIDE.
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
RECREATIONAL AND ECONOMIC
ECOLOGICAL VALUE IN THE FOR THIS
IS FOR THE STATE.
WE CAN'T WE CAN'T AFFORD TO WE
CAN BIRD PROTECTION IN THE FACE
OF THE OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
OTHER CHALLENGES.
THAT BIRDS IN THE STATE FACE
INSTEAD WE MUST MAKE SURE THAT
WE PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL
RESOURCES FOR THE BENEFIT OF
FUTURE GENERATIONS -- AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
STATED A BEFORE FIFTY FOUR IS.
SEEKS TO MAINTAIN THE STATUS QUO
AT HAS YES IT HAS BEEN FOR
DECADES IN THE STATE -- BY
MERELY INSURING THE CALIFORNIA
DECIDES FOR ITSELF HOW TO
PROTECT MIGRATORY BIRDS WITHIN
ITS BORDERS.
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
URGE AN AYE VOTE ON THIS MATTER
MATTER THANK YOU. TOO MUCH
EITHER IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON FEDERAL AND ON
BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND US TO LET YOU KNOW DOORS
AND CALIFORNIA REALLY FALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANKS SO MUCH.
HI JENNIFER FEARING ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MORNING LUCAS FOR X. ABOUT THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING RICK AMOUNTS FOR
THE NOT A WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
BRIAN A WIKI CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT ALRIGHT THANKS.
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SORRY AROUND AN RTC IN SUPPORT.
VERY MUCH.
LISA I WANT TO BE ON A RAPTOR
ARE THE SOLUTION SOLUTION STRONG
SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD THANKS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKEDLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATER FOUND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANKS.
FOR THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF THE GRASS AND
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
NICHOLAS SECOND ON BEHALF OF
SUCH COMPASSION AND LEGISLATION
AND SUPPORT THANKS SIR.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL OUT OF
THE LOCAL THIRTEEN THANK YOU.
MARGIE SORT OF THE CASUAL
ALLIANCE WE SUPPORT THIS GOOD
THANKS -- ANTHONY LAWRIE ON
BEHALF OF EVERYBODY SINCE TWO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
AVERY CERRADO COMMUNITY MEMBER
FROM TORRENT SUPPORT IT VERY
GOOD -- ALLEN.
THE LONG TREK OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
YES PLEASE COME FORWARD.
DAMON FILIATION EVER CLAWSON
ABOUT -- SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION SUPPORT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIDE NEVADO STRONG
SUPPORT.
GREAT THANKS PRESENT BIRD
WATCHER FROM OAKLAND IN SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
LESLEY GOLDBERG ORGANIZER FOR
COMPASSIONATE BAY IN SUPPORT
THANKS.
CHRISTINA LEE YOU FROM BERKELEY
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DEALERS A CASKET FROM BERKELEY
AND COMPASSIONATE BAY I SUPPORT.
SIR.
FISH RODRIGUEZ FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU CAN PULL THAT MY BREAKDOWN
THAT SCIENCE HIGH OF ONE A CREEK
I SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MR AND FROM PALO ALTO AND I
SUPPORT THANKS.
ANA TOMLINSON PROJECT PEYOTE IN
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR WILDLIFE
REHABILITATED IN SUPPORT VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH.
A SENIOR CITIZENS FOR DOING IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
BUT MYSTERY.
WARNING WARNING.
IS RESTORING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS BY READ.
WITH READ GOVERNMENT LESSONS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CENTER
VALLEY FLOOD CONTROL ASSOCIATION.
THREE PRINCIPAL CONCERNS
ARGUMENTS AGAINST THE BILL --
FIRST AND FOREMOST THERE'S
PENDING LITIGATION ON THIS ISSUE
AND TYPICALLY POLICY COMMITTEES
IN THIS HOUSE AND AND OTHER
HOUSES.
TEND NOT TO TAKE UP LEGISLATION
WHEN PENDING LITIGATION IS UNDER
WAY -- IF CALIFORNIAN THE OTHER
SIX STATES SUCCEED I THAT
LITIGATION.
IN THIS ISSUE OF DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
CALIFORNIA GOES AWAY.
SO WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO HOLD THE BILL --
UNTIL THAT LITIGATION RUNS ITS
COURSE -- THE SECOND IS THAT.
EVEN UNDER THE CURRENT SITUATION
INCIDENTAL TAKE A STILL A
VIOLATION UNDER STATE LAW.
SO IT'S UNCLEAR AS TO WHAT THE
NEED FOR THIS LEGISLATION IS.
ONLY THE FOR THE FINAL IN THE IN
THE MOST CONCERNING FOR THE
ASSOCIATION MEMBERS IS.
THAT.
THE MIGRATORY BIRD TREATY ACT AS
A STRICT LIABILITY STATUTE.
NO INTENT NOTHING IF YOU KILL A
BIRD.
DESTROYED AND ASKED BREAK AN EGG.
YOU VIOLATED THAT STATUTE THE
BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A RATHER
NEBULOUS STANDARD OF
INCONSISTENCY.
IF IF IF.
FEDERAL LAW ARE THERE SOME
INCONSISTENCY WITH STATE LAW
THEN THAT WOULDCREATE AN ISSUE
AND THEN AS TO WHO TO TERMS
INCONSISTENCIES AND CONSISTENCY.
THE BILL IS SILENT ONE WOULD
ASSUME IT WOULD BE SOME OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
BUT WE DEAL WITH -- MULTIPLE
DISTRICTS FOR DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE AND THEY'RE NOT ALL
CONSISTENT WITH THEIR
APPLICATION OF THE LAW OR WITH
THEIR WORK IN THE FIELD --
FINALLY THIS MIGRATORY BIRD
TREATY ACT.
EVEN WITHOUT THIS BILL CREATES
VERY.
WRONG CONCERNS.
FOR STATE EMPLOYEES M. EMPLOYEES
OF LEVY MAINTAINING AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE.
UNDER A FEDERAL ASSURANCE
AGREEMENT THE CALIFORNIA ENTERED
INTO AND AN ASSURANCE AGREEMENT
THAT THE LOCAL MAINTAINING
AGENCIES FOR LEVEES ENTERED INTO
AT THE STATE.
WERE COMPELLED TO OPERATE
MAINTAIN LEVEES AND FACILITIES
OF THE STATE PLAN OF FLOOD
CONTROL PURSUANT TO THE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEER MANUALS.
SO WE'RE OUT THERE MOWING LEVEES
TAKING DOWN TREES BRUSH AND WHAT
HAVE YOU.
IN DOING THAT IN COMPLYING WITH
THOSE ASSURANCE AGREEMENTS.
AN EMPLOYEE BREAKS IN A DESTROYS
ANNOUNCED -- INADVERTENTLY YOU
KNOW TAKES A BIRD.
THEN UNDER THE STRICT LIABILITY
STATUTE.
THEY ARE SYSTEM THEY COULD BE
FACED WITH A FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
FINE AND UP TO SIX MONTHS IN
JAIL.
SO WE'RE PUTTING IN OUR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES IN OUR LOCAL AGENCY
EMPLOYEES AT RISK.
WITH -- WITH BILLS LIKE THIS AND
SO WE WOULD REQUEST -- THAT THE
BILL BE HELD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- MEMBERS
BRING BACK TO THE DAYS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
DO YOU WANT TO RESPOND AS SOME
OF THE ISSUES RAISED.
SURE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
HELLO BUT THIS BILL SEEKS TO DO
IS ESSENTIALLY -- AS WAS
MENTIONED BY THE BAR OR
WITNESSES WHAT'S BEEN STATUS QUO
OF THIS TREATY IS BEEN WE'VE
BEEN SIGNATORIES TO OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS UNTIL THE
ADMINISTRATION.
PUT US OUT OF IT -- OUR
INDUSTRIES -- HAVE DONE JUST
FINE OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
DECADES UNDER BOTH REPUBLICAN
AND DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATIONS
THAT HAVE SUPPORTED.
THIS TREATY.
AND ESSENTIALLY THIS -- BILL --
WOULD ACTUALLY.
CREATE EXPECTATIONS THAT
INDUSTRY CAN RELY ON AND THAT'S
WHY YOU HAVE SO MANY INDUSTRIES
PULL OFF OPPOSITION AND ALL IT
WILL WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE TO ACTUALLY
SET THOSE GUIDELINES AND
EXPECTATIONS OF BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES -- AND SO IT BECOMES
INSULTING.
THIS THIS TREATY AND THIS
PARTICULAR THIS PARTICULAR BILL
IN CONFORMANCE WHAT THE TREATY
HAS DONE OVER MANY DECADES
DOESN'T SAY THAT ABOVE.
A BIRD COULD NOT BE TAKING COULD
NOT BE KILLED YET THESE
BASSMASTER PRACTICES AND SO --
THERE'S REALLY NOTHING -- THAT
WILL PREVENT -- THE FLOOD
CONTROL ASSOCIATION AND ITS
MEMBERS WILL CONTINUE TO OPERATE
WITHIN OPERATED FOR MANY MANY
DECADES.
THERE'S NO REAL TO THERE'S NO
RISK OF INCREASED LIABILITY AT
ALL VERY GOOD.
YOU FOR THAT -- AND IT SEEMS YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT MAY SEEM SELF
EVIDENT -- IN TERMS OF THE
FISHING GAME -- CODE AND AND
SORT OF ENFORCEMENT THERE DIDN'T
SOUND LIKE THERE'S ANY VERSION.
TO THAT CLARIFICATION SO THAT
THAT SEEMS LIKE A A SOLVABLE
ISSUE AND THEN WHEN IT COMES TO
THE ISSUE RAN PENDING LITIGATION.
I MEAN THAT THE LITIGATION IS
ABOUT -- AN ABUSE OF DISCRETION
ESSENTIALLY FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THE
INTERPRETATION OF MIGRATORY.
BIRD TREATY ACT AND THE FACT IS.
I'M.
YOU KNOW REGARDLESS OF WHAT
DISCRETION NAY ONE EXERCISE I
THINK IT'S IN THE INTEREST OF
THE STATE TO DO ITS OWN PART
HERE AND LOOK AFTER OURSELVES --
AND NOT BE SUBSERVIENT HERE I'D
TO SOME OUTCOMES SO.
I'M I'M NOT PARTICULARLY
COMPELLED BY THAT POINT GIVEN
THE EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES
WE FIND OURSELVES IN WHEN IT
COMES THE STATE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
LAW IN THE STATE OF SCIENCE IN
WASHINGTON DC SO -- BUT I I
APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK THERE IN
THE CLARIFICATION ON THE INTENT
OF THE MEASURE -- MEMBERS ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
A MOVIE YES CENTER.
I I JUST WOULD LIKE -- TO
COMMENT THAT I I'M NOT GOING TO
BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY NOT
BECAUSE I DON'T BELIEVE WE
SHOULD.
SAVE MIGRATORY BIRDS IT
DEFINITELY AT A REAL ISSUE -- I
HAVE ONE OF THE LAST REMAINING.
WETLANDS AREA IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE ONLY REASON
IT WORKS IS BECAUSE THERE'S
FEDERAL LAND THEIR STATE LAND
AND THERE IS SIGNIFICANT PRIVATE
LAND IN.
AS PART OF THE CAN AT A
CONSERVANCY AND AND AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS.
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE PART OF
THAT CONSERVANCY ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL BUT I NEED TO
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT BETTER --
THE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY
THE CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD
ASSOCIATION -- THEY ARE.
OBVIOUSLY IMPACTED BY THE
DECISION THAT WE MAKE HERE TODAY
AND BY THE END IMPACT ON THIS
BILL AND I WENT UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE BIT BETTER.
WHAT KIND OF AMENDMENTS THEY ARE
SUGGESTING IF AT ALL -- BEFORE I
WOULD BE WILLING TO SUPPORT IT
ON THE FLOOR SO IT IT I MAY GET
THERE BUT I JUST HAVE TO SAY
THAT FOR TODAY -- MY I JUST DIE.
GIVEN GIVEN HOW MUCH TERRITORY
HAVE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
THE IMPACT IT CAN HAVE ON THE
OPERATIONS OF THE WORK THAT THEY
DO AROUND THE LEVY SOMEONE
ANDERSON AND A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
YOU SAID EARLIER -- I'D BE
WILLING TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION --
SO THAT'S A MOTIONS SENATOR
ALLEN LIGHT A CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR --
AND I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT.
THE THE FIVE FOUR CONTROLS ASIAN
AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
OPERATE EFFECTIVELY FOR DECADES --
UNDER THE RULES OF THE CARE AND
WILL ACTUALLY CREATE
EXPECTATIONS THERE'S A SENSOR
DATA GENERATE TWENTIETH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE THAT MAY BE
ABLE TO MEANT TO BE AMENDED TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT SOME POINT
DEPENDING ON WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
NEAR FUTURE.
AT THE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
LIBEL VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE MOTION IS TO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CENTER STERN HI STERN I'D
JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE FORGES CABALLERO
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HUESO JACKSON MONEY.
ON A NIGHT HAS THREE IT'S ON
CALL OKAY WE THE MEASURE ON CALL
WITH THREE VOTES -- AND I AM
GONNA NOW PASSED THE GAVEL TO MY
VICE CHAIR I'VE GOT TO GO
PRESENT IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE --
SO YOU'RE IN GOOD HANDS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY I BELIEVE IS NEXT --
SO WITH THAT [inaudible]
COMMITTEES YOURS [inaudible]
OKAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY IS -- FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIX THIRTY EIGHT MR GRAY.
THANK YOU -- THIS CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'D LIKE -- TO FIRST OF
ALL THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE NOW SYSTEM THE SUGGEST
AMENDMENTS WHICH I THINK IMPROVE --
THE LEGISLATION -- THE NOTION
HERE MEMBERS IS SO WE'RE FACING.
A CRISIS IN CLIMATE CHANGE --
AND HOW WE STORE AND THE
STABILITY AND SUSTAINABILITY OF
OUR WATER SUPPLY -- IT.
IS FRONT END.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE A D. W.
R. TO LOOK AT THOSE IMPACTS AND
COME BACK WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE THE
NECESSARY.
ADJUSTMENTS TO SEE -- INSURE
BOTH THE SECURITY OF OUR
ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO -- OUR
ECONOMY AND OUR COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA GOING
FORWARD SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
FOR THE MERITS RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR VOTE ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BARBARY WITH READ GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ON BHALF OF THE
VALLEY AG WATER COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
THE MORNING ANTI ON A CITY HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS.
SO WHY I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT --
I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO IN THIS BILL -- THERE IS
NO QUESTION THAT.
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA
THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED AS MANY
TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO MEET THE
NEEDS.
ARE IN PARTICULAR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AT THE WATER THAT IT
NEEDS AND I THINK HAVING.
HAVING A HAVING THEM WATER BOARD
DO THAT ANALYSIS SO THAT WE CAN
START LOOKING AT WAYS TO BE ABLE
TO EXPEDITE WHETHER IT'S FLOOD
MAR WHETHER IT'S NO PACK WHETHER
ITS REPORT RE PURPOSING THE DAMS.
ALL OF THAT IS GOING TO BE PART
OF THE OF THE CHANGES WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO DO AND SO I
APPRECIATE THIS AND IF YOU DO
ANOTHER AMENDMENT I'D LIKE TO BE
ADDED.
AS A CO AUTHOR.
THIS COMPARES THAT EMOTION YES
MOVE THE BILL WE HAVE A MOTION
ANYMORE COMMENTS FROM THE DíAS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BUT MATT MOTIONS DO PASSED TO AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTERS STERN JONES BY JONES I
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BUSH'S CABALLERO
CAREER AYE HERTZBERG HUESO
JACKSON MONNING.
MONNING I THE BILL HAS FOUR
POINTS ON CALL.
IF YOU HAVE.
YOUR FOUR AFFIRMATIVE VOTES AND
THE BILL IS ON CALL.
AND THE JOB QUESTION.
OR COMMENT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU CENTERS THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT.
YEAH RIGHT RUBIO.
ARE YOU PRESENTING FOR WE'RE ON
THE JOINT AUTHORS.
OKAY.
BUT YEAH YEAH THAT'S WHAT I WAS
WONDERING YOU'RE TRYING.
TO INDICATE TO ME.
US SO -- MR GRAY'S AGAIN HER
PRESENT -- ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
SEVEN NINETEEN FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO -- WHO ADDED MISTER
GRAY IS INDICATING HE'S A CO
AUTHOR?
SO IF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THAT BILL CAN PREPARE THEMSELVES
MISTER GRAY YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
WE'RE WAITING ONE SECOND ON THE
ASSEMBLY ONE OF I MISUNDERSTOOD --
JUST WING IT
.
CHECK WITH HER STAFF.
OF A SERVANT JUDICIARY SOARING
TO BE HERE ALL DAY ANYWAYS SO.
WELL CERTAINLY BEEN IMPRESSED
WHICHEVER WITH THE BREVITY OF
THE SENATE HEARINGS.
WE TRY TO RUN A TIGHT SHIP.
I APPRECIATE YOUR FISHING THE
BREVITY AND ALSO AT THE SAME
TIME BREAKING IT UP.
HAPPY TO BE OF ASSISTANCE SIR
.
MEMBERS WHILE AWAITING A ARE YOU
AMENABLE TO TAKING UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND I TO GET
SOME BUSINESS DONE WHILE
AWAITING THANK YOU.
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
MR A MOVE BY MR MINING.
OF THESE OF THESE ITEMS OF
ANNOUNCED THE FILE ITEMS FOR
CONSENT TO FILE ITEM ONE AB ONE
THIRTY SEVEN FILE ITEM.
THREE EIGHTY TWO FIFTY SIX FILE
ITEM EIGHT A. B. FORTY NINE AND
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN A. B. NINE
FIFTY FIVE ARE ALL ON CONSENT WE
HAVE A MOTION.
LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
AND THERE'S STERN JONES JONES I
ALLEN FORGES CABALLERO.
HI HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON
MONNING.
MONEY NINE PUT BACK ON CALL.
FOR OTHER MEMBERS.
OF THAT BACK ON FILE FOR THE
MEMBERS
[inaudible]
YOUR REPRESENT.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO PRESENT.
THE BEST TIME
.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO WELCOME
BACK -- WE ARE ON ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB.
SEVEN NINETEEN AND IF YOU'D LIKE
TO PRESENT WERE READY WHEN YOU
ARE THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
A. B. SEVEN NINETEEN WHICH SEEKS
TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE IMPORTANT.
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL CONSERVATION
COMMERCIAL AND MEDICAL RESEARCH
PURPOSES.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE SALE OF
THEM IMPORTATION OF GOODS MADE
OF ALLIGATOR AND A CROCODILE
PARTS WOULD BE COMPLETELY AND
TOTALLY BANNED IN CALIFORNIA AT
THE END OF THE CALENDAR YEAR.
THIS BAND IF ALLOWED WOULD BE
ENACTED I'M SORRY FOR ALLOWED TO
BE ENACTED WOULD HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT THE A WETLANDS AND
HABITAT CONSERVATION.
AND I'M GROUNDBREAKING MEDICAL
RESEARCH BEING CONDUCTED RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IT IS THIS.
IT IS THAT RESEARCH THAT I WANT
TO FOCUS ON RIGHT NOW.
AS A MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE WHICH APPROVED THIS
BILL IN APRIL I WAS VERY
INTERESTED TO LEARN ABOUT SOME
OF THE AMAZING MEDICAL SCIENCE
RESEARCH BEING CONDUCTED USING
VARIOUS ELEMENTS OF ALLIGATORS.
IT TURNS OUT THAT ALLIGATORS
HAVING EVOLVED AND SURVIVED OVER
MILLIONS OF YEARS HAVE A VARIETY
OF CHARACTERISTICS AND QUALITIES
WHICH ARE SHEDDING LIGHT.
AND HELPING RESEARCH INTO MANY
HUMAN CONDITIONS MUCH OF THIS
RESEARCH IS BEING DONE RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA -- CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITIES.
ALLIGATORS HAVE A NATURAL
DEFENSE AGAINST MANY INFECTIOUS
DISEASES THAT PLAGUE HUMAN SUCH
AS HIV AND GONORRHEA.
RESEARCHERS AT UC IRVINE ARE
CURRENTLY CONDUCTING RESEARCH IN
THE ANTI.
PROPERTIES OF ALLIGATOR BLOOD.
IN ADDITION THE CANCER RESEARCH
HAS GONE PER IT'S REALLY
PERSONAL TO ME.
I HAVE RECENTLY LOST A CLOSE
FRIEND AND MENTOR TO CANCER AND
IF THERE IS A POTENTIAL TO MAKE
PROGRESS ON CANCER RESEARCH WE
MUST ENSURE THAT THIS IS ALLOWED
TO CONTINUE. FOR WHATEVER REASON
IT APPEARS THAT SELLS AN
ALLIGATOR BLOOD ARE COMPLETELY
RESISTANCE TO CANCER.
STANFORD UNIVERSITY IS CURRENTLY
CONDUCTING CLINICAL TRIALS ON
TERM OR DIP TUMOR DIRECTED
IMMUNOTHERAPY DRUGS USING
ALLIGATORS.
I BOTH CSU SAN MARCOS AND CSU --
SAMPLER DINO RESEARCH IS BEING
CONDUCTED.
IN TWO CARDIOVASCULAR
CARDIOVASCULAR AND PULMONARY
QUALITIES FOUND IN ALLIGATORS
WHICH MAY HELP IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR PEOPLE
SUFFERING FROM STROKES.
USC IS ALSO CURRENTLY CONDUCTING
DENTISTRY RESEARCH INTO
ALLIGATOR CAPACITY TO DO
REGENERATE TEETH WITH THE GOAL
OF CREATING THAT QUALITY IN
HUMANS.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES OF
THIS TYPE OF GROUND BREAKING
MEDICAL RESEARCH BEING CONDUCTED
USING ALLIGATOR BLOOD.
TEETH BODY PARTS AS WELL AS
WHOLE ALLIGATORS.
SO HOW DOES THIS BILL HELP WITH
THE RESEARCH.
IN TWO WAYS FIRST.
IF THE CURRENT LAW BANGLES INTO
EFFECT.
ON JANUARY FIRST ALLIGATOR BLOOD
SERUM TEETH THE BODY PARTS
EXCEPT -- A WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
BE SOLD OR DONATED TO
UNIVERSITIES FOR THOSE
CONDUCTING RESEARCH USING
ALLIGATOR EGGS OR YEAR EARNINGS.
BUT COST OF THESE RESEARCH.
THE OPPOSITION CLAIMS THAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT EXPENSE HE
EXPENSIVE LUXURY GOODS MADE FROM
ALLIGATOR CROCODILE HIDES
PRODUCTS THAT THEY BELIEVE ARE
NON ESSENTIAL LUXURY GOODS.
I DO NOT OWN ANY OF THOSE
PRODUCTS BUT I DO CARE ABOUT THE
AMAZING MEDICAL RESEARCH THAT IS
BEING CONDUCTED AND THE NEED TO
PASS THIS BILL SO WE DO NOT
ELIMINATE OR INCREASE THE COST
OF THAT RESEARCH. TWO OTHER
QUICK POINTS WE MUST NOT FORGET
THAT THOSE PRODUCTS ARE SOLD BY
BOTH LARGE AND SMALL BUSINESSES
IN THE STATE.
THERE ARE FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MANUFACTURES OF SMALL LEATHER
GOODS HERE CALIFORNIA THAT USE
THESE LEGITIMATE HEIGHTS FOR
THEIR BUSINESSES AND HELP
WORKING PEOPLE PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE.
ALSO OUR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RECEIVE AN ESTIMATED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN SALES.
AND USE TAX REVENUES FROM THE
SALES OF THOSE PRODUCTS.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO REPLACE THE
REVENUE OF THE SALES OF PRODUCTS
ARE BANNED?
THIS BILL WOULD EXTEND THE
CURRENT LAW SUNSET BY FIVE
ADDITIONAL YEARS AND REQUIRED
THAT THOSE CONSUMER PRODUCTS BE
ACCOMPANIED BY A CONSUMER
DISCLOSURE.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO PASS THE
BATON OVER TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAY WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENTAL WETLANDS
IMPACT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. FOR SOME RUBIO THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CENTERS.
SHOULD THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
ALONGSIDE MY COLLEAGUE TODAY ON
A. B. SEVEN NINETEEN AS MANY OF
YOU ARE FAMILIAR SENATOR CAFIERO
AND I SHARE DISTRICT.
THAT IS HOME.
TO SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
PRODUCTIVE WETLANDS.
THE GRASSLANDS ECOLOGICALLY AREA
WHICH INCLUDES OVER A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
WETLAND HABITAT AND IS HOME. TO
AND SUPPORTS OVER TWO MILLION --
WATER FELL FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SHORE BIRDS. 50% OF WHICH USE
THE PACIFICFLYWAY JR MIGRATION
SO WHERE IMPORTANT PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S -- ENVIRONMENT
HABITAT AND AND SUSTAINING THAT --
HERE WE SEE EVERY DAY BACK ON
THE REAL WORLD IMPACT OF THIS
PRESERVATION.
AND ONE THING THAT'S OFTENTIMES
LOST INFOSYS'S WETLANDS ALSO
SERVED A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
CAPTION CARBON.
AS WE ALL STRUGGLE. TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS AND CHALLENGES CLIMATE
CHANGE.
UNIVERSITY SCIENCE FOUNDATIONS
OUR OWN.
CALIFORNIA HAS FOUND THAT
PROPERLY RESTORED MAINTAIN
WETLANDS CAN ACTUALLY SEQUESTER
UP TO FOUR TIMES THE CARBON PER
ACRE THAN FOREST SO THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT.
CONTRIBUTION MEMBERS NOT ONE TO
BE TAKEN LIGHTLY.
SO WHAT IS AB SEVEN NINETEEN
HAVE TO DO WITH WETLANDS IS
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T HAVE
ALLIGATORS MERCED COUNTY --
ALLIGATORS NATURAL HABITAT IS
WETLANDS AND COASTAL MARSHES IN
THE SOUTH.
EASTERN UNITED STATES IN THE
EARLY NINETEEN SEVENTIES WITH
ALLIGATORS ARE PLACED ON THE
ENDANGERED.
SPECIES LIST TO GO DWINDLING
POPULATION THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ALONG WITH STATE FISH
AND WILDLIFE DEPARTMENT -- AS
WELL AS ALLIGATOR FARMS JOINED
TOGETHER TO FORGE EFFORTS TO
RESTORE THE WETLANDS THIS
SERVICE NATURAL HABITAT. FOR
ALLIGATORS.
THESE EFFORTS ARE FUNDED
SIGNIFICANT BY FARMERS WHO
PURCHASE ALLIGATOR EGGS FROM
WELL IN ORDER FOR FARMING
PURPOSES.
ALLIGATORS ARE ONLY FOUND IN
NATURAL WETLANDS WHICH WOULD NOT
EXIST WITHOUT FARMERS
CONSERVATION MINDED
ORGANIZATIONS STATE AND FEDERAL
WILDLIFE AGENCIES WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY TO RESTORE THOSE
WETLANDS AS A SIMILAR TO WHAT
THEY DO -- BACK HOME IN MY
DISTRICT.
IN LOUISIANA ALONE THE REVENUE
FROM HARVESTING AND REPLENISHING
OF THE SPECIES EXCEEDS ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
THESE REVENUE SERVICE MATCHING
FUNDS.
WHICH THE WETLANDS CARETAKERS
USED TO OBTAIN FEDERAL WETLAND
CONSERVATION FUNDING.
CALIFORNIA YOU LET US IS THE
SAME CONSERVATION FUNDING FOR
ITS WETLAND RESTORATION
ACTIVITIES.
IF THE SALE OF THESE PRODUCTS
HAS BEEN IN CALIFORNIA IS
ESTIMATED TO FARMERS WILL
EXPERIENCE A 25% REDUCTION IN
THESE REVENUES.
OBVIOUSLY IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING
THAT CALIFORNIA'S A MASSIVE
MARKET AND CAN HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THIS ON
THIS -- ECONOMIC.
SITUATION.
BLUNTLY STATED OUR ACTIONS THEY
MEMBERS WILL IMPACT THE
RESTORATION AND MAINTENANCE OF
WETLANDS THROUGHOUT THE
SOUTHEASTERN UNITED STATES.
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF ACRES OF
THESE WEAPONS IN THE SOUTHEAST
MOST OF WHICH ARE THE NATURAL
HABITAT OF ALLIGATORS AND OVER
SEVENTY SEVEN HUNDRED OTHER
SPECIES.
OF FLORA AND FAUNA.
LATEST POPULATION SURVEYS
INDICATE THAT THERE ARE NEARLY
FIVE MILLION ALLIGATORS LIVING
IN WILD IN THOSE WETLANDS I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT.
THERE ARE ONLY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND ALLIGATORS LIVING
THE SAME WETLANDS WHEN THEY WERE
LISTED ON THE ENDANGERED SPECIES
LIST SO MUCH WORK HAS BEEN DONE.
THIS IS TRULY A SUCCESS STORIES
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS THE PRE
EMINENT EXAMPLE OF THE SUCCESS
OF THE ENDANGERED SPECIES
PROGRAM.
FINALLY I'LL POINT OUT THAT THE
MILLIONS OF ACRES OF WETLANDS
STORE MILLIONS OF TONS OF CARBON
KEEPING THAT CARBON FROM
ENTERING OUR ATMOSPHERE THAT
CARBON SEQUESTRATION IS POSSIBLE
ONLY WITH THE PREMIER
MAINTENANCE OF THOSE WETLANDS
MADE POSSIBLE.
BY THE REVENUES WERE DISCUSSING
TODAY.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT THE ALLIGATORS
IN THE OTHER SEVENTY SEVEN HER
FLORA FAUNA SPECIES THAT THRIVE
AND SURVIVE IN THE WETLANDS.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT CARBON
SEQUESTRATION I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU CONSIDER THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY.
AND BE HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN ANY
QUESTIONS LIKE TO REHAB SEVERAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME MEMBERS.
THANK YOU -- WHEN ISN'T SUPPORT
PLEASE MINUTES EACH?
THANK YOU CHAIR.
AND SENATORS. FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY I'M CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER FOR DUCKS UNLIMITED.
AND FORMALLY FOR ABOUT THIRTY
YEARS I WORKED IN THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
YEAH WITH THE FLORIDA FISH AND
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION COMMISSION
AND SERVED AS THEIR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR EIGHT YEARS.
WE'LL HAVE A LITTLE EXPERIENCE
WITH THIS ISSUE.
NOW IT DUCKS UNLIMITED WE'RE
DEDICATED TO CONSERVATION
AMERICA'S WETLANDS. FOR THE
BENEFIT OF WATER FOUND NUMEROUS
SPECIES OF FISH WILDLIFE AND
PEOPLE.
I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE YOU'RE
WEIGHING.
THE FUTURE OF A PROGRAM THAT HAS
MADE GREAT CONTRIBUTIONS. TO
WETLANDS PROTECTION ACROSS THE
SOUTHEASTERN UNITED STATES.
AND THIS IMPORTANT AT A TIME
WHEN WETLANDS ECOSYSTEMS
CONTINUE TO BE IN GREAT PERIL.
THE VERY EXISTENCE AND FUNCTION
OF WETLANDS ECOSYSTEMS AND MUCH
MUCH OF IT IN PRIVATE OWNERSHIP.
LEANS ON THE ECONOMIC VALUES
THAT CAN BE DERIVED FROM THE USE
OF THESE LANDS AND LANDSCAPES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE ECONOMIC
FACTORS.
HAVE DRIVEN AND CONTINUE TO
DRIVE WETLAND CONVERSION AND
LOSS.
CALIFORNIA HOWEVER IS RECOGNIZED
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
CONSERVATION AND CLIMATE CHANGE
MITIGATION AND FOR SERVING AS A
POSITIVE AND POWERFUL INFLUENCE
FOR PROACTIVE CONSERVATION
ACROSS THE NATION.
NOW THIS MAY COME AS A SURPRISE
TO SOME BUT I'D ARGUE THAT.
CALIFORNIA ALLOWING THE SALE OF
SUSTAINABLE ALLIGATOR PRODUCTS
YOU'VE DEMONSTRATED THAT
LEADERSHIP AND YOU'VE HAD GREAT
INFLUENCE IN PROTECTING WETLANDS
ACROSS THE SOUTHEAST TODAY.
YES THE FUNDING THAT FLOWS FROM
THE SALE OF SUSTAINABLE
ALLIGATOR PRODUCTS.
HAS GREAT BEARING ON PROTECTION
AND PRESERVING FUNCTIONAL
WETLANDS ALLIGATOR HABITAT.
AND HEALTHY POPULATIONS OF
ALLIGATORS ACROSS THE SOUTHEAST
SO YOU MAY BE ASKING HOW DOES
THIS WORK HOW DOES A CELL OF
ALLIGATOR PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA
CONNECT BACK TO WETLANDS IN
SOUTHEASTERN STATES.
BACK IN THE LATE EIGHTIES AS
THESE PROGRAMS ARE BEING
DEVELOPED I WAS ACTUALLY
INVOLVED IN THE DESIGN OF
FLORIDA'S ALLIGATOR PROGRAM WE
WORK WITH THE TEAM A
CONSERVATION BIOLOGIST PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS TO DESIGN A PROGRAM.
THAT DELIVER THE ECONOMIC VALUE
FROM THOSE PRODUCTS BACK TO THE
LANDOWNER BACK TO THE LANDSCAPE.
BACK TO INCENTIVES FOR
PROTECTING THOSE WETLANDS.
NOW LOOKING BACK OVER THIRTY
YEARS THIRTY PLUS YEARS.
AFTER THESE PROGRAMS OF AN
IMPLEMENTED AND BEEN IN PLACE
AND BIN MONITOR SCIENTIFICALLY
WE CAN DEFINITIVELY SAY THEY'RE
WORKING.
THEY'VE SERVED PROTECT WETLANDS
ACROSS THE SOUTHEAST.
THEY'VE SERVE TO BOOST ALLIGATOR
POPULATIONS NOT JUST THE STAIN
WE'VE GONE BEYOND SUSTAINABILITY
WITH A PROGRAM THAT ACTUALLY
BOOST.
AND ENHANCES ALLIGATOR
POPULATIONS AND THEREFORE
BENEFITS ALL THE SPECIES OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE MANY.
THAT ARE THREATENED AND
ENDANGERED THE MIGRATORY BIRDS
YOU'VE BEEN TALKINGABOUT.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE ACTUALLY A
BENEFIT FOR ALL OF THOSE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE WATERMAN SENATORS THANK
YOU ALL OF ROCK OR A CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES SOCIAIS SHOULD WE
HAVE THE IMMENSE PRIVILEGE OF
REPRESENTING -- ROUGHLY A
THOUSAND COMPANIES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA RANGING FROM -- BY
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES
ACADEMIC AND RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS MEDICAL DEVICE
MANUFACTURERS AND SMALL AND
MEDIUM SIZE STARTUP COMPANIES
THAT ARE DOING.
SOME OF THE VERY GROUND BREAKING
MEDICAL RESEARCH THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO ALLUDED -- TO THAT
RESEARCH IS BEING CONDUCTED INTO
INFECTIOUS DISEASES HIV CANCER
CHRONIC DISEASES CYSTIC FIBROSIS
ACHE -- FIBROSIS UE ME AND ANTI
MICROBIAL RESEARCH I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
SINCE THE ALLIGATOR WAS REMOVED
FROM THE ENDANGERED SPECIES LIST
IN -- NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THE
ROUGHLY THIRTY YEARS OF OF
RESEARCH HAS BEEN CONDUCTED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
WITHOUT SOME INCREDIBLE
ADVANCEMENTS -- IN OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF NOT ONLY HUMAN
ANATOMY BUT ANIMAL ANATOMY.
WE REPRESENT COMPANIES THAT MAKE
VACCINES FOR THESE ANIMALS TO
PROTECT THEM FROM WEST NILE
VIRUS THAT IN TURN PROTECT THE
ECOSYSTEMS IN WHICH THEY LIVE.
HI THRE ARE CRITICAL COMPONENT
OF OUR ABILITY TO KEEP DOING --
GROUND BREAKING RESEARCH INTO
DISEASES SUCH AS ALZHEIMER'S AND
OTHER NEWER DEGENERATIVE
DISEASES -- SO WITH THAT NUMBER
ANY OTHER TIME WE WOULD SIMPLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL -- AND DRIVERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
HE'S COMING FORWARD.
NAME AN AFFILIATION.
MR MEMBERS MARK SMITH ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY OUR PARTNERS A
DUCKS UNLIMITED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARIN
HIGGINS REPRESENTING VIACOM AND
IT'S OVER -- THIRTEEN HUNDRED
LIFE SCIENCES AND BIOMEDICAL
COMPANIES AND AT THE MED THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MR CHERRY THIRTY MILLION ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA GREEN
FEET ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR.
THE COOKING UNITS ON BEHALF OF
THE PET FOOD INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CATHERINE BRANDENBURG
REPRESENTING OUR PROTECTING
ENVIRONMENTS ANIMALS COMMUNITIES
AND HABITATS FOR THE LANDOWNERS
AND FARMERS AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT OKAY VERY GOOD
THANKS SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN NORWOOD ON
BEHALF OF HEARING OR ENGLAND AND
STRONG SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEING
NONE -- THOSE IN OPPOSITION YOU
HAVE TO WITNESSES AND THEN
OTHERS.
OTHER OPPONENTS CAN.
COME FORWARD AFTER THAT THANK
YOU ARE WE MAY BRING YOU BACK TO
SO THANK YOU GUYS [inaudible]
MORNING WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE URGING YOUR NO VOTE.
ON THIS BILL I'M A LITTLE
HISTORY ENACTED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY PENAL CODE SIX FIFTY
THREE OH WAS INTENDED TO KEEP
CALIFORNIANS FROM CONTRIBUTING
TO THE ILLEGAL TAKE OF
ENDANGERED WILD ANIMALS ACROSS
THE GLOBE.
THERE ARE TWENTY SIX SPECIES OF
ALLIGATORS CROCODILES CAME IN
SYNC AERIALS LISTED IN PROTECTED
UNDER THE CONVENTION ON
INTERNATIONAL TRADE IN
ENDANGERED SPECIES SPECIES OR
EXCITING.
AB SEVEN NINETEEN LIKE EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN WHICH STALLED
IN THE ASSEMBLY EARLIER THIS
YEAR UNDERMINES THE GOALS OF
PENAL CODE SIX FIFTY THREE OO.
WELL RECOVERY OF THE AMERICAN
ALLIGATOR AS WE'VE LEARNED AS A
SUCCESS STORY DUE TO THE EFFORTS
OF MANY AND THE PROTECTIONS
AFFORDED BY THE FEDERAL
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT.
WILD ALLIGATORS **** AND
CROCODILES AND CAME IS THE LIVE
OUTSIDE OF THE UNITED STATES ARE
FARING SO WELL.
THOSE ANIMALS FACE SIGNIFICANT
THREATS FROM HABITAT LOSS ANY
LEGAL KILLING TO FUEL MARKET
DEMAND FOR SKINS AND PRODUCTS
MADE FROM THEIR SKINS.
IN AN ANALYSIS OF WILDLIFE
SHIPMENTS FROM LATIN AMERICA
SEIZING UNITED STATES BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
UNCOVERED A WHILE THE TRAFFIC IN
CRISIS.
AND URGENT NEED TO STEP UP
EFFORTS TO STOP THE PERNICIOUS
TRADE AND IMPERILED SPECIES.
CAME IN AND CROCODILE SKINS WERE
TWO OF THE FIVE MOST ILLEGALLY
TRADED ANIMALS THE PRESSURE ON
THEIR SERVER THE PRESSURE ON
THEIR SURVIVAL IN THE WILD
DRIVEN BY COMMERCIAL DEMAND FOR
THEIR PARTS IS SIGNIFICANT.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY EXIST IN
HIGH NUMBERS IN FARMS OR IN THE
WILD IN ONE OR TWO STATES THE
UNITED STATES DOES NOT ALLEVIATE
THE FACT THAT THESE ANIMALS ARE
BEING DRIVEN TO EXTINCTION
OUTSIDE OF THE U. S..
CONSUMERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICALS CANNOT TELL THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PRODUCTS MADE
FROM LEGALLY FARM ANIMALS VERSES
ILLEGALLY WHILE CUT ANIMALS IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN US SPECIAL
WILDLIFE SERVICE RULING NOTED
THAT SMALL PARTS AND PRODUCTS OF
CROCODILIAN LETTER ARE NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO DISTINGUISH WHEN
MATED TO GOODS.
THAT'S HAMPERING THE
IDENTIFICATION OF LEGAL
ALLIGATOR PRODUCTS FROM THOSE OF
ENDANGERED OR THREATENED POCKET
ALIENS.
PROBLEMS OF THE DEDICATION COULD
INCREASE ILLEGAL TRADE IN
ENDANGERED CROCODILIAN PRODUCTS.
PAST LEGISLATIVE ANALYSES OF
PRIOR EXTENSIONS OF THE STRAIGHT
ALLOWANCE NOTED ONGOING CONCERNS
REGARDING ENFORCEMENT OF
SOCIETIES AND THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT AND ACTING AB SEVEN
ONE NINE WOULD WRONGLY SIGNAL
THAT SUCH CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED WHEN IN
FACT THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ADDRESSED
A ALL.
THE AMENDMENT MADE HASTILY IN
THE THE ASSEMBLY WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE IS FRANKLY
MEANINGLESS ALL THAT AMENDMENT
DOES REQUIRE THAT ALL ALLIGATOR
CROCODILE PARTS BROUGHT INTO
CALIFORNIA -- LABEL TO SAY THEIR
SITE IS COMPLIANT WITHOUT ANY
WAY TO CONFIRM THE RIVER AT CITY
OF THAT CLEAN.
EVEN THOUGH IT THIS INDUSTRY HAS
KNOWN FROM ITS INCEPTION THAT IT
WAS ENGAGING IN COMMERCIAL TRADE
OF PARTS FROM ANIMALS FACING
GLOBAL ILLEGAL TRAFFICKING RISKS
AND HAS KNOWN FOR FOUR YEARS
THAT IS MOST RECENT EXPANSION
WAS GOING TO EXPIRE IN
CALIFORNIA ON JANUARY ONE OF
NEXT YEAR.
AND HAS KNOWN THAT WILDLIFE
PROTECTION ORGANIZATION HAVE
RAISED ALARMS THAT THE MARKETING
OF ALLIGATOR CROCODILE PRODUCTS
WAS FEELING THE ONGOING
EXTINCTION OF SPECIES OUTSIDE
THE U. S..
THE INDUSTRY HAS FAILED TO EVEN
TRY TO SET UP A CREDIBLE
VERIFIABLE SYSTEM ESSENTIALLY
THIS INDUSTRY WANTS THE
LEGISLATURE TO GIVE THEM A
FOURTH EXEMPTION FROM
CALIFORNIA'S ILLEGAL WILDLIFE
TRAFFICKING POLICY WITHOUT DOING
ANYTHING MEANINGFUL IN A STATE
WHERE CRACKING DOWN ON WHILE
THEY TRAFFICKING HAS BECOME A
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
PRIORITY THE TIME HAS COME FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO SAY NO THANK
YOU.
AS YOU KEEP IT RELATIVELY SURE
WE LET HER GO OVER A LITTLE BIT
SORRY THING I TO WRITE A
PARAPHRASE IF YOU CAN'T.
NICHOLAS I GET SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION I JUST WANT TO SAY
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I DID
COMPLETE MY MASTERS IN STUDIES
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF BY IS IN
SPAIN. ONE THING YOU ALMOST NO
IS THAT SOCIETIES HAS NO ANIMAL
WELFARE OR ANIMAL.
PROTECTION REQUIREMENTS YOU CAN
KILL AND SLAUGHTER AN ANIMAL
ANYWAY YOU WANT UNDER SITE IS
AND BE STUDIES COMPLIANT WE HAVE
ACCESS TO INVESTIGATIONS OF
ALLIGATOR CROCODILE FARM
INVESTIGATIONS INTO BY WAY.
YET NAM AND IN TEXAS.
WE HAD.
IN ALL OF THE SKINS FROM THOSE
FACILITIES WENT TO LOUISVUITTON
AN ERROR MAYES.
EACH FACILITY CONFINED ANIMALS
IN GRAND BEREN AND TOTALLY
UNNATURAL CONDITIONS IN VIETNAM
MANY COCKTAILS LANGUISHED IN
CELL SMALLER THAN THE LENGTH OF
THEIR BODIES.
THE OPERATION IN TEXAS KEPT
ALLIGATORS IN DARK WAREHOUSES IN
PIZZA PUTRID WATER WITH A RISK
THAT REEKED OF RANCID EXCREMENT.
OUT WORKERS WERE THERE -- WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO SHOOT THE ALLIGATORS
IN THE SKULL WITH  CAPTIVE BALL
GUN TO RENDER ANIMALS IN
SENSIBLE BEFORE SIGN INTO THEM
WITH BOX CUTTERS.
BUT DURING OVER FIVE HUNDRED
SLAUGHTERS THIS IS NOT DONE ONE
TIME.
THEY CUT THE ALLIGATORS NECKS
AND SHOVED A ROD UP THEIR SPINAL
CORD COLUMNS IN ATTEMPTS TO PIT
OR SCRAMBLE THEIR BRAINS.
THE MANAGER HIMSELF STABBED FOR
CONSCIOUS ALLIGATORS WITH A
KNIFE TO DISLOCATE THEIR
CERVICAL VERTEBRAE AS A
SUFFERING ANIMALS FLAILED AND
STRUGGLE.
IN VIETNAM WORKERS ELECTRO SHOCK
CROCODILES IN ORDER TO
IMMOBILIZE THEM HACK INTO THEIR
NECKS IN RAMROD'S DOWN THEIR
SPINES NOT EVEN ATTEMPTING TO
DESTROY THEIR BRAINS FIRST.
A WE KNOW THAT ALLIGATORS HAVE A
VERY SLOW METABOLISM AND THEY
DIE VERY SLOWLY THIS IS.
INCREDIBLY PAINFUL THE WAY THEY
ARE SLAUGHTERED -- WE KNOW THAT
THEY SUFFER IMMENSELY IN THESE
CONDITIONS WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE
NOT FURRY AND CUDDLY LIKE.
THE ANIMALS THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING IN AB.
FORTY FOUR BUT THEY FEEL PAIN
ALL THE SAME THING WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO OPPOSE THIS
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD IF WE COULD
JUST TO NAME.
AND AFFILIATION.
SAMANTHA HOCKEY WITH THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
CAN A MCCARTY OF ONTO DISTRICT
LEADER THE MAIN STUDY THEY'RE
NOT THE UNITED STATES IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
KAREN SHOT PEOPLE FOR THE
ETHICAL TREATMENT OF ANIMALS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
VICTORIA ROOM WITHIN OUR DC IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
BRIAN -- WORKING WITH THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN
OPPOSITION.
THANKS.
RECALL MUSTARD ON AUTO TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND IN OPPOSITION.
WHEN CALLEN SMELL NINE
FOUNDATION AND OPPOSITION THANK
YOU?
CHRIS WHEN FROM OAKLAND IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANKS.
RUSSELL SACRAMENTO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER CANNON WITH HSUS AN
ELDORADO COUNTY IN OPPOSITION.
VERY MUCH.
LESLEY GOLDBERG EL SERENO
CALIFORNIA IT COMPASSIONATE BAY
IN OPPOSITION.
PATRICIA RODRIGUEZ SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA WITH THE XC IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT IS YEAH KEEP QUEUING UP HERE.
NEIL LAWRENCE MARIN COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
TOMLINSON PROJECT KOTV AND
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF WILDLIFE
REHABILITATED IS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE C. PLACATE ISN'T SAN DIEGO
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ERIN HOW HE APPROACH A CANADIAN
HUMANE SOCIETY OF UNITED STATES
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHEN THE MIDDLE SOURCE FOR
SOCIAL COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION IN OPPOSITION?
THANK YOU MA'AM.
JOHN FROHNMAYER FROM D. EXCEED
AND BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I'M
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
I AM PROUD TO THE SUIT FROM
MOUNTAIN VIEW CALIFORNIA DIRECT
ACTION NEVER EVEN IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANGELA WOMAN'S FRIENDS FOR
ANIMAL JUSTICE IN TXE AND I'M IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THAT MEANS EATING I'M IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT THANKS.
THIS KAREN PELADO WITH DIXIE AND
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
RUNNING A COLOGNE WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION VERY GOOD THANKS.
FIND OUT OF POLY WALNUT CREEK
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE IN UC
BERKELEY STRONG OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
SCOTT YOUNG SONOMA COUNTY WITH
THE X. THE OPPOSITION THANK YOU
SIR.
MAN VHS FROM CINEMA COUNTY AND
THE ACSI OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THERE IS A FEE FROM CINEMA
COUNTY THE XC OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
NO SMITH WITH BLOOMBERG OPINION
OPPOSITION.
MARCY BERMAN FROM MILL VALLEY
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
A THANKS.
IS ONE OF THREE D. FROM THE XC
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
NEVER COSTA NEVADO STRONGLY
OPPOSED.
THANKS THANK YOU SIDE NEVADO
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
BETH BROUGHT KILO COUNTY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
NATALIE NUMBER THE MATH ON NAPA
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE LABOR OAKLAND
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MARKET SLEEPER OAKLAND STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU SIR.
RIGHT NOW LOVE MILL VALLEY
STRONGLY OPPOSE OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH.
I AM DANTE SORE BE REDWOOD CITY
STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
I'M JOHN PRESTON I'M IN
SACRAMENTO I AM.
STRONGLY OPPOSED OPPOSED OKAY
THANKS.
EXAMPLES FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE.
THANK YOU MUCH.
WHICH IS A GOOD FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I JUST WALKED A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILES FOR ANIMALS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE THEN STORY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
NAMES CHRIS CLUB AS I ALSO JUST
TALKED A HUNDRED FIFTY MILES
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TAKE A FEW MORE STEPS.
GOOD LUCK THANK.
YEAH HELLO MY NAME IS ROCKY
SHALL FROM SERRES GO CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANGIE THIS MONDAY I'M
A DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE.
I WALKED A HUNDRED FIFTY MILES
TO EXPERIENCE ON WAS SUFFERING
I'M AGAINST THIS BILL.
EMILY ROMERO FROM DALY CITY AND
WITH SEXY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS DAN SHOW FROM OUR NEW
CALIFORNIA I'M WITH THE XC I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THE FURROW FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I'M OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MILEY FLANAGAN FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA WITH ALL SENTIENT
BEINGS PLEASE OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GYRO LISTEN I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS WELL.
MY NAME IS JULIE WATER FROM ON
THE CREEK CALIFORNIA WITH
COMPASSION AND DAY INDIA
EXCEEDED AYE OPPOSED THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS WENDY BROWN
MINE FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
REPRESENT IN DEFENSE OF ANIMALS
AND I WALKED A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILES WITH DIRECT ACTION EVER TO
SEE PLEASE DON'T PASS THIS BILL
THANK.
RESERVATIONS SACRAMENTO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MY NAME IS EISSA FROM SACRAMENTO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CINDY VIA LOBOS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS CODY FROM SACRAMENTO
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THINKING
IT WAS.
RANK A SOLID SET OF FRESNO AND I
OPPOSE.
AND HE'S A GUY SANTA IS OUT OF
FRESNO AND I OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NOW NOT SALAS SOME
FROM A MORE CALIFORNIA WITH D.
X. SEE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
PRODUCT ISN'T RUNOFF FROM THE
MORE CALIFORNIA NINE OPPOSES
BILL THANK.
SERGIO FRANCO RESIDENT ALAMEDA
COUNTY I OPPOSE BILL THANK YOU.
I'M GOING DANIELSON ARE AND
ACTIVISTS FROM HALF MOON BAY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MUCH.
JOSHUA CAMANCHE OPPOSES BILL
WHAT MOTHER EARTH THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY THREE KEY FREE BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU SIR.
THIS FROM HAPPENED A CALIFORNIA
I OPPOSE THIS BILL OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH.
I THOMAS CHIANG FROM SOME CISCO
CALIFORNIA WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU MISTER.
HELLO MY NAME IS WORKING WITH MY
GF FROM SAN FRANCISCO ON AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
A MINISTERIAL -- NUMBER HEALTH
MONDAY PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND KEEP POLLUTING THE WORLD I
THINK A THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I AM ALICE STEVE FROM
REAL TIME CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
THE THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS OF WE
CARE ABOUT ANIMALS THEY HAD THE
EXIT.
THANK YOU.
AM I TO ARGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
COMPASSIONATE BAY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M THOMAS HENDRIX FROM REDDING
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU SIR.
JOE INDIE FROM READING
CALIFORNIA WITH DIXIE OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI -- I'M EMILY DAVIS AND I'M
FROM REDDING CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS JESSE FUNTIME
FROM REDDING CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROLE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO COMPASSIONATE BAY
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE I
SUPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S OUT FROM I'M A FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD ACTIVISTS FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS ANTONIO MORA FROM SAN
MATTEO CALIFORNIA AND I'M WITH
THE XC AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S POLICY CENTER AREA --
FROM FAIRFIELD AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANKS WHEN A BILL IN THE U. I'M
A STUDENT YOU SENATORS AND I
POSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU I'M ALEXANDER TAYLOR
I'M FROM SAM CISCO AND OPPOSED.
THANKS.
SEAN SHAPIRO LOS ALTOS
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
BUT I'M STILL IN WELLS
REPRESENTING STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS FOR ANIMAL
LIBERATION AT SAC STATE
UNIVERSITY WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME'S HAS THE SOONEST PSYCH
STATE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
I LIKE CENTURY -- SOLANO COUNTY.
THIS BILL.
SEND EMAIL BERKELEY OPPOSE.
KIRK NELSON SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY YOU WE CLOSE FLORA MO AND MAY
VERY AYE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
JOHN CAMERON DOUBLING CAM AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SHY AND DINNER IN
FROM SAN FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CORRIE ROWLAND I LIVE
IN BERKELEY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VIRGINIA FEEL FROM
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M BOB BACK ALIVIA RESIDENT OF
WALLER CREEK CALIFORNIA AND
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HEY FRANCO DIXIE I'M A
COMPASSION THANK. THREE ZERO
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA WITH THE XC
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MEGAN STEIN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANKS SO
MUCH.
GUY GILBERTSON FROM ELDERLY
MINNESOTA I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANKS.
AMY SANDOVAL FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION.
TIFFANY WORTHINGTON FROM SANTA
CRUZ CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES FELT LIKE SO MUCH.
J. FITZGERALD TAXPAYER AND
REGISTERED VOTER FROM STANISLAUS
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE GO FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA CONCERNED CITIZENS
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE.
HI KATIE ME BOBBY HAVE A SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION THE
ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE FUND AND
WILD OR GUARDIANS ON STRONG
OPPOSITION VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
WHEN SHOWN FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU?
MICHAEL GOLDBERG WITH THE
BERKELEY BASED COMPASSIONATE DAY
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
EVEN HAMMER OF OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI ANASTASIA MOUTH FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I'M A DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
AMIR TANNER FROM BERKELEY AND I
WALKED ALL THE WAY HERE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOR ANIMALS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JACOBS -- BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
AND I'M OPPOSED THANK YOU.
CAROL ALSO FROM CARMICHAEL
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I'M CRISTINA LEVER BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MUCH I'M CHEYENNES HIVE ON THE
CREEK AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DEAN WAS A CASKET FROM
COMPASSIONATE IN BERKELEY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JON KARL MARX TO THOSE OF FROM
BERKELEY AND I'M OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
THANKS HELLO I'M A MEAN MUHAMMAD
FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ALTHOUGH THE CUSTOMER FROM THE
BERKELEY IN RIGHT CENTER OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
FULLER BERKELEY I OPPOSE
[inaudible]
IN HERE.
I AM NEVER MATTERS I'M FROM ELK
GROVE CALIFORNIA AYE POSES BILL
VERY GOOD THANK MEN.
SEEKING FROM BERKELEY AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
I AM ANYONE FROM BERKELEY I
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS KEITH YEAH I'M
FROM OAKLAND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IN YOUR THANKS.
KAREN RUBIO FROM LOS GATOS AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL OR TAKEN.
MICHAEL DELL FROM SAN BENITO
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
VICTORIA WOODS FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KATIE JONES FROM BERKELEY AND I
POSES BILL.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
OKAY.
SEEING NO OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
HAVE CAN BRING BACK TO THE DíAS
FROM FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
CENTER AROUND.
OKAY WELL I'VE GOT -- SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL I THINK --
ALONG TH LINES OF WHAT IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION AND AND I'M AND
BASICALLY ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE
ANALYSIS WHICH I THINK DOES A
GOOD JOB [inaudible]
OF RAISING A NUMBER OF THE
CONCERNS RELATING TO SOURCING
AND TRACKING.
I'M ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT SOME OF
THE ETHICAL IN WELFARE CENTERS
THAT HAVE BEEN.
BROUGHT UP AS WELL I THINK IN
THE END OF THE DAY.
THE CONCERN OUT THERE IS THAT
THIS WAS PASSED BACK IN THE
SEVENTIES BECAUSE THERE WAS A
FEAR.
OPTICALLY RELATED TO THE
ENDANGERED.
SIDE I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THE
DANGER STATUS HAS BEEN REMOVED --
WITH REGARDS TO THE LOUISIANA
BASED.
ALLIGATORS BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
ARE THERE IS A PRETTY ROBUST
ILLEGAL TRADE -- FROM OTHER
PLACES WHERE THERE DOESN'T SEEM
TO BE THE SAME KIND OF STANDARDS.
AND AND YOU KNOW THE INDUSTRY
HAS BEEN PUSHED OVER AND OVER
AGAIN TO TAKE SUBSTANTIVE ACTION
IN THIS AREA AND HAS FAILED TO
DO SO.
AND I THINK THEY JUST YOU KNOW
RELIED ON BEING ABLE -- TO GET.
YOU KNOW -- YOU KNOW GET --
EXTENSIONS TO THE SUNSET OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND I
THINK YOU'RE MY FRUSTRATION IS
HERE THEY ARE AGAIN AT THE LAST
MINUTE -- THIS THING IS ABOUT TO
SUNSET AGAIN -- YOU KNOW
LITERALLY IT AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR.
AND AND HERE WE ARE BEING ASKED --
JUST GIVE US A LITTLE MORE TIME
AND MIKE MY WHOLE CONCERN IS
WILL YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT ARE WE
GONNA.
WHAT DO YOU DO DIFFERENTLY THIS
TIME?
I'M.
AND THAT'S I GUESS MY QUESTION
TO THE AUTHORS. TO START FIRST
OF ALL CAN COME WE HAVE MY
SUPPORTERS APPEARS SO THAT WE
CAN ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS FOR
YOU THANK YOU SIR.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO TAKE A CRACK AT
THAT TERM.
FIRST OFF I WOULD SAY I'M NOT
SURE.
WHAT I'M IN AGREEMENT WITH THE
PERSPECTIVE THAT YOU'RE RAISING --
HOW DO WE USE THIS BILL?
TO ADDRESS OR RESOLVE SOME OF
THESE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED B
THE ABSENCE LEGITIMATE ISSUES
WHERE WE'VE GOT.
YOU KNOW IT INTERNATIONAL TRADE
PROBLEMS AND BAD PRACTICES AND
HOW CAN CALIFORNIA TAKE A STAND
IN -- INSURING THAT WERE DEALING
IN LEGAL PRODUCT THAT MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE NOW I'M NOT SURE
FROM WHAT I HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION -- THAT.
ADDRESSING THOSE CONCERNS WILL
REMOVE KIND OF THE PUREST
POSITION -- EVERY THERE'S A
SENIOR SOME OF THE FOLKS -- THAT
IDEA WITH IRREGULAR SACRAMENTO
WHO THINK EGGS ARE GROWING ON
THE SHELVES OF WHOLE FOODS --
THAT'S SIMPLY NOT THE CASE THESE
ARE NECESSARY INVESTMENTS IN
WHAT ONCE IS A NECESSARY
INVESTMENTS NIKOLOC RESTORATION --
TO MAKE SURE I MEAN WE TRY DRAW
YOUR TENSION I THINK PAGE --
THREE PAGE TWO AND THREE OF THE
ANALYSIS YOUR NOSE TO PROPOSE A
LOT LAYS OUT THE THREE ITEMS
THAT THIS BILL.
ACCOMPLISHES THIS OBVIOUS
EXTENSIVE SUNSET TO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE IT PROHIBITS
ENDANGERED SPECIES THE
IMPORTATION.
OR SALE OF AND THAT REQUIRES
THAT WE BEING CLOSE COMPLIANCE
WITH INTERNATIONAL -- AND LEGAL
STANDARDS THOSE ARE THINGS I
WOULD ASSUME WE'RE ALL IN
AGREEMENT ON WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
IS HOW DO WE ENFORCE THAT.
AND IS THERE SOMETHING WE CAN DO
IN THE BILL. TO STRENGTHEN
ENFORCEMENT I THINK I'D BE A
GREAT PLACE FOR CALIFORNIA A
LEAD AND I WOULD BE -- CERTAINLY
OPEN AND WOULD WELCOME.
THE COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATIONS
AS TO HOW WE INSURE -- THE THIRD
OF FORTUNE OCCURS AND WHAT --
BENCHMARKS WE COULD PUT THIS
BILL TO ENCOURAGE THE ISSUE NOW
YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE HERE LAST MINUTE THIS THAT
THE NEXT THING.
OBVIOUSLY THAT HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME IN THIS -- PROCESS AND
SINCE I DON'T DO SPONSORED BILLS
I DO ADAM GRAY BILLS.
ARE BEFORE YOU WITH THAT ISSUE
THAT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND MAKING IT A
BETTER BILL.
YEAH I MEAN I GUESS SO IF YOU
BUILD THE FINAL PARAGRAPH OF THE
ANALYSIS WHICH IS ON THE BOTTOM
OF PAGE EIGHT I THINK GETS INTO
THIS WHOLE ISSUE OF AN EFFECTIVE
TRACKING SYSTEM -- SAFEGUARDS.
YOU KNOW AS THE F. W. ET CETERA
BECAUSE I THINK.
YOU KNOW IN THE END OF THE DAY
AYE AYE MY UNDERSTANDING OF
HISTORY THIS IS THAT THIS COMES
UP EVERY TIME THERE'S AN ATTEMPT --
TO TO TRY TO EXTEND THE SUNSET
INDUSTRY SAYS ALL WE'RE WORKING
ON WE'RE WORKING ON A AND THEN --
NO SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IS MADE
AND AND THEY KEEP TALKING ABOUT
ALL THE GOOD THINGS HAPPENING
LOUISIANA AND THAT ALL MAY BE
THE CASE YOU KNOW I I DON'T I
CAN'T SPEAK TO PERSONALLY -- BUT
I I I AND AND THAT'S THAT'S ONE
ISSUE AND I THINK THERE'S A
BUNCH OF ETHICS ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION.
I WOULD RATHER SPEND SOME TIME
LOOKING AT AS WELL IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW THE WAY THESE ANIMALS
ARE TREATED BUT BUT THIS BROADER
QUESTION OF THE ILLEGAL TRADE
AND WHAT WE CAN AND WHAT WE ARE
WHAT WE ARE NOT DOING WITH
REGARDS -- TO TRACKING YEAH IT
SEEMS TO CONTINUE TO BE KICKED
DOWN THE ROAD AND I IN AN ACT.
I THOUGHT YOU KNOW MY MY MY MY
SENSE IS THAT WE ARE NOT PASS
SOMETHING IKE THIS.
IF -- I A YOU GIVEN GIVEN THE
TRACK RECORD IF IF WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO SOMETHING THAT WOULD.
REALLY ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT
ARE LAID OUT HERE ON PAGE DO THE
ANALYSIS.
THAT'S MY MY COURT CONCERNING
SENATOR -- YEAH PLEASE IF YOU
WANNA RESPOND OR OTHER TIMES I
THINK CENTER MONNING IS A COMMON
AND CENTER HERTZBERG POTENTIAL
AS WELL.
BUT LET ME LET THE FEAR THE
SENATORS REMARKED ON ANTS OKAY
THAT'S GREAT LET'S DO THAT.
IN A MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I'M A SAUNA FOCUS ON A MEDICAL
APPLICATIONS SIDE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO FOCUSED ON IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THIS BILL PERTAINS
ONLY -- TO DEAD ALLIGATORS IF
YOU WILL NOT LIVING IN A LOT OF
THE MEDICAL TESTING IS WITH
LIVING ANIMALS IS THAT CORRECT.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S A 100%
ACCURATE WE ALSO IMPORT THE EGGS
ON THE CAL STATE SENATOR DEAN OF
GROUP IS WRITTEN GETTING READY
TO GO DOWN.
AND BRING THE EGGS DO YOU
CONSIDER THEM LIVE OR DEAD.
IT'S AN ALLIGATOR PARTS AND SOUL
IT'S THE BAN ON ALLIGATOR PARTS
ANY PART IS MY UNDERSTANDING AND
SO THAT INCLUDES.
DEAD OR ALIVE.
THAT'S NOT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
I'VE HAD THE BILL INTERPRETED TO
ME BUT I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
THERE SUCH A DISTINCTION IN MY
VIEW.
BETWEEN.
POTENTIAL MEDICAL APPLICATION.
IN COMMERCIAL SALE -- HAVE YOU
CONSIDERED.
NEARING AND PROTECT MEDICAL
APPLICATION.
SO PART WE DID HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION AND THE WAY THE WORK
I'M CALLING IT -- THE ECONOMIC
ECOSYSTEM IS THAT THE FUNDING
FOR THE MARSHES AND IF WHERE'S
THAT MIGHT THAT GUY -- CAN
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THE RESTAURANT.
THAT'S WHAT HIS NAME IS THAT THE
GUY -- BY THE SALE OF THOSE.
FEDEX.
THE REST RESTORATION OF THE
MARSHES SO IT'S ALL CONNECTED
IT'S NOT ONE OR THE OTHER IF YOU.
ELIMINATE ONE THAN THE OTHER
FUNDING DOESN'T HAPPEN AND SO
IT'S KINDA IT'S ALL THE
ECOSYSTEM IS CONNECTED.
I I APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE
DID YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT.
THAT THROUGH THE CHAIR.
YEAH -- THE IN YET MAYBE WE
COULD GET SOME CLEARING JUST
LOOKING AT THE CODE HERE JUST.
IT'S CURRENT LAWS.
DEAD BODY OR ANY PART OR PRODUCT
THEREOF SO WHETHER THE THE PART
[inaudible]
THEREOF IS SENATOR AND HAS TO BE
RELATED BACK TO THE DEAD BODY
VERSES LIVE BIG RIGHT COULD YOU
COMMENT ON A MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S TWO POINTS HERE YOU'RE
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT ABOUT
THE READ OF THE CURRENT STATUTE.
THE RESEARCH IS CONDUCTED NOT
JUST WITH EGGS WHICH MAY BE
CONSIDERED OF A LIVING THING.
ALSO ALLIGATORS LIVE ALLIGATORS
BUT IT'S ALSO CONDUCTED WITH
SERUM BLOOD.
T. ANOTHER ALLIGATOR PARTS THAT
COME FROM.
THAT ALLOCATED BODY SO.
THE RESEARCH BEING DONE USING
THOSE PRODUCTS WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE BECAUSE OF THE BAND.
SECONDLY RELATIVE TO THE LIVE
ALLIGATORS CENTER MONNING WHICH
IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF THIS.
THE WAY THE ECO SYSTEM WORKS IS
THAT THE WETLANDS WHICH IS THE
SOURCE OF THE YEARLING
ALLIGATORS THAT ARE IMPORTED FOR
CAL STATE SAMBAR DINO WAR THE
EGGS THAT ARE IMPORTED AT USC.
IS SUPPORTED BY THE FINANCIAL
REVENUE THAT.
EMANATES FROM THE COMMERCIAL
MARKET IF THAT AN INITIAL
REVENUE ISN'T THERE TO SUPPORT
THE WETLANDS THE NESTING AREAS.
THEN. ONE OF TWO THINGS HPPENS
EITHER IN THOSE RESEARCH PARTS
BECOME.
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE.
AND AND I CAN TESTIFY ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL DOING OTHER
MEDICAL RESEARCH WHEN YOU HAVE
TO PAY THE TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A MOUSE. TO DO.
RESEARCH SECOND TELL YOU A
BECOMES VERY EXPENSIVE VERY
QUICKLY.
SO IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
COMMERCIAL MARKET TO SUPPORT.
THE EGGS AND THE LIVE ALLIGATORS
THE FARMS THAT PROVIDE THE LIVE
ALLIGATORS FOR THE WILD.
THE COST OF THOSE BECOME.
A MUCH HIGHER IF YOU'RE USING
LIFE PRODUCTS BUT IF YOU'RE
USING IN FACT.
PARTS OF DEAD ALLIGATORS FOR THE
RESEARCH THAN THAN THE BAN WOULD
NOT ALLOW THAT TO OCCUR IN WHAT
PERCENT OF THE COMMERCIAL MARKET
[inaudible]
IS CALIFORNIA.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING AND
ESTIMATES DONE BY OTHER STATES
IS THAT CALIFORNIA'S SHARE OF
THE NATIONAL MARKET IS
APPROXIMATELY 25% [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'VE GOT NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
RIGHT NOW THANKS.
THANK SAID ARRIVAL WILL AYE AYE
AYE AND SHE ADDS I THINK WAS IN
SOME EMIGRES OPENING
PRESENTATION ABOUT THE EXPECTED.
ECONOMIC DECLINES IN THE MARKET
I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
ENGAGING SO LET'S TOUCH ON THAT
I'LL KICKING THE CENTER
HERTZBERG THEN WE CAN TRY TO
SORT OF CENTRALIZED SOME OF
THESE ISSUES HERE SO.
UNLESS.
JUMP IN OKAY OUT I WOULD YOU TO
PLEASE GO CENTERS FOR WANT TO
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WERE
CENTER ALLEN.
I THINK THAT THERE IS THIS ISSUE
ABOUT TRACKING THAT IF IN FACT.
IGGY WAS BEEN EXPLAINED TO ME
THIS IS LIKE SALMON OR THERE'S
ALL SORTS OF THINGS WHERE.
WE HAVE LIVING -- ANIMALS THAT
ARE.
BUT IT'S COWS OR WHATEVER ELSE
IT IS BUT THAT THE INCENTIVE
VISION FOR IT IS IN A WAY FOR
FOR THIS NOT TO HAPPEN THAT
CONCEPTS TO CREATE SOME.
I CAN -- CONSTRAIN TIMELINE TO
DEAL WITH THIS TRACKING AND MAKE
IT REALLY REAL TO ME.
IS SOMETHING THAT IN ESSENCE
BASICALLY SAYS THIS IS WHAT YOU
REPRESENTED IN THE ART THE
ARGUMENT IT WOULD BE.
DO WHAT YOU SAY YOU'RE GOING TO
DO IT RIGHT LET'S JUST MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A SYSTEM IN PLACE THAT
ALLOWS THAT HAPPENED THE TIME TO
DO THAT SO I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THAT FLAW
CIRCLE BACK WITH WITH SENATOR
ALLEN TERMS OF THAT.
OF OF HOW DO -- APPROPRIATELY --
FIGURE THAT OUT OKAY THANK YOU
CENTERS BURKE -- WE ONLY A FEW
MINUTES HERE LET BEFORE CAUCUS I
DON'T WANT TO RUSH THE
DISCUSSION BUT I DID WANT TO
PINPOINT A FEW THE SETTLE ANY
ISSUES OF CONTENTION SO. ONE IS
ABOUT THE CONCERN AROUND MEDICAL
RESEARCH IN THE DEPRESSION
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE.
ON THAT SIDE OF THINGS I'M LOOK
I'M I'M VERY SENSITIVE TO THAT
ISSUE I LIKE YOU'VE LOST YOUR
FRIENDS.
TO CANCER.
HAVE YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS GOING
TO ALZHEIMER'S WHICH WE WE KNOW
THAT THAT'S A BIG DEAL SO TO THE
FOLKS IN LIFE SCIENCES.
I'D LOVE A FRAMEWORK FRANKLY
WHERE WE DIDN'T.
HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS ENTIRE
BROADER COMMERCIAL MARKET ISSUE
AND DEAL DIRECTLY WITH HIS
MEDICAL RESEARCH ISSUE.
BUT I I UNDERSTAND THAT THE THE
SUPPORTERS ARE SAYING WELL IF
YOU START TO UNDERCUT.
THE TRADE IN GENERAL YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE A MARKET DEPRESSION.
THE THE THE NOW SAYS.
SAID ABOUT A BILLION ANNUALLY
GLOBAL BASIS GIVE OR TAKE.
NO NO NATIONAL MARKET MIGHT BE
LESS BUT LET'S SAY 25% DROP OFF
COMES FROM.
THE THE BAND GOING INTO EFFECT --
SEE ABOUT A SEVEN FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR TRADE MEAN [inaudible]
I. D..
I'D BE A LOT MORE COMFORTABLE
LOOKING AT IT AT THIS SORT OF
RESEARCH DRIVEN APPROACH WHERE
YOU'RE ACTUALLY TRYING TO
ADDRESS A THE ABILITY FOR
INSTITUTIONS KEEP DOING THIS
RESEARCH.
AND THEN.
LOOK LOOK AT STUDY REPORT ON
ECONOMIC IMPACTS AND SEE HOW
THAT MIGHT DIRECTLY IMPACT --
THE THE INDUSTRY SO IF PRICES IN
FOR INSTANCE MISTER LANG POINT I
BECAME EGREGIOUS AND YOU'RE
SEEING SOME MAJOR ECONOMIC
IMPEDIMENT TO BEING ABLE TO GO
TO THAT CANCER RESEARCH.
AND WE COULD SORT OF TO A LOOK
BACK AT IT.
THE PROBLEM HERE IS AND YOU MAY
YOU KNOW I I I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU ARE TRYING TO DO IN GOOD
FAITH.
I I I DO APPRECIATE THAT AND AND
FROM A WETLANDS PERSPECTIVE.
TO BACK TO MY TAKE IS A IT'S
JUST IT'S IT'S SLIGHTLY.
DIFFERENT JUST BECAUSE IF WE
SORT OF SAY YES AGAIN.
AND THEN HOPE THE INDUSTRY COMES
UP WITH.
SOME ANSWERS.
I KIND OF I'M NOT COMFORTABLE
SORT OF BANKING ON THAT PROMISE
I'M IF THERE WAS A PRESENTATION
FOR THE COMMITTEE FOR INSTANCE
OF A NEW RFID CHIPS SYSTEM OR
SOME OTHER.
SYSTEM THAT WAS ACTUALLY UP AND
RUNNING TODAY TRACK AND TRACE
READY -- I THINK WE MAY BE
HAVING A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION ON THE ON THAT SORT
OF SPECIES DECLINE ISSUE THE
PROBLEM IS NOW IF WE AUTHORIZES
IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
IT.
WAS WE'RE SORT OF EVEN IF WE
CONDITION DIDN'T SAID.
IT CAME PROCEED BUT YOU KNOW THE
INDUSTRY SHALL COME UP WITH SOME
TRACKING STANDARD WE'RE STILL
SORT OF MAKING A FOR LOOKING
PROMISE THAT WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE A GUARANTEE.
WE CAN DEAL WITH.
THE TORTURE BECAUSE IT IS
TORTURE WHAT'S HAPPENING OUT IN
PLACE LIKE VIETNAM AND I'VE EVEN
HEARD TESTIMONY ABOUT TEXAS --
ENDS.
I DON'T WANT TO SIT HERE AND
ALSO OVER PRESUME WHAT WE CAN DO
ABOUT TEXAS LOUISIANA LET
WEAPONS POLICY.
BECAUSE THOSE STATE LEGISLATURES
AND STATE GOVERNMENTS I THINK
COULD BE DOING SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT BUT I'M SENSITIVE ALSO
THESE CARBON SSUES THAT ARE
RAISED HIM AND AGAIN.
IF WE CAN SORT OF DO THAT FOR
LOOKING ANALYSIS AND SAY OKAY IF
WE REALLY START TO COLLAPSE FOR
INSTANCE A WEAPONS PROGRAM FOR
RESEARCH PROGRAM LET'S TAKE A
SECOND LOOK AT IT -- AFTER THIS
THIS BAN TAKES EFFECT BUT I I
DON'T SEE THE HUGE RISK TODAY IN
LETTING THAT BEEN.
GOING TO AFFECT STUDY THE
IMPACTS -- OR FRANKLY HOLD THIS
IN TAKE A LOOK AT IT NEXT YEAR
EVEN ONCE WE HAVE A LITTLE
BETTER PERSPECTIVE SO I JUST
WANTED.
TO GET YOUR ALL'S TAKE ON IT.
DO YOU THINK IT LEASE IS THAT
FAIR MATH TO SAY IF I'M IF I'M
SORT OF PROJECTING THE MAX
IMPACT 25% FALL OFFER SO.
THOSE RAID -- AND BY THE WAY
THEY DO NOW SOUNDS POINTS AT 25%
ILLEGAL SO IF IF WERE FALLING
OFF TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY FIVE
YEAH I DON'T MIND LOSING THAT
PORTION THE MARKET.
YEAH PLEASE WRESTLING AND ALL OF
THE AUTHORS AND WRAP UP WHEN
THEY WHEN THEY EVERYONE.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME YES
CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE NEEDS --
TO TAKASU IT'S CAUCUS SIX RIGHT
THAT'S IMPORTANT STUFF.
I WOULD OFFER UP IN DRAWING MY
ATTENTION.
TO SIR ALAN'S POINT ON THAT PAGE
EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS IF WE GET
TO THE FINAL PARAGRAPH.
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT --
MISTER CRAVEN HAS OFFERED UP --
THAT YOU KNOW PERHAPS WE SHOULD
HOLD THE BILL UNTIL THIS
DEVELOPING SUCH A SYSTEM IT'S
ARTS ARE.
AT AND THAT'S KIND OF THE POINT
YOU'RE HIT NON AND WHAT
GUARANTEED WE HAVE AND AND WE'RE
BEFORE YOU WITH A FIVE YEAR
EXTENSION.
I WOULD OFFER MAYBE WE START BY
CUTTING THE TIME IN HALF -- YOU
KNOW.
TO AS FAR AS THE SUNSET
EXTENSION -- WITH A LEGISLATIVE
REVIEW -- AND SOME KIND OF SIGN
OFFER MANDATE MAYBE WITH THE
FISH AND WILDLIFE -- SO THAT WAS
WHAT WE SAID A MARKER BECAUSE I
DO AGREE DEADLINES DRIVE.
RESULTS RIGHT AND WE'VE SEEN
THAT HERE IN LEGISLATURE -- WERE
DEADLINE DRIVEN -- BODY SO LET'S
USE THIS VEHICLE TO YOU KNOW
SPLIT THE DIFFERENCE HERE SO TO
SPEAK AND ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL
THAT I THINK YOU'RE PUTTING
FORTH AND SURROUNDS PUTTING
FORTH AND SIR HERTZBERG. TO IN
FACT YOU KNOW CALL THE CALL THE
QUESTION AND REQUIRE SYSTEM TO
PUT IN PLACE IF WE'RE GOING TO
FOR THAT RIGHT AND ALSO MAYBE
SET A FRAMEWORK IN PLACE THAT
MIGHT BE APPLICABLE OUTSIDE OF
JUST -- THIS PARTICULAR SPECIES
RIGHT I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT -- IT'S IMPORTANT
STANDARD THAT MAYBE HAS BROADER
IMPLICATIONS FOR THIS BODY AND
IN A VARIETY OF BILLS SO WOULD
BE COMMITTEE ENTERTAIN.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
I I THINK I'D BE INTERESTED IN
IN A NARROW APPLICATION TO DEAL
WITH THIS RESEARCH ISSUE BECAUSE
I AM SENSE OF THOSE GAPS.
BUT I THINK THE DEADLINE IS
ALREADY IN LAW FOR THE
COMMERCIAL MARKET TO DO THEIR
THING I MEAN HERE IT IS CLOCKS
TAKEN ON THE END OF THIS YEAR --
AND SO.
I I THINK THE LAW ITSELF ALLOWS
THAT DEADLINE I MEAN IF IF YOU
COME IN WITH THAT TRACK AND
TRACE PROGRAMMING IT'S THAT'S
ONE THING BUT YEAH I I SEE THE
DEADLINE IS BEING THERE.
I WOULD I BE OPEN TO THIS THIS
MEDICAL RESEARCH CONCEPT OF SO
FAR WE HAVEN'T REALLY SEEN HAD
AS TAYLOR.
HAD THAT ISSUE IN PARTICULAR BUT
YES I THINK I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE MATURED SAY THAT WE
HAVE NOT IDENTIFIED IN ANY
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION -- THE GOAL
OF TRACK AND TRACE PROGRAM BY
THIS DATE RIGHT WE'VE GOT WE'VE
NOT LAY DOWN THE MARKET I
UNDERSTAND YOUR POINT IS WE'VE
GOT A LONG WAY OKAY FINE.
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
RIGHT EXTENSION IS I DO KNOW
THAT DISRUPTING.
PRIVATE MARKETS DOESN'T SERVE
ANYONE YOU KNOW THESE IMPORTANT
REVENUES THAT -- JUST LIKE THEY
DO IN MY HOME DISTRICTS.
HELPS PRESERVE AND SECURE THESE --
THESE WETLANDS AND THAT HAS.
BENEFITS THAT WE'VE ALL TALKED
ABOUT -- SO WE WOULDN'T WANT TO
DISRUPT THE MARKET IN SAYING
WE'RE GONNA STOP AND WE MIGHT
REINSTATE IT LATER -- YOU KNOW
AS MUCH AS WE FIND OURSELVES TO
BE -- HONORABLE UNPREDICTABLE
PRIVATE SECTOR MARKETS DON'T
ALWAYS KNOW WHAT TO TAKE FROM
OUR ACTIONS AND SO WE HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL AND IN IN HOW WE WE
PROCEED THERE BUT SOME BRIEF
EXTENSION OF TIME I WOULD OFFER
UP TO CUT THE TIME IN HALF.
BUT PERHAPS THE COMMITTEE HAS A
DIFFERENT OPINION THAN THAT BUT
SOME EXTENSION WITH THE ABSOLUTE
MANDATE THAT YOU HAVE TO ACHIEVE
THIS -- TECHNOLOGICAL CAPABILITY
BY THE STATE PERIOD RIGHT AND WE
SET THE MARKET THE LEGISLATURE
SENT A MESSAGE AND WE'VE
ACHIEVED MULTIPLE PUBLIC POLICY
GOALS WHICH I WOULD TAKE THE
COMMITTEE FOR THAT -- GUIDANCE
AND DIRECTION OKAY -- I'D BE
WILLING TO LOOK AT THE STUDYING
OF MARKET DISRUPTION BECAUSE I I
AM AGAIN SENSITIVE NOT JUST TO
THE MEDICAL RESEARCH BUT ALSO
THE WETLANDS PIECE.
AND MEMBERS ARE WELCOME.
TO MAKE DECISIONS IN THEIR OWN
DISCRETION -- YEAH I I I DON'T
WANT TO PUT TOO HEAVY OF A THUMB
ON THE SCALE HERE -- BUT I WOULD
JUST SAY -- I'D BE MORE
COMFORTABLE.
WAITING AND SEEING.
WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENS AND NOT
TRYING TO PREDICT THE FUTURE IN
SOME BIG COLLAPSE HERE AND
SEEING IF IT IS TRULY THAT
CATASTROPHIC FRIENDS IS ON THE
WETLAND SIDE ON THE MEDICAL
RESEARCH SIDE?
AND REVISITING IT NEXT YEAR --
SO I'M SURE THEY'LL BE THAT OR
TRYING TO ACTUALLY PUT IN PLACE --
BEFORE LIKE BEFORE WE DO RE OPEN.
DOING THIS SORT OF TRACK AND
TRACE PROGRAM SO JUST SORT OF
FLIPPING THE ORDER IN OTHER
WORDS -- CONDITIONING THE
EXTENSION ON THE SORT OF
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION TO
TRACK AND TRACE PROGRAM.
IN ADVANCE OF ANY -- OPENING BUT
THAT SOME YOU KNOW SOME FINING
OR PRESENTATION AFTER YOU MADE
I'M JUST NOT COMFORTABLE WITH
THIS SORT OPEN ENDED NATURE OF
IT DOING IT IN THAT ORDER.
I GUESS THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
ESSENCE OF MY CONCERN.
YOU CAN GO OUT YEAH JUST EXPLAIN
THE PRO TEMPORE TRYING TO WORK
ON IT.
SO -- DO WE WANT TO TRY TO THINK
PROCEDURALLY HOW TO HOW BEST TO
DO THIS -- DO WE WANT TO LEAVE
THE MEASURE ON ON HOLD AND TALK
THIS THROUGH DO WE HAVE ANY
PERSPECTIVES ON I MEAN THIS THIS
NARAL.
MEDICAL RESEARCH ISSUE SEEMS
SOLVABLE -- I JUST I'M NOT
WILLING TO OPEN UP.
A VERY TOUGH TO REGULATE
COMMERCIAL MARKET WITH.
INDISTINGUISHABLE PRODUCTS
COMING DOWN.
HAVE PAIN AND SUFFERING IN THIS.
THE CORE OF WHERE THEY COME FROM --
AS A STATE IT IS IT'S TOO MUCH --
SO SHERMAN YEAH PLEASE I'M A
LITTLE CONFUSED.
LVM LEASE UNDERSTAND WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM IF IN FACT WE
HAD A EXTENSION IT WAS A SHORTER
PERIOD OF TIME THE FIVE YEARS
AND IF IN FACT WE MANDATED THIS
TRACK AND TRACE TECHNOLOGY.
BY THAT SUCH DATE WHATEVER THAT
DATE -- THAT THE COMMITTEE WOULD
DECIDE DOES THAT MEET YOUR
METRIC OR YOU SAYING YOU KNOW
I'M NOT OKAY WITH THAT I'M
SAYING WE COULD DO.
I'D BE INTERESTED IN GETTING
TRACK AND TRACE UP BEFORE ANY
EXTENSION OCCURRED BUT WE DON'T
HAVE TRACK AND TRACE TODAY AND
THE EXTENT EXPIRES NOW SO THAT
OPTIONS OFF THE TABLE RIGHT.
WELL I I MEAN I I DON'T KNOW HOW
QUICKLY INDUSTRY I MEAN I DON'T
KNOW IF IS IS A SIX MONTH PERIOD
BEFORE YOU CAN GET SOMETHING UP
AND RUNNING I I'M NOT SURE WHAT
TIME LINES ARE ACTUALLY LIKE
THERE SO.
SO MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GELANG
REPRESENTING THE FARMING
INDUSTRY.
VARIOUS TECHNOLOGIES ARE
CURRENTLY BEING DEVELOPED.
WHAT'S BEEN MISSING QUITE
FRANKLY IS.
A GOVERNMENT SANCTIONED FOR
THOSE COMPANIES TO COOPERATE AND
COLLABORATE WITHOUT FEAR OF ANTI
TRUST ARE OTHER CONCERNS. TO
ACTUALLY DEVELOP THE TECHNOLOGY
TOGETHER UNDERSTANDING THE
YELLOW THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
MAKE THAT TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE
NOT JUST TO THEMSELVES BUT TO
THE FOREIGN FIFTY SMALL
MANUFACTURERS IN CALIFORNIA.
WHO NEED THAT TECHNOLOGY
[inaudible]
I THINK.
WE'RE PREPARED TO HAVE OUR FEET.
TO THE FIRE. TO MAKE THIS
TECHNOLOGY REALITY EACH
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S BEING.
DEVELOPED RIGHT NOW HAS
DIFFERENT ISSUES FIGHT EACH
TECHNOLOGY HAS.
HAS SOME CAPABILITY BUT ALSO
SOME DOWNSIDES.
THE INDUSTRY KNOWS THAT THIS
MUST HAPPEN A MUST HAPPEN
QUICKLY I THINK PROVIDING THAT
BOTH INCENTIVE AND AND WORKING
WITH THE STATE GOVERNMENT TO
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE NGOS.
DEVELOP THE RIGHT TECHNOLOGY AND
MAKE SURE IT WORKS WE'RE READY
TO DO WERE READY TO HAVE OUR
FEET PUT TO THE FIRE.
WE JUST NEED THE CONTEXT IN
WHICH TO DO THAT WITHOUT.
PULLING OUT THE UNDERPINNING OF
THE FINANCIAL SUPPORT
[inaudible]
UNDERSTOOD I I THINK WE'RE
HAVING A SORT OF ALLIGATOR THE
EGGS.
WHICH COMES FIRST -- DISCUSSION
IN AND SO.
I'M IF I'M HEARING YOU RIGHT
THERE'S OPEN IS.
TO SPEEDING UP IN FIGURING OUT A
TRACK AND TRACE PROGRAM.
TIMELINE WISE [inaudible]
DON'T.
GIVE US YOUR SENSE OF IT WITH
THIS GOVERNMENT SANCTION I MEAN
IF WE IF THIS BILL WAS FOR
INSTANCE TO SAY.
JUST SETTING UP A TRACK AND
TRACE PROGAM THAT WAS THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL.
AND THEN CONDITIONING ANY.
EXTENSION OF THE BANDS.
REVERSAL -- ABATEMENT.
ON THE THAT SORT OF GOVERNMENT
SANCTIONING.
THROUGH SORT OF NOT DOING THE
TWO AND A HALF YEARS AS THE TIME
AS THE SHOT CLOCK BUT INTO THIS
YEAR IS THE SHOT CLOCK.
BUT THAT WE WOULD OR WHATEVER
YOU WANNA CALL CONSISTENCY TO
SOME DETERMINATION BUT THEN --
ALLOWED.
TO LOOK AT TWO AND A HALF OR
EVEN FIVE I MEAN I I THINK I'M I
THINK IF IF I FELT CERTAIN I
THINK TO BE A LOT MORE OPENNESS
I THINK.
I MIGHT SUGGEST CENTER THAT --
IF WE WERE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
TRACK AND TRACE PROBLEM IF THAT
WERE POSSIBLE BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR.
YOU JUST LEFT THE SUNSET ALL THE
ALL TOGETHER I WOULD UNDERSTAND
THE NEED FOR A SUNSET TO SUNSET
WOULD BE TO DRIVE THE DEADLINE
WILL BE TO DRIVE THE BEHAVIOR
RIGHT SO YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET
BEYOND X. DATE.
WITHOUT IMPLEMENTING X. PROGRAM
AND OF COURSE WE AND WE PUT
SUNSET DATES INTO LEGISLATION
FOR LEGISLATIVE REVIEW THAT'S
EXACTLY THE PURPOSE.
IF WE ACHIEVED THE OUTCOME OR
LOOKING FOR WE COULD PULL THE
SUNSET ALL TOGETHER I DON'T
THINK ESPECIALLY THE INTEREST I
I PREFER THE IDEA OF KEEPING THE
SUNSET IN PLACE.
FOR PERPETUAL LEGISLATIVE REVIEW
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD TO ENSURE
GOOD PRACTICES AND BEST
PRACTICES OR NOT BUT LET'S SET A
GOAL TODAY THAT WE CAN FORCE THE
INDUSTRY. TO GET THE STRUCTURES
THE AND IF THAT'S NOT THE END OF
THE YEAR -- IF IT'S NOT TWO AND
A HALF YEARS FROM NOW WHAT IS IT
IS IT IS IT YOU KNOW JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS A JANUARY --
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS JERRY TORRE
TWENTY THREE I DON'T KNOW WOULD
BE OPEN TO THE IMPORTANT TO ME
BUT I THINK THAT WOULD BE A NICE
LANDING SPOT -- CAUCUS IN TIME
IF YOU WANT TO LEAVE THIS OPEN
ENDED FOR SOME DISCUSSION AMONG
MEMBERS THEN COME BACK FOR A
VOTE ONLY.
AND KICKING THE TIRES LOW FOR
THE HERE BUT BUT JUST TO BE
CLEAR ABOUT MY BOTTOM LINE I'M
NOT JUST WILLING TO GO.
ON GOOD FAITH OPEN ENDED HERE AT
AND THAT'S AND I AND I TRULY
THINK IF A WORD ABOUT THE
MEDICAL RESEARCH PIECE.
I THINK WE CAN SOLVE THAT HERE
TODAY -- ACT I REALLY DO THINK
IT'S DOABLE IF THAT IS THE
NARROW ISSUE WELL.
IF I MAY AT LEAST I AGREE.
THIS PLACE IS ABOUT HURRY UP
THING WAITING THAT'S BEEN MY
EXPERIENCE HERE AND NOTHING
HAPPENS UNLESS THERE'S SOLID
DEADLINES AND YOU ARE CORRECT
BUT THAT IN I AGREE WITH --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY THAT IF WE
EXTENDED THE SUNSET IN BY.
WHATEVER DAY WE DECIDE THAT'S
NOT DONE THEN THIS BILL THE US
SUNSET IS ENACTED SOLD NOTHING.
IN THIS HOUSE OR IN THIS
BUILDING HAPPENS WITHOUT THOSE
DEADLINES AND SO IF WE CAN.
EXTEND AGAIN EITHER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO OR TWENTY
THREE WHAT WHATEVER'S A PLEASURE
OF THE COMMITTEE BUT IF THAT IS
THE TRACKING SYSTEM IS NOT IN
PLACE BY EX STATE.
THAN THAN BAD VOIGTS THAT THAT
EXTENSION.
YEAH I GUESS I'M TALKING ABOUT
THE REVERSE ORDER THAT IS HAVING
TRACK AND TRACE THEN LOOK IN THE
EXTENSION IS DOING EXTENSION
THEN LOOKING AT WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT.
MR STERN YOU KNOW HOW DIFFICULT
IT IS TO TO GO THROUGH THESE
TYPES OF POLICIES AND TRYING TO
GET IT BACK ON HERE.
BECAUSE I THE OPPOSITION IS NOT
WORRIED ABOUT THE TRACK
INTRIGUED TRACK AND TRACE OTHER
THERE'S OTHER ISSUES AND SO SO
SO ONCE THIS IS GONE TRYING TO
GET IT BACK ON IS NEARLY.
IMPOSSIBLE YOU KNOW THAT IN A
AND WE KNOW THAT AND AND IF.
ABSOLUTELY WE'RE HERE AND THAT'S
THE POINT RIGHT SO THAT WE CAN
COME TO A COMPROMISE THE
OPPOSITION IS NOT WILLING TO
COMPROMISE IF THERE IS A AN
EXTENSION AND THAT'S WHY.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE COMMITTEE
AND FOR YOU TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS AND THAT'S THE
COMPROMISE THAT WE ARE ASKING
FOR SO THAT IF THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN IT SATISFIES YOUR YOUR
REQUEST.
RIGHT IF BY EX DATE IT'S NOT
DONE THEN THIS THIS IS COMPLETE
BILLS WHATEVER THE TWO YEARS TWO
AND A HALF.
IS COMPLETELY GONE I THINK THAT
WOULD DRIVE THE THE URGENCY
WOULD DRIVE DOWN THE INDUSTRY TO
COME UP WITH THAT TRACK AND
TRACE PROGRAM.
I APPRECIATE THAT -- IT FEELS
PRETTY URGENT TO THEM RIGHT NOW.
THEY'RE ALL HERE -- AND SO.
AT THIS POINT.
I WANT TO SEE I MEAN IS MY
PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE JUST THE
PERSPECTIVE OF ONE MEMBER HERE
BUT I THINK THE DEADLINE WE'VE
GOTTEN LAW IS THE DRIVER.
I'M HAPPY TO MAKE THIS A TRACK
AND TRACE STUDY BILL.
OR BUT ALSO RESEARCH MIL BUT
MISTER TEN RESIDENT YOU CAN
SPEND SOME TIME IF YOU WANT
DURING RECESS WHEN WE GO OFF AND
DO SOME THINKING.
BUT THE AGAIN THE GOOD FAITH
LIKE TAKE ANOTHER TWO AND A HALF
AND FIGURED OUT THAT IF IT WORKS.
NINE WERE FROM GAIN BUT OUT
AGAIN WITH ALL DUE RESPECT WE
DID CALL WE CALL THE OPPOSITION
FOR STAKEHOLDER MEETING AND
NOBODY SHOWED UP.
SO SO YOU'RE PUTTING ON THESE
YOU KNOW THESE REQUIREMENTS BUT
WHEN PEOPLE ARE NOT AT THE TABLE
WE CAN'T HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS
THE SHERMAN OCCURRED BEFORE EVEN
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT WE AT LEAST BE AFFORDED.
THE DURATION OF THE SESSION TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE RIGHT AND A
IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
OF TWENTY TWENTY WITH THIS
EXPIRES RIGHT IF WE EXTENDED IT
TO JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WE WOULD -- HAVE IN PLACE A
ALMOST AS URGENT DEADLINE IS
ONLY ONE YEAR -- ADDITIONAL TIME --
MAYBE WE COULD WORK SOME
COOPERATION THEM WITH FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND HAVE THE DIRECTOR
PLAY SOME ROLE IN -- IN YOU KNOW.
MONITORING THE PROGRESS AND A
AND AN ADDRESS THAT BUT I THINK.
YOU KNOW.
UNLESS THE INDUSTRY'S PREPARED
TO TELL US TODAY THAT THEY CAN
HAVE A TRACK AND TRACE PROGRAM
IN PLACE BY JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY WHICH I DON'T BELIEVE
THEY ARE IN MY DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE INDUSTRY AND I'LL LET THEM
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
I THINK A A MINIMUM ONE YEAR I
WOULD SAY TWO YEARS -- TO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWITTER TO BUT GIVEN
YOU KNOW YOUR STRONG FEELINGS
THAT WE NEED TO MAINTAIN.
THEIR FEET TO THE FIRE AND I
DON'T I DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT -- PERHAPS A
WHEN YOUR SCHEDULE ALLOWS TO
MOVE FORWARD WE COULD STICK TO
TRACK AND TRACE LANGUAGE AND WE
COULD.
ENGAGE THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND AND REALLY
START TO SET A MODEL THAT WOULD
SERVE THIS COMMITTEE AND THIS
LEGISLATURE ON OTHER BILLS AS
WELL.
IN CASE GET SOME PERSPECTIVE
FROM THE OTHER THE OPPOSITION
STAKEHOLDERS AND THEN.
HI THIS IS A VERY ROBUST HEALTHY
CONVERSATION HERE SO I
APPRECIATE IT -- BUT JUST IN
TERMS OF PROCESS WISE IN RIGHT --
SO UP.
BIG PROBLEM WE HAVE WITH THE
TRACKING TRACES.
WE CAN IMAGINE THAT THE STATE OF
LOUISIANA COULD POSSIBLY PUT IN
A TRACK AND TRACE I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE I
CERTAINLY DON'T THINK IT COULD
BE DONE BY THE END OF THE YEAR.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TEXAS
FLORIDA VIETNAM?
BOB WAY PLACES ALL AROUND THE
WORLD.
ANY ANYTHING THAT THE FOLKS HERE
COULD COME UP WITH WOULD NOT
AFFECT THOSE PLACES THOSE
PRODUCTS THOSE ANIMALS WILL BE
COMING INTO THE CITY CALIFORNIA
BEING SOLD.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE THEY COULD
CRAFT THAT WOULD PULL THOSE
COUNTRIES IN.
YOU PROBABLY HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THEN
UP THEIR SITE IS TO DO SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN QUICKLY
[inaudible]
AND JUST SO EVERYONE KNOWS.
THIS IS FOR THE MEDICAL PORTION
YOU CAN HAVE.
A LIVE ANIMALS COME INTO THE
STATE SO RESEARCH PLACES COULD
HAVE LIVE TRUCKS COME IN AND
THEN THEY HANDLE THEM WITHIN THE
RESEARCH LAB.
WE KNOW THAT OUR CURRENT LAW
YEAH UNDER CURRENT LAW UNDER THE
IF THE BAND GO WENT INTO PLACE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE HAVE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE
READ ALOUD FOR RESEARCH BUT ARE
NOT COMMERCIALLY SOLD.
THAT DOES NOT SEEM LIKE IT WOULD
BE AN ISSUE -- WILL TAKE ONE
MORE COMMENT PERHAPS ADDRESS
THAT LAST POINT SO -- EVEN IF WE
WERE ABLE TO IMPORT LIVE
ALLIGATORS IN THE STATE IN ORDER
TO CONDUCT RESEARCH THE
AVAILABILITY THE SUPPLY OF THOSE
ALLIGATORS WOULD BE THREATENED
BECAUSE THE FUNDING FOR THE
FARMS IN PARTICULAR IN THE
WETLANDS PRESERVATION WOULD BE
DIMINISHED WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
EARLIER SO.
IF YOU INCREASE THE COST OF THE
RAW MATERIAL YOU INCREASE THE
COST OF THE RESEARCH WHICH MEANS
THE RESEARCH WILL BE DONE.
BUT UNLIKE THE RESEARCH DONE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY THAT RESEARCH
WILL BE DONE IN NEVADA OR
MINNESOTA OR YOU TO OR ANOTHER
STATE YOU'RE SAYING A 25%
REDUCTION IN A BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY WILL DRIVE UP THE COST
OF THOSE PARTS SUCH THAT IT
WOULD BE.
NOT COST EFFECTIVE DO THAT
RESEARCH ANYMORE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE
THAT RESEARCH SHOULD BE
CONDUCTED ELSEWHERE BUT THEN
LET'S MAKE THIS WORK ON A
MEDICAL RESEARCH EXEMPTION HERE
AND THEN MAKE THAT THE CONDITION
OF THE THE TWO AND A HALF YEAR
THE ONE YEAR SOLELY FOR THOSE
PURPOSES SO WE DON'T DO ANY HARM.
BUT THEN DON'T AUTHORIZE THIS
COMMERCIAL MARKET IN THE
MEANTIME.
BUT THAT EXEMPTION COULDN'T
PRICE SAID THE RAW MATERIALS THE
NO NO YOU TO STUDY THAT ISSUE
AND YOU SEE IF THERE'S SOME.
YEAH.
WE COULD ACTUALLY TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT BUT RESEARCH FOLLOWS
FUNDING AND THE FUNDING SOURCES
WILL GO TO OTHER STATES BECAUSE
THE COST OF THOSE MATERIALS CAN
GET A CHEAPER SO THAT RESEARCH
WILL BE CONDUCTED ELSEWHERE.
IN IF WE DEVELOP THE CURE THEY
WILL BE DEVELOPED IN OTHER
STATES IRAQ'S THAT'S THE RISK
YEAH I I THINK.
THERE'S YOU CAN ARGUE THAT RISK
THE RISK OF FURTHER IN BOLD
INNING IN INTERNATIONAL WILDLIFE
TRACKING FEENEY.
TRAFFICKING INDUSTRY FOR TWO
YEARS.
TELL ME FAR OUTWEIGHS THAT RISK
AND I THINK WE CAN DEAL WITH
THAT RISK HEAD ON RIGHT NOW IN
THE CONTEXT OF THIS BILL IN
DOING.
A CONDITIONAL EXTENSION ON JUST
THE MEDICAL RESEARCH PIECE --
AND THEN LOOKING GIVING THE SHOT
CLOCK ON GETTING TRACK ENTRY
SANCTION UP AND RUNNING AND THEN
REVISITING THIS SPANISH IN THE
FUTURE SO I AGAIN I I'M WILLING
TO SOLVE.
THAT PROBLEM HERE I JUST DON'T
KNOW.
I DON'T.
I CAN'T.
GO ON BLIND FAITH OR EVEN.
ANY KIND OF FAITH RIGHT NOW IN
THE ZIMBABWEAN GOVERNMENT TO THE
VIETNAMESE GOVERNMENT'S
COMPLIANCE WITH PUTTING RFID
CHIPS IN.
YOU KNOW THESE CRACKS ME AYE AYE
EIGHT WE HAVE A TOUGH ENOUGH
TIME ENFORCING LABOR LAWS AND
ALL THE REST OF IT SO THAT'S
WHERE I'M STRUGGLING.
YEAH ARE YOU JUST MEASURE THE
WEEK.
AGAIN I'M I'M GET LOST BECAUSE
IF WE HAVE A TRACK INTEREST
PROGRAM.
AND IF WE REQUIRE FOR THE SALE
OF PRODUCTS WITHIN THE BOUNDS OF
CALIFORNIA I KNOW SOME OF US
LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE THIS TO
BE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT
IN FACT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
WE JUST RUN CALIFORNIA BUT NONE
THE LESS.
WE COULD HAVE A PROGRAM THAT
RESTRICTS SO CELLS OF ANY PLACE
THAT DOESN'T COMPLY WITH THEIR
TRACK AND TRACE PROGRAM IF THE
TECHNOLOGY IN PLACE SORRY IT'S
AN ABSURD READ HER ARGUMENT TO
SUGGEST WHILE THERE WAS NO WAY
TO CONTROL.
OUT THERE IN FACT IS.
WHEN YOU START YOU KNOW WE ARE
VERY EFFECTIVE IN DEALING?
HAVE WHATEVER IN IT AND IT'S NOT
A LOT IT'S NOT ALLOWED IN.
HAS IT AND SO OF LOUISIANA CAN
MEET THAT STANDARD OF FLORIDA
CAN MEET THAT STANDARD -- GREAT
IF VIETNAM CAN'T WELL THEY'RE
NOT SELLING THEIR PRODUCTS HERE
RIGHT -- I'M NOT HERE TODAY
CERTAINLY WORTH THAT I AM HERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE WETLANDS IN
LOUISIANA AND FLORIDA AND THE
IMPACT OUR MARKET HAS ON THOSE
AND I'M CONCERNED THAT WE ARE UP
AGAINST A DEADLINE I WISH WE
WERE BEFORE YOUR COMMITTEE A
YEAR AGO BUT WE'RE HERE TODAY.
AND WE NEED MORE TIME -- I THINK
WE NEED A COUPLE YEARS.
I OFFERED UP TO THE COMMITTEE
PERHAPS WE CAN JUST DO A ONE
YEAR EXTENSION TO AT LEAST GET
US TO THE END OF THE SESSION SO
THAT WE CAN WORK IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH YOU.
AND THE COMMITTEE TO PUT IN
PLACE HARD DEADLINES ON A TRACK
AND TRACE AND ANY OTHER --
REFINEMENTS OF CALIFORNIA LAW
THAT WE THINK ARE APPLICABLE ARE
NECESSARY. TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
ONLY DEALING IN A LEGAL PRODUCT
WITH INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS AND
TREATIES AND SO ON SO I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR HELP IN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HELP IN --
DRAFTING OPPOSE THAT GIVES US AT
LEAST THAT ONE YEAR IF NOT TWO
YEAR PERIOD OF TIME TO
ACCOMPLISH SO SIX AND SUCH A
HARD DEADLINE ON TRACK ENTRIES
WE DON'T HAVE THAT LONG NOW WE
DON'T HAVE BY TWENTY TWENTY IF
YOU DON'T HAVE A TRACKING TRICKS.
LET'S PUT THAT IN WHAT WHAT WHAT
LET'S YOUR SHOW SOME LEADERSHIP
ON THAT ISSUE -- NOT JUST FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR THE COUNTRY.
I THINK THAT'S A COMPELLING
ARGUMENT.
I WOULD SAY LET'S LET'S JUST DO
THAT THEN IN THE BILL AND NOT
BUT NOT THE IN THE MEANTIME
UNTIL WE HAVE IT.
WE JUST START HOPE IT WORKS OUT
I MEAN I THAT THAT'S THE THING
IS.
WHAT WHAT HAPPENS IN THE GAP?
WHAT WHAT HOW DO WE DEAL WITH
THE GAPS OF THE ONES?
YEAH SORRY BUT LOOK AT I WERE I
DON'T WANT.
TO YOU CERTAINLY DON'T IT CENTER
COVER YOU'RE IN TROUBLE WITH
CAUCUS.
OTHER.
BUT I'M THE ONE KEEPING THIS
COMMITTEE GOT A FRIEND OVER
THERE I THINK WE CAN WORK CAN
YEAH YEAH I UNDERSTAND -- DID
YOU A QUICK COMMENT CENTER GO
HERE WELL I HEY I GUESS I WANTED
TO BRING THIS TO COME TO A
CONCLUSION ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
AND I WHAT I HEAR.
WE HAVE THE STATUS QUO RIGHT NOW
THE STATUS QUO IS WORKING.
SO I SUGGEST WE TAKE THE OFFER
THAT WAS MADE WHICH IS.
TO AB IT EXTENDED FOR A YEAR OR
TWO I THINK THE TRACK AND TRACE
IS REALLY IMPORTANT THAT'S THE
DIRECTION WE NEED TO GO IN AND
QUITE FRANKLY IF WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO BE IF WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
THIS.
IN THE LEAFY GREEN.
OUR AREA -- WE CERTAINLY.
AND WE'RE DOING IT IN IN THE
MARIJUANA CONTEXT WE OUGHT TO BE
ABLE TO DO IT WITH WITH -- LIVE
ANIMALS AND SO I I JUST THINK WE
CAN GET THERE I THINK WE NEED A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME TO DO IT.
I'M PREPARED TO MOVE MOVE THAT
WE MOVE THE BELT WITH THEY
WONDER TO WHATEVER THE CHAIR --
AB FED WOULD FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH THE EXTENSION SO THAT THE
STATUS QUO CAN CONTINUE AND WITH
THE REQUIREMENT THAT WE CREATE
THIS TRACK AND TRACE.
PROGRAM -- AND IT'D BE UP AND
RUNNING WITHIN IT WITH A DATE
CERTAIN SO THAT WE GET WHAT WE
REALLY WANT WHICH IS MY I THINK.
WHAT THE THAT THE ANOMALY HERE
IS YOU HAVE YOU HAVE STE AND AN
ANIMAL OVER THERE THERE IS --
STRONG FEELINGS AGAINST USING
THEIR PRODUCTS BUT WE ALSO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY I THINK TO HELP
THE WETLANDS WHICH IS
DESPERATELY IMPORTANT ON AIR AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT THE
FARMING CAN.
SUSTAINABLE FARMING OF THE
ANIMALS CONTINUES THAT'S HOW WE
IT SUPPORTED AND SO ANYWAY THAT
THAT WOULD BE MY MOTION IF THE
CHAIR -- I DESIRE BUT MIGHT MY
ONLY DISAGREE WITH EVERYTHING
YOU SAID IS I DON'T THINK IT'S
AS CLOSE WORKING.
AND I AND I'M NOT WILLING TO
EXTEND THIS WHY WHY ISN'T
WORKING ON THAT'S MY QUESTION
BECAUSE THERE'S A THERE'S A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR A MORE
INTERNATIONALLY.
WILDLIFE TRADE WHERE ANIMALS ARE
BEING CUT AT THE BACK OF THEIR
NECKS AND RAM ROGER RAM DOWN
THEIR SPINE I MEAN LIKE I MEAN.
WE'LL STUFF DON'T HAVE SOMETHING
INTO OUR COMMERCE AND I DON'T
WANT THOSE PRODUCTS THE ENDING
UP IN ST LOUIS VUITTON STORE
INSTEAD OF CAO FINE IS AN AGREED
BUT THAT'S THE THE VIETNAM AND
WHAT WE'RE SUGGESTING IS THAT
DOUBLES PRODUCTS.
NOT BE IMPORTED ONES GIVE US
TIME TO DO THE TRACK IN BETWEEN
GIVE US TIME ALLOWS IT FOR THAT
TIME. TO THAT THAT'S THE PROBLEM
IS WHEN YOU SAY GIVE US TIME IT
GIVES US TIME TO ALLOW MORE THAT
PRODUCT COME IN IF YOU WANT TO
CUT IT OFF.
ON THE CURRENT STATUTORY
DEADLINE AND THEN SET UP A
PROGRAM WE CAN HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION -- I'M I'M VERY OPEN
TO THAT BUT IT'S THE ORDERING AT
THINGS I THINK WE'RE GOING
AROUND IN CIRCLES A LITTLE BIT
HERE SO.
I I'M I'M HAPPY ALSO ENTERTAIN
THAT MOTION I'D I DON'T CONSIDER
THAT HOSTILE THEM IF YOU WANNA
MAKE THAT BUT I CAN'T BE THERE
ON ON THAT KIND OF SORT OF ONE
YEAR TO YEAR -- AND THEN THAT
THE SHOT CLOCK IS HERE NOW --
AND IF YOU ALREADY TO COME FORTH
WITH YOU KNOW A PRODUCT THAT
WORKS TODAY GREAT IF NOT --
LET'S WORK ON A MEDICAL ISSUE OR
LET'S SEE IF IT EVEN IMPACTS THE
INDUSTRY IS YOU'RE YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT SO -- ANY ON
THIS ISSUE CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMENTS SIR COME HERE
THANK YOU CLOSE TO MINE I WILL
MAKE THIS MY CLOSELY -- AND THE
REVIEWS SAY -- I WOULD WELCOME A
MOTION.
I THINK.
YOUR POINT SHERMAN YOU'RE IN A
PLACE OF TWENTY TWENTY IS A
DEADLINE PERIOD THE END NO.
NO EXTENSION WEATHER HAS TRACK
CONTRITION NOT WHERE WE ARE IN
AGREEMENT AS WE'D ALL LIKE TO
SEE TRACK AND TRACE PROGRAM THAT
THAT IS THE AREA OF AGREEMENT WE
FOUND HERE.
IF.
IF YOU WOULD MAKE A MOTION SIR
CARRIER THAT WOULD EXTEND US A
PERIOD OF TIME.
WITH A HARD DEADLINE OF GETTING
THAT TRACK AND TRACE PROGRAM --
YOU KNOW I SAID TWO YEARS.
PEOPLE SAID ONE YEAR MAYBE MAYBE
YEAR AND A HALF MAYBE EIGHTEEN
MONTHS WOULD BE NICE -- AND
THAT'S THE HARD DEADLINE AND I
CAN TELL THE COMMITTEE THE
CHAIRMAN A REAL SO I WILL NOT BE
BACK BEFORE YOU -- ASKING FOR
MORE TIME I WILL WORK WITH YOU
TO ENSURE THAT THE INDUSTRY MEET
THAT DEADLINE -- IT BEING A HARD
DEADLINE.
I'M HERE TO MAKE THE MOTION --
AND THE AND I MAY BE THE ONLY
ONE THAT SUPPORTS IT BUT I I I I
MOVE THAT WE WE ACCEPT.
SUPPORT THE BELL WITH A TRACK
AND TRACE REQUIREMENT IN IT AS
WELL IT'S NOT THERE RIGHT NOW
WHICH IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
AMENDED -- AND THAT WE WE GIVE
THEM A YEAR AND A HALF.
I'LL TAKE THE YEAR AND A HALF.
OKAY SO I'M.
WILL ON ORTHODOX BUT I DON'T
MIND THE ROBUST DISCUSSION SO
THE MOTION IS JUST TO BE.
BE CLEAR HERE -- IT. TOO IT'S A
FIVE YEAR EXTENSION ME IN THE
POSE IN THE BILL NOW WOULD BE A
ONE AND A HALF YEAR EXTENSION.
I'M WITH A REQUIREMENT THE END
OF THAT ONE AND A HALF YEARS TO
ESTABLISH A TRACK AND TRACE
PROGRAM.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE THE MOTION
BEFORE THE COMMITTEES HAVE IT IN
PLACE HAVE IN PLACE AT THE END
OF THAT ONE AND A HALF YEARS.
AS I SAID WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I
CAN'T SUPPORT THAT -- BASED ON
THE CURRENT STATE IN THE
INDUSTRY SO.
I'LL BE A NO ON THAT BUT I DO
WELCOME.
OTHER MEMBERS.
TO TAKE THEIR OWN VIEWS HERE
CENTER ALLEN YOU WANT TO CHIME
IN WITH ONE LAST BIT OF WISDOM
YEAH I WAS LIKE YOU EIGHT EIGHT
CAUCUS TO WHICH I'M VERY UPSET
ABOUT -- I'M HOPING YEAH YOU'RE
SATISFIED.
IN DOWN YOU THIS WHEN I WHEN I I
HEAR YOU'VE BEEN DOING A GREAT
JOB MISTER CHAIR HOLD DOWN THE
FORT AND OF THE PREACHING AND
ROBUST NEGOTIATION.
HI SO I APPRECIATE THAT -- WE
HAD SOME WEIRD BIZARRE PIECE IN
USE IN IN IN CAUCUS I'LL TELL
YOU ABOUT.
I'M.
ALL RIGHT SO I I I HAVING ANY
UPDATES IN A I AM.
MY PLAN RIGHT NOW I I LIKE THE
DIRECTION THIS IS GOING I THINK
IT'S STILL WHAT YOU PROPOSED ON
CENTER COVER YOUR EYES.
A LITTLE TOO LEAN FOR ME GIVEN
THE HISTORY.
I'M SO MY PLAN RIGHT NOW IS TO
LAY OFF AND AND HAVE OUR STAFF
CIRCLE THAT THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING IS GOING TO CONTINUE
GOING FOR MANY MANY HOURS I
THINK GIVEN.
THE LENGTH OF THIS AGENDA AND SO --
YOU KNOW I'M GONNA LAY OUT FOR
NOW WITH THE GIVE AND CAN SEE
WHERE THE CONVERSATIONS GO -- I
DO LIKE THE FACT WE'RE GETTING
SERIOUS ABOUT TRACK AND TRACE I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
ME THAT THERE BE. FIVE YOUR DFW
SIGN UP FOR SOMEONE SIMILAR AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING IT JUST BE
POLICED BY THE INDUSTRY'S I'LL I
MEAN I YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK
THE INCENTIVES ARE STRUCTURED.
PROPERLY FOR THAT [inaudible]
I'M.
I THINK WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT
SOME CERTAIN ANIMAL WELFARE
COMPONENT TO THIS.
I'M I'M BUT I I I I CERTAINLY I
I APPRECIATE THE OPEN ENDED
DISCUSSION THAT THAT I'VE I'VE
BEEN HEARING ABOUT IN.
OUR APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT OF
THE CHAIR AND I THINK YOU'VE
BEEN PUSHING BACK AND ALLOW THE
RIGHT DIRECTIONS CENTER.
SO I'M GONNA LEAVE IT TO YOUR
DISCRETION DO YOU DO YOU WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT MOTION NOW OR DO
YOU WANT TO LEAVE THE MEASURE ON
CALL -- I THINK GIVEN SURROUNDS
ONE IS TO HAVE STAFF.
GET TOGETHER AND HAVE SOME
DISCUSSIONS AND SIR COVERS
WILLINGNESS TO MAKE MOTION ONE A
WE HOLD OFF ON THE MOTION RIGHT
NOW JUST MAKE THE MOTION THAT.
HAS CONSENSUS IF IN FACT WE GET
THE CONSENSUS THIS AFTERNOON I
THINK THAT WOULD BE -- THERE HAS
MISTER CHAIRMAN AFTER AMENABLE
VERY GOOD OKAY -- SO.
THANK YOU FOR THE THOROUGH
CONVERSATION ALL THE ENGAGEMENT
HERE FROM ALL MEMBERS -- WE WILL
CALL A RECESS AND WE LEAVE THEM
OUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
VERY GOOD I'LL GO UP AND TRY TO
FIND SOME SCRAPS.
YEAH ALL RIGHT -- WE CAN KILL
WILL BE RECONVENING.
AT ONE THIRTY IN ROOM -- ONE
THIRTEEN SO ROOM. ONE THIRTEEN
AT ONE THIRTY THAT'S A RECESS
PATIENT AUTHOR HERE'S SOMETHING
MEMBER BLOOM WITH US -- WE NEED
TO RE ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO WE
DON'T NEED TO REESTABLISH MORE
SO.
ANSWER I THINK YOU'VE GOT TO
MEASURES BEFORE US HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBER.
AT YOUR DISCRETION HAVE WHATEVER
ORDER YOU WANT THANK YOU WILL
LOVE BEGIN -- IF IT'S ALRIGHT
WITH.
AB.
FIFTEEN ELEVEN THE SANTA MONICA
BAY RESTORATION COMMISSION AND
THAT -- BACK IN ANOTHER LIFE I
WAS THE A A MEMBER OF AND AND IT
AND THE CHAIR OF IS A NON
REGULATORY STATE AND EIGHTY
ENACTED BY THE STATE LEGISLATURE
AND IT'S TASKED WITH
COORDINATING FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL EFFORTS TO RESTORE.
AND ENHANCE.
OUR BEAUTIFUL SANTA MONICA BAY
AND THE AND THE WATERSHED THAT
SURROUNDS IT.
AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN UPDATES THE
STATUTES GOVERNING THE
COMMISSION BY REPLACING THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD IS THE AGENCY RESPONSIBLE
FOR ITS ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT.
WITH THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY.
AND IT REVISES THE PURPOSE OF
THE COMMISSION GIVING AT NEW
GOALS RELATED TO THE RESTORATION
AND ENHANCEMENT OF THE BAND
WATERSHED THAT WERE ALSO ADOPTED
AND APPROVED.
BY THE COMMISSION IN. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE REVISED PURPOSE AND
GOALS OF THE COMMISSION CREATE A
NATURAL ALIGNMENT WITH THE ROLE
OF THE STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY
WHO ALREADY PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
FOR GRANTS AND OTHER SUPPORT TO
THE COMMISSION.
AND THE BILL DOES NOT IN ANYWAY
ALL TO THE COMMISSION'S
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE NOR DOES IT
CHANGE THE PUBLIC PROCESS THAT
IS CURRENTLY UNDER WAY. TO
ADDRESS THE STRUCTURE IT'S
SIMPLY REPLACES THE STATE AGENCY
THAT IS CHARGED WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE DUTIES ONLY.
THIS IS GOING TO LEAD TO A MORE
EFFECTIVE APPROACH FOR THIS
IMPORTANT IMPROVEMENT OF SANTA
MONICA BAND THE WATERSHED.
THE BILL IS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
TODAY SEATED NEXT TO ME IS TOM
FORD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE BAY
FOUNDATION WHO WILL AT HIS
COMMENTS AND ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE VERY
GOOD THANK.
WELCOME THANK YOU.
VERY VERY BRIEF AND I'VE GOT A
BIG DAY -- THE SOME SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES NOW IN OUR APPROACH.
TRYING PROTECT PROMOTE PRESERVE
ENHANCE THE ECOLOGY AND WATER
QUALITY SOCIO ECONOMIC BENEFITS
OF OF SANTA MONICA BANDS VALUES.
SOME ARE.
I THINK SO THAT WOULD BE VERY
AWARE OF CLIMATE CHANGE HAS
CERTAINLY ARRIVED WE ARE TRYING
TO MODIFY OUR APPROACH IS AND
CHANGE SOME OF OUR PRIORITIES.
TO DRESS AT THE DECADES OF
DEDICATED WORK AND INVESTMENT IN
IMPROVING WATER QUALITY ARE
DELIVERING RESULTS -- AND THAT
HAS ALLOWED US TO ACTUALLY
CONDUCT MORE EFFECTIVE -- IN
LARGER SCALE RESTORATION
PROJECTS ARE VERY PROUD OF THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING ON OUR
BEACHES VERY PROUD OF THE
PARTNERS THAT WE WORK WITH --
AND A RESERVE MANY OF MY
ANYTHING ELSE THAT YOU NEED TO
HEAR FROM YOU TODAY IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS.
SHE THAT -- DO HAVE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE
[inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND FOR
HELPING US THROUGH THIS.
INNOVATION AN EVOLUTION OF WHAT
THE THE COMMISSION HAS BEEN AND
KNOW THE HISTORY IS LONG.
THE ONE OFFERED OPPORTUNITY TO
THE CENTER OF JURISDICTION EVEN
THOUGH WE SHARE THE SANTA MONICA
BAY.
AT THE NORTHERN EDGE.
DOWN TO THE SOUTHERN -- BUT ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
I MEAN I I MY STAFF IS TALK TO
YOUR STAFF.
SOME MEMBER AND AND YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY SINCE YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE I KNOW THERE BEEN SOME
CHALLENGES WITH ON ISSUES
RELATED.
TO YOU KNOW NOW SENATOR I'M
SORRY AS A SIGN UP IN A A LOT OF
AMBIENT NOISE YEAH YEAH.
ANOTHER BILL YOUR INVOLVEMENT I
THINK OUTSIDE.
SO [inaudible]
ANYHOW -- I GUESS MY MY QUESTION
WELL IT DID IT LOOKS AS THOUGH
WE FROM MY UNDERSTANDING.
THE PRIMARY CONCERNS THAT I'VE
HEARD THEY'RE OUT THERE ABOUT
THE BILL REALLY.
HAVE LESS TO DO WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BILL THEY HAVE TO DO
WITH HER BROADER CONCERNS ABOUT.
I A ISSUES IN THE EXACTLY
DIRECTOR AND THE ME IN THE
STRUCTURE OF OF OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO PULL TOGETHER HERE SO
I I CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE ANY
PROBLEM WITH WHAT YOU'RE DOING
THIS BILL -- I DO THINK.
BUT BUT THERE ARE THERE ARE
THERE ARE SWIRLING IN A BROADER
ISSUES THAT IN REYES BY THE
OPPOSITION I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK
TO THEM AT ALL BUT BUT I THINK
IT.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE IS EMILY
REASONABLE?
SENATOR ALLEN YOU'VE GOT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR HERE.
RIGHT YEAH CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU THE BUT WHAT I
WOULD SUBMIT IS THAT -- THE THE
LOCAL CONTROL OF THIS
PARTNERSHIP THAT DEAD ROUTE IS.
INHERENT IN THE SOUND MARKET
NATIONAL HISTORY PROGRAM
INHERENT IN THE SANTA MONICA BAY
RESTORATION COMMISSION -- IS
PRECISE WHERE THAT SHOULD BE --
SO THAT BODY THE COMMISSION IS
UNDERGOING.
A CONSIDERATION OF ITS
STRUCTURAL AND GOVERNANCE
PRACTICES RIGHT NOW -- THAT WE
ANTICIPATE THAT IN AND YOU WILL
BE PRODUCED BY THE END OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR IF NOT EARLIER
THAT'LL HELP CLEAR UP SOME OF
THAT CONFUSION -- WHAT I WOULD
SUGGEST IS THAT IF IF THERE'S
ANY -- ANY RESPONSIBILITY THAT
HAS THAT I WOULD TAKE ON OR MY
PREDECESSORS BEFORE ME THAT WE
WERE VERY GOOD AT TIGHTENING UP
OUR PAPERWORK SOMEWHERE
SOMETIMES ALONG THE WAY.
AND THE JUSTIFIABLE CONFUSION AS
A RESULT BUT I THINK WE'RE READY
TO DO WITH THIS THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD AND THE
STATE BECAUSE CONSERVANCY ARE ON
BOARD.
KNOWING WHAT THEY'RE GETTING
INTO AND ARE LOOKING FOR TO
PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT.
YEAH I HAVE AND YOU A YOU'VE
BEEN ENGAGING WITH THE SIERRA
CLUB ON THEIR CONCERNS AND I
THINK THAT THE HOUSES ARE POINTS
OUT THE MAYBE THEY'LL BE A
CONFUSION WITH REGARDS TO THE
CLUBS OPPOSITION TO THE MAYBE
COMPLAIN DRINKING WATER SUPPLY
WOULD PROPOSE NEW.
TERM WATER SUPPLY.
BUT I THINK WE'VE BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM BUT
CERTAINLY THEY HAVE BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM -- BUT I
WOULD SAY IS THAT AS THE
RESPONSE -- FROM THE CONSULTANT
ON THIS IS THAT A LOT OF THE
PROJECT THAT WE LOOK AT AREN'T
INTENDED JUST.
PROVIDE.
IMPROVED WATER QUALITY BUT IN
THE CONSCIOUSNESS THAT AND WE
HAVE A LIMITED WATER SUPPLY OR
THAT WERE IN SOMETHING MORE OF A
PERENNIAL DROUGHT.
THAT GETTING THAT WATER BACK
INTO THE GROUND RECHARGING OUR
AQUIFER'S AND PUTTING LA BACK ON
ITS OWN FEET FROM A LOCAL WATER
STANDPOINT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'VE
BEEN ASKED TO DO BY OUR PARTNERS
IN THE REGION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
VERY HELPFUL -- AND I'M SORRY
BUT I BROKE PROTOCOL HERE AND
DID NOT ALLOW OPTING FOR
OPPOSITION TO TESTIFY.
SO -- PLEASE TAKE A MOMENT ANY
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD
YES.
YOU CAN CHECK TO SEE IF HE IF
YOU.
YES WHAT WILL FREE UP THAT SEAT
FOR SEX [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE CAN HAVE YOU BACK IN A MINUTE
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU WATER
MEMBERS IN THE BY ON A WETLANDS
LAND TRUST.
WE OPPOSE WITH THE UNLESS
AMENDED NOT BECAUSE WE CARE
ABOUT WHO PROVIDES OFFICE
SUPPLIES TO THE COMMISSION OF
THE GUEST LIMIT AB FIFTEEN
ELEVEN IS ABOUT. TO UNDERSTAND
ARE CONCERNED IF YOU LOOK AT THE
FROM.
ASSEMBLY RELATIONS ANALYSIS
YOU'LL SEE THAT.
THE CONSERVANCY IS CONTEMPLATING
WATER TO STATE EMPLOYEES SO
RIGHT OFF THE BAT THAT COULD BE
A CUT IN HALF OF THE EXISTING
CITY EMPLOYEES
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
THE COMMISSION STAFF FOR DECADES
HAS MOSTLY COME FROM THE
FOUNDATION.
DO YOU ARE BASED ON AN AGREEMENT
THAT'S VERY CLEAR AT STILL
ARCHIVED ON THE COMMISSION'S
WEBSITE.
IN WHICH THE FOUNDATION WOULD
GET THE FEDERAL USEPA FUNDS.
AND WOULD IT TAKE THOSE FUNDS TO
HIRE THE COMMISSION STAFF SOME
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN FOR
EXAMPLE.
THERE ARE EIGHTEEN COMMISSION
STAFF POSITIONS.
LISTED IN THE WORK PLAN AND
THESE FOLKS WERE DOING AGENCY
WORK THINGS LIKE PRESS RELEASES
FROM THE COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR.
SITTING HERE DOING BUDGETARY
WORK TO THE MINISTRY OF DR SO
ANY STAKEHOLDER THE COMMISSION
WE DON'T CARE ABOUT WHERE THE
OFFICE SUPPLIES COME FROM WE
CARE ABOUT THE FACT THAT.
WHAT WAS A FULLY STAFFED STATE
AGENCIES DOES NOT A FULLY
STAFFED STATE AGENCY?
AND THAT THIS AGENCIES NOT GOING
TO IN DEPEND BE ABLE TO
INDEPENDENTLY EXECUTE THE DUTIES
THAT THE EXISTING LEGISLATION.
AND THE FUTURE LEGISLATION
INCLUDE THE OTHER THING I'LL SAY
IS THAT.
STATE DISSIPATION IN THE ANY P.
IS NEVER INTERFERENCE IT'S
ACTUALLY REQUIREMENTS TO FIT THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE CLEAN WATER
ACT.
THIS IS A THIRTY ONE YEAR OUR
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
WATER BOARDS AND THAT THE
COMMISSION WHICH USED TO BE
CALLED THE PROJECT.
AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY.
COMPELLING CHANGE THE ACTION
PLAN WAS ADOPTED IN OCTOBER
EXPRESSLY EMPHASIZES THE
CONTINUITY OF THE MISSION OF THE
COMMISSION.
AGAIN IT'S A CLEAN WATER ACT
PROGRAM SO THERE'S NOT A
MOVEMENT AWAY FROM CLEAN WATER
AND THE OTHER ISSUES IN TERMS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE COASTAL ACCESS.
HABITAT RESTORATION HAVE LONG
BEEN PRIORITIES OF THE
COMMISSION.
SO WE WOULD SIMPLY ASK.
IS THAT.
IF THIS IF.
IF THE WAY THAT THE COMMISSION
HAS STARTED RUNNING IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS OF THAT'S WHAT YOU
WANT.
THERE SHOULD BE A VERY PRECISE
LEGISLATIVE BILL FOR LOTS OF THE
PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS WHAT'S GOING
ON IF THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU WANT.
THEN WE WOULD ASK YOU.
TO THINK ABOUT THIS BILL BECAUSE
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS HAPPENING
HERE IS THAT.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT.
THAT WHEN THE PUBLIC TRIES TO
ENFORCE STATE TRANSPARENCY LAWS
AND PUBLIC INTEREST LAWS.
THE ARGUMENT GOING TO BE THAT
YOU FOLKS ENDORSED.
THIS DIMINISHMENT OF THE OF THE
COMMISSION PROPERLY STAFF STATE
AGENCY AN AGENCY THAT DOES NOT
STAFF DIED.
I WOULD JUST ARGUE THAT.
THE THE THE SALES AND THE WRITER.
AND THE CREW RIGHT OF THIS
VESSEL HAVE BEEN TAKEN AWAY AND
IT'S IT'S NOW JUST SORT OF
FLOATING IN A DINGY BEHIND THE
FOUNDATION.
AND THAT'S NOT MEANT TO BE A
KNOCK ON THE FOUNDATION IT'S
MEANT TO BE.
A PROTECTION AGAIN OF THE PUBLIC
INTEREST WHEN THIS COMMISSION
WAS GREAT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO THAT WAS A MULTI YEAR MULTI
STEP VERY DELIBERATE OF PROCESS.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE
THIS.
WAS WRITTEN SO INNOCUOUS AN
INNOCUOUS LEE.
THAT ANYONE FELT THE NEED TO
READ THROUGH ANY OF THOSE
DOCUMENTS.
BUT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT HISTORY TO
UNDERSTAND WHY WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT A. B..
FIFTEEN ELEVEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I APPRECIATED -- WE'VE ANY
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION HERE TODAY.
OKAY SEEING NONE -- BRING IT
BACK TO THE DíAS OR MAYBE GIVE
YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND AS
SOME OF THOSE CRITICISMS I I
DIDN'T ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND THE
FULL NATURE OF THE OPPOSITION
UNTIL JUST NOW SO -- YEAH --
WHAT IT WOULD DO WE SAVE BACK?
TO THE THOSE CONCERNS
[inaudible]
HE CHANGES THAT THIS BILL BRING
FORWARD ARE RELATIVELY LIMITED
THE OVERSIGHT OF THE AGENCY IS
GOING. TO RESIDE.
WITH A DIFFERENT AGENCY THAT'S
GOING TO ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF
THE BAY RESTORATION COMMISSION
TO DO WHAT IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN
CHARTERED TO DO AND THAT'S TO
LOOK OUT FOR THE BEST INTEREST.
OF SANTA MONICA BAY AND THE AND
THE WATERSHED.
YEAH WHAT WHAT I MIGHT DODD ADD
OF CURRENTLY THE WATER RESOURCE
QUALITY CONTROL BOARD FOR A
PROVIDES ONE POINT TWO P. WHY --
TO SUPPORT THE COMMISSION -- THE
SOME OF THE DESCRIPTION THAT
MISTER LAMB JUST PROVIDED FOR US --
THAT THE STATE STAFFING USED TO
BE VERY -- THAT MUCH MORE
ELEVATED THAN IT IS NOW THAT THE
FOUNDATION SORT OF GOBBLED UP
THOSE PEOPLE -- THE THERE WAS A
TRADITION DURING THE
200-082-0009 -- RECESSION AND
THOSE.
POSITIONS WERE NEVER REPLACED --
ALL OF THE WORK THAT THE
FOUNDATION HAS DONE.
TO USE THE MONEY THAT THEY
UNITED STATES ENVIRONMENT
TEXTING Z. PROVIDES TO THIS
PRIVATE PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP.
LOCAL STATE FEDERAL BOMB HAS HAS
HAD GREAT SUCCESS -- I THINK
WE'RE MAKING A SMART MOVE TO
FIND A AGENCY IN THE STATE
BECAUSE OF CONSERVANCY THAT IS
EAGER TO SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM --
I THINK THEY WILL WORK HARD TO
FIND SOME MORE RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM AND I DON'T
THINK THAT THERE'S REALLY. TOO
MANY -- I I COULDN'T UNDERSTAND
SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS I WOULD
SAY THAT WERE PRESENTED.
YOU'RE SAYING AS IT DID YOU'RE
DOING THIS FOR FOR READ FOR
RESOURCE PURPOSES THAT IS AT THE
HEART OF THE BILL.
EFFORT IS A GOVERNANCE AND
IMPLEMENT BY MAYBE THAT RESOURCE
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU MEAN
SERVICE ENDED TO ADEQUATE
STAFFING YOU HAVE TO CHANGE.
NO I WAS I WOULD SAY THAT SOME
OF THE PRIORITIES -- THAT WE
RECOGNIZE AS HIGHER PRIORITIES
AND INCREASED PERHAPS AN
ORDINATION -- DURING THIS
REVISION -- OF THE PLAN IN THE
APPROVAL OF A NEW PLAN IN
OCTOBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT
COASTAL ACCESS CLIMATE CHANGE.
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE
PLANNING AND NUMBER OF THOSE
ASPECTS.
ARE MORE REFLECTIVE OF THE
EXPERTISE AND THE STRATEGIC PLAN
OF THE STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY
RATHER THAN THAT OF THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES QUALITY CONTROL
BOARD.
DECADES OF IMPROVEMENT IN WATER
QUALITY.
YOU MIND IF I JUST AS JUST RUN
THAT TO GROUND THE OPPOSITION
AND I'M.
ALRIGHT IN ANTICIPATE THIS.
EVEN TAKE YOUR BUT GIVE A
COMMENT ON THAT THAT WHAT YOU
CAN YOU CAN COME UP TO THAT MY
HAVE TO CONTEST THE IDEA THAT
THIS IS FROM THE RECESSION FROM
TWO THOUSAND THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT.
A DROP IN STAFF FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE FY TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN IS A PRINTER.
FORTY WORK PLAN.
IN IT IT IS BLACK AND WHITE
PEOPLE JUST ACTUALLY HAD THE
TIME TO READ THE DOCUMENTS IT'S
STILL ON THE COMMISSION WEBSITE.
EIGHTEENS POSITIONS TO FROM THE
STATE SIXTEEN FROM THE
FOUNDATION.
WE FILED THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST IN JUNE OR JULY OF TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WITHIN TWO
WEEKS.
A BIG CHUNK OF THOSE EMPLOYEES.
CAME OFF THE STATE AGENCY
WEBSITE THESE ARE FOLKS WHO
HEADED OUT BUSINESS CARDS THEY
WROTE.
LETTERS ON STOP GOOD GOVERNMENT
AGENCY STATIONARY.
THEIR EMAILS ENDED WITH
COMMISSION.
THEY'RE GONE.
AND SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
HAVING EIGHTEEN POSITIONS
COMMISSION POSITIONS.
GOING DOWN TO POTENTIALLY ONE OR
TWO I AGAIN THE COMMISSION
HASN'T ISSUED A PRESS RELEASE IN
THREE YEARS.
I USED TO HAVE A COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR AND THEY WOULD ISSUE
PRESS RELEASES.
THEY HAVEN'T ISSUED A PRESS
RELEASE IN THREE YEARS.
IS A NUMBER THAT WE WE CARE
ABOUT THE VIOLENCE.
WHEN THE DRAFT A ARE CAME OUT?
THIS IS A HIGH PRIORITY PROJECT
OF THE COMMISSION HAS BEEN FOR
MANY YEARS.
THE ONLY REASON THEY GAVE AS TO
WHY THEY COULDN'T WAY IN.
WHICH IS WHAT THE LEGISLATION
MANDATES RIGHT MONITOR ASSESS
COORDINATED BY THE ONLY REASON
THAT WAS GIVEN WAS THE LIMITED
STAFF CAPACITY OF THE COMMISSION.
SO WE HAVE A LEGITIMATE REASON
TO CARE ABOUT THIS DROP AND
STAFF.
I WOULD SAY ONE QUICK QUESTION
IF I COULD JUST PUT IT IN. FOR
YOU DO SO SO THE SENATE THE
ISSUE THE CONCERN FROM THE
OPPOSITION IS ABOUT.
THE LACK OF RESOURCES.
GOING INTO STAFFING POSITIONS IN
SORT OF LEAVING A SHELL OF THE
COMMISSION.
IS THIS BILL.
ADDRESS RESOURCES IN ANY WAY OR
IS THIS MORE ABOUT.
GOVERNANCE AND REORGANIZATION IN
YOUR MIND IS IT'S THE LATTER --
THE REASON FOR THE CHANGE HERE
IT IS -- BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT -- CAN BE
PROVIDED BY THE CONSERVANCY IS
MORE IN LINE WITH THE GOALS AND
THE MISSION OF THE CONSERVANCY
THAN THE STATE WATER RESOURCES.
CONTROL BOARD -- MISTER FORD CAN
RESPOND.
TO EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE HEARD
OF BUT I THINK IT THAT YOU'VE
HEARD BUT I I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO FOCUS IN ON THE
FACT THAT THIS IS A VERY LIMITED
CHANGE THAT'S BEING.
MADE HERE -- AS FAR AS THE SOME
OF THE ISSUES -- THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU.
THAT I ACTUALLY.
CHAIRED THE COMMISSION.
THROUGH THE PERIOD OF TIME
THROUGH THE RECESSIONARY PERIOD
OF TIME.
WHEN THERE WAS A REDUCTION?
IN THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE. TO
THE COMMISSION BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY -- I WANT TO ASSURE
YOU THAT THERE'S NOTHING
NEFARIOUS GOING ON WITH THE
FOUNDATION. FOR THE COMMISSION.
THIS IS A ORGANIZATION THAT DOES
ALL OF ITS BUSINESS.
IN PUBLIC.
IS THERE OPPOSITION TO SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT THE COMMISSION
HAS DONE OVER THE YEARS -- AN
EXAMPLE BEING THE MALIBU LAGOON
PROJECT THAT YOU'RE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH YES IN FACT THERE
HAS BEEN OPPOSITION TO IT.
NOT UNLIKE THE FACT THAT THERE'S
OPPOSITION TO VIRTUALLY ANYTHING
THAT'S PROPOSED AND THAT'S
HEALTHY.
OF OF FOR EVERYONE WHEN WE
ENGAGE IN THAT KIND OF DIALOGUE.
BUT I THINK WITH REPECT TO THE
SPECIFICS.
OF THIS REPORT IS PROBABLY BEST
POSITION TO DO THAT YEAH I JUST
ONE TRY JUST ONE THING -- AND
AND MISTER LAMB SHOULD KNOW THIS --
HE DID HE WE WENT WE WENT TO
COURT AND LITIGATED -- QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHERE THE COMMISSION
STARTED AND STOPPED WHERE THE
FOUNDATION STARTED AND STOPPED.
AND PRIOR TO MY ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
OF RUNNING THE ORGANIZATION.
THERE WAS A CONFLATION OF THE
COMMISSION.
EVERYBODY WORKED FOR THE
COMMISSION TOM I THINK IT WAS
DONE LARGELY INNOCENTLY BUT
FAIRLY ENOUGH THE COURT SAID HEY.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
COMMISSION IS AND WHERE THE
FOUNDATION IS AND YOU GUYS NEED
TO CLARIFY THOSE RELATIONSHIPS.
YOU DON'T NEED TO JUST TALK THAT
TALK ME TO WALK THAT WALK AS
WELL SO WE'VE MADE ALL THOSE
STEPS.
TOM AND THAT IS WHERE WE ARE
TODAY -- SO IF WE SHINE THE
LIGHT INTO PLACE WHERE IT WAS
MURKY BEFORE I DON'T WANT TO
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT -- AND IF
ANYTHING YES WE ARE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF THE ASSETS
THAT WE CAN ACQUIRE AND ASSEMBLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ACHIEVE OUR
MISSION.
IS A THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE TO
DO.
AND I THINK AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN IT
IS A STEP IN THAT RIGHT
DIRECTION THAT HELPS BRING MORE
TO US CAN YOU JUST BEFORE WE
CLOSE HERE OF AND I KNOW THERE'S
A LONG HISTORY AND I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF CONTENTIOUSNESS
ABOUT PROJECTS AND DEVELOPMENTS
AND I'M VERY SENSITIVE.
SOME OF THE ISSUES GOING ON A BY
OWN -- AND I UNDERSTAND THAT A
LOT OF THE CONCERNS THE
COMMUNITY THERE AS WELL AS A
LAGOON.
I DON'T REALLY WANT TO
ADJUDICATE THOSE ISSUES HERE
TODAY AND I AYE.
AYE BUT I'M TRYING TO SORT OF
SEPARATE.
THOSE ARE ANCILLARY ISSUES FROM
THE GOVERNANCE QUESTION A HAND.
AND EVEN FROM THE RESOURCE.
CONCERN WHICH I THINK IS
LEGITIMATE AND BUT IT SOUNDS
LIKE THIS ISN'T THIS ISN'T A
BUDGET BILL THIS IS A POLICY
BUILT.
ON JUST ON THE POLICY FOR YOU
CAN YOU JUST RESPOND AS HERE
CLUBS CONCERNED ABOUT THIS WATER
SUPPLY.
PURPOSE IN THE GOING NO THEY'RE
NOT HERE BUT DO YOU DO YOU SEE
THAT AS A AS A CAUSE FOR CONCERN
EXPANDING INTO WATER SUPPLY WAS
IF THAT AQUIFER RECHARGE.
ISSUE UNDERLYING I JUST WANT TO
FIND SOME WAY IF WE OULD EVEN
IF WE NEED TO REFINE THAT OR
MAKE THAT EXTRA CLEAR THAT THIS
IS IN.
SOME OTHER.
AGAIN SOME OTHER STALKING HORSE
FOR SOME OTHER PROJECT AND
PEOPLE DON'T REALLY KNOW ABOUT
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT SOME
OF THE IT WILL REACH HE HAD NO
SAID THAT THE DAILY I CAN I CAN
SUGGEST -- IS I'VE HAD NO
CONVERSATIONS WITH ANYONE THAT
PUTS US INTO THE WATER
MANAGEMENT -- ARENA -- WE'RE NOT
UNDERTAKING REGULATIONS ARE NOT
GOING TO BECOME A WATER
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS CONTRIBUTE.
TO THE MANY PARTNERSHIP THAT WE
HAVE IN THE LA BASIN TO PROJECTS
THAT PRIORITIZE.
INCREASING WATER ABUNDANCE FOR
FUTURE WATER SUPPLY TIME MOST
THE TIME THOSE GO HAND IN GLOVE
WITH WATER QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE WAY THAT WE WORK IN A
BUILT AN UNBUILT ENVIRONMENT.
I MIGHT SUGGEST THAT IT MIGHT BE
WAITED A FEW SOME OF THE TENSION
TO JUST CLARIFY THAT INTENT I
MEAN EVEN IF YOU EVEN IF YOU
RETAIN SOME OF THE THE
IMPROVEMENT OF WATER SUPPLY IN
THE MEASURE YOU COULD ALSO
POTENTIALLY.
IT SO MANY CONSIDER GOING FOR
THE BUILDING WAS FOR TODAY.
MAYBE THESE ARE TO TAKE SOME OF
THOSE ANCILLARY ISSUES OFF THE
TABLE AND SAY YEAH THE INTENT
HERE IS NOT TO ESTABLISH TIS IS
A WATER MANAGEMENT SUPPLY AGENCY.
OR SOME OTHER WAYS TO PROVIDE
SOME ASSURANCES TO THE COMMUNITY
SO THEY SORT OF KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GETTING IT IT'S REALLY
IT'S ABOUT COASTAL RATHER STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
BUT IT'S NOT IS TALKING OR FOR
SOME OTHER -- OF SOME OTHER SO I
I DON'T KNOW IF THE AUDIO.
I'M I'M PERFECTLY OPEN TO THAT --
NOTION BUT WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
THAT.
THE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE MAKING
THAT DECISION FOR THE SANTA
MONICA BAY NATIONALIST WAY
PROGRAM.
WHICH HEAVILY INVOLVED THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS INTENDED BE
LOCALLY DERIVED HOUSE OF THE
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING THAT
IS IN PROCESS RIGHT NOW TO
CLARIFY.
ALL THESE RELATIONSHIPS OF THE
VARIOUS ENTITIES INVOLVED IS
HAPPENING.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHERE IT'S
SUPPOSED TO UNDERNEATH THE
FEDERAL GUIDANCE THAT WE
RECEIVED AS A NATIONAL ESTUARY
PROGRAM.
I THINK THE BILL AS AS IS
AUTHORED AT SPECIFICALLY ALLOWS
FOR THAT BODY TO DO ITS JOB AND
DID NOT INTERVENE.
UNDERSTOOD SO I'M PERHAPS THAT'S
SOMETHING YOU'D CONSIDER JUST
CLARIFYING -- GOING FORWARD --
JUST TO MAKE DOUBLE SURE HERE I
KNOW CENTER CABALLERO HAD A
COMMENT BUT THAT I MEAN SEE WHAT
WE CAN DO.
OKAY -- ENTER YEAH I JUST WANTED --
TO MAKE SURE I'VE GOT THIS RIGHT.
I READ THIS AND I SAW THIS IS A
GOVERNANCE ISSUE AND FRANKLY --
SUPPORT THE CHANGE I THINK IT
MAKES SENSE -- DOES IT AM I
CORRECT THAT THE STOPPING IN THE
FUNDING ISSUES ARE NOT IN THE
BILL.
THAT'S THAT'S NOT PART OF THE
BILL AND INTO SPACE AND THOSE
ARE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY OUTSIDE ORGANIZATIONS IN
REGARDS TO PASS CONTACTED
SYMPTOMS EFFORTS SAY.
US PRESENT -- RIGHT I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND IT IN
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU'RE WHEN
YOU'RE PREPARED FOR WHEN YOU'RE
READY -- I'M I'M PREPARED TO
MAKE THE MOTION.
SO WILL RECOGNIZE THAT IS A
MOTION.
THE COMMISSION FROM THE AUTHOR
TO LOOK INTO THIS ISSUE FURTHER
I'M HAPPY TO ENGAGE FURTHER WITH
THOSE CONCERNS ARE TO CLARIFY
WHAT THIS BILL IN ISN'T ISN'T
ISN'T -- BUT I APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY TODAY AND BEGINNING TO
SOME OF THOSE DETAILS -- AND A
CLEANER SAFER HEALTHIER
PARTICIPLE SANTA MONICA BAY --
SO THE THEM THEM MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS -- SO
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE
TODAY BUT KEEPING AN EYE ON
THESE ISSUES BEFORE THE FLOOR SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- MOTIONS TO
PASS REVIEW OF PROVISIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CENTER STERN AYE
STERN AYE JONES ALAN.
OR JUST CABALLERO.
AYE HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON
MONEY NOT BILLS ON OKAY WILL
MERELY THE MEASURE ON CALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIR.
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
NEXT.
NEXT IS AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT LET ME
KNOW WHEN YOU'RE READY MISTER
CHAIR.
YEAH LET ME CHECK HERE SO
[inaudible]
ONE FILE ORDER AND
SOME OF THE MEMBERS WAITING
WE'RE GONNA HAVE AND I'M WAITING
FOR WHITNEY AND WAITING FOR A
WITNESS HERE FOR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
SWITCH BACK.
WHEN HAVE YOU GUYS COME BACK?
TO SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT IN A
MINUTE AND THEN.
STICK WITH FILE ALREADY HERE
NEVER THANK YOU SUMMER BLOOM FOR
FILLING OUR SPOT THERE AT THE
BEGINNING -- SO LET'S LET'S SEE.
MISTER ARAMBULA I BELIEVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA WITH
FILE ITEM.
TEN AB SIX FIFTY EIGHT CORRECT
YES ALRIGHT THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS TODAY I PRESENT AB SIX
FIFTY EIGHT AND LET ME BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
AND THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
DENNIS O'CONNOR FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL.
AB SIX FIFTY EIGHT CREATES A NEW
PROCESS WHICH WILL ALLOW THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO ISSUE A
FIVE YEAR TEMPORARY WATER PERMIT.
THIS PERMIT WILL ALLOW
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES OR LOCAL AGENCIES. TO
APPLY FOR THIS NEW PERMIT TO
DIVERT WATER TO UNDERGROUND
STORAGE DURING HIGH FLOWS.
ADDING ANOTHER TOOL FOR
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE FOR FACING
DRASTIC CHANGES DUE TO SAY
IMPLEMENTATION.
AS WE KNOW MANY COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE ARE FACING
CHALLENGES IN IMPLEMENTING SIGMA.
AB.
SIX FIFTY EIGHT WILL HELP
COMMUNITIES AND USERS AND MY
DISTRICT AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA
TO IMPLEMENT CIGNA.
BY USING RECHARGE TO ITS FULLEST
POTENTIAL.
MORE FREQUENT AND SEVERE
DROUGHTS COMBINED WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SIGMA ARE GOING
TO VASTLY CHANGED THE LANDSCAPE
OF OUR FARMING AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES.
IF WE DO NOT ADEQUATELY PREPARED.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS OVER A YEAR
OF WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
STARTING WITH AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY NINE WHICH WE HEARD AND
PASSED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR.
ALTHOUGH AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
NINE STALLED ON THE SENATE FLOOR
CONVERSATIONS CONTINUED DURING
THE WINTER TO ADDRESS TECHNICAL
CONCERNS BY A NUMBER OF INTEREST
GROUPS.
THE STAKEHOLDERS ONTINUE TO
MEET AND ISSUES WERE ADDRESSED
AND NOW THERE IS WIDE SUPPORT.
FROM WATER USERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
EARNING GOOD AFTERNOON I GUESS
NOTHING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ADAM CAN YOU ASSEMBLY HAPPY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES HERE IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. ONE THING
AS A MEMBER ARAMBULA -- AS WELL
AS HIS STAFF ARTURO THEY HAVE
BEEN.
SPEARHEADING THIS FOR QUITE SOME
TIME AQUA'S BEEN WORKING ON THIS --
CONCEPT FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW.
WE ARE VIDAK WAS VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF GROUNDWATER RECHARGE -- TO TO
REPLENISH SOME OF THESE DEPLETED
BASINS.
THE HOW AND WHEN WE DO THAT
RECHARGE IS THE TRICKY PART.
AND THIS BILL I'M REALLY CRAFTS
A VERY NARROW FRAMEWORK -- FOR
OUR WATER SYSTEMS TO START DOING
RECHARGE BUT ALSO AT THE SAME
TIME PROTECTING DOWNSTREAM USERS --
SO WE ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS -- AS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE SOME
NUMBER AND STATE WATER BOARD IN
THIS LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
STRUCTURE MEMBERS SAID MANNING
ON BEHALF OF LESSONS WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.%
THERE IS A PARTICULAR AMENDMENTS
THAT.
WAS BROUGHT UP BY MISTER CONNOR
AND ITS ANALYSIS.
DEALING WITH WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS THIS IS THE SAME ISSUE.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING COOPERATIVELY
WITH THE AUTHOR ON FOR A WHILE --
IT ADDRESSES.
IN HIS BRILLIANCE MISTER
O'CONNOR ARRIVED AT A SOLUTION
THAT SATISFIES BOTH WESTLANDS
AND EDEA BELIEVE IT OR NOT I
THINK SO.
I DON'T SPEAK FOR THEM BUT SO WE
SUPPORT THAT AMENDMENT AND THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR ALL TO WORK ON
THIS SO IT'LL BE -- TOOL FOR US
ANOTHER WATER DISTRICT TO USE
FOR A LONG TIME THANK YOU.
IF YOUR GUY WHEN I THINK WE'LL
BE HEARING FROM MEDIA FOR THE
MOMENT SEVEN THANK YOU.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BABRI BUT ON BEHALF OF VALLEY
ATWATER COALITION IN SUPPORT.
JONATHAN CLAN ABOUT THE METROPOL
WATER DESERVE SOMETHING
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. FOR SO I
CAN JUST HEAR BE OF BEHALF OF
SAN JOAQUIN -- COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DANNY MERKLEY
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON PUBLIC AFFAIRS
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
WE HAD A SUPPORTERS AMENDED
POSITION I THINK.
MISTER MANNING CHARACTERIZE
WHERE WE ARE NOW ACTUALLY I
THINK THEY'RE TWO ISSUES --
UNREASONABLE -- ADVERSE
UNCERTAIN SIX AT THE SIGNIFICANT
ADVERSE IMPACTS RATHER THAN ON
REASONABLE AFFECTED WE WANTS TO
GO BACK TO AND REASONABLE FACT
BECAUSE OF RAINY SEQUEL LIKE
STANDARD INTO WATER IT'S LAW.
AND THE SECOND ISSUE IS THAT
WATER QUALITY CONTROL PLANS WE
CERTAINLY SHERMAN TANK WE DON'T
WANT THESE SERVERS AND IMPACT.
THE ABILITY -- TO BUT SHE WATER
QUALITY CONTROL PLAN OBJECTIVES
SO I THINK YOU -- THE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCES DOES A NICE JOB OF
SORT OF THREADING THAT NEEDLE
AND I THINK -- WITH.
THOSE -- WITH TOES THEY'RE
PROBABLY TOO MUCH GOOD.
BUT WITH THOSE EVENTS WILL BE
HAD.
IN SUPPORT AND THANKS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR TAKING THIS
ISSUE ON THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON TEA ON THE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE GROUND WATER
RESOURCES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
OKAY -- SEE NO THERE'S IN
SUPPORT AND YOU HAVE ANY IN
OPPOSITION HERE.
SEEING NINE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DíAS.
SO LET ME JUST DODD THINKER MY
MY GOOD FRIEND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADAM LEFT FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ON IT FOR A LONG TIME.
THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
PILOT PROJECTS IN THE VALLEY
THAT HAVE -- BEN TRIALS OF OF
HOW THIS WORKS -- IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR -- IFYOU MAKE
ANY AMENDMENTS BUT BUT LET ME
JUST SAY THAT -- THIS IS ONE OF
THE SOLUTIONS -- IT'S NOT THE
ONLY SOLUTION THERE'S GOING TO
BE A WHOLE HOST OF BUT IT'S ONE
OF THE SOLUTIONS WHERE THE
FARMERS ARE TAKING IT AT A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF RISK BY
FLOODING THEIR PROPERTY --
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO IS THE
COST OF TAKING OUT THE DRIP
YOU'RE CHANGING THE DRIP
IRRIGATION SYSTEM THAT OUT TO
ALLOW FLOODING.
DURING THE HIGH.
MANY TIMES IS -- IS AN EXPENSE
AS WELL AND THAT THE ABILITY TO
CREATE A IT ALLOWS.
QUICK DECISION TO BE MADE GRAINS
COMING TOMORROW WE MIGHT BE A
GOOD TIME TO OPEN THOSE WEIR'S
IS REALLY IMPORTANT SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS AND
IT'S NOT EASY TO DO BECAUSE IT
HERE FOR GOING TO RECHARGE.
ARE DEPLETED AQUIFER'S
SOMEBODY'S GONNA SAY HEY WAIT A
MINUTE THAT THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
MY HE WATER -- AND AND SO IT'S
REALLY I THINK IT'S GOING TO
TAKE -- A COOPERATIVE EFFORT ALL
AROUND AND I'M GLAD TO SEE YOU
TAKING A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN THIS
SO.
LET ME -- SO MY COLLEAGUE HERE --
I HAVE BEEN OUT TO SOME OF THESE.
FORMS IN.
I'M YOU KNOW IN A ONE THINKS
JUST DROUGHT ALL THE TIME WHEN
THEY THINK ABOUT SIGMA BUT WE
SOMETIMES FORGET.
IS WHAT YEARS AND ALL THE
COMPLEXITIES BUT ALSO THE MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES FRANKLY THEY WERE
WERE WERE FACING AN YOU KNOW
SICK MAN FROM INTENTIONS GOING
TO ALREADY IS COMPLICATED AND
CHALLENGING AND SO.
ANYTHING WE CAN BE DOING TO GET
AHEAD OF THIS AND GIVE.
GROWERS TOOLS TO MANAGE BOTH IN
DRY AND WET PERIODS I'M ALL FOR
SO I ACTUALLY JOINED HER IN
ASKING TO JUMP ON IS A CAPITAL
CO AUTHOR HERE TODAY AND REALLY
KEEP WORKING WITH YOU AND THE
REST THE CENTRAL VALLEY
DELEGATION AND MAKING SIGNAL
WORKABLE AND REALLY MAKE.
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY SUSTAINABLE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
JUST TO CLARIFY THE THE MISTER
MANNING IN GARZA YOU'RE YOU'RE
OKAY WITH.
THAT A MAN YES SIR OKAY VERY
GOOD I'M IS THERE NEEDS TO BE
ANY FURTHER CLARITY I KNOW WE'VE
GOT LANGUAGE HERE BUT IF IT'S IF
IT'S AMENABLE -- ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE AN ENTERTAIN A MOTION AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE -- YOU BECAUSE THE
FLASHBACK THOUGH THINKING ABOUT
DON CAMERON WHO WAS THE PERSON
WHO SPOKE TO US.
FROM TERRANOVA WHO GOT THE KILO
WARD A YEAR AND A HALF AGO I
BELIEVE.
NOW DON'S DAUGHTER ACTUALLY WENT
TO PROM WITH MY BROTHER WHICH IS
HOW THINGS WORK IN THE VALLEY
BUT BUT IT WAS THE COMMUNICATION
THAT HE WAS ABLE TO TELL ABOUT
WHAT WORKED ON HIS FARM THAT
HOPEFULLY WILL CREATE THAT
SUSTAINABILITY.
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
SO THANK THIS COMMITTEE FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE AND IF
YOU WILL ALLOW ME THIS IS MY
LAST WEEK HAVING OUR TURN OVER
OFF US IN OUR OFFICE BEFORE.
HE MOVES ON TO WORK -- FOR THE
KAREN ROSS SAID THE SECRETARY OF
AGRICULTURE AS FOR THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY -- FOR CDFA BUT A LOT
OF HIS WORK OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS HAS BEEN ON THIS.
BILL AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
HIM.
FOR SPENDING SO MUCH TIME FOR
SOMETHING THAT MATTERS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU FOR GALGIANI THANK YOU
FOR STAYING IN THE SERVICE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I KNOW
WILL BE SERVING CREDIBLY WELL BY
YOU THERE WAS SECRETARY ROSS SO.
THANK YOU BOTH AND I ACTUALLY
MISTER CHAIRMAN IN MIND TO WIN.
SIGNED ON SO -- BUT ADVOCACY OF
FROM THE VALLEY -- ENTERTAIN A
MOTION AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME --
MOVED -- THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
UNDER STERN HI.
AND I JONES ALAN OR JUST COVER.
AYE HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON
MONNING I'M CALLING HER I
BELIEVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL
THANK YOU SEMI MEMBER I
UNDERSTAND AMONG ARE WAITING
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THERE'S BEEN AN
AGREEMENT. TO ALLOW -- MISTER
MALL IN. TO GO AHEAD OF THIS
COMP [inaudible]
SORRY KAMLAGER-DOVE.
GO AHEAD OF MR MOMENT -- SO
[inaudible]
THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
HOLD ON A SECOND I'M SORRY I'M
SORRY MR O'DONNELL.
IS AHEAD OF BOTH OF YOU NOW MR
MOMENTS I'M SORRY.
KAMLAGER-DOVE COME ON FORWARD.
AND THEY WILL COME TO YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL AND THEN YOU MISTER
MOMENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE APOLOGIES [inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU TO MISTER MALL AND ASK
FOR A GREEN.
I WITNESSES.
ARE ON A TIMELINE I WON
UNDERSTOOD THAT I TURN THIS OFF
SO I CAN BE RESPECTFUL OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB.
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR AB TWELVE
FIFTY FOUR PLACES A MORATORIUM
ON THE TROPHY HUNTING.
A BOBCAT.
BOB CATS ARE NOT CLASSIFIED AS A
GAME SPECIES BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
AND ARE NOT PRIMARILY KILLED FOR
HUMAN CONSUMPTION.
SINCE THE TRAPPING BAN WAS
IMPLEMENTED BOB CAT.
ONLY CAN BE CONSIDERED A TROPHY
HUNTED FOR SPORT AND DISPLAYS.
WITH THIS BILL THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION MAY RE OPEN THE
BOBCAT HUNTING SEASON UPON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A BOBCAT
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
THAT USES CREDIBLE SCIENCE AN
ECOSYSTEM BASED APPROACH TO
INFORM DECISIONS REGARDING
BOBCAT POPULATIONS INCLUDING
AFFECTS ON THEIR PREY.
DISEASE ABATEMENT AND BENEFITS
TO FARMERS INCLUDING THE CONTROL
OF INVASIVE SPECIES. FOR EXAMPLE
BOBCATS ARE AN IMPORTANT FACTOR
IN THE CONTROL OF RODENT
POPULATIONS INCLUDING INVASIVE
NUTRIA WHICH ARE SPREADING AND
CAUSING EXTENSIVE DAMAGE TO
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES.
THE MORATORIUM ALLOWS FOR
COMMONSENSE EXEMPTIONS TO
PROTECT HUMAN SAFETY PUBLIC
PROPERTY.
AND LIVESTOCK.
THE STATE WIDE THE LAST
STATEWIDE BOBCAT POPULATION
ASSESSMENT IS MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS OLD AND IS WHOLLY OUTDATED.
AB TWELVE FIFTY FOUR SUPPORTS
THE NOTION THAT WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT SHOULD BE BASED ON
THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE.
RATHER THAN ON AND RELIABLE DATA
SOURCES INCLUDING SELF REPORTING.
AND SELF REPORTED HUNTER SURVEYS
WITHOUT CREDIBLE SCIENCE WE
CANNOT INSURE THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING OUR WILD CATS. TWO
WEEKS AGO ON JUNE TWENTY FIFTH
THE LA TIMES REPORTED THAT
RECENT SCIENTIFIC STUDIES
SUGGEST AN ALMOST ONE IN FOUR
CHANCE THAT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
MOUNTAIN LIONS.
COULD BECOME EXTINCT IN THE
SANTA MONICA AND SANTA ANA
MOUNTAINS WITH IN FIFTY YEARS WE
MUST ENSURE THAT BOBCATS A
SIMILAR SPECIES ARE NOT DESTINED
FOR A SIMILAR FATE.
CALIFORNIA'S WILD CATS ARE MUCH
MORE VALUABLE TO CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS ALIVE THAN DEAD.
YOUR WITH ME TO TESTIFY AS WINDY
KEEP OVER A SENIOR CARNIVORE
SPECIALIST WITH THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND DOCTOR JEAN TRAP FROM CSU
SACRAMENTO WHO IS A RETIRED
PROFESSOR OF BIOLOGY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WELCOME
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY APPRECIATED
COMMITTEE -- YES WE ARE LOOKING
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON ON AB --
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR ACCORDING TO A
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN POLL THAT
REMINGTON DID OF CALIFORNIANS
70% OPPOSE TROPHY HUNTING OF
BOBCATS AND 75% WOULD VALUE
SEEING ONE IN THE WILD.
BOBCATS RARELY OCCUR.
WHEN SOMEONE HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO VIEW THEM SUCH AS THAT --
POINT REYES NATIONAL SEASHORE
THEY CAN CONTRIBUTED IMMENSELY
TO LOCAL ECONOMIES -- IN A
WILDLIFE WATCHING TOURISM.
BUT BY ALLOWING ONE PERSON TO
KILL THAT ANIMAL IT TAKES
OPPORTUNITY AWAY FROM US DOZENS
OF OTHERS TO PHOTOGRAPH OR TO
VIEW IT.
BOB CATS ARE PRIMARILY HUNTED
FOR THEIR BODY PARTS TROPHY
HUNTERS TAKE WILD CATS IN
RENDERED THEM OR THEIR PARTS
INTO TROPHIES STATE POSE WITH
THE CARCASSES AND FOR BRAGGING
RIGHTS ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
LIKE MOUNTAIN LIONS WHO WERE
BANNED FOR SPORT HUNTING
STARTING IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN YEARS AGO.
THEY ARE NOT PRIMARILY HUNTED
FOR FOOD.
ANY BIOLOGISTS HAVE NOTED THAT.
TROPHY HUNTING BOBCATS IS AN
INAPPROPRIATE WAY TO INTERACT
WITH ANIMALS WHO HAVE
SOPHISTICATED LEVELS OF
INTELLIGENCE THE MOTION AND
SOCIOLOGY.
WHICH IS PROFOUNDLY DISRUPTED BY
TROPHY HUNTING -- BOBCATS HAVE A
LOT OF IMPORTANT INTRINSIC
VALUES -- THEY REDUCE RODENT
POPULATIONS INCLUDING NUTRIA
COULD DAMAGE -- NOT ONLY CROPS
BUT WETLANDS -- WE ANALYZE USDA
DATA -- AND LOOKING AT LIVESTOCK
LOSSES IN IN CALIFORNIA BOBCATS
KILLED NEW.
CATTLE OR SHEEP FROM THE FROM
THE LAST -- AND DATA REPORTS
FROM USDA AND DATA FROM.
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
SHOW THAT CONFLICTS WITH
CHICKENS AND RABBITS ARE
EXTREMELY RARE.
SO -- YET THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
FOR COMMONSENSE EXEMPTIONS FOR
RANCHERS TO KILL BOBCATS TO
PROTECT THEIR LIVESTOCK AND
PROPERTY -- SO IT DOESN'T BàN
BOBCAT HUNTING INTO PERPETUITY
AT MARLEY PAZ'S BOBCAT HUNTING
UNTIL THE STATE CAN UPDATE IT'S
THIRTY FIVE YEAR OLD MANAGEMENT
PLAN.
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO PASS
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE -- AND
FOR YOUR EXPERTISE ON THIS
MATTER -- OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
WELCOME SIR [inaudible]
GREETINGS -- MY NAME IS GENE. TO
INTERRUPT -- PRESS PROFESSOR
EMERITUS FROM CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO.
WHILE JUNIPER I'M AND I'M --
WILDLIFE BIOLOGIST -- AND I'VE.
ECOLOGY ANIMAL BEHAVIOR IN THE
MAIL HELLO OF COURSE IN THE
GREAT COURSES BEHAVIORAL ECOLOGY
FOR THIRTY YEARS.
AND HAS THIRTY THREE MASTER
STUDENT STUDYING MAMMALS IN THE
FIELD.
INCLUDING SOME.
A LITTLE BIT LIKE A BOBCAT.
RED SOX GRAY SOCKS. ONE OF THE
BIGGER ONE BLACK BEAR.
DETAILS MY SPECIALTY --
INSTRUCTIONS THANKS.
START DISCOUNTS AND SPOTTED
SKUNKS.
ANYWAY SO I THE APPOINTED WITH
SOME OF THE BIOLOGY OF PREDATORS
AND SO ON THERE IS THERE IS NO
GOOD DATA SET FOR MANAGING
BOBCATS IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S BEEN STUDIES -- BACK.
THE COURSE OF THAT WERE KIND OF
PILOT STUDIES
THEY'REBOTH IN THE DESERT ONE
WAS DOWN THE MOHAVE DESERT WENT
UP IN NORTHEASTERN SAGEBRUSH
DESERT.
I WANT YOU LEARN THERE WHAT THE
WHAT THE RESEARCHERS SAID.
APPLIES OVER THERE TO THE DESERT
OKAY.
NOT TO THE REST OF CALIFORNIA
AND THERE'S A LOT OF CALIFORNIA
LEFTOVER SO -- FISH FISH AND
WILDLIFE DEPARTMENT HAS TO HAVE
SOME BY HER HOUSE.
A NUMBER OF STUDIES SPREAD
AROUND THE STATE. TO GET DATA ON
BOBCAT POPULATIONS SEX RATIOS.
MANY YOUNG HOW MANY OLD INSTANT
WHAT'S IMMORTALITY RATE.
SUCH AS THAT.
AND SO WE REALLY NEED.
A FISHING GAME TO FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE -- AT THE STATE.
TO COME UP WITH A GOOD
MANAGEMENT PLANTS WE CAN HANDLE
BOBCATS THE STATE IN A RATIONAL
WAY.
THIS IS NO -- THERE'S NO GOOD
REASON TO HUNT BOB YES JUST FOR
THE PLEASURE OF KILLING THEM AND
BRAGGING ABOUT THE SKIN SO YOU.
HANG UP ON YOUR WALL -- I AGREE
THANK YOU SIR.
THE TESTIMONY WE COMEBACK TO
YOU IF WE HAVE ANY OTHER NEEDS
FOR FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS OF OKAY
OKAY I JUST AND THEN WE'LL WORK
ON ONE AND HAVE A MORE WORDS.
YEAH JUST -- ABOUT CATS AND
RATHER SLOW REPRODUCTIVE RATE.
SOMETIMES IT'S JUST ONCE YOU'RE
CENTER AND THIS EVERY TWO YEARS
IT MIGHT BREED.
THE USUALLY HAVE THREE KITTENS
AS FAR AS PREDATORS GOING
GENERAL.
GENERAL EVEN BOBCATS MOST OF THE
YOUNG DIE IN THE FIRST YEAR.
THANK YOU FOR THAT -- WE'VE
OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT.
YEAH PLEASE COME FOR JUST A A
NAME AND AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL.
A GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN HOW THE
PROJECT COYOTE -- HUMANE SOCIETY
OF THE UNITED STATES AND CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
WHO WOULD KILL A BOBCAT FOR FUN?
THANK YOU.
PIPER KRYSTLE A SAYS U. S.
SENIOR DISTRICT LEADER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I CANNOT
PREVEZA I'M HERE FOR RAPTORS ARE
THE SOLUTION AND THE BETTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IF TONY
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
VERONICA COLOGNE WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
PROJECT FUNDED TOMLINSON PROJECT
KOTV IN SUPPORT WE BELIEVE
BOBCATS ARE WORTH MORE THAN THE
THREE DOLLAR AND TWENTY FOUR
CENTS TAG.
THE CALIFORNIA FISHING GAME GETS
FOR A HUNTING A BOBCAT.
SAMANTHA HOW DO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE ANIMAL WELFARE
INSTITUTE AND HUMANE SOCIETY
LEGISLATIVE FUND AND SUPPORT.
FIND OUT OF POLY WALNUT CREEK
ANDWITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE STRONG SUPPORT.
BRENDA WIKI CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
NICHOLAS SECOND SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION AND
SUPPORT.
THAT BROUGHT A CITIZEN OF YOLO
COUNTY SUPPORT.
BOB GREENWALD THIS IS FROM FROM
DAVIS STRONG SUPPORTER.
LINDSEY LARISA ANIMAL LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND IN SUPPORT.
SAMANTHA BRUGER WILDER'S
GUARDIANS IN SUPPORT.
WHEN SHOWN CO FOUNDER DIXIE ON
BEHALF OF THE HUNTERS SO PLUS
PEOPLE OUTSIDE THE ALL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU?
INDIVIDUALS OR SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA DIXIE IN SUPPORT.
ME A LAWRENCE MARIN COUNTY H. S.
U. S. IN SUPPORT. TO ELLEN RYAN
YOLO AUDUBON SOCIETY SUPPORT
[inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
JENNIFER KENNEDY AGENCY WES
ELDORADO COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- AND I I WILL TREAT --
THE GENTLEMAN FROM THE AXES
TESTIMONY IS REPRESENTING THE
THE HUNDREDS OF OTHERS ON THE
HALL SO FOR THE SECOND TIME WE
CAN.
KEEP THE REST THE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
TRUNCATED HERE.
BUT WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
MANY PEOPLE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT I DO WE HAVE ANY IN
OPPOSITION.
IF SO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
ANY OF ANY OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU CAN TAKE ONE AND THEN MAYBE
ONE OF THE MIKE.
YOU GUYS WANT TO DO [inaudible]
ONE ONE THAT WAY.
WE GIVE YOU GUYS EVEN TIME.
RATE THAT'S FINE.
PHIL BUT WHATEVER WORD YOU WANT
TO PROCEED IN YES.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL GAINES
CITY REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DEAR ASSOCIATION THE ROCKY
MOUNTAIN ELK FOUNDATION AND THE
WHILE SHE FOUNDATION AND ELEVEN
OTHER.
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS.
IN OPPOSITION THIS AB.
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR FIRST OF ALL
THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSION WAS
ESTABLISHED BY THIS CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HUNDRED AND FORTY
NINE YEARS AGO SPECIFICALLY. TO
DEFINE AND DETERMINE NATURAL
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT DECISIONS.
THE FIVE MEMBER PANEL ALL
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE.
ALL FIVE MEMBERS RIGHT NOW WERE
APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN.
FISHING GAME PROCESS FISH AND
GAME COMMISSION PROCESS IS VERY
THOROUGH TO THREE MEANING
PROCESS YOU HAVE AN INITIAL
MEETING WHICH WHERE THE ISSUE
WAS NOTICED.
THEY TAKE FULL PUBLIC TESTIMONY
THERE TAKE INPUT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
THERE AS WELL SECOND MEETING IS
JUST A DISCUSSION HEARING. FOR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THERE AS WELL
NO ME TOO IS I MEAN THEY'LL GIVE
YOU UP TO A MINUTE SOMETIMES UP
TO THREE MINUTES BUT NO LESS
THAN A MINUTE.
IN THE THIRD HEARING WHICH IS
KNOWN AS THE ADOPTION HEARING.
AGAIN FULL TESTIMONY INPUT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT.
IN FULL PUBLIC TESTIMONY THERE
AS WELL.
IT'S ALSO WRAPPED IN SCIENCE AN
APARTMENT A FISH AND WILDLIFE
BRINGS THEIR SCIENCE TO THE
TABLE AS TO VARIOUS MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC RING THEIR SCIENCE
TO THE TABLE AS WELL ALL OF THAT
IS FULLY CONSIDERED.
BEFORE THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION MAKES A DECISION.
SPEAKING OF SCIENCE IT ALSO
REQUIRES CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT.
FORMED IN THAT THAT BE TAKEN
CARE OF AND PUT INTO THE SYSTEM
BEFORE THEY CAN RENDER A
DECISION ON THAT SO IT'S FULLY
WRAPPED IN SCIENCE.
WHEN IT COMES TO ENFORCEMENT AB
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR WILL HARM
BOBCATS MORE THAN HURTING?
NOBODY HATES POACHERS MORE THAN
LAW ABIDING HUNTRS.
TO THERE'S NO MISTAKE ABOUT THAT.
BOB MINING HUNDREDS WHEN THEY'RE
OUT IN THE FIELD PURSUING
BOBCATS OR WHATEVER IT MAY BE
ALSO ARE THE EYES IN THE YEARS
OF THE DEPARTMENT.
WHEN IT COMES TO TO FINDING AND
REPORTING TO CALTECH ANOTHER
MEANS POACHERS THAT ARE OUT IN
THE FIELD?
IF YOU OUTLAWED THE HUNTING OF
BOBCATS FOR FIVE YEARS IT'LL
TAKE THOSE LAW ABIDING HUNTERS
IN THE EYES NEAR THEY PROVIDE.
OUT OF THE FIELD AND MAKE THEM
NO LONGER A BENEFIT TO FISHING
GAME ENFORCEMENT.
FURTHER IF YOU TAKE HUNTERS OUT
OF THE FIELD FOR THOSE FIVE
YEARS THE DEPARTMENT'S DATA IS
GOING TO SUFFER AS WELL IN ORDER
TO TO HARVEST A BOBCAT IN
CALIFORNIA.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A BOBCAT TAX IN
WHEN YOU DO HARVEST ONE
SUCCESSFUL YOU HAVE TO REPORT
WHERE WOMEN AND HOW THAT BOBCAT
WAS TAKEN.
THAT DATA PROVIDES INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT INFORMATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND GAME WHEN
THEY'RE MAKING DECISIONS WORKING
WITH THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION.
BUT BOBCAT REGULATIONS.
GORDON SAYS HE TO WRAP IT UP IN
A SEC HERE SIR SO.
HE ONE FINAL COMMENT ONE FINAL
COMMENT ON THE MANAGEMENT PLAN
THIS BILL IS YOU KNOW.
DOES REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE PERFORM A
MANAGEMENT PLAN ON BOBCATS
TECHNICALLY THAT SHOULD BE DONE
BEFORE.
THE THE HUNTING OF BOBCATS IS
PROHIBITED NOT DURING OR AFTER.
IN THE DATA IN THAT MANAGEMENT
PLAN WHEN THEY'RE PUTTING A PLAN
TOGETHER IF THEY'RE DOING IT ON
BOBCATS THERE'S THOUSANDS OF
OTHER SPECIES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S LIMITED STAFF.
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO PERFORM
RESEARCH ON THAT ARGUABLY ARE
MUCH MORE CRITICAL NEED THE
BOBCATS IT'S BECAUSE OF ALL
THESE REASONS THAT WE URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO ON AB.
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MARKEDLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION.
WE SEE THIS BILL IS BEING -- A
PURELY AN ANTI HUNTING MEASURE
THAT IS NOT BASED IN SCIENCE OR
SOUND WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT
PRINCIPLES.
BOBCATS ARE VERY ABUNDANT
THEY'RE FOUND IN ALMOST EVERY
COUNTY OF CALIFORNIA HAS THEIR
FOUND THROUGHOUT MOST STATES.
ALL THE WAY UP INTO ALSO CANADA
DOWN INTO MEXICO.
THEY'RE BY NO MEANS RARE --
HONEYMOON WHICH IS HIGHLY
REGULATED AS YOU KNOW.
NBA BASED ON THE BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENE HAS LITTLE IF ANY IMPACT
ON THIS PC.
AN EXAMPLE -- IN -- TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BOB DURING
THAT BOBCAT HUNTING SEASON.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE -- SOLD ALMOST TWELVE
THOUSAND BOBCAT TAGS BUT ONLY
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
ANIMALS WERE HARVESTED SO THAT'S
MINUSCULE COMPARED TO THE
OVERALL POPULATION -- WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT BOBCATS
ARE TROPHIES VC WE WOULD DOUBT
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THAT
WE HAVE TROPHY PROVISIONS WHICH
ARE IN OUR FISHING GAME CODE
THAT RELATE TO DEER.
ELK ANTELOPE THOSE TYPES OF
CRITTERS NO WE'RE IN THERE ARE
BOB CHECK BOBCATS CONSIDER
TROPHY SPECIES SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT -- ARE REAL FEAR IS
THAT IF YOU PASS THIS TODAY
WHAT'S GOING TO BE NEXT IN IS IT
GONNA BE BEARS NEXT YEAR -- HI
OATS WATERFOWL WHO KNOWS WHERE
THIS WALL LEAD.
AND WAS TOUCHED ON EARLIER YOU
KNOW WHETHER YOU.
BELIEVE OR NOT AND HUNTING -- I
I RESPECT PEOPLE HAVE DIFFERENT
VIEWS ON THAT IT COULD BE AN
EMOTIONAL ISSUE.
BUT WE ALL SHOULD BE AGREEING
THAT THE PROPER WAY TO MAKE
THESE MANAGEMENT DECISIONS IS
BEFORE FISHING GAME COMMISSION.
THEY HAVE THE SCIENCE THE OF THE
BIOLOGY THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO DO IT LET THEM DO THEIR JOB
AND WE'LL GET THIS THING RIGHT.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE IT HAS MY
THANK YOU I'M TO THE OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION IS DETERMINED AURORA
GRIFFITHS BECOME HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION BECAUSE BRIEFLY
EXPAND ON THE RETIRED GAME
MORTON. TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OF
DOING THAT OF WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
SAID AS A 100% ACCURATE EVERY
TIME YOU TAKE A LAWFUL MEMBER
OUT OF THE FIELD.
THOSE EYES ARE LOST TO THAT AS A
TOOL TO THE GAME WORDS TO TO
REPORT OTHER ACTIVITY.
SECONDLY REAL QUICK AS THE ARE
THREE MOVE IN CALIFORNIA THE TO
RECRUIT NEW HUNTERS.
WERE TAKEN AWAY YET ANOTHER
THING THAT.
GETS PEOPLE OUT IN THE FIELD
GETS PEOPLE MOTIVATED.
CALIFORNIA HUNDRED NUMBERS A
DECLINE FROM OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND THE SEVENTIES TO LESS
THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
TODAY.
TENNIS OF STRONG MOVEMENT RIGHT
NOW CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR BROWN
CALLED FOR A COUPLE YEARS AGO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENCOURAGE
NEXT GENERATION CALIFORNIA'S FOR
SOME CONSERVATION IS IN THIS.
BILL FLIES TO FACE THAT THANK
YOU SIR THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN CAPPING WINTER PRISON
SPARK CLUB INTERNATIONAL OUTDOOR
SPORTS FANS COALITION CALIFORNIA
SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION ON
OPPOSITION I WOULD JUST.
STATE ONE ONE THING -- LAST YEAR
IN THE BUDGET YOU ALL PUT FOR
WORD A LOT OF MONEY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
TO KIND OF REORGANIZE ITSELF
LOOK AT WHERE IT'S THE MONEY IS
GOING LOOK AT WHERE THE PROGRAM
SHOULD GO.
IT'S A THREE YEAR PROCESS AND WE
SHOULD LET THAT PROCESS WORK
THANK YOU THANK YOU AIMS BUNCH
[inaudible]
YES.
RESEARCHER -- NO OTHER MEMBERS.
MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GUIDES AND
SPORTSMEN'S ASSOCIATION AND
WE'RE IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS BEST
HANDLED BY.
THE APPOINTED BODY THE FISH AND
GAME COMMISSION THANK YOU THANK
YOU -- SEEN NO OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION -- WILL BRING IT BACK
TO AN EMPTY DíAS.
AND ME.
BUT IS THERE YEAH.
YOU WANT.
TO SEEM LIKE THEY WERE THERE ARE
TWO DIFFERENT ISSUES ONE IS
TIMING OF THE MANAGEMENT PLAN.
AND HI SIR.
IT FELT A LITTLE MORE LIKE A
RESOURCES BUDGET QUESTION AND
ONE AND THEN THE OTHER WAS ABOUT
THEN YOU FOR DECISION MAKING.
LEGISLATURE YOU HAVE A QUICK
COMMENT ON I WILL -- TRY TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE THINGS
AND THEN I WILL ALLOW A WINDY --
TO RESPOND TO SOME OF THE OTHERS
AND I'LL TRY TO BE AS SUCCINCT
AS POSSIBLE -- YOU KNOW I KNOW I
KNOW THE OPPOSITION SAID THAT IS
NOT A TROPHY ANIMAL BUT NO ONE
IS EATING THE BOBCATS SO I MEAN
I DON'T KNOW HOW WHAT ELSE TO
DEFINE IT OTHER I DON'T WANT TO
SAY IT'S KILLING FOR VANITY BUT
THEY'RE NOT.
EATING THEM AND SO THE QUESTION
IS.
YOU KNOW MORALLY THERE'S A
QUESTION ABOUT WHY -- THEY WOULD
NEED TO BE -- SHOT THE OTHER
ISSUE IS I KNOW PEOPLE ARE
SUGGESTING THAT THE SETS A BAD
PRECEDENT BUT I'M TO MY
KNOWLEDGE IN THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS THE ONLY HUNTING BAN --
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS AN
ACTED AS BEEN A BAN ON MOUNTAIN
LION SO I DO THINK YOU KNOW
WHERE THIRTY YEAR TIME SPAN DOES
SUGGEST THAT WERE BEING
INCREDIBLY JUDICIOUS.
ABOUT THE BANDS THAT WERE
PLACING WE DO AGREE -- THAT THE
COMMISSION SHOULD BE HIGHLY
INVOLVED IN FACT -- IN IT WAS IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
COMMISSION -- STAFF THAT WE
SUPPORTED I MAINTENANCE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE AS IT RELATES TO
THE MANAGEMENT PLAN -- THEY IT
IS REALLY SORT OF UP -- TO THE
COMMISSION TO DECIDE.
HOW QUICKLY THEY WANT TO DO
THEIR STUDY IN THE QUICKER THEY
DO THE STUDY THE QUICKER THE BAN
IS LIFTED -- BUT THIS CERTAINLY
DOES SORT OF PUT A PAUSE ON
THOSE KINDS OF KILLINGS OF OF
BOBCATS AND AND WILD CATS WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO
WAIT. FOR A SPECIES TO BE ON THE
BRINK OF EXTINCTION BEFORE WE
HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT WE SHOULD BE PROTECTING
THEM -- AND THAT ISSUE BEFORE
INTERRUPT YOU.
THE AMENDMENT SUGGESTED IT.
I AM IN TERMS O THE BOBCAT
MANAGEMENT PLAN USE INCREDIBLE
CREDIBLE SCIENCE AND WE ACCEPT.
OKAY SO SO THAT IS IN THERE AND
HOPEFULLY THAT DOES PROVIDE A
LITTLE MORE CERTAINTY TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF SCIENCE BEING
INTEGRATED INTO THE PROCESS
GOING FORWARD.
BROWN UTILIZING ECOSYSTEM BASED
APPROACH -- DID YOU HAVE FURTHER
COMMENT.
THE RESPONSE ON AND JUST ONE
POINT THAT AND YOU AND THEN
TIMING -- YEAH. TO ONE POINT THE
THE COMMISSION HAS HAD THIRTY
FIVE YEARS TO GET IT RIGHT AND
THEY HAVEN'T DONE IT YET SO --
DOES THIS GIVES THEM.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT YEAH.
WE'VE GOT NO THEY HAVE NO
SCIENTIFIC DATA ON BOBCAT
POPULATIONS.
CALIFORNIA.
NINE ZERO OKAY SO -- VERY GOOD --
I I SEE YOUR OTHER WITNESS HAS A
HAS ONE MORE PIECE OF
INFORMATION.
IT'S YOU'VE COME ALL THIS WAY
YOU WANT TO TAKE THIRTY SECONDS
HERE AND MAKE ONE MORE PIECE TO
TELL YOU CAN YOU CAN COME RIGHT
UP TO THE MIKE YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WAIT THEIR GO.
GO RIGHT AHEAD AND THEN WE WILL
WRAP UP HERE -- GO TO THE OTHER.
I'M GONNA RECOMMEND.
YEAH.
ALTHOUGH MISTER O'CONNOR.
NO IT'S OKAY.
BOB BOBCATS ARE IN NO WAY A
BUNDLE.
THE BOB CANCELED HAVE HOME
RANGES WHERE THEY HAVE ALL THE
RESOURCES.
AND TERRITORIES OR MALES DEFEND
AGAINST OTHER MALES FEMALES
DEFEND AGAINST OTHER FEMALES IN
THEIR TERRITORIES IN THESE ARE
HOME RANGES INCLUDING ALL THE
RESOURCES.
THE HOME RANGE.
OF A RANGE OF HOME RANGE SIZES
ARE SOMETHING LIKE ONE SQUARE
MILE. TWO UP TWO HUNDRED SQUARE
MILES OR MORE PER BOBCAT.
AND I I I'VE BEEN A BIOLOGIST IN
ANIMAL.
PERSONAGES TO FOR MY WHOLE LIFE
AND I'VE BEEN OUT IN THE FIELD
THAT HAD A LOT OF STUDENTS DOING
RESEARCH ON MAMMALS.
I'VE SEEN. THREE BOBCATS IN MY
LIFE.
THANK YOU SIR -- I DO SEE A
RESPONSE FROM THE COALITION BUT
I'M JUST I'M.
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO OTHER
MEMBERS UP HERE [inaudible]
HI.
WELL I A IT WILL WRAP IS THE THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THAT THEY'RE
FOUND IN EVERY COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA OTHER THAN SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY.
AND THEN WAS BROUGHT UP EARLIER
REGARDING.
PROP ONE SEVENTEEN THAT WAS AN
INITIATIVE PASSED BY THE VOTERS
THAT WAS NOT THE LEGISLATURE
BANNING THIS.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION FOR THE RECORD --
SEPTEMBER THANK YOU FOR THE
THOROUGH.
INVESTIGATION THE ISSUES THERE
AREN'T ANY MOTIONS AVAILABLE
THIS TIME WHICH ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE AND LEAVE THE MEASURE ON
CALL.
TO SEE IF.
THANK YOU I JUST I WON I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR ALLOWING
THIS BILL TO BE HEARD AND ALSO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN FOR
LETTING ME AM TO TAKE HIS SPACE
I JUST -- YOU KNOW ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR AFTER WE VOTED ON
IT MY COLLEAGUE CAME UP TO ME
AND SAID.
I AM A NATIVE AMERICAN IN IN MY
CULTURE I AM PART OF THE COYOTE
CLAN.
AND WE ARE PROHIBITED FROM
MARRYING OR LOVING ANY OTHER
PERSON WHO WAS UNLESS THEY ARE
FROM THE WILD CAT PLAN.
HE SAID IN SO IT IS BECAUSE OF
MY CULTURE THAT I HAD TO VOTE
FOR THIS BECAUSE IF I VOTED
AGAINST IT.
I WOULD ACTUALLY BE VOTING TO
KILL.
OTHER CLAN MEMBERS THAT ARE PART
OF MY INDIGENOUS CULTURE SO WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THE SCIENCE WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THE MANAGEMENT WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THE BUDGET.
THERE'S ALSO A SPIRITUAL
COMPONENT OF THIS BILL THAT EVEN
I DIDN'T RECOGNIZE AND SOMEONE
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HOW WE ARE
MANAGING THE ECO SYSTEM IN THE
BIO DIVERSITY OF THE STATE I
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THAT
WE TAKE THOSE OTHER SORT OF
CULTURAL -- RELEVANT SEES INTO --
CONSIDERATION WHEN WE ARE VOTING
ON A MEASURE LIKE THIS AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
BELIEVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL --
AND KEEP HIS HEARING MOVING.
SO MR MULLIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
AND YOUR DIFFERENCE -- WE HAVE.
ITEM THIRTEEN THAT'S A. B. NINE
TWO NOPE AB.
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SEA LEVEL
RISE IS ONE OF THE MOST SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AS YOU KNOW.
SAN MATTEO COUNTY AS MORE PEOPLE
AND PROPERTY VALUE AT RISK FROM
RISING SEA LEVELS THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTY IN THE STATE.
MANY EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE
THREAT OF SEA LEVEL RISE
FLOODING IN COASTAL EROSION ARE
ALREADY WELL UNDER WAY. SEVENTY
OF COUNTY TWENTY CITIES NEED
COORDINATED APPROACH TO
ADEQUATELY PREPARE FOR THESE
THREATS ACROSS THE COUNTY AS A
WHOLE.
AB EIGHT TWENTY FIVE WOULD
MODIFY THE EXISTING SAN MATEO
COUNTY FLOOD CONTROL DISTRICT.
AND RENAME IT THE FLOOD AND SEA
LEVEL RISE RESILIENCY AGENCY THE
AGENCY LIKE THE EXISTING HAVE CD
WOULD BE A COUNTY WIDE SPECIAL
DISTRICT.
THIS MODIFIED ENTITY WOULD BE
TASKED WITH SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSING FLOODING.
COASTAL EROSION SEA LEVEL RISE
TO BEST PROTECT AND PREPARE THE
COUNTIES COMMUNITIES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS IS A
COORDINATED IN PROACTIVE
APPROACH FOR THE COUNTIES -- FOR
THE COMMUNITIES IN SAN MATEO
COUNTY AND WITH ME TODAY IS
STEVE KERR'S ON BEHALF OF SAN
MATEO COUNTY TO OFFER ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SENATOR WELCOME YES
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS SPEAKERS ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR COUNTY -- FIRST OF
ALL THANK SEPTEMBER MULLIN FOR
INTRODUCING THE BILL AND HE
COVERED THE ESSENCE OF IT I
WOULD.
ONLY ADD THAT -- THAT TO CALL
TWENTY ONE CITIES IN THE COUNTY
HAVE -- SIGNED ON IN SUPPORT AND
I'M AS HE INDICATED -- I WOULD
ALLOW US TO DO MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL PLANNING -- AND
CREATE EXPERTISE IN ONE AGENCY
AND ALLOW US TO BETTER COMPETE
FOR STATE.
AND FEDERAL GRANTS AND SO FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBINSON ON BEHALF THE SAN
MATTEO CITY COUNTY ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS.
ALONG WITH THE COUNTY WE HELP
MANAGE SOME OF THE WATER QUALITY
ASPECTS OF THE PLAN AND SENATOR.
ANDWE THINK THIS BILL GO A LONG
WAY TO BRING BETTER COORDINATION
COUNTY LEVEL -- WITH THAT WE ASK
YOUR SUPPORT SIR OTHERS IN A
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MALLORY SPOKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE
ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
GOOD BILL.
LET'S MOVE IT I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION THE APPROPRIATE TIME LIKE
A CLOSE THANK YOU SIR OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE
MEASURE ON HOLD.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY'RE BETTER
CLOSE THE ROLES ON ME IN
ASSEMBLY PRIVACY -- THE MOTHER
GOT A RECESS HERE.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIND TO FIND
ANOTHER MEMBER TO COME BACK IN
HERE YOUR BILL --
FOR ALL
[inaudible]
THIS IS
.
THEY SAID THAT.
YOU WELL OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH
.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
RUN A SO THE THE BREAK IS OVER
WE'RE GONNA -- PROCEED WITH THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL.
YOU ARE UP.
I'M ASSUMING YOU'RE GONNA TAKE
OF AB.
NINE TWENTY SIX FIRST.
I NINE YES MA'AM OKAY OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB NINE TWENTY SIX
WHICH WILL ELIMINATE THE CAP ON
THE OIL TRUST FUND AND HELP
ENSURE THE CLEANUP.
OF THE VAN AND WELL SO MY
DISTRICT THAT'S WHAT THE LONG
BEACH AREA.
THE LONG BEACH THAILAND'S ARE
AND AND THE OUR HOME TO THE
WILMINGTON OIL FIELD ONE OF THE
LARGEST OIL AND NATURAL GAS
FIELDS IN THE COUNTRY.
THE FEEL PRODUCES APPROXIMATELY
FORTY SIX THOUSAND BARRELS FROM
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED ACTIVE
WORLDS EACH DAY.
BECAUSE THESE OPERATIONS ARE
LOCATED ON STATE LANDS ENTRUSTED
TO THE CITY OF LONG BEACH THE
STATE RECEIVES A SHARE OF THE
NET PROFITS FROM THESE
OPERATIONS.
HOWEVER THESE WELLS WILL NOT
LAST FOREVER.
AND CURRENT PROJECTIONS ESTIMATE
THAT OIL OPERATIONS WILL CEASE
TO TO PRODUCE AROUND THE YEAR.
TWENTY THIRTY SIX TO ENSURE THE
STATE HAS THE FUNDS NECESSARY TO
DECOMMISSION THE WELLS.
AND MITIGATE POTENTIAL
ENVIRONMENT AND MIDDLE IMPACTS
THE LEGISLATURE CREATED THE OIL
TRUST FUND IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIVE A PORTION OF
THE STATE'S SHARE OF NET PROFITS
BEGAN GOING INTO THE FUN.
WITH THE INTENT OF COVERING THE
EVENTUAL DECOMMISSIONING COSTS
OF THE OPERATIONS.
AT THE TIME OF THE FUND'S
CREATION.
CAP OF THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WAS PLACED ON THE FUN
BASED ON THE ON THE PREMISE THAT
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE MORE MONEY
THAT IS NECESSARY. TO OFFICIALLY
CLOSING CLEAN UP THOSE WELLS YOU
DON'T JUST TURN WELL OFF YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE TO FILL IT UP WITH
CEMENT INTO A VARIETY OF OTHER
THINGS TO ENSURE.
A LONG TERM SAFETY OF THAT WILL
ALSO THAT OIL DOESN'T COME OUT
AGAIN.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN OIL TRUSTS
AND REACH THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR CAP ESTIMATES
PLACE THE STATE'S EVENTUAL COST
FOR CLEANING UP THE WORLD'S AT
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS REALLY THE STATE WITH THE
SHORTFALL OVER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WILL LIKELY
HAVE TO COME OUT OF OUR STAGE
GENERAL FUND.
SO WE SEEK TO DO SIMPLY TODAY IS
TO ADD MORE MONEY TO THAT FUND
SO THAT WE CAN EVENTUALLY CLEAN
UP THOSE OIL WELLS.
AND WITH ME HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
THE CITY LONG BEACH IS -- IS A
MEMBER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AMY BROWN ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LONG BEACH
WE THANK THE AUTHOR -- FOR
RUNNING THIS BILL LIFTING THE
CAP OBVIOUSLY WILL BENEFIT THE
CITY AND OUR PARTNER THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION.
AN ADDITIONAL -- OIL ABATEMENT
AND ENVIRONMENT PROTECTION AS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SO I'D LIKE TO WELCOME YOU TO
THE MIKE YOU COULD GIVE US YOUR
NAME.
HERE TOO SO ON BEHALF OF HEAL
THE BAY IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION.
MR DONAHUE MAKE CONCLUDE JUST
SAYS FOR AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND CHAIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING THIS
BILL THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WE'LL TAKE THAT UP WHEN WE HAVE
ANOTHER COMMITTEE MEMBER THEY
CAN MAKE A MOTION.
SO THE NEXT ITEM.
IS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE
WHICH IS AB.
SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND THANKING HIM THE
STUFF FOR THEIR FINE WORK ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR WHICH WILL
EXPAND THE TERRITORY OF THE SAN
GABRIEL AND LOWER RIVERS
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY TO INCLUDE
THE DIMMING IS CHANNEL WATERSHED.
IN CATALINA ISLAND.
THIS IS A STATUS FOR TWENTY
YEARS AGO THE RIVERS ND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY HAS
SUCCESSFULLY PURSUED A MISSION
OF PRESERVING OPEN SPACE.
AND HABITAT WELL FACILITATING
PUBLIC ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA'S
WILDERNESS AND WILDLIFE.
BY PROVIDING GRANTS TO VARIOUS
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE
TERRITORY IN THE EASTERN LOS
ANGELES WESTERN ORANGE COUNTY'S.
THE CONSERVANCY HAS IMPROVED
WATERSHED.
RESTORE WILDLIFE HABITAT CAM
PROVIDED NUMEROUS OUTDOOR
RECREATIONAL AN ASIAN
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
WELL THE CONSERVANCY HAS AS
GREAT TO HAS FOUND GREAT SUCCESS
WITH NUMEROUS PROJECTS WITHIN
ITS TERRITORY.
SEVERAL NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES
HAVE NOT HAD.
THE SAME ADVANTAGE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES.
THE NEW MINGUS CHANNEL WATERSHED
LOCATED. TO THE EAST OF LOS
ANGELES ANGELS RIVER IS ONE AREA
WITH SEVERAL COMMUNITIES IN NEED.
INCLUDING PORTIONS OF INGLEWOOD
CARSON TORRANCE SAMPEDRO AND
SEVERAL OTHER COMMUNITIES THE TO
MAKE THIS WATER SHOP.
IS HEAVILY DEVELOPED.
IN SEVERELY LACKING AND PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE OPEN SPACE.
AND OTHER NEARBY AREA OF LAND IS
CATALINA ISLAND WHICH TO I
REPRESENT.
WELL NOT IN NEED OF MORE OPEN
SPACE ACCESS TO THAT OPEN SPACE
CAN PROVE TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE.
ADDITIONALLY THE ISLANDS
DEPENDENCE ON THE VOLATILE
TOURISM MINISTRY MAKES IT
DIFFICULT TO SECURE CONSISTENT
LONG TERM FUNDING FOR OPEN SPACE
OR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
THE SAN DIEGO RIVERS AND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY AS HE IS
IN A UNIQUE POSITION TO HELP
THESE AREAS EXPAND THEIR MISSION
OF PRESERVING CALIFORNIA'S
NATURAL RESOURCE.
IN A WAY WE ALL CAN ENJOY AB
SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR WILL ALL
THEM TO IDENTIFY TO I'M TO DO
EXACTLY THAT BY EXPANDING THEIR
TERRITORY. TO BETTER SERVE OUR
PUBLIC AND WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY IS -- MISTER MARK
STANLEY HE IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE TANGO RIVERS AMOUNT
CONCERNS HE DOES A GREAT JOB.
OF ALLOWING A LOT OF COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE A LOT OF CHALLENGES
ACCESS TO OPEN SPACE AND
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITY MANAGER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU.
AS MENTIONED I MARK STONE THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER ROOMS
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY.
THE ARMS HE IS OUTLINED BY THE
SAN GABRIEL MOUNTAINS -- THE
WATERSHED OF THE SAME GAME OR
RIVER FROM ITS HEADWATERS DOWN
TO THE OUTLET OF THE PACIFIC --
IT ORANGE COUNTY IN THE LOWER
HALF OF THE LOS ANGELES RIVER
BELOW THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
TO THE PORT OF LONG BEACH
ADDITION OF SENATE CLEAN
CATALINA ISLAND AND THE MINGUS --
CHANNEL WATERSHED SHARE MANY OF
THE CHARACTERISTICS OF THE LAND
WITHIN THE EXISTING CONSERVANCY
BOUNDARIES.
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT IS.
IN VERY HIGH NEED WITH AND MANY
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES PARK FOR
COMMUNITIES.
ARE NO DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THE
CONSERVANCY CURRENTLY PROVIDES
RESOURCES TO WILL WE THAT -- THE
MAKERS CHANNEL END SENDING
CATALINA ISLAND.
THE INCLUSION OF SANTA QUE.
CATALINA IN THE DIMMING AS-WATERSHED REPRESENT LESS THAN A
4% INCREASE IN THE RESOURCES.
OF THE CONSERVANCY WHICH IS OVER
FOURTEEN HUNDRED SQUARE MILES.
THIS PROPOSAL TAKES IN INGLEWOOD.
AREA DEFINEDBY LAW STANDPOINT.
EIGHT PARKS. FOR FOR ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE CITY OF
CARSON WITH. ONE POINT FIVE
ACRES PER ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
HARBOR GATEWAY COMMUNITIES WITH
LESS THAN POINT.
FOUR ACRES FOR ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE SO SEVERELY PARK -- FOR
COMMUNITIES WITHIN THIS
EXPANSION AREA.
YEAH FOR CATALINA THE CALORIE
CATALINA ISLAND CONSERVANCY IN
THE CITY OF AVALON.
PLANS ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
CONSERVANCY IN ITS EFFORTS TO
CONSERVE EDUCATE AND PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOW IMPACT
RECREATION.
IN THE TIMING OF THIS SECTION
APPEARS APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE
ARM C. WAS FORMED.
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE SOME
TWENTY YEARS AGO BY SB. TWO
SIXTEEN IT IS DUE FOR ITS UPDATE
OF THE OPEN SPACE PLAN.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO INCLUDE
CATELYN AT THE BIGGEST CHANNEL.
YEAH THOSE UPDATES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD.
TO MOVING AHEAD THIS THANK YOU.
FOR OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IN MEMBER -- DOCUSIGN
REPRESENTING THE WATERSHED
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY SUPPORT
THANKS SO MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
SEEN ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING THEM.
BACK TO THE DíAS [inaudible]
SENATE CAREER.
THIS ONE AT THANK YOU FOR THE
THE MAP THAT WAS PRODUCED IT'S
REALLY HELPFUL BECAUSE WHEN YOU
START MENTIONING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THEN YOU.
ADD PASSWORD IS A STATE AND
RANCHO PALOS VERDES AND THE IT'S
HARD TO UNDERSTAND.
HOW INCLUDING THOSE AREAS BUT
THE MAP IS REALLY GOOD I THINK
IT MAY IT SHOWS PRETTY
SIGNIFICANTLY YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE REGION JUST OUTSIDE OF
THE COASTAL?
ZONE SO THANK YOU AND APPRECIATE
THAT AND I'M PREPARED TO MAKE A
MOTION WHEN YOU'RE READY.
SO THAT.
WILL TREAT THAT AS A MOTION FOR
CENTER COVER YOUR ANALYZE A UP
TO ANY CLOSER.
AJ RECESS THE COMMITTEE VERNE
I'VE -- MISTER THANK YOU -- SO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL ROTH CENTER STERN BY
STERN JONES ALLEN WE'RE JUST
COVER EURO.
I HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON MONEY --
I SEE SIMILAR PETRIE-NORRIS HERE.
LIKE THE MOTION ON THE FIRST
BILL.
YES.
WE WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
FILE ITEM WHAT IS IT. FOURTEEN
AB.
NINE TWENTY SIX AM OF THAT BILL
OKAY SO MOVED FROM CENTER COVER
YOUR THE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
EIGHT AB NINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ANOTHER STRAND FIVE STERN AYE
JONES ALLEN OR JUST CABALLERO I
HAVE YOUR AYE HERTZBERG HUESO
JACKSON MONNING OKAY VERY GOOD
WE'LL LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL
OF THAT IS TO VOTES.
HANDS MOVING ON ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE THIRTY THREE
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WELCOME [inaudible]
AFTERNOON.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FIRST I AM
HAPPY EXCEPT ALL THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS DETAILED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK.
ON ON THE SPELL. EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY THREE WILL ESTABLISH THE
ECOSYSTEM RESILIENCE PROGRAM IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
ADD TO FIND WATERSHED
COORDINATOR POSITIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. FOR YEARS WATERSHEDS
OCCUPY A VARIETY OF UNIQUE
GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS INCLUDING
URBAN AGRICULTURAL AND FORESTED
LANDS CHANNELING RAIN FALLING
SNOW MELT TO CREEKS STREAMS AND
RIVERS AND EVENTUALLY THÅU
FLOW POINT SUCH AS RESERVOIRS.
DAYS AND THE OCEAN.
DESPITE THEIR PIVOTAL ROLE IN
ENSURING HEALTHY ECOSYSTEMS
FUNDING FOR THE MANAGEMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S WATERSHED.
HAS BEEN INCONSISTENT IN RECENT
YEARS -- ACTIVE MANAGEMENT IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURE HEALTHY
WATERSHEDS WATERSHED
COORDINATORS PLAY AN IMPORTANT
ROLE HERE DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING WATERSHED
IMPROVEMENT PLANS.
FACILITATING COLLABORATION AMONG
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS IDENTIFYING
AND SECURING FUNDING FOR WHAT
WATERSHED IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS
AND LEVERAGING THIS FUNDS TO
MAXIMIZE BENEFITS.
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA'S
WATERSHED TO FIGHT A MULTITUDE
OF BENEFITS ARE COMMUNITIES
WILDLIFE AND ENVIRONMENTS.
PLEASE INTRODUCE AS SUPPORTERS
HERE TO TESTIFY HOLLY ROBINSON
FROM SACRAMENTO RIVER WATERSHED
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I HAVE.
MEANT MY NAME IS HOLLY JORGENSON
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER WATERSHED
PROGRAM.
BEFORE ASSUMING THIS POSITION I
WAS THE ORGANIZATIONS WATERSHED
COORDINATOR AND PRIOR TO THAT I
WAS THE WATERSHED COORDINATOR
FOR THE DEER CREEK WATERSHED
CONSERVANCY.
I TESTIFIED TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINE THIRTY THREE
AND ONE OF THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR HER LEADERSHIP
ON THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
GIVEN THE RISING FREQUENCY AND
SEVERITY OF FIRES IMPACTING THE
STATE'S WATERSHED SYSTEMS THIS
BILL AND THE PRACTICE MANAGEMENT
WHAT SHOULD MANAGEMENT EFFORTS
THAT IT PROMOTES ARE ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY.
BUT LIMITED RESOURCES AND
MILLIONS OF ACRES OF FORESTED
WATERSHED IN NEED OF ACTIVE
MANAGEMENT IT IS CRITICAL THAT
OUR EFFORTS ARE COORDINATED IN
COMPLEMENTARY.
FROM MY EXPERIENCE WATERSHED
COORDINATORS HAVE BEEN HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE AND IMPLEMENTING
WATERSHED MANAGEMENT EFFORTS
GIVEN BY CONCERNS ABOUT LOCAL
AND REGIONAL ISSUES.
WATERSHED COORDINATORS PROVIDE A
BASIS FOR CONTINUAL MANAGEMENT
AND HELP TO ENSURE THAT WATER
SAID PLANS AND PROGRAMS ARE
IMPLEMENTED AND THE LINE WAS
STATE WIDE AND REGIONAL
OBJECTIVES.
EFFECTIVE WATERSHED MANAGEMENT
EFFORTS ARE BUILT UPON A STRONG
FOUNDATION OF ADEQUATE RESOURCES
TECHNICAL TOOLS AND COOPERATION.
WATERSHED COORDINATORS ESTABLISH
RELATIONSHIPS WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND SERVICE THE
POINT OF CONTACT FOR LANDOWNERS
ORGANIZATIONS AGENCIES AND
POLICY MAKERS TO INCREASE
AWARENESS AND SUPPORT.
AND LEVERAGE FUNDING AND
RESOURCES.
FROM 200-022-00015 THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
FUNDED LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
OURS THE HIGHER WATERSHED
COORDINATORS TO FACILITATE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
AND SUSTAIN CALIFORNIA'S.
THE HELP OF CALIFORNIA'S
WATERSHEDS.
A RECENT ASSESSMENT OF THIS
PROGRAM ON THE WATERSHED
COORDINATORS WERE EXCEEDINGLY
EFFECTIVE AT GENERATING LOCAL
SUPPORT AND LEVERAGING
ADDITIONAL FUNDS AVERAGING A
SEVEN FOLD RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
BECAUSE OF THIS WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT YOU CAN.
COUNT THE SAME TAKE A NICE CHAIR
THE FEW ALREADY GOT THE PRINT
OUT YOU KNOW.
MY EYES WERE LEAN AND WELCOME
GOOD AFTERNOON [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THE CHAIRMAN STERN -- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOSH WHAT
BRAT I AM THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA URBAN STREAMS
PARTNERSHIP OR COST.
WE COLLABORATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WATERSHED COALITION
OF THE ENDS TOGETHER ARE GROUPS
INCLUDE -- WELL TOGETHER ALBUM
WITH THE WORK THAT WE DO IS WE
RESTORE SALMON HABITAT ON THE
NORTH AND CENTRAL COAST.
AND THE SACRAMENTO AND SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY.
OUR GROUPS MANAGE FORESTS RIVERS.
A FIRE PREVENTION NEEDS IN THE
SIERRA NEVADA.
OUR GROUPS RESTORE THE WATER
WAYS OF LOS ANGELES ORANGE
RIVERSIDE AND SAN DIEGO COUNTIES.
TO RESOLVE STORMWATER FLOODING
AND ACHIEVE A NEIGHBORHOOD RIGHT
REVITALIZATION.
IN RESTORING URBAN STREAMS AND
WATERSHED FOR HABITAT.
FLOOD REDUCTION FIRE REDUCTION
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA --
WE ALL MET A YEAR AND A HALF AGO.
TO IDENTIFY OUR TOP PRIORITIES --
TO MAKE OUR WORK MORE EFFECTIVE
IN THE UNANIMOUS TOP PRIORITY
FROM VERY DIFFERENT REGIONS IN
ENVIRONMENTS THE STATE IS THE
BILL -- A. B. -- NINE THIRTY
THREE ALTHOUGH OUR WATERSHED
COALITION MEMBERS SERVE RURAL
AND URBAN REGIONS WE SHARE THE
SAME NEEDS.
WE DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO A
THEM IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO IDENTIFY WHAT
PROPERTY OWNERS AND LOCAL
AGENCIES NEED TO MANAGE
FIRESTONE'S.
CLEAN POLLUTED WATER.
REDUCE DAMAGES FROM THE STORM
WATER.
IN FLOODING.
AND RECOVER THREATENED AND
ENDANGERED SPECIES WE CAN'T
DELIVER THE SERVICES THAT THE
PUBLIC RIGHTFULLY EXPECTS.
WE DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
IDENTIFY THE POTENTIAL PRIVATE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL FUNDING
SOURCES WE CAN MATCHING COMBINE.
WE LOSE A STRATEGIC TOOL FOR
ACTION.
WE DON'T HAVE THE BASIC
RESOURCES TO INTERACT.
WITH RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS EXTENSION SERVICES
UNIVERSITIES AND TECHNICAL
EXPERTS SUCH AS ENGINEERS AND
BIOLOGISTS.
OF OUR ACTIONS MAY HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
ORGANIZATIONS DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES. TO PUT PUBLIC INPUT
UP FRONT ON WATERSHED MANAGEMENT
NEEDS WE DON'T HAVE LEGITIMATE
MANDATES.
AB NINE THIRTY THREE WILL CODIFY
EXISTING PROGRAM IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION.
WITH THE PROVEN RECORD TO HELP
US MEET THESE BASIC NEEDS.
OF PLAY AND YOU KNOW I'VE USE
THE THE D. O. C. -- COORDINATOR.
BOB PROGRAM BEFORE I AND IN IN
RICHMOND AND SAN PABLO
ON WILDCAT CREEK AND SAN PABLO
CREEK SPECIFICALLY.
AND WE DEVELOPED -- WATERSHED
ACTION RESTORATION PLANS THAT
HAVE GENERATED ABOUT FOR
PROJECTS AFTER AFTER DOING THE
WORK OF IDENTIFYING AN ACTION
PLAN WHICH WAS BASED ON HAVING --
COORDINATING COORDINATION
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO US.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TO
HAVE OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
TODAY.
WELCOME THE FEAR OF AGO OVER THE
PLANNING CONSERVATION THEY CAN
SUPPORT OKAY VERY GOOD THANKS SO
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE GOING
TO HAVE A LOT OF ON CALIFORNIA'S
PART.
THANK YOU.
HERE TOO SO ON BEHALF OF HEAL
THE BAY IN SUPPORT.
THANKS.
THE MUMMY HAVE RENT
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
APOLOGIES FOR NOT GETTING A
LETTER AND ON TIME.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
I WANT TO BE ON THE RAPTORS ARE
THE SOLUTION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TURN MEMBER -- I'M ACTUALLY KIND
OF A TWEENER SO I JUST WANT TO
JUMP IN AT THE END OF THE
SUPPORT LINE -- SO I'M JULIE
HALL AT THE SAYS CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF WATER AGENCIES
AND I TWENTY THINK THE AUTHOR
AND HER STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING ON THIS BILL --
AND WITH THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS WERE ACTUALLY MOVING
OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MAKES ALL THE DIFFERENCE.
THERE YOU GO MORE COMPLIMENTS
COMING FOR MISTER O'CONNOR TO
JUST.
FLATTERY -- ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT TWEETERS OPPOSITION.
SITTING.
NINE BRING BACK TO THE DíAS
COMMENTS QUESTIONS MOTIONS.
I'M OF THE BILL.
SO THAT'SA MOTION -- WE KNOW
OUR OUR WATERSHED COORDINATOR
CERTAINLY IN RESEARCH
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS IN.
MY BACKYARD SEMIAUTOMATIC GUNS
IN CRITICAL BUT ALSO THERE'S A
VALLEY RIVER AND ALL THE URBAN
OPPORTUNITIES OUT THERE THESE
FOR GUN PARTS OF THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY WE NEED YOU SO.
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT YOU PUT
INTO THIS AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH OUR COMMITTEE -- SO
I THINK IS GOING TO BE A GOOD
FRAMEWORK ON FORD I THINK
THERE'S A LOT WE CAN DO HERE --
SO IT THE MOTION IS -- TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATION BUT
ALL I YOU TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR DR OKAY
THANK YOU SO MEMBERS -- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL UNDERSTAND BY.
HI JONES ELLEN BURGESS CABALLERO.
HI HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON MONEY.
VERY GOOD WE WILL LEAVE THE
MEASURE ON CALL THANK YOU BOTH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY MAKE THE TRIP
YEAH.
NOW WE JUST HANG OUT FOR A
MINUTE YEAH
[inaudible]
RIGHT
YEAH
[inaudible]
THAT
YEAH
[inaudible]
COM
AND
ALL RIGHT THIRD DEFERENTIAL
MOVE FROM SOME MEMBER LEVINE
APPRECIATE IT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WERNER **** BATH.
WELCOME I THINK YOU ONLY HAVE
ONE ITEM UP BEFORE US TODAY AB --
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE SO PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON WHILE PEEING CAM
THANK YOU CHAIR AND THE SENATORS
WATCHING.
OFFICES -- TODAY IT'S AN HONOR
TO PRESENT AB MY BILL AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE WHICH A
PROPERLY REGULATE SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTAL PLATFORMS.
AND SAN DIEGO COUNTIES COASTAL
ZONE AS A THREE YEAR PILOT.
WE ALL KNOW TOO WELL THAT
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE MIDST OF A
STATEWIDE HOUSING CRISIS.
ARE YOU ALL KNOW THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS CAN REGULATE OR
BAN SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS
AS THEY SEE FIT.
EXCEPT IN THE COASTAL ZONE.
AND THE CLOSE IS ON THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
HAS THE ABILITY TO REGULATE LAND
USE BUT NOT ONLY IS APPLIES TO
COAST BUT ONLY AS IT APPLIES TO
COASTAL ACCESS.
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO BALANCE COASTAL ACCESS WITH
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY.
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION REQUIRE CITIES TO
HAVE SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR
AFFORDABILITY EVEN IN COUNTIES
THAT DO AN EXCELLENT JOB IN
PROVIDING LOW COST COASTAL
CONDITIONS LIKE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
SAN DIEGO COUNTY ACCOUNTS FOR
NEARLY ONE THIRD OF THE STATE'S
ACCOMMODATIONS IN THE STATE.
WITH ABOUT ONE PER ONE THOUSAND
PER COUNTY RESIDENTS.
TRANSLATED THAT MEANS THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY.
WE DO NOT HAVE AN ISSUE WITH LOW
COST COAST ACCOMMODATIONS ARE
COASTAL ACCESS.
BUT WE DO HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS
IS EXACERBATED BY THE
PROLIFERATION OF SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS WHICH ARE
REMOVING HOUSING FROM OUR
HOUSING STOCK ESPECIALLY DUE TO
THE POPULARITY IN EASE.
THROUGH WHICH SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTAL PLATFORMS MAKE
IT EASY TO RENT OUT OUT UNITS.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IN ISSUE.
WHEN ANY VIRTUALLY INCENTIVIZE
AS FULL TIME SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS OVER LONG TERM RENTS?
IN ADDITION A RENT A RECENT SIR
A STUDY THAT CAME OUT JUST READ
RESPONDING TO THE NOW SAYS FROM
UCLA AND A RESEARCHER FROM USC.
SO THAT ACTUALLY WHEN YOU HAVE
AN INCREASE IN AIRBNB RENTALS
FOR SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS
RENT DOES GO UP.
AND THAT EFFECT IS EXACERBATED
WHEN YOU HAVE THESE NON OWNER
OCCUPIED RENTALS LIKE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SCHOOL SYSTEM.
CURRENTLY THERE ABOUT FOURTEEN
THOUSAND SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY MOST
OF WHICH ARE FULL TIME.
WE ESTIMATE THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY FIVE THOUSAND FULL
TIME SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS
IN THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
CONSORTIUM.
WHEN IN THE MIDST OF A STATEWIDE
HOUSING CRISIS WILL WE ALLOW
FIVE THOUSAND UNITS TO BE
DEMOLISHED AND NOT REPLACE?
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
INFORMATIONAL SURVEY OF AIRBNB
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY 50% OF THE
HOST OF MULTIPLE PROPERTIES
LISTED.
WHICH MEANS THESE ARE PROBABLY
COMPANIES THAT ARE BUYING UP
PROPERTIES AND THE RENTING THEM
OUT RUNNING THEM ESSENTIALLY AS
MANY HOTELS.
IN FACT IF YOU LOOK AT SOME OF
THE TOP POST INCENDIO COUNTY
SOME OF THEM ARE BLUE WATER
VACATIONS.
PENNY REALITY.
THESE ARE NOT FAMILIES JUST
HAVING A SECOND HOME THESE ARE.
INVESTORS OPERATING FULL TIME
COMMERCIAL SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS.
AND THAT MEANS THERE ARE FIVE
THOUSAND UNITS IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY COASTAL ZONE NOT
AVAILABLE TO BUY OR RENT LONG
TERM FOR FAMILIES THING YEARS OF
VETERANS OR WORKERS.
IS HOUSING SUPPLY WHICH WE ALL
KNOW INCREASES RENTS AND HOUSING
PRICES.
I REMEMBER THESE UNITS ARE
COUNTED IN SENATE CITIES RENO
NUMBERS FOR HOUSING NOT VISITORS
SERVING USES BUT SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS ARE.
WELL NOT ALL THESE UNITS WILL BE
AFFORDABLE THE PUSH HIGHER
INCOME FOLKS DOWN THE HOUSING
MARKET WHICH CAUSES THE
DISPLACEMENT OF OUR FAMILIES.
FIGURES VETERANS AND WORKERS. TO
ADDRESSTHIS MARKET DISTORTION
EIGHTY SEVENTY THIRTY ONE IS
NARROWLY TAILORED TO
APPROPRIATELY REGULATE SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTAL PLATFORMS
OF THE SAN DIEGO COMIC A SYSTEM.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE ALLOWS
LEGITIMATE HOME SHARING WHILE
PREVENTING THE REMOVAL OF
HOUSING FROM THE HOUSING STOCK.
DUE TO FULL TIME SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS AND MANY HOTELS.
AT ITS CORE AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE SAYS THE PRIMARY RESIDENT IS
ONSITE THEIR EXEMPTION FROM THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILLS.
THAT MEANS IF YOU LIVE IN YOUR
EIGHTY YOU YOU CAN READ OUT YOUR
FRONT HOUSE IF YOU LIVE IN A OR
FRONT HOUSE YOU CAN RENT ROOMS
IN YOUR HOUSE.
IF YOU LIVE IN THE FRONT HOUSING
COMMITTEE OUT HERE AT YOU.
I AM A RESIDENT IS NOT ON SITE
IN THE SHORT TERM VACATION WOULD
APPLY FOR MAY BOOK THAT UNIT FOR
UP TO THIRTY DAYS.
A YEAR WITH A MAXIMUM NINETY
DAYS IF THAT.
PROPERTY OWNER CHOOSES.
TO A PLATFORM.
THAT MEANS ALMOST EVERY WEEKEND
OF THE YEAR FOR THE ENTIRE
SUMMER.
THAT MY FRIENDS IS LEGITIMATE
HOME SHARING.
AB SEVENTY THIRTY ONE WAS A
MINUTE ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES -- TO ADD IN AN OPT
OUT PROVISION BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
AND THIS MEANS THERE'S A LOT OF
THE OPT OUT PROVISION WOULD BE
BUT THERE'S A RESIDENTIAL
TOURISM STONE AND SERVICE CITY
CHOATE SAID WE WANT TO BE OPTED
OUT OF THIS BILL.
THEY CAN ZONE OR PUT IT
RESIDENTIAL TOURISM OVERLY OVER
THAT AREA THEY WANTED TO BE
OPTED OUT.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE ALLOWS
OF RETURNS OF THE MUCH NEEDED
TRANSIT OCCUPANCY TAX TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
THIS IS CRITICAL TO ALLOW CITIES
TO OPERATE THE EMERGENCY IN
TERMS OF RELATED IMPACTS SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTALS.
WHICH ARE MANY HOTELS AND HOW
THE IMPACT THE COMMUNITIES THIS
ALSO ALLOWS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO COMPARE.
RENTING OVER THE PLATFORMS TO
WITH LOCAL PERMITTING PROCESS
ONE OF THE THAT'S ONE OF THE BIG
ISSUES THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HAVE.
WHICH IS CRITICAL FOR THE
AFFORDABLE ENFORCEMENT OF LOCAL
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL
ORDINANCES.
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE LAST
COMMITTEE MEAN THAT THIS IS A
THREE YEAR PILOT.
IT WILL GET A MUCH NEEDED STUDY
ON THE IMPACT OF SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTAL PLATFORMS ON THE
HOUSING MARKET IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY SCHOOL SYSTEM.
SPECIFICALLY I'M INTERESTED IN
THE EFFECT OF LONG TERM RENTAL
RATES AND HOUSING AVAILABILITY.
TO IMPLEMENT IT REQUIRES
PLATFORMS TO ADD FOR CHECK BOXES
THAT WOULD CATEGORIES A UNIT IN
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY COASTAL
ZONE IS ELIGIBLE UNDER THIS BILL.
IS THAT PERSON PRIMARY RESIDENT
OR NOT IS IT THE PERSON LIVING
ON SITE OR OFFSITE IS THAT A
RENTER NOT AND IF SO DO THEY
HAVE THE PERMISSION FOR THE
LANDLORDS FOR THE SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS.
CITIES WILL SEE THIS RECEIVE
THIS INFORMATION FROM THE
TRANSIT OCCUPANCY TAX TO BE ABLE
TO ENFORCE FOR THEIR LOCAL
POLICIES.
AB SEVENTY THIRTY ONE PROTECTS
PROPERTY RIGHTS BUT NOT
REGULARLY PROPERTY OWNERS THEY
CAN STILL RENDON'S SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTAL.
UP FOR THEIR LOCAL ORDINANCES
AND WITHOUT THE STV ARC
PLATFORMS THAT MEANS THE COMING
OUT TO FAMILY AND FRIENDS BUT
ASIDE FROM THEIR HOUSE THAT HAVE
THEIR WEBSITE.
AND OF COURSE NOTHING STOPPING
THEM FROM RENTING LONG TERM FOR
NINE MONTHS OR HOWEVER THEY SEE
FIT.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S A WRAP OKAY.
I SEIZE LOOKING SO EXPECTANTLY.
ON THE ISSUE OF PROPERTY RIGHTS
I LIKE TO POINT OUT THIS BILL
DOES NOT REGULATE THE USE OF THE
RESIDENTIAL HOME FOR SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTAL.
ONLY REGULATES HOW LONG THEY'VE
EVEN MADE.
BOOKS OVER THE SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTAL PLATFORM.
AND AS A POINT OF FACT USE OF A
RESIDENTIAL HOME FOR A SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTALS NOT
ADDRESS THE PROPERTY RIGHT.
IT'S A VISITORS SERVING USE
GRANTED ONLY IF ALLOWED BY THE
LOCAL JURISDICTION THE A
PERMITTING REGISTRATION
LICENSING ETCETERA IT'S NOT
AUTOMATICALLY INVESTED IN THE
HOMEOWNER.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE
PRESERVES LOCAL CONTROL BY THE
RESIDENTIAL TOURISM POPPED UP
PROVISION.
AT AND ALSO PRESERVES COASTAL
ACCESS BE ON LOW COST BECAUSE
ACCOMMODATIONS BY ALLOWING
LEGITIMATE HOME SHARING WITH THE
PRIMARY RESIDENT ON SITE FOR THE
ENTIRE YEAR OR WHEN THE PRIMARY
RESIDENCE OFFSITE. FOR UP TO
THIRTY DAYS PER PLATFORM FOR
TOTAL NINETY DAYS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY ON THIS
IMPORTANT BATTLE TO ADDRESS ONE
PART OF THE EQUATION OF
ADDRESSING HOUSING AFFORDABILITY.
AND THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY COASTAL
ZONE WITH ME.
HERE TODAY IS IMPERIAL BEACH
COUNCIL MEMBER MARK WEST TO
SHARE A LOCAL PERSPECTIVE ON THE
POSITIVE IMPACT THIS BILL WILL
HAVE OUR SAN DIEGO COUNTY
COUNCIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST TO
CLARIFY YOU WROTE YOUR OKAY
TAKEN THE AMENDMENTS.
IN THE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES YES
OKAY VERY GOOD AND I I THINK
THOSE WILL BE ADOPTED IF THE
BILL MOVES TODAY.
IN GOVERNANCE AND FINANCES THAT
I SHOULD THE BILL MOVE FORWARD --
WELCOME AND JUST.
YEAH PLEASE TAKE TWO MINUTES
THANK YOU SOMEONE NUMBER I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU CENTER CHAIR
EVERYONE.
MY NAME IS MARK WES AND I AM --
COUNCILMEMBER FROM IMPERIAL
BEACH IN HIS OF THE LOCALS CALL
IT ID -- AND I AM HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE SEVEN THREE ONE FIRST OF ALL
I SHOULD MENTION THAT I AM AN
ENVIRONMENTALIST I'M THE FORMER
CHAIR OF THE SAN DIEGO CAP DE
GOT CHAPTER SURFRIDER. THIRTEEN
YEAR RESIDENT IMPERIAL BEACH
RETIRED NAVAL OFFICER IN A
STRONG PROPONENT AND SUPPORTER
OF TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT.
NOW LET ME GIVE YOU SOME
BACKGROUND ABOUT I BEACH IS
REALLY IMPORTANT.
WE ARE COMPLETELY SURROUNDED ON
ALL SIDES OF OUR CITY WE HAVE
THREE SIDES ON WATER WITH THE
TIJUANA RIVER WHICH MANY OF YOU
ARE PROBABLY AWARE OF ON ONE
SIDE.
THE SAN DIEGO BAY THE OCEAN AND
THEN WE HAVE THE CITY OF THE SAN
DIEGO.
AND ALSO WE ARE ONE OF THE MOST
IMPOVERISHED COMMUNITIES AND ALL
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
BECAUSE OF THESE REASONS WE HAVE
STRUGGLED FOR YEARS TO UNLOCK
THE INVESTMENT OF HOUSING IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
NOT ANY HOUSING I'M TALKING
ABOUT HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS ALONG
OUR MAIN CORRIDORS THAT ARE
AFFORDABLE FOR THE MAJORITY OF
OUR RESIDENTS.
IN DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN ARTS COUNCIL CAME
TOGETHER.
AS A COHESIVE TEAM AND TOOK A
MAJOR STEP FORWARD.
APPROVING OUR FIRST TEO DE WITH
TWO HUNDRED UNITS UNFORTUNATELY.
AS MANY DEVELOPMENTS IN
COMMUNITY STATEWIDE IT WAS
SHOCKING TO LEARN THE WITHIN
JUST A FEW MONTHS TWENTY FIVE OF
THOSE TWO HUNDRED WERE
IMMEDIATELY CONVERTED TO SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTALS.
I LOVE THE VISITOR SERVING USES
AN IV AND THE SAN DIEGO COASTAL
ZONE.
WE ALL DO AS THE CHAIR OF
SURFRIDER I ADVOCATED
PASSIONATELY FOR BETTER ACCESS
TO COASTAL ZONES THROUGHOUT ALL
OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
BUT WE ARE STRUGGLING WITH THE
FIGHT THAT WE'VE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE AND OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
HAVING A HARD TIME ADDRESSING IT.
AND THAT'S A CRISIS OF THE
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY.
NOW FOR US IN SAN DIEGO LIKE
DECEMBER MEMBER SAID WE DO A
GREAT JOB OF PROVIDING.
A LOW COST COMMUNITY COASTAL
ACCOMMODATIONS ALMOST 30% LESS
SHE MENTIONED IS WENT INSANE YOU
COUNTY.
AND IN FACT IN MY CITY RIGHT NOW
WE'RE BUILDING MORE AFFORDABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS WERE BUILDING
HAMPTON IN RIGHT NOW SO WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE MORE PEOPLE TO COME
TO OUR COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT GOOD HARD WORKING FAMILIES
CAN HAVE A PLACE TO LAY THERE
HAD A NIGHT.
SO WE'RE EXCITED TO LEARN ABOUT
THE SOMEBODY'S AUTHOR BILL AND
WE WANT TO GET TO THE ROOT OF
THE PROBLEM SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL PLATFORMS ARE MAKING IT
TOO PROFITABLE.
IT TOO EASY FOR A LARGE
INVESTORS TO COME INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND BY APARTMENTS
AND BEACH HOUSES AND USE THEM
FOR FULL TIME SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS.
COUPLE THIS WITH THE FACT THAT
IT IS A GREAT INVESTMENT.
IB IS REALLY SEEN PROPERTY
VALUES INCREASE OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS AND IT'S IT'S A WIN
WIN FOR THOSE PEOPLE BUT NOT FOR
MY COMMUNITY.
THIS DOES NOT BAN OUR COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS FROM DOING THIS ON
THEIR OWN IT HELPS THEM IN IT WE
ALLOWS MORE AT COASTAL ACCESS TO
OUR COMMUNITY.
IT DOES NOT ARE PETE OUR ABILITY
AS A COUNCIL OR AS A PROPERTY
OWNER TO RANT THANK YOU YEP.
WE ARE IN A STATE RISING HAD.
THE STATE WIDE HOUSING PRICES
AND I URGE YOU NOT TO LOSE THIS
BATTLE I WANT TO WE SUPPORT THIS
AND I WON IN A LOVE TO HEAR ON A
VOTE.
AND I VOTE TODAY THANK YOU
COUNSELOR FOR MAKING THE TRIP
NORTH. FOR ALL OF AYE BE --
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
VALERIE SOCCER WITH CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AND COUNSELOR VEGAS ASK YOU JUST
GIVE UP YOUR SEAT FOR A SECOND
MAY HAVE YOU COME BACK AND THEN --
UNLESS YOU ALL YEAH IN TEXAS.
SO WE'RE GONNA DO WHAT DO YOU DO
TEN MINUTES EACH -- AND THEN
MOVED TO OTHER OPPOSITION.
THE BILL WAGNER REPRESENTING
AIRBNB I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
JOAN A MECHANIC PRESIDENT OF
SHARE SAN DIEGO AS WELL AS ADAM
TOM'S EVENT FROM AIRBNB WHO WILL
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
OF THE NATIONAL RESOURCE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOHN
MECHANIC ON THE PRESIDENT SURE
SAN DIEGO WHICH IS A COALITION
OF SHORT TERM.
RENTAL OWNERS MANAGERS AND
PROPERTY RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN SAN
DIEGO.
AS H
THIRTY ONE DUE TO DEVASTATING
EFFECT IT WILL HAVE ON OUR
REGION AND LOCAL ECONOMY. FOR
MORE THAN A HUNDRED YEARS SAN
DIEGO COUNTY IS DEPENDENT ON
SHORT TERM RENTALS ARE REGION'S
RICH HISTORY OF SUPPORTING THESE
LOW COST VISITOR ACCOMMODATIONS
MADE OUR COMMUNITY A VIBRANT
PLACE.
I'M ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S TOP
TOURIST DESTINATIONS.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS INCLUDING THOSE
IN RESIDENTIAL AREAS ARE
IMPORTANT VISIBLE VISITORS
SERVING ASSET.
UNFORTUNATELY AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE ATTEMPTS TO TURN BACK
THE CLOCK AND MAKE IT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF FAMILIES THAT VISIT OUR
COASTAL COMMUNITY EVERY YEAR.
ESSENTIALLY BANNING ON HOSTED
SHORT TERM RENTALS.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE WILL
ALSO BE DISASTROUS THE
LIVELIHOOD OF LOCAL SAN DIEGANS
CONTRARY TO WHAT YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD.
THE OWNERS OF THESE PROPERTIES
ARE NOT NAMELESS FACELESS
CORPORATE ENTITIES THEY'RE
PEOPLE JUST LIKE YOU AND ME.
I HAVE HERE A PRINT OUT FROM THE
SAN DIEGO TRANSIT OCCUPANCY
DEPARTMENT APPROVES THIS EXACT
POINT.
EVERY PERMIT HELD AN INDIVIDUAL
NAME HAS BEEN HIGHLIGHTED IN
GREEN.
EVERY PERMIT HELD IN A
CORPORATION'S NAME HAS BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED IN RED.
BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO PROVIDE
THIS TO YOU AFTERWARDS. 95% OF
THE SHORT TERM RENTAL PERMITS
ARE HELD IN INDIVIDUALS NAMES
NOT IN CORPORATE NAMES.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE PEOPLE WHO
NEED THIS INCOME TO PAY THEIR
MORTGAGE THEIR PROPERTY TAXES
CHILDREN'S TUITIONS AND FUND
THEIR RETIREMENT INCOME.
THOUGH THIS BILL AS AMENDED AS A
PILOT PROGRAM TO SUNSET AFTER
THREE YEARS THOSE THREE THREE
YEARS WOULD BE CRIPPLING TO
LOCAL SAN DIEGANS.
THE LIVES OF THESE PROPERTY
OWNERS IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY ARE
NOT.
AND SHOULD NEVER EVER BE TREATED
LIKE A PILOT PROGRAM.
PASSAGE OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE WILL DEVASTATE HUNDREDS OF
FAMILIES WHO RELY ON SHORT TERM
RENTAL INCOME TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
AS YOUR ANALYSIS MAKES CLEAR
THIS BILL IS A MISGUIDED
EXPERIMENT TARGETING A SMALL
PIECE OF HOUSING PROBLEM WITH
POTENTIALLY DISASTROUS
CONSEQUENCES FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME.
AND THE THOUSANDS I AM HERE
REPRESENTING RELY ON HOSTING
PLATFORMS TO MAKE OUR FAMILY'S
NEEDS.
WITH SO MUCH AT STAKE FOR OUR
REGION I RESPECTFULLY QUEST THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE VOTE
NO ON AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
MAKE A COUPLE MORE COMMENTS.
YOUR OVER TIME ALLOW YOU TO WRAP
UP VERY QUICKLY FIRST AND
FOREMOST ANY REALTY IN BLUE
WATER REALLY TO DO NOT OWN
PROPERTIES I KNOW THIS -- FACTOR
MANAGEMENT COMPANIES THEY'RE NOT
OWNERS OF PROPERTIES.
SECONDLY BAYSIDE LANDING WHICH
IS DEVELOPMENT THAT'S BEEN
TALKED ABOUT IMPERIAL BEACH HAS
AN H. AWAY WITH CC AND OURS IF
THEY WANT TO ELIMINATE SHORT
TERM RENTALS THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY.
BY SIMPLY CHANGING THEIR CCAR'S
IN THERE IT'S A WAY TO SAY THAT
NO SHORT TERM RENTALS ARE
ALLOWED UNDERSTOOD OKAY THANK
YOU FOR THIS POINTS THANK YOU
YOU SHOULD YOU TEST MONEY SIR.
YES WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
COMMON TODAY MY NAME SOME TALKS
FOR HIS SERMON AIRBNB IS PUBLIC
POLICY TEAM.
UNDER THIS BILL MOSTLY CASE
RENTALS WOULD BE BANNED ALONG
THE ENTIRETY OF THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY COAST.
AND LOCAL RESIDENTS WISHING TO
RENT OUT THEIR HOMES WHILE
THEY'RE AWAY WOULD BE LIMITED TO
THREE DAYS PER CALENDAR YEAR.
UNLESS THEY PHYSICALLY OCCUPY
THE RESIDENCE FOR TWO HUNDRED
SEVEN DAYS A YEAR.
A FAMILY THAT LIVES IN LOS
ANGELES AND OWNS A HOME IN SAN
DIEGO.
THE BARD UNDER THE TERMS OF THIS
BILL.
USING A HOSTING POPPING LIKE
AIRBNB TO RENT OUT THEIR SECOND
HOME.
AIRBNB WOULD BE PROHIBITED FROM
LISTING A PRIMARY RESIDENCE FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY DAYS UNLESS WE
COULD ASCERTAIN THE HOMER
ACTUALLY LIVED IN THEIR HOME FOR
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DAYS.
LEAVETHAT THIS IMPOSES ON
REASONABLE AND ON WORKABLE
REQUIREMENTS ARE HOSTING
COMMUNITY.
WE BELIEVE AB SEVENTY THIRTY ONE
WAS SEVERELY ON UNFAIRLY ACCESS.
UNFAIRLY LIMIT ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIA'S COAST WHICH IS
PROTECTED BY LAW.
UNDER THE COASTAL ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX REALLY COOL
SO OCT LOWER COSTS A BIZZARE.
AND RECREATIONAL FACILITIES
SHALL BE PROTECTED ENCOURAGED
AND WHERE FEASIBLE PROVIDED.
THE CALIFORNIA COAST COMMISSION
HAS CONSISTENTLY FOUND THAT
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS
INCLUDING THOSE IN RESIDENTIAL
AREAS OR IMPORTANT.
BIZZARE SERVING ASSET AND ARE
PROTECTED UNDER THE ACT.
A COMPREHENSIVE STUDY BY THE
UCLA FOUND THAT FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS.
THE COST OF THE TRIP IS THE
BIGGEST BEAR TO THE COAST.
THE REPORT IDENTIFIED THAT A WAY
TO COMBAT THIS ISSUE IS BY
PROTECTING AND INCREASING THE
SUPPLY OF LOWER COST FIGURE
ACCOMMODATIONS.
THIS BILL WOULD DO JUST THE
OPPOSITE.
SHRINKING THE SUPPLY OF LOWER
COSTS ACCOMMODATIONS AND THEREBY
LIMITING AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO
THE COAST.
ACCORDING TO PRESIDENT OF THE
SAN DIEGO BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN AN INTERVIEW WITH
KPBS TENURE COUNTY.
AND ONE HALF THE HOUSES A USE
ONE HALF THE HOUSES USED TO
BUILD WHAT THE POPULATION IS
INCREASING THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION.
WELL SEND YOU COUNTY HAS A
SMALLER POPULATION THE BILL
FIFTEEN THOUSAND IS A YEAR FOR
THIRTY ONE ST YEARS UNTIL.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WHEN A JOB
TO AN AVERAGE OF SEVEN FIVE
HUNDRED UNITS A YEAR.
AB SEVENTY THREE ONE DOES LITTLE
TO ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC
CHALLENGES AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS.
INSTEAD THE BILL WILL NATIVELY
IN DIRECTLY IMPACT POCKETBOOKS A
MINI SANYO COUNTY RESIDENTS RELY
ON SHORT TERM RENTALS TO MAKE
ENDS MEET.
THANK YOU I JUST ASK YOU TO WRAP
UP HERE YES SIR.
CALIFORNIA'S COAST FROM THE
CALIFORNIA'S CO SHOULD REMAIN
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE TO ALL.
WE HAVE WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH
LOCAL SEIZING TIES IN CRAFTING
FAIR REGULATIONS AND REFLECT THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF EACH COMMUNITY
AND HELPING TO COLLECT TO TO
REVENUE. TO SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
WE BELIEVE THE ISSUES RAISED BY
THIS BILL OR PASS RESOLVED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE OTHERS IN OPPOSITION MR
KERRY MEMBERS THE ONLY COVERED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE RESTS ON
BEHALF OF EXPEDIA GROUP IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MUCH.
MANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DíAS MEMBERS COMMENTS QUESTIONS
ETCETERA.
I'M Y. LOVE IF WE DO HAVE.
FOLKS FROM BOTH SIDES HERE
BECAUSE I I SO.
ON THE LAST COMMENT THAT WAS
MADE. ONE OF THE LAST COUNT WAS
MADE IN INCOME AND IT WAS MADE
ME WHEN I WAS.
MEETING WITH THE OPPOSITION.
WAS IT THIS IS BEST IS ALL THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND AYE AYE.
THIS IS THE KIND OF THING THAT I
I I TEND TO AGREE WITH THAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S BEEN.
A KIND OF AN ATTEMPT HERE.
TO PUSH BACK ON SOME STUFF
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON THE COASTAL
COMMISSION.
YES MY YOU MIGHT MY BROADER
SENSE HERE IS THAT TO THE EXTENT
THE BILL.
HI I'M SEEKS TO ALLOW LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO BE MORE
RESTRICTIVE [inaudible]
I'M. FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT I
MISSTATED BY THAT SUPPORTERS I
WOULD TEND TO BE SUPPORTIVE TO
THE EXTENT THAT IT.
WOULD RESTRICT THE ABILITY OF A
CITY TO BE.
OUR MORE PERMISSIVE.
I GUESS I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT IF IF WE GIVE A LOCAL
COMMUNITIES DECIDED THAT IT YOU
KNOW WANTS.
TO I'M.
YOU KNOW THE ONCE MORE THIS KIND
OF I THINK AT THE COAST.
OVER IT WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES
THE WEATHER BEING THERE COUNTY
OR IN THAT THE SEA LEVEL.
I'M I KNOW THAT THE ARGUMENT IS
MADE BY THE AUTHOR IS THAT.
THE THE OUT HERE IS THAT IT
ALLOWS.
THE BILL ALLOWS THE CITY. TO
ZONE.
FOR OUR RESIDENT A SORRY --
TOURIST PRISON RESIDENTIAL
RESIDENTIAL TOURISM RESIDENTIAL
TOURISM.
I'M AND IF THE CITY DOES THAT.
THEN.
THE PLATFORMS AND STILL BE
ALLOWED TO OPERATE [inaudible]
I'M.
SO I ALSO A BRIBE WAS CONCERNED
HOW THIS MIGHT INTERACT WITH SB
THREE THIRTY WHICH IS.
TENER SKINNER'S BILL THE HOUSE
TO DO A DOWN ZONING AND YOU KNOW
THAT'S CONTROVERSIAL.
THE THE THE AUTHOR HAS AGREED TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
IS A DRESS THAT THE LAST THING I
WANT TO HAVE IS. FOR US TO HAVE
LANGUAGE IN HERE THAT HAS TO DO
THAT REQUIRES A REZONING OF
SORTS.
AND THEN HAVE THAT JAMMED UP BY
THE LANGUAGE OF THREE THIRTY A
THREE THIRTY IS THE PAST YOU
HAPPEN TO PASS I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN A BILL.
BUT I JUST WANT -- TO THIS OUT
THERE LET ME HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION IN SUPPORT.
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE YOU DID I
MEAN I KNOW THESE BROADER ISSUES
HAVE BEEN RAISED BY OPPOSITION
BUT BUT THE ONE OF THE CRITICAL
COMMENT THAT FOR ME IT WAS MADE
BY. ONE OF THE WITNESSES JUST
NOW AND IT WAS ALSO MADE.
IN A I'M.
YOU KNOW IN A IN A PREVIOUS
CONVERSATIONS HAVING OPPOSITION.
IS THAT THIS BEST TO RESOLVE THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND TO THE EXTENT OF
THIS BILL ALLOWS A COMMUNITY. TO
DO THE REZONING WHICH WOULD
ALLOW FOR THE PLATFORMS TO
CONTINUE OPERATING IF THAT'S
WHAT THE COMMUNITY WANTS.
THAT MAKES ME FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE SUPPORTING THE BILL
IN THE AND YOU KNOW IF IF SO
FOLKS HAVE RESPONSES THAT
REACTIONS I'D LOVE TO HEAR.
I'VE GOT SOMETHING WRONG IF I'M
MISTAKEN.
SURE SO OUR BELL WE EXPLICITLY
ALLOW THE OPT OUT MECHANISM FOR
THE RESIDENTIAL TOURISM.
I APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN IN
MAKING SURE TO STATE LAWS DON'T
CONFLICT WITH EACH OTHER AND
CAUSE PROBLEMS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
MORE HAPPY TO TAKE. ONE OF THE
REASONS WE DIDN'T WANT TO OPT
OUT MECHANISM TO BE A REZONING
PROCESS IS BECAUSE THAT ALLOWS
THE PUBLIC HEARINGS AND THE
PUBLIC TO WEIGH IN.
PERSON OTHER MECHANISMS I THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR SELF
DETERMINATION LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
I LOOK TO HEAR FROM A POSITION
OF THAT YEAH I THINK -- OUR OUR
CONCERN WOULD STILL BE THAT --
TO SOME DEGREE THE BILL AS IT'S
DESIGNED EVEN WITH SORT OF A
CHANGE IN THAT WAY IT'S STILL
SORT OF CIRCUMVENTING.
THE COASTAL COMMISSIONS PROCESS
AND SO THERE HAVE BEEN CITIES UP
AND DOWN THE COAST -- WHO HAVE
WHO HAVE MORE RESTRICTIVE --
POLICIES IN PLACE MORE FLEXIBLE
POLICIES IN PLACE AND THERE IS A
PROCESS THAT ALREADY EXISTS
WHERE.
RESIDENTS CAN WEIGH IN -- IN
THOSE LOCAL ORDINANCES AND THE
COASTAL COMMISSION CAN SORT OF
BALANCE THE ACCESS AS WELL AS
THE CONCERNS FROM THE COMMUNITY.
AND SO WE'D STILL BE CONCERNED
THAT THIS BILL IS NOT NECESSARY
BECAUSE ALL OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS
CAN HAPPEN AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHETHER IT IS.
A CITY THAT ONCE MORE
RESTRICTIVE POLICIES IN PLACE OR
MORE.
FLEXIBLE POLICIES IN PLACE THAN
WHAT'S CURRENTLY IN THE BILL
JUSTICES OF TO PARLAY AFTER THAT
I MEAN THE ISSUE IS THE ISSUE
THAT THE COASTAL COMMISSION HAS
BANNED.
KIND OF STEPPING IN ON THE
ABILITY OF CITIES.
TO SET THEIR OWN RULES YES SO
THE BECAUSE THE COMMISSION DOES
NOT HAVE ACCESS -- DOES NOT HAVE
AUTHORITY THE BALANCE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY WITH COASTAL
ACCESS THAT'S NO LONGER THE HOW
CLOSE LET THAT WAS REMOVED AND
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES SOMEONE A
COASTAL COMMISSION LOOKS AT AN
ORDINANCE.
I CAN ONLY MAKE A DECISION ON
COASTAL ACCESS AND JUST FOR A
POINT IN THE CASE OUR CASE IN
POINT THE BECAUSE THE COMMISSION
HAS NOT TAKEN A POSITION ON THE
BILL AND I GUARANTEE YOU OF
ANYBODY ON THE COAST COMMISSION
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT.
THIS BILL AFFECTING COASTAL
ACCESS THEY WOULD NOT BE NEUTRAL
WE ALL KNOW WHO ALL OF US WHO
REPRESENT BECAUSE AREAS KNOW
EXACTLY HOW THE THE BECAUSE
COMMISSION WOULD BE.
I WAS VERY PROTECTIVE OF THAT
WHAT NOW LET ME ASK ANOTHER
QUESTION AND MAYBE IT.
IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN WHEN
I WAS ASKING.
FOR AND THEN ONCE AGAIN IMAGES
EFFORTS PERSPECTIVES.
I SO YOU FRAME THIS VERY MUCH IN
THE CONTEXT OF ADDRESSING THE
HOUSING CRISIS HOUSING
AVAILABILITY [inaudible]
AND AFFORDABILITY.
I WHAT IS TO STOP YOUR BILL FROM
SIMPLY BEING USED [inaudible]
AS A YOU KNOW AS A AS A GOD.
RESIDENT DRIVEN ME ON I HATE
THIS WORD BUT NEED ME DRIVEN --
ATTEMPT TO STOP OUTSIDERS FROM
COMING INTO TOWN.
I AS OPPOSED.
TO YOU KNOW THE DEALING WITH IT
LIKE A GOOD FAITH ATTEMPTED TO
ADDRESS HOUSING CHALLENGES.
SO SO WHEN.
YOU IF YOU IMAGINE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IMAGINE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY SCHOOL SYSTEM.
WE PROVIDE 30% OF THE STATE'S
LOW COST BECAUSE ACCOMMODATION.
WE DO A GOOD JOB AT IT.
AND WE ARE I DON'T I DON'T THINK
THAT'S BECAUSE EVERYBODY.
NO LOCUS BECAUSE ACCOMMODATIONS
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVANCY DO NOT CLUED IN
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS.
THAT IS JUST LOOK WHAT WE HAVE
THE MOTELS HOTELS HOSTELS
CAMPSITE.
OKAY SO.
WE DO A GOOD JOB WE HAVE PEOPLE
COMING TO OUR VISITORS ALL THE
TIME AND AND SENATORS TO MOVE MY
BEACH WE GET THREE MILLION
VISITORS A YEAR.
NO ONE'S TRYING TO STOP AND AS
AS A COUNCIL MEMBER MENTION
THEY'RE BUILDING NEW LOW COST
BECAUSE ACCOMMODATIONS AND I'D
BE WE ARE VISITORS SERVING.
COMMUNITY WE ALL KNOW IN THE
COASTAL ZONE WE WELCOME VISITORS
TO OUR OUR BEACHES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
BUT AT SOME POINT.
THERE'S A TIPPING POINT WHERE WE
DON'T HAVE A PLACE FOR OUR
WORKERS TO LIVE THE PEOPLE WHO
CLEAN THOSE AIRBNB IS AND THE V.
RB OWES ON THE HOME WAYS.
THEY'RE NOT LIVING IN OUR
COMMUNITY THEY DON'T HAVE A
PLACE TO LIVE THE WORKERS TO
BUILD OUR FREEWAYS DO NOT HAVE A
PLACE TO LIVE THE VETERANS WHO
HAVE SERVED OUR COUNTRY ARE
STRUGGLING.
WITH VERY VERY HIGH RENTAL RATES
DO NOT HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE
FAMILIES ENTIRE SCHOOLS AND SOME
OF THESE AREAS HAVE CLOSED DOWN
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT A FAMILY IS
TO GO TO SCHOOL BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MANY SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS.
THIS IS.
YOU KNOW MY BILL WAS
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED OF HOW DO
WE ALLOW.
JIM AT HOME SHARING SO PEOPLE
CAN EARN THE EXTRA BUCKS ON THE
SIDE.
AS WELL AS AN PROVIDE THAT EXTRA
BOOST TO COASTAL CAPPELLO COSCO
ACOSTA ACCOMMODATIONS.
AND MAKE SURE WE'RE ADDRESSING
THE HOUSING CRISIS THAT IS SO
CUTE.
AND JUST AS A REFERENCE POINT.
IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE MY CITY
IN SIN IS THE AVERAGE HOME PRICE
WAS THREE HUNDRED FORTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THAT PRICE IS ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TODAY FOR THE
FOR YOU KNOW IT'S THIS IS ONLY
ONE PART OF THE YOU KNOW THE
OPPOSITION WHERE WE AGREE THIS
IS ONE PART OF THE PROBLEM.
BUT IF WE CAN'T STOP THE
BLEEDING OUT THE BACK END.
WHY SHOULD ANYBODY BILL MORE IN
THE COASTAL ZONE THEY'RE JUST
GOING TO BE FULL TIME SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS BOUGHT UP BY
OUT OF TOWN AND OUT OF STATE AND
OUT O COUNTRY INVESTORS?
WHO ARE NOT PROVIDING THE
HOUSING THAT OUR COMMUNITY SO
DESPERATELY NEED?
CAN YOU GIVE ME A A BETTER SENSE
OF WHAT EXACTLY IS MEANT BY.
RESIDENTIAL TERRORISM LIKE WHAT
WHAT ARE THE IMPLICATIONS ARE I
NEVER SEVEN A CITY COUNCIL OKAY --
THAT THAT THAT THAT'S A THAT'S A
KIND OF A SEPARATE CATEGORY
ALLOWED UNDER LAW.
SO SO IT CAME ABOUT ACTUALLY
VERY ORGANICALLY THE EYES WAS
SPEAKING WITH THE MAYOR OF
OCEANSIDE.
AND HE WHEN I FIRST INTRODUCED
MY BILL AND HE SAID WE HAVE HE
ZONE CALLED RESIDENTIAL TOURISM
AND WHEN YOU READ THE DEFINITION
OF THAT ZONE.
IT'S MEANT FOR SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS AND I THINK IF
THE CITY HAS PROPERLY ZONE IS
THE WE WANT TO BELIEVE IT OR
TERM.
BUT NO NO NO IT'S IT'S A
RESIDENTIAL TOURISM ABOUT HOW
MANY ASIAN OF SUMMER COTTAGES
HOMES SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS IF YOU GO EAD THE
DESCRIPTION.
OF THAT ZONE -- IT SPECIFICALLY
ALLOWING SHORTER VACATION
RENTALS AND THAT'S WHERE WE CAME
UP WITH THE OPT OUT MECHANISM
THE BELL SO AND WE WILL BE
WORKING ON A DEFINITION OF THAT
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE ROBUST
SO IT'S VERY CLEAR -- WHEN IN
JURISDICTIONS OWNS FOR THE THAT
IT'S THERE IT'LL BE CLEAR THAT
THAT'S ALL MACINNES THEM OKAY
THAT'S IMPORTANT?
AND I'VE I WOULD REALLY YOU KNOW.
IF I'M GONNA SPORTS TODAY IT
REALLY HANGS A LOT ON THAT OKAY
SO -- I CERTAINLY I WOULD WANT.
TO BE A REVIEW WHATEVER LANGUAGE
YOU'RE GOING TO ACCEPT.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO SHARE THAT WITH
RELATION AYE BECAUSE IN MY IN MY
YOU KNOW AND I I WOULD WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE WOULDN'T BE
AN OVERLY ONEROUS PROCESS --
ONCE AGAIN MY THE IDEA BEING
THAT YOU HAVE GIVEN THE COMMENTS
THAT I MADE EARLIER.
ABOUT THIS.
ABOUT RESPECT FOR LOCAL LEVEL
DECISION MAKING IF IF.
YOU KNOW IF IF THE LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS WANTED. ONE ALLOW FOR
THESE PLATFORMS WE ARE THAT WE
OUGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO SO.
AND I'LL CONTINUE FOLLOWING THIS
VERY CLOSELY AND IF THERE IS ANY
LOCAL ISSUE AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES CAUSES ON YOU BETTER
BELIEVE I'LL BE BACK TO HELP
CLARIFY THAT I WANT I SERVED ON
ANTHONY IS CITY COUNCIL I WAS ON
THE PLANNING COMMISSION BEFORE
THAT.
I BELIEVE IN LOCAL CONTROL AND I
WILL BE INTRODUCING THIS BILL IF
I IF.
THERE WAS NOT ANOTHER WAY TO DO
IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER I
KNOW CENTER HERTZBERG HAD A
COMMENT OR QUESTION CENTER.
THERE IS ONE APOLOGIZE TO THE
THE AUTHOR IS REACHED OUT
DILIGENTLY ME ON MANY OCCASIONS
AND RENTAL OTHERWISE PREDISPOSE
IN THE SENATE ON MATTERS DEALING
WITH WILDFIRES THAT.
THEY CAN WIN MY SCHEDULE DOING
THAT SO THE WE MET ONCE.
YOU GET A CHANCE TO TO GET INTO
THAT I APOLOGIZE TO YOU.
ON I KNOW YOU WANTED TIME AND
YOU'VE WORKED YOUR BILLS -- IN A
FABULOUSLY I GIVE YOU GREAT
CREDIT FOR THAT.
BUT AS SOMEONE WHO WAS VERY
INVOLVED WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION FOR YEARS WHAT I KNOW
IN ALL OF MY EXPERIENCE FOR
DECADES IN THE COASTAL
COMMISSION IS IT EVERYTHING'S
ABOUT ACCESS AND OTHERS BEEN
LITIGATION.
I I I READ QUE I DECIDED THAT IS
IN THE IN A PASSIONATE WAY.
THAT THE THAT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION HAS HAS A TEST IN HIS
THIS IS ALL THESE COASTAL CITIES
I'M INVOLVED THIS IS PROP THE
TWENTY WAS PASSED.
BUT HOW MANY YEARS AGO THAT WAS
BUT AS LONG TIME -- MONEY
PROBABLY KNOWS.
EVEN WITH HOW. SEVENTY EIGHT NO
MONEY LOOK ALL RIGHT HERE BUT
CENTER MONEY LOOK GREAT BY THE
WAY.
SO IN ANY EVENT.
IT IS SO THIS IS BEEN THE FACT
WE DEALT WITH THIS SO MANY YEARS
AND SO MANY APPOINTEES ACCESS
ACCESS ACCESS.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER
MEASURES AND OTHER IT BY LOCAL
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN THE
TENSION BECAUSE COASTAL
COMMUNITIES GT GREAT.
OPPORTUNITIES THAT'S WHY PEOPLE
READ THIS THEY TALK ABOUT
FAMILIES AND LESS EXPENSIVE AND
ALL THIS STUFF.
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE WITH YOUR
SEEKING TO DO WITH THE
UNDERLYING AND CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ADEN ISSUES OF
UNDERSERVED PEOPLE LESS PEOPLE
LESS WELL TO BE ABLE TO GET
ACCESS PURSES THE ABILITY OF
LOCALS? TO DEAL WITH ESPECIALLY
WITH HOUSING IT HAS TO DO WITH.
BEING A YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN SO
MANY COMMITTEES IN THIS
COMMITTEE OVER SO MANY YEARS WE
DEAL WITH THIS WHOLE ISSUE OF
ACCESS AND PEOPLE HAVING ACCESS
TO THESE.
EXTRAORDINARY CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES AND ONE OF THE A BATES
AGAIN IS THE COASTAL COMMISSION
HAS CONSISTENTLY SAID THAT HOW
DOES WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE
RECONCILE WITH THAT VERY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY.
I THINK THAT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF POLICY BUT WHEN YOU GO
BACK YOU LOOK AND SAY LOW COST
BECAUSE ACCOMODATIONS HOTEL
MOTELS HOSTELS AND CAMPSITES.
OF THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEN HE'LL COUNTIES
CAUSES ON PROVIDES ONE THIRD OF
THAT WE DO A GREAT JOB AND THERE
ARE PLACES THAT TO DOCTOR GREAT
JOB ON THAT ARE STILL STRUGGLING
FOR THAT.
SO I THINK WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT IS THAT.
I'M SORRY -- WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT IS THAT WE ARE DOING A
GREAT JOB PROVIDING THAT MY
LOCAL IKANA LODGE IS A HUNDRED
TWENTY DOLLARS A NIGHT YOU GO
FOR A FAMILY OF FOUR AND THERE --
WHEN YOU LOOK AT -- WE LOOK AT
OF THREE BEDROOM -- SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTAL IT'S ABOUT
NINETY FIVE DOLLARS I THINK ON
AVERAGE NIGHT HAS BEEN CITED
THAT'S NINETY FIVE DOLLARS
COUNTING FOR PEOPLE PREVENTION
THAT'S TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
NIGHT.
THAT IS NOT LOW COST COAST
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR MOST OF THE
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS
UNLESS YOU LOOK AT THE MOBILE
HOME PARKS THE COMMISSION
ADDRESS THAT IN THEIR OPINIONS
THAT I READ.
THE MIDDLE OF NIGHT SOMETIME I
CAN'T MOVE DECISION WAS A BY
JUST REMEMBER THAT IS THE IDEA
THAT IT PROVIDES THE FAMILY THAT
YOU COULD HAVE A KITCHEN AND ALL
THOSE THINGS BUT IT REALLY IS
ABOUT.
CREATING THAT AVERAGE OPTION
THEY SAID BECAUSE I FOLLOWED UP
AS A RESULT OF OUR DISCUSSION A
COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS I'M
FOLLOWING UP AS A RESULT OF OUR
DISCUSSION BUT TO ME.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN MAKE THAT
ARGUMENT I'M JUST TELLING YOU
THEY SAID NO.
THEY SAID NO SO MY QUESTION TO
YOU IS IF YOU IF YOU'RE SINCERE
ABOUT THIS IS MOVES FORWARD I
DON'T KNOW WHY I'M NOT HERE TO
VOTE ON THAT ISSUE BUT I JUST
SUGGESTED.
THEN THAT HAVE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION APPROVED IT ONCE WE
PASS THIS BILL MAKE A CONDITION
OF THE COASTAL COMMISSION MAKE
SUCH AN APPROVAL. FOR THAT IS
THAT IT RATHER THAN US SITTING
THERE TELLING THE GUYS STOP
HAVING OTHER LITIGATION IF
YOU'RE BALANCING THESE INEREST
WHY CAN'T WE ENGAGE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND ALSO WITH THAT
WITH THE CO SO COMMISSION --
REPRESENTATIVE SEVERAL TIMES.
ON THE COAST COMMISSION IS
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL.
AND I THINK WE ALL KNOW THE
CAUSE MISSION IF.
THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT IT
ACTUALLY LIMITING COASTAL ACCESS
THEY WOULD NOT BE NEUTRAL FIRST
OF ALL I THINK -- THE OPPOSITION
HAS BEEN VERY DILIGENT ABOUT
SENDING IN LETTERS TO THE
BECAUSE THE COMMISSION.
AND WHAT I THINK WHAT THAT'S
ABOUT IS WE DO A GOOD JOB OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY ABOUT PROVIDING
THOSE LOCAL SCHOOLS
ACCOMMODATIONS ON TOP.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON CAN STILL
WITHIN THEIR CITY'S ORDINANCE
PRINT OUT UP TO NINETY DAYS A
YEAR IF THEY PLATFORM HOP SO
THIRTY DAYS PER PLATFORM.
SO THEY CAN PLATFORM HOT.
AN ENTIRE SUMMER THAT'S ALMOST
EVERY WEEKEND OF THE YEAR THAT
IS SUFFICIENT ACCESS TO THE
COAST AND BUMPS UP OUR VISITORS
SURVEYING -- ACCOMMODATIONS AND
TIMES WHEN THERE IS THE HIGHEST
DEMANDS.
THAT KIND OF AREA OF THAT I WANT
TO EXPLORE WITH THE THE WEEKS
BOARD MY OFFICE.
IS THIS LARGER ISSUE ABOUT ARE
YOU REALLY SOLVING A PROBLEM.
KIND OF WHAT CENTER AROUND WAS
TALKING ABOUT IN OTHER WORDS.
HOW MANY HOMES ARE THERE?
WHAT'S THE NATURE OF THE HOMES.
AND AND AND AND AND WHAT WOULD
BE THE IMPACT SO YOU NOW MAKE
THIS PREVENTION OF THIS STUFF
THIS IS A LARGER DYNAMIC TO ME I
KNOW YOUR LIMITS AND YOU COUNTY
BUT I THINK THAT.
ALSO STATE LEGISLATORS IN
PARTICULAR RATE COAST WE HAVE TO
ANALYZE THIS IN A BROADER
CONTEXT BECAUSE IT DOES SET OF
POLICY.
THE QUESTION IS YOU KNOW ARE YOU
REALLY SOLVING A PROBLEM IS THIS
I MEAN ARE THESE LOW INCOME
HOUSING ARE THESE AVAILABLE TO
PEOPLE THAT WOULD OTHERWISE NOT
BE AVAILABLE AS RENTALS IN SOME
WAY.
IF IN FACT IT'S COST SO MUCH
MONEY TO RENT THEM AIRBNB OR
WHATEVER THE OTHER COMPANIES ARE.
THE QUESTION IS ARE YOU REALLY
AND HOW MANY SUCH UNITS ARE
THERE AND WHAT IS THE NATURE OF
THE PROBLEM.
AND AND YOU KNOW WE WE WE ALL
TALK ABOUT HOUSING IN AND OUT WE
SEE ALL THESE PROPOSALS.
WHAT DO YOU REALLY AFFECTING
WHAT HOW MANY HUMAN BEINGS HOW
MANY LIVES ARE BEING AFFECTED
THE COUNTY YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
THAT'S WHAT I ASKED YOU ABOUT I
HAD SOME NUMBERS ON IT?
BUT I'D LIKE TO HEAR YOUR
RESPONSE BECAUSE IT'S IT'S ONE
THING TO TALK ABOUT IT THE FACTS
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES DESERVE
MATIC PROBLEM GIVE SO MUCH LAND
SO MANY UNITS SO MUCH NUMBERS.
WHAT'S THE IMPACT YOU NEED TO IT
SEEMS TO ME YOU NEED TO MAKE
THAT COMPELLING CASE THAT SHOWS
THAT YOUR POLICY RESULTS IN
BETTER ISSUES ON HOUSING.
GO AHEAD I'LL RESPOND AFTERWARDS
BUT HOUSE MEMBER MARK WEST
FELONY REALLY I WANT TO FRAME
THIS IN AN ARGUMENT FROM MY OWN
CITY BECAUSE IMPERIAL BEACHES
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE LEAST OF LAW
COMMUNITY AND ALL SENIOR COUNTY.
AND WHEN AIRBNB THERE ARE
STUDIES OUT OF UCLA AND USC THAT
DIRECTLY SAY.
THIS AFFECTS THE RENTS IN MY
COMMUNITY SO THIS IS I'M ALREADY
ONE OF THE MOST -- THE MOST I
HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING TWO
AND THREE JOBS RIGHT NOW AND
BECAUSE OF THE INFLUENCE OF
AIRBNB AND THAT THESE THE THE
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS IT'S
ACTUALLY DRIVING UP THE RENTS ON
THOSE PEOPLE BECAUSE ACTUALLY
PEOPLE HAVE TO RAISE THE RENT
JUST TO COMPETE WITH.
THOSE AND THEY'RE GETTING MORE
MONEY SO IT'S IT DIRECTLY
AFFECTS MY COMMUNITY AND MAKING
PEOPLE THAT ARE ALREADY WORKING
TWO JOBS ON FOOD STAMPS AND
REALLY NOT BEING ABLE TO GET BY
EVEN MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT AND
ON ANECDOTAL DATA.
THOSE ARE GREAT WORDS ONLY
WHAT'S THE EVIDENCE TO MAKE THAT
SHOWING YOU SAY YOU'RE CITY IN
MIGHT MIGHT IN MY CITY IN MY
SOMETHING.
IN MY CITY WE POINT WELL IN MY
CITY WE HAVE WE'RE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
WE'VE SEEN THE HIGHEST PROPERTY
VALUE INCREASES THE PAST TWO
YEARS IN A ROW. 10% LAST YEAR
12% THIS YEAR IT IS IT IS
OBVIOUS THAT IT IS HAPPENING IN
MY COMMUNITY RIGHT NOW.
AND ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE HAVE IS -- CITIES THAT
USUALLY HAVE A PERMITTING
PROCESS SO WE COULD COUNT THE
NUMBER OF PERMITS.
BUT SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL
PLATFORMS DO NOT RETURN BACK TO
THE CITIES EVEN THE CITIES THAT
DO HAVE AGREEMENTS WITH.
AIRBNB FOR EXAMPLE THEY RETURN A
LUMP SUM THEY DON'T SAY THIS
PERSON STATE HERE FOR THIS MANY
NIGHTS I'M AT THIS LOCATION SO
IT'S VERY VERY HARD TO ACTUALLY
WHITTLE DOWN THAT NUMBER AND
THAT'S HOPEFULLY WHAT.
SOME OF THE THINGS OF THIS BILL
WILL DO BECAUSE IT CLICKS TO TEA
AND MORE.
SPECIFYING THAT THE NAME OF THE
THE HOST THE LOCATION AND THE
NUMBER OF STAYS AND AND THE
GUEST ALL BE REMITTED BACK TO
THE CITY SO WE CAN.
YOU KNOW SO CITY HAS ABILITY TO
MANAGE THIS IS WHAT'S BEEN LIST
ON THE PLATFORM AND THIS IS
WHAT'S BEING ACTUALLY IT WHAT'S
WITHIN A PERMIT.
MY CITY WE HAD PAID SOMEBODY
PART TIME FOR NINE MONTHS JUST
TO PUT CHECK THE PLATFORMS AND
THEN ISSUE THEM A LETTER SAYING
YOU NEED TO HAVE A PERMIT. FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE WERE LISTING ON
THE PLATFORM THEY DIDN'T HAVE A
PERMIT IN JUST MY CITY OF SIXTY
TWO THOUSAND WE ESTIMATE THERE
ARE FIVE THOUSAND UNITS THAT ARE
BEING ROOM OF THAT HAVE BEEN
REMOVED.
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY COASTAL
ZONE DUE TO FULL TIME SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS THIS.
IF WE CANNOT STOP THE BLEEDING
OF THE BACK AND NO ONE OF MY
COMMUNITY IS DOUBLE MORE BECAUSE
WE'RE JUST GOING TO BLEED AND AN
EXAMPLE -- COUNCILMEMBER WEST
GAVE WAS A T. O. D. DEVELOPMENT
WHEN AND THESE A LOT OF
POLITICAL CAPITAL TO BUILD IT.
FOR THEIR FAMILIES FOR THEIR
WORKERS FOR PEOPLE OF THIS
COMMUNITY. TWO HUNDRED UNITS
MULTI FAMILY DEVELOPMENT WITHIN
THREE MONTHS TWENTY FIVE OF
THOSE TWO HUNDRED UNITS WLL FOR
ALL TIME SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS.
THAT'S THE IMPACT OF THE
PLATFORMS ARE HAVING AND SO I
THINK WE HAVE TO BE HONEST IF
WE'RE A HOUSING CRISIS OR SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTAL CRISIS.
I'D SAY WE'RE IN A HOUSING
CRISIS BUT LEADERSHIP QUESTION
WE PASSED OUT OF GOVERNANCE THE
MAN'S FIVE YEARS AGO.
A MEASURE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
WHO'S CURRENTLY SERVES AS THE
CHAIR OF THAT COMMITTEE THAT
DEALT WITH THIS VERY ISSUE IN
TERMS OF COLLECTING DATA AND
WHAT THAT MEANT.
AND THE QUESTION WAS THE TIME
THAT INFORMED.
INFORM THE THINKING HAD TO DO
WITH THE ALL OF THE ISSUES IS IT
IT WAS THE BALANCE BETWEEN
CITIES COLLECTING THE REVENUE
RIGHT.
AND MAKING SURE PEOPLE SIGNED UP
FOR THEIR T. O. T..
AND REQUIRED THEM TO DO THAT.
HEY AND THEN ON THE OTHER HAND
THE ISSUE OF GATHERING
INFORMATION ABOUT WHO'S DOING
WHAT AND HOW THEY'RE DOING IT.
AND AND WHAT THE AUDIT
PROVISIONS WERE IN THE REAL.
FOCUS WAS COLLECTING THE MONEY
BECAUSE THEY WERE SIDE STEPPING
THE MONEY AND THE UNDERLYING
ARGUMENT WAS WHAT WE WANT TO
FIND OUT THE SITUATION SO WE CAN
GATHER NAY BUT NEIGHBORHOODS ARE
GO AFTER PEOPLE AND GATHER
INFORMATION FOR THAT STUFF.
AND THAT WAS THE BALANCE THAT
WAS STRUCK AND NOW YOU'RE YOU'RE
BASICALLY TOUCHING THAT ISSUE
THAT WE WITHOUT NOT TO SAY IT
SHOULDN'T CHANGE I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT.
BUT I'M JUST SUGGESTING WE WE
SPENT MONTHS AND MONTHS GOING TO
THIS VERY ISSUE IN GOVERNANCE
FINANCE WHEN I WAS CHAIRING THE
COMMITTEE.
DEALING WITH IT AND WE DECIDED
ON A STRUCTURE THAT RELATEDTO
COLLECTION WAS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO COMPENSATE
CITIES.
RATHER THAN GATHERING
INFORMATION THAT THEN COULD.
YOU DEAL WITH SOME OF KIND OF
THE THE THE PLEASE POWER ISSUE
UNDERSTOOD AND IF IT HELPS AT
ALL THIS IS.
REFERRED ALSO TO GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SO THEY'LL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY WHEN SHOULD IT PASS
COMMITTEE TODAY BUT I APPRECIATE
THE THE WAY IN THERE -- SEEING
NO OTHER.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS I
APPRECIATE THE THOROUGH
DISCUSSION -- WHEN IT IS A
RESPONSE TO SENATOR HURTS FOR
WHAT WE GOT TO WRAP THIS UP HERE
THE OF A QUICK?
FACTS COUPLE OF CLARIFICATIONS
ON THE COASTAL COMMISSION PIECE
I DON'T BELIEVE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION HAS TAKEN ANY
POSITION I DON'T THINK IT'S DO
GET OUT OF THERE TO PROVIDE
THROUGH NOT TAKING AND THEY HAVE
NOT TAKEN A POSITION OKAY.
YOU'RE CORRECT OKAY AND I WOULD
JUST I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT --
FOR THE CITIES THAT ARE IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY THERE ARE CITIES
THAT HAVE ATTEMPTED TO PASS --
FOR ORDINANCES THAT DO RESTRICT
ACCESS SO TO THE AUTHOR'S POINT
ABOUT -- SAN DIEGO PROVIDING A
LOT OF ACCESS -- ONE CITY IN
PARTICULAR HAD A SEVEN NIGHT
MINIMUM WHICH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION THOUGHT WAS TOO
RESTRICTIVE AND SO THERE ARE
STILL RECENT EXAMPLES OF CITIES
WITHIN THE COUNTY THAT.
ARE LOOKING AT LOOKING TO
RETREAT WE RESTRICT ACCESS AND
JUST THE LAST POINT ON HOUSING --
THE BILL IS ACTUALLY TARGETING
HOSTING PLATFORMS SO TO THE
POINT ABOUT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION NOT HAVING
JURISDICTION OVER HOUSING THE
BILL DOES NOT.
PROVIDE THAT IN ORDER.
TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
HOUSING THE BILL ALSO DOES NOT --
TARGET PROPERTY OWNERS WHO ARE
ACTUALLY THE ONES WHO SHOULD BE
OR COULD BE INCENTIVIZE TO PUT
THEIR HOMES BACK IN THE LONG
TERM RENTAL MARKET.
ALL THE BILL REALLY DOES IS
LIMIT THE WAY THAT A PROPERTY
OWNER CAN ADVERTISE THEIR
PROPERTY AND WHAT'S THE STATE'S
INTEREST IN UNDERSTOOD.
WHO IS GOING TO BE ONE MORE
BRIEF COMMENT BECAUSE WE'VE GOT
A WE'VE GOT?
RELEASE THAT LAST COMMENT WHICH
WHICH KIND OF RAISES IT WILL
JUST GET GIVE ME GIVE ME A SENSE
OF BRIEF.
YEAH I JUST OKAY THIS IS WE'VE
GOT IT WE GOT SOME FOLKS HERE
WAITING HAVE COME A LONG WAYS TO
SO JUST BUT PLEASE PROCEED.
JUMP IN.
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH -- APPRECIATE THE
DELIBERATE NATURE THE SENATE AND
HIS BODY THOUGH AND IT'S BEEN A
THOROUGH DISCUSSIONS YOU AREN'T
VERY DELIVERED OF AND YES WE ARE
THANK YOU SO MUCH NOTHING IF NOT
DELIVERED IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
PLEASE WAY IN THIS OF A ROOF
SENATOR BEFORE I ALLOW A MEMBER
TO CLOSE HERE [inaudible]
I THE DAY A DOES THAT THAT ISSUE
I THINK.
MY TIE THIS UP IN COURT.
YEAH THAT THAT DID THIS THIS
WHOLE ISSUE OF THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THIS IS.
PROHIBITING A PARTICULAR.
UP APPROACH TO SALES AND
MARKETING RATHER THAN.
A LAND USE.
SO THE SO WE EVALUATED MANY WAYS
IT HAS TRIED TO CATCH UP WITH.
TO RESPOND TO THAT ISSUE IN YOUR
AS PART OF YOUR CLOTHES.
SURE WHEN WE DO IT THAT WAY --
SINCE I THINK SO YOU CAN ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE OF ANY POTENTIAL
LEGAL RISKIER -- IN YOUR CLOTHES
AND REJECTS ANY OTHER MEMBER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS REYES THANK YOU
WELL I DO APPRECIATE THE VERY
DELIBERATE OF APPROACH YOU OF
ALL TAKEN -- TO THIS BILL.
WE CONSIDERED EIGHT DIFFERENT
POSSIBILITIES OF DRESSING THIS
ISSUE BEFORE READING THIS BILL --
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
IT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
BALANCING -- THIS ISSUE BECAUSE
IT WE DO HAVE A HOUSING FOR A
CRISIS AND ONE OF THE ASPECTS IS
THE EASE OF WHICH PLATFORMS --
AND ABLE THE REMOVAL OF HOUSING
FOR THE HOUSING MARKET LOWERS
THAT THRESHOLD TO THE POINT
WHERE IT IS MORE PROFITABLE FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL TO RENT OUT.
A HOME.
COUNTED IN ARENA NUMBERS DESIGN
FOR A FAMILY OR VETERAN OR
SENIORS THEN TO RENTED OUT FOR
LONG TERM RUNS WE KNOW FROM
STUDIES THAT.
THERE WAS A STUDY PUBLISHED
RECENTLY IN THE NEW YORK TIMES
THAT SHOWED IN MANHATTAN ANOTHER
HIGHLAND VALUE AREA THAT RENTAL
RATES INCREASE ABOUT 30%. TO THE
FULL TIME SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS.
THIS IS REAL WE I'VE EXPERIENCED
IT MY CITY A AND CITY THIS
MARKET ACCOUNTS MEMBER WEST AS
EXPERIENCE IT AND IMPERIAL BEACH
TWO VERY DIFFERENT CITIES IN THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY COASTAL ZONE.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU AND I
APPRECIATE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR BY THE VERY GOOD THANK
YOU -- WE WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION AT THIS TIME -- BUT IF
THERE'S NO MOTION ALSO WE CAN WE
CAN LEAVE THE MEASURE ON HOLD
AND WAIT FOR THEIR MEMBERS BUT
BELIEVE IT OFF ALL MOVE THE ITEM
BUT I I REALLY -- WATCH THIS
DISCUSSION WITH CLOSELY IN AND I
THINK THERE'S STILL A NUMBER OF
ISSUES HAVE TO BE RESOLVED.
OKAY SO -- THE MOTION IS.
DUE PASSED TO GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WHERE THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS WILL BE.
ADOPTED -- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR STERN BY STERN HIGH
JONES ALLEN.
ALLEN I'D FORGES CABALLERO
HERTZBERG.
HUESO JACKSON MONEY OKAY WE'LL
LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH RESIDENTS.
YES OF COURSE -- THE VERY
PATIENT SEVEN OR GIPSON AND ALL
THE WORKERS HERE TODAY THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR PATIENCE HELLO --
THE GIPSON IS.
NO IT'S ACTUALLY GIPSON FIRST.
YES.
WE'RE GOING TO FILE ORDER HE'S.
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE GOING ON
FILE ORDER HERE. TO DO THAT.
THAT'S THAT'S TRUE.
LEVINE YOU HAVE.
I BELIEVE AN ITEM HERE ACTUALLY
YOUR OTHER ITEMS UP FOR CONSENT
SO I BELIEVE THAT IS THE ONLY
MEASURE PRESENTING.
I DO APOLOGIZE HAVE EXPLOITED
NOW YOUR DIFFERENCE IN RESPECT.
MR LEVINE -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AS
CHAIRMAN OF MY OPENING REMARKS
SAYS GOOD MORNING -- SO.
LET ME THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL -- THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE.
THAT THE CALIFORNIA PORTS OUR
POSITION TO IMPROVE THE
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCY WHILE
ALSO MAINTAIN THE LIVELIHOODS OF
THOSE WHO DEPENDS ON THEM -- FOR
STABLE JOBS AUTOMATED TECHNOLOGY
ARE GROW IS GROWING -- IN THEIR
APPLICATION TO VARIOUS
INDUSTRIES.
WE HEAR OFTEN ABOUT THE BENEFITS
OF AUTOMATION AND HOW IT
IMPROVES EFFICIENCY AND HELP --
IN AND INTRODUCE CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY HOWEVER.
AS MORE.
FIND MORE JOBS AUTOMATED IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT FOR EVERY
JOB -- IN WHICH A WORKER IS
DISPLACED -- THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES ARE IMPACTED AS WELL
FOR EXAMPLE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
15% OF THE MANUFACTURING TASKS
GLOBALLY WERE PERFORMED BY
ROBOTS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN WHICH IS EXPECTED TO
GROW -- 225% IN TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE AS A RESULT THIS BILL SEEKS
TO REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LANDS COMMISSION.
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TO HOLD
A SERIES OF MEETINGS AROUND THE
CALIFORNIA PORTS TO REVIEW THE
IMPACT OF AUTOMATED TECHNOLOGY
ACROSS CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
THESE CONSIDERATIONS ARE TO
INCLUDE THE SAFETY OF THE WORK
ENVIRONMENT ECONOMIC IMPACT AND
THE AND THE AND THE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS OF THE USE
OF OF OF AUTOMATED TECHNOLOGY.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE WOULD
INVEST CALIFORNIA'S TECHNOLOGY
IMPORTS.
ALSO -- ACCOUNTING FOR HOW IT
WILL AFFECT THE LIVELIHOODS OF
THE WORKERS WHO RELY ON THESE
JOBS DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT BEING
AGAINST AUTOMATION WE ARE SIMPLY
FOR WORKING PEOPLE TRYING TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES --
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO UNDERSCORE I REPRESENT
THE SIX POURS DISTRICT AND
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I AM
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT ABOUT
AUTOMATION SPECIALLY IN THE PORT.
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES AND LONG
BEACH IT HELPS DRIVE THE ENGINE
IN CALIFORNIA WE CANNOT BRAG
UNLESS WE TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
PORTS THE BOMB IS DOING DAY IN
AND DAY OUT DAY IN DAY OUT WHEN
IT COMES DOWN.
TO IT IMPORTANT EXPORT WE ARE
THE FIFTH WORLD ECONOMY BECAUSE
THE PORTS EXIST BECAUSE THE MEN
AND WOMEN ARE THERE TO MAKING
SURE THAT GOODS MOVEMENT
CONTINUE TO FLOW -- THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE PORTS THAT IN HERE
AND CALIFORNIA HERE WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS --
MARVIN PIANO WAS MORE.
OKAY -- WELL LET ME GO TO THAT
THE PRESIDENT OF I. O. W. -- WHO
WILL STILL PRODUCE AND -- GIVE
SUPPORTING COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SOME MEMBERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT AB.
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE MY NAME IS
REALLY FAMILY OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE INTERNATIONAL LONG SHORE
AND WAREHOUSE UNION LOCAL
THIRTEEN AND I'M HERE TO IMPRESS
UPON YOU THE IMPORTANCE.
OF THE VOTE YOUR ABOUT TO TAKE
REGARDING A. B..
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE AS I ASK
THAT YOU APPROVE THIS BILL FOR
CONSIDERATION.
OF THE FULL ASSEMBLY.
THE I. O. W. AS A PROGRESSIVE
UNION THAT REPRESENTS LONG SHORT
WORKERS ON THE WEST COAST AND WE
HAVE A VERY LONG HISTORY AND
TRACK RECORD OF ADVOCATING FOR
WORKERS.
RIGHTS TO WORK IN SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS AND TO EARN GOOD
WAGES AND BENEFITS.
I'LL W. SUPPORT SOCIAL POLITICAL
AND ECONOMIC CAUSES.
THAT BENEFIT ALL WORKERS IN THIS
GREAT STATE AND THIS BILL IS ONE
OF THOSE CAUSES.
I AM HERE TODAY TO IMPRESS UPON
YOU THE IMPORTANCE OF SUPPORTING
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT WILL HELP
SAVE.
THE ECONOMIES OF THIS STATE.
AND ITS LOCAL PORT COMMUNITIES.
TODAY IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
ENSURE.
JUSTIN SAFE TRANSITION FROM
ECONOMIES.
ARE GROUNDED IN HONEST
HARDWORKING HUMAN LABOR.
SPENDING THEIR EARNINGS. TWO ONE
THAT WILL DEPEND ON
UNSUSTAINABLE AUTOMATED AND
ROBOTIC LABOR.
THIS VOTE IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE STATE TO BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES
AND THE ANTICIPATED NEGATIVE
IMPACTS.
THE AUTOMATED AND ROBOTIC LABOR
WILL HAVE ON OUR STATE AND
ESPECIALLY TO ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
WORK.
LIVE OWN BUSINESSES AND SHOP
THERE.
WITH THIS VOTE YOU CAN BEGIN TO
ADOPT POLICIES THAT WILL REDUCE
OR PREVENT IF NECESSARY THOSE
ANTICIPATED NEGATIVE IMPACTS AND
BARRIERS.
THAT WILL FALL ON OUR STATE AND
OUR LOCAL ECONOMIES AND ON THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THE STATE.
WITH YOUR VOTE YOU CAN INSURE
THAT THE STATE WILL CONTINUE TO
PROSPER AND IT IS WORKING PEOPLE
CAN CONTINUE TO EARN GOOD HOURLY
WAGES.
TOOL FOR THEIR OWN HOMES TO LIVE
HAPPIER LIVES. TO AFFORD HIGHER
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCES FOR
THEIR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE
YOU TODAY SINCERELY APPRECIATE A
SUPPRESSED -- MISTER PENA DID
YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY OR WE CAN JUST TAKE IT.
YEAH AND HIS MARIN WE HAVE A
THAT INTERNATIONAL LONG SURE
WHERE HOUSE UNION SUPPORT VERY
GOOD OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
COME FORWARD I THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR PATIENCE.
MIKE ROUNDS OF OIL W. LOCAL
SIXTY THREE GAME WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
JOE CORTEZ I'LL GIVE YOU LOCAL
NINETY FOUR WE SUPPORT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU.
PLEASE SEND ALL WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL -- SURE WINNER
HOUSE UNIONS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT COUNCIL AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT YES SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
RARE INTERNATIONAL LAUNCHER
WAREHOUSE LOCAL THIRTEEN VICE
PRESIDENT AND COMMUNITY RESIDENT
IN SUPPORT VERY GOOD THANK YOU
SIR. ZERO MCDONNELL JUNIOR I'M A
RESIDENCE AND FUTURE.
AND I'M AND FOR THOSE OF A VERY
GOOD THANK YOU.
HI I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
I'M DIANA CHAVEZ FIVE BUT I'M
NOT JUST HERE SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF.
I'M SPEAKING AS A RESIDENT OF ST
PETER OR IS A MEMBER OF THE I.
O. W. OR JUST MY PORTAL.
THIRTEEN I'M NOT A LOCAL.
SIXTY THREE PRIOR HUSBAND
REPRESENTED HIM AS A MECHANIC
FOR LOCAL THIRTEEN MY SISTER AND
FONG CHARMING FOR LOCAL THIRTEEN
BY BROTHER AS A LONG CHORE OF
WALKING BONDS FOR LOCAL.
NINETY FOUR MY SON WHO IS A
TEACHER YOUR HIGH SCHOOL AND A
MEMBER OF THE U. T. LA.
AS WELL AS THE REALTOR FOR MORE
OLD AND MY TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER WHO GOES TO LONG BEACH
CITY COLLEGE.
AND I'M HAPPY TO SEE THAT.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON I JUST SPOKE
ABOUT.
EVERYONE OF THEM SUPPORT A
LETTER IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
THANK YOU.
THIS BRIDGE BUILDING LOCAL
THIRTEEN I SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SHANNON ROSS AND BEHALF
ON A HOMELESS SORRY AND BEHALF
OF THOUSANDS OF LONGSHOREMEN
FAMILIES IN THE SOUTH HARBOUR
AREA OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT AB. THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
TO SAY YES TO PEOPLE AND SAY NO
TO ROBOTS AND I OF THOUSANDS WHO
HAVE SIGNED A PETITION IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY ONE AND HERE'S A POSITION
SIX THOUSAND IF YOU CAN GIVE
THAT TO THE SERGEANTS SO THAT WE
COULD -- HAVE THAT SUBMITTED FOR
THE PUBLIC RECORD THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT FORD.
HELLO MARTY SIR TO I'M IN
SUPPORT I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT WE ALSO HAVE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK INTO THERE'S OVER
THREE THOUSAND STUDIES
CIRCULATING RIGHT NOW POINTING
OUT THE DANGERS OF WIRELESS
TECHNOLOGY THAT THEY PLAN ON
BLINKING IN THE PARK WITH.
I WOULD LIKE TO SUBMIT THE
STUDIES PLEASE -- WE DO OF THE
SERGEANTS HERE SO WE COULD
ACCEPT THOSE STUDIES INTO THE
RECORD AS WELL THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THEM FOR IT SIR
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY I ALSO
HAVE A ECONOMIC STUDIES --
HIGHLIGHTING WILL TAKE WHAT YOU
GOT IN SUPPORT OF THE GREAT THE
BILL AS WELL THINKING VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SIR.
WILL ENTER AND THE RECORD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES YOU'RE WELCOME ZEKE MINERAL
MOMENT REPRESENTING THE CASUALS.
LONGSHOREMEN.
WERE IN FAVOR AND SUPPORT A. B..
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE THANK YOU
SIR.
CANCEL LEE'S SUMMIT LOCAL
THIRTEEN MEMBER AND LONG BEACH
RESIDENT IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
TWENTY ONE THINKING THANK YOU.
YOU DO AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FIRST FOR HEARING ALL
THIS REALLY APPRECIATED -- DAVID
CERRADO I'LL W. MEMBER ALSO A
COMMUNITY.
MEMBER FROM TORRANCE CALIFORNIA
MISTER VAN ALLEN THERE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS EILEEN
DIAMOND I AM -- FOR GENERATION
BORN REYES AND ALL FOR
GENERATIONS TO LIVING IN ST
PETER RESIDENT.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU
MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS LINDA GONZALEZ
AND I AM.
FROM LOCAL.
THIRTEEN AND I AM.
THE A COMMUNITY I LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND I SUPPORT THAT
THANK YOU FAMOUS ITSELF.
WE GOT YOU WE GUY MY NAME IS
LISA RUTH AND I AM A TWENTY YEAR
MEMBER OF WILD W. I AM ALSO
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER.
AND A COMMUNITY MEMBER AND I'M
VERY CONCERNED COMMUNITY MEMBER
AND I DEFINITELY SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR ME.
HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE HERRERA
I LIVE IN RANCHO PALS FOR YOU
SOME PART OF LOCAL THIRTEEN AND
A SPORTS FAN THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VERONIQUE A STORE TO
HAVE A SMALL BUSINESS AND I AM I
W. THIRTEEN AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRANDY GOOD
WILLIAMS I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL I AM A COMMUNITY MEMBER.
I AM A MEMBER OF DELTA SIGMA
THETA SORORITY INCORPORATED LONG
BEACH ALUMNAE CHAPTER WHICH HAS
A LARGE IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITY
SURROUNDING THE PORT.
I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF LOCAL
THIRTEEN AS WELL AS A BUSINESS
OWNER VERY GOOD THANK YOU MA'AM
THANK YOU.
HI I'M QUITE OFTEN I'M A LOCAL
THIRTEEN MEMBER.
ARMY VETERAN.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAMERON.
HERE TO REPRESENT AND SECOND I'M
FOR SPORT THANK YOU SIR.
HI AM ANDRIANA BURKE CAMERA
FLOORS I'M REPRESENTED A
REPRESENTING YOUR ANIMAL WISHES
AND FLICK OR GO THE MARK TO SAM
PETER BASED BUSINESSES ALONG
WITH TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY OTHER
BUSINESSES THAT WE HAD
SIGNATURES FOR THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE SUBMITTED I'M NOT
SURE IF YOU GUYS HAVE THEM.
BUT WE DO HAVE THEM -- I ALSO
LIKE TO SOME INFORMATION ABOUT A
BIRD SANCTUARY THAT WILL BE
AFFECTED IF -- ARE POOR IS
AUTOMATED AND ALSO I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT -- THIS AUTOMATION
DOES NOT IMPROVE EFFICIENCY HAS
BEEN PROVEN THAT HUMANS -- WE'VE
ACTUALLY BREAKING OR BROKEN
RECORDS HAVING HUMAN LABOR AND
ALSO I WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND-THAT THE THE STATE TAXES THAT
WILL BE.
TAKEN AWAY FROM US OR FROM YOU
GUYS.
LET'S SAY FIVE HUNDRED JOBS ARE
LOST LITTLE BE NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL TAXES THAT
WILL BE LOST THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE TAXES. THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND
SOCIAL SECURITY AND ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN MEDICARE THANK THANK.
HELLO ONE USERS ARE RISEN I'M A
LONG TIME SOME PEOPLE RESIDENT
BORN RAISED AND I OF IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN WILL MAKE YOU
VERY MUCH.
THE HI MY NAME IS ELENA MORALIS
I'M SUPPORTING THIS BILL -- ON
BEHALF OF LIMITED AND I AM LOCAL
THIRTEEN MEMBER THANK YOU.
HELLO AND THANK YOU MY NAME IS
FRANK TOMATO AND I'M ONE OF MANY
I'M WITH THE CASUAL ALLIANCE AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I GOT THINGS AMERICA.
THANK YOU SIR.
AM I AM -- RICHARD FLORES A
MOMENT AND I REPRESENT ARE
FAMILIES BUSINESSES -- DAVID'S
RADIATORS ARE A GIVES RADIATORS
AND THE RAIDERS ON WHEELS AND
WHERE FOR THIS MOTION VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS ANTHONY LAWYER ON
BEHALF THE EVERYBODY'S IS TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO MICHELLE ECONOMY A
LIFETIME MEMBER OF RESIDENT OF
LOS ANGELES AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL I ALSO REPRESENTS --
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE IN SAN PEDRO
AND THE HARBOR AREA WHO ALSO
STAND IN SUPPORT NOT JUST
RESIDENTS BUT BUSINESSES VERY
GOOD THANK YOU MA'AM.
OKAY A SENIOR OTHERS IN SUPPORT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION BEFORE WE DO I KNOW
AS A MEMBER YOU SPOKE TO YOU
ACTUALLY I THINK WE'RE QUOTING
FROM THAT AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAD
DISCUSSED.
IN YOUR OPENING BUT WE'RE WE'RE
YOU'RE OKAY ACCEPTING THOSE YES
OKAY VERY GOOD -- SO --
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD
SO WE'RE GONNA DO YEAH TWO
MINUTES EACH AND AND THEN WE'LL
TRY TO KEEP IT BRIEF HERE I KNOW
WE'VE GOT A LONG QUEUE SO.
LET'S TRY TO BE RESPECTFUL THAT
THANK YOU BUT PRESHEAF YOUR TIME
SIR WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF OUR HERE THIS
AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF THE
PACIFIC MARITIME ASSOCIATION --
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN
PRINT -- WERE CURRENTLY
REVIEWING -- THE AMENDMENTS SO
YOU KNOW WE MAY REVISIT THAT AS
WE MOVE FORWARD -- PMA AS THE
COUNTERPARTY TO THE AISLE W. YOU --
WE HAVE A CONTRACT IN PLACE THAT
RECOGNIZES THAT AUTOMATION IS
PART OF THE FUTURE AS WE TRY AND
BALANCE -- THE ZERO EMISSION
GOALS OF THE PORT ALONG WITH
STAYING COMPETITIVE IN A VERY --
ROUGH.
A COMPETITIVE MARKET IN THAT --
THE FUTURE EMPLOYMENT OF MISTER
GIBSON'S -- CONSTITUENTS IS OF
AN UTMOST PRIORITY FOR ALL OF US
AND WE ARE ENDEAVORING TO
BALANCE ALL THE COMPETING
INTERESTS SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO TAKE IN THE VOLUME.
OF GOODS -- THROUGH THE LOS
ANGELES LONG BEACH PORTS IN
PARTICULAR WAS A BAY AREA -- BUT
THAT WE BRING IN THE VOLUME TO
SUPPORT THE INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
BEING MADE TO ACHIEVE THOSE --
OFTENTIMES COMPETITIVE GOALS
WITH WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH RESPECT TO THE ENVIRONMENT
AS FAR AS EMPLOYMENT IT'S A
DELICATE BALANCE I KNOW MISTER
GIBSON IS WELL AWARE OF AND WE
APPRECIATE.
HIS WILLINGNESS -- TO BRING THIS
ISSUE FORWARD AND CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IT SO SO THANK YOU TO
ALL AND LIKE I SAID WE'LL BE.
LOOKING AT THIS BUT THIS IS A
LOT MORE DIFFICULT -- THAN ANY
OF US WOULD LIKE IT TO BE.
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSHUA SHOT
FOR THE PACIFIC MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION OUR
COMPANIES ARE THE OCEAN GOING
CARRIERS THE MOVE THE CARGO TO
AND FROM THE PARTS OF LONG BEACH
AND LOS ANGELES AND OAKLAND ALL
UP AND DOWN.
THE WESTERN UNITED STATES WE ARE
THE COMPANIES THAT LEASE THE
SPACE FROM THE PUBLIC PORTS IN
OPERATE THESE MARINE TERMINALS.
AND SIMILAR TO THE PMA WE HAVE
BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH US IN MEMBER GIPSON AND
APPRECIATED SUPPORT -- FOR THE
PORT ACTIVITY IN THE
INTERNATIONAL TRAE THAT YOU
MENTIONED AND AND THE SUPPORT OF
THE MEN AND WOMEN.
WHO LIVE IN AND WORK AT LIVE IN
THE COMMUNITIES AND WORK AT THE
PORTS -- IN THE MEANTIME WE ARE
LIKE PMA OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN
PRINTAND DO APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION THAT YOU JUST
OBTAIN THEIR MISTER CHAIR.
ON THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
WE WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR YOUR
STAFF OF THE US A MEMBER AND HIS
SPONSORS. FOR AGREEING TO TAKE
THOSE A MINUTE CITY BECAUSE
CERTAINLY WE BELIEVE THAT'S
THAT'S A HAVING A DIFFERENT
APPROACH AND WHATIT IS IN THE
BILL IS A GOOD THING AND WE HOPE
IN SOME WAY.
THE PROMULGATION OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS REFLECTS IN SOME SALT
SMALL PART ARGUE THAT HAVING THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION PICKING
CHOOSE WINNERS AND LOSERS AT
THESE PORTS AS BETWEEN DIFFERENT
AUTOMATION PROJECTS MAYBE ONE
HERE MAYBE NOT ONE THERE.
IS NOT A GREAT SIGNAL TO BE
SENDING THE INTERNATIONAL TRADE
COMMUNITY OF COURSE CARGO IS
DISCRETIONARY DOESN'T HAVE TO
COME TO LONG BEACH.
OR LOS ANGELES TO GO TO GEORGIA
OR FLORIDA OR THE EAST COAST --
SO WE APPRECIATE SOMETHING
DIFFERENT -- HAVING SAID THAT
OUR COMPANY IS NOT OUR OUR
ASSOCIATION HAS NOT YET HAD A
CHANCE TO TAKE.
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TODAY TO
OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR
POSITION SO WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU JUST OFFERED MISTER CHAIR.
THAT THE MEMBER TOOK BUT WILL BE --
SEEKING A SOME SORT OF POSITION
AS THE BILL MOVES THROUGH I DO
KNOW THAT -- THERE'S AN EXISTING
STATUTE ON THE BOOKS TO SOME OF
OUR EDUARDO GARCIA -- AB THREE
NINETY EIGHT OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
HAD THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD AND THEIR RESOURCES BOARD
STUDY THE THROUGH THE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION GOALS OF THE STATE
THE IMPACT ON THE WORK FORCE OF
SOME KINDS OF TECHNOLOGY
VERTICALLY AT SEA PORTS.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S ON COMMISSION
ON THE EACH OF WORK IS GOING TO
BE LOOKING AT THE INNOVATION THE
INTRODUCTION OF NEW TECHNOLOGY
AND THE IMPACT ON THE LABOR
FORCE.
ME TIME WE KNOW THAT SINCE THE
CONTRACTED PMA NOTED HAS BEEN IN
FORCE THE LABOR FORCE HAS GROWN
BY 44% AT THESE COURTS WERE TO
PORTS ARE ALREADY AUTOMATED OR
HAVE AUTOMATION THERE.
SO WE'RE NOT SURE WE'RE GOING TO
BE ON THE STUDY BUT WE
APPRECIATE WE'RE NOT PICKING
LOSERS IN THE MEANTIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
VALERIE NARROW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND
PRINT BUT WILL LIKELY REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION WHEN IT COMES INTO
PRINT WITH THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU.
AS CHAIRMAN -- MANY TIAS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL INDUSTRY WHICH INCLUDES
THE TO CLASS. ONE FOR APRIL'S
BNSF YOU AND UNION PACIFIC
RAILROAD.
AS WELL AS A SHORT LINE
RAILROADS WE JUST INTRODUCED ON
OPPOSE LETTER.
WE HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO LOOK AT
THE A MEMBERS WE HAVE WE
APPRECIATE YOU KNOW YOU WORKING.
UP WITH THE AMENDMENTS BUT I CAN.
OPPOSE LETTER.
AND ONE THING TO KEEP IN MIND IS
OUT -- BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
GOODS MOVEMENT -- WHAT TIME A
ONE THIRD OF THE ECONOMY VERY
IMPORTANT OFFICE FOR THE WORLD
WE PLAY A BIG PART IN THAT?
AND THE GOVERNOR WE SPENT ABOUT
THREE YEARS WELL ON WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS FOLKS AND DOING
THE SUSTAINABLE FREE STRATEGY.
WHICH TALKED ABOUT THE
COMPETITIVENESS WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT WE LOOK AT THE ECONOMY.
SO HOPEFULLY CAN GET WORKED UP A
WE ARE CLOSE RIGHT NOW OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
ACTUALLY HAVE A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION SYLVIA SO LEASE
ON BEHALF OF CITY OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI -- THE MAYOR
CURRENTLY HAS A SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED POSITION WE WOULD LIKE A
AN AMENDMENT TO MAINTAIN THE
STATUS AND JURISDICTION OF LOS
ANGELES OVERSTATE THAILAND'S AND
THE SAN PEDRO WILMINGTON AREA.
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
BILL HAS BEEN AMENDED.
WAS TO BE AMENDED TODAY WE WILL
REVIEW THAT AND SEE IF THIS
CHANGES THE POSITION THANK YOU
VERY GOOD THANKS US FOR IT DOES
NOT ADDRESS THE IMMENSE --
THAILAND'S ISSUE THE
JURISDICTIONAL QUESTION -- I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S DIRECTLY
[inaudible]
ADDRESS THEIR ALTHOUGH SECOND
HASN'T CHANGED.
YEAH I'VE WE IT IT'S UNCLEAR THE
BILL ACTUALLY CHANGES THAT
JURISDICTION TO BEGIN WITH SO
BUT LEGISLATORS JUST FINISH THE
OPPOSITION WE CAN GET GET TO
THAT QUESTION SO MANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEING NONE -- DID YOU ASKED
THAT CLEAR I GUESS WHAT I'D LET
US IN I'VE CENTER ALLEN IT ALL
AND SERVE.
AS QUICK QUESTION FOR YOU AND
THEN WE CAN PROCEED HERE YES
CENTER OUR THOUGHT IF YOU IF I
IF I MAY MISS CHAIR SO THE BILL
DOES TAKE THE AUTHORITY AWAY
FROM THE PUBLIC LANDS COMMISSION
AND IT DOES NOT -- GIVE THAT
AUTHORITY TO THE LOCAL HOWEVER
COMMISSION SO THAT'S NOT AND
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
OUR IT'S A THE THE THE BUT THE
ISSUE HAS BEEN RAISED BY THE
CITY HAS TO DO WITH.
WITH LANDOWNERSHIP ASSOCIATED
WITH THE WETLANDS AT THE HARBOR
IS THAT IS THAT THE IS THAT WHAT
I'M HEARING.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT --
AND THE CITY OF LA COULD JUMP.
SPEAK BUT THEY WOULD SUPPORT THE
BILL IF IT WOULD BE AMENDED TO
HAVE INSTEAD OF THE PUB PUBLIC
LANDS COMMISSION.
THE LOCAL HARBOR COMMISSION MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS BUT AGAIN THAT'S
NOT ADDRESS AND AMENDMENTS.
AND GIVEN THAT -- IF YOU IF YOU
READ IF YOU GO YOU KNOW.
ARE YOU WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
CITY TO MAKE SURE THIS GETS
ADDRESS [inaudible]
OKAY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MEN'S DEAL
WITH THAT SECTION -- TWO IN THIS
THIS THE NEW COMMISSION ANALYSIS
WITH KOBE IS I THINK IT SHOULD
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES --
A SOME OF THE OTER ISSUES
RAISED BUT YEAH THE WE DID NOT
INTERPRET THE LANGUAGE CURRENTLY.
TO ASSERT ANY NEW JURISDICTION.
OVER THAT.
CONCERN RAISED -- OKAY -- SEEING
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE MEMBERS BOB I'M SAM
I'LL BE WILLING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL MOVE THE BILL I'M WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU'LL BE
WORKING WITH THE CITY JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT ISSUES ADDRESS I
I'D.
APPRECIATE IT AS YOU'VE TAKEN
AND SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE YOU'RE
WELL ON YOUR WAY HERE.
OKAY SO YEAH SO THAT'S A MOTION --
DID YOU WANT TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES IN YOUR CLOTHES SURE --
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR I
DO WANT TO GO ON RECORD THAT I
HAVE A LETTER OF SUPPORT.
FROM THE MAYOR OF LONG BEACH --
MAYOR ROBERT GARCIA IN SUPPORT
OF THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE AS WELL
AND SO -- LISTEN WE WANT TO WE
WANT TO WORK WITH.
EVERYONE THOSE WHO REYES OF
OPPOSITION SO WE WANT TO WORK
WITH THEM WE MET WITH THEM AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
WITH THE SOME CONCERNS -- AS
BEST AS WE CAN MOVING FORWARD --
SO YOU DO HAVE MY COMMITMENT
WORK WITH THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES TO TRY TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THEIR CONCERNS I THINK THE
MINUTES WILL IN FACT ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS I UNDERSTAND THAT
PEOPLE.
ARE JUST NOW GETTING SOME OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS BUT IT'S A IT'S
IT'S OUR MAIN THRUST IN OUR MAIN
PURPOSE IS MAKING SURE.
THAT WE DON'T DO ANYTHING IS
GOING TO DISPLACE INDIVIDUALS AT
THE PORT ON THESE INDIVIDUALS --
RELY ON THEIR JOBS IS LIKE MOST
KICK EM EVERYBODY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- I REPRESENT AS I
INDICATED SIX POURS DISH TO
CONSIDER CALIFORNIA -- WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR PORT IS
HEALTHY AND MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING EACH AND
EVERY DAY CONTINUE TO HAVE A
PLACE TO GO AND WORK PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES EACH AND EVERY
DAY.
AND SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE.
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLOSE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CENTER STERN BY
STERN.
JONES ALAN.
ELLEN I BURGESS CABALLERO.
CAREER AYE HERTZBERG HUESO
JACKSON MONEY IN THE BILL'S ON
CALL WITH THREE VOTE OKAY WE'LL
LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH -- I MEAN I FAVOR
YOU'RE RESPECTED YOUR ATTENTION
FOCUSED -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
YOUR PATIENCE IS APPRECIATED --
CHAIRMAN ALAN PROXY CHAIRMAN --
THING TO MEASURES AND YES MISTER
CHAIR IF I MAY HIDE LET US JUST
GET JUMP INTO IT LET'S GO FOR IT
YET THANK YOU SO MUCH AB
FOURTEEN FORTY UPDATES LAWS.
THAT WERE IN -- IN ACTED BACK IN
THE NINETEEN THIRTIES GOVERNING
OUR OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION WE
NOW WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN PRIORITIZE.
PROPERLY -- PRIMARY
CONSIDERATION GIVEN TO THE
ENVIRONMENT AND PUBLIC HEALTH
WHILE MAKING OIL WELL PER MANY
DECISIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION.
OKAY -- OTHER FOLKS WANT TO
RAISE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
OPPOSITION.
YEAH CONCERNS [inaudible]
YES.
SHE STUCK TRYING.
TO NON AUTOMATED TRAFFIC
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MELISSA ROMERO CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU ANYONE WANTS
TO RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
OPPOSITION OKAY.
I SEE NOTHING MATTERS FOR THE
KEY QUESTIONS FOR THE MEMBERS.
ONE EIGHTEEN EMOTION.
OKAY.
LOOKING TO SEE IF ANYBODY ELSE
WE'VE GOT WE'VE GOT VICTORIA
ROOM FROM ENERGY SHE WANTS.
TO ADD ON SUPPORT.
WE'RE YEAH WE'RE GET YOU TO KEEP.
I GET AFTERNOON VICTORIA WRONG
WITH NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL -- THIS FALL BUT THIS
BILL JUST UPDATE.
AND REVISES DOCKERS MISSION
STATEMENT AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU AND I'M REALLY
HONORED AND PROUD TO BE WORKING
WITH AN RTC HONEST THANK YOU.
OKAY -- TO MOVE BY SENATOR
CAFIERO YOU MAY CLOSE OUR STUFF
LAST NIGHT VOTE IT'S ABOUT TIME
WE PRIORITIZE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENT ON OIL PERMITTING
DECISIONS.
WITH WHAT WITH.
PRIORITIZE PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT ON OIL WELL
PERMITTING DECISIONS ON BY DAGR.
HOPE HOPE THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN A
CORE PRINCIPLE LEAST RECENTLY.
IT IT WAS NEVER PART OF THE LAWN
AND THIS BILL WILL MAKE IT PART
OF THE LAW AFTER SHE DIED A
SECURE BECAUSE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS A APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS
STERN.
JONES ALLEN HI ELLEN I'D FORGES
CABALLERO CAREER AYE HERTZBERG
HUESO JACKSON MONEY IN THE
BILL'S ON CALL WITH TWO ROWS.
OKAY THANKS UNIX BILL US SAID
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
I THINK YOU AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN I'M SURE THIS IS THE
UMPTEENTH TIME THAT CENTER
GLAZER AND I HAVE ATTEMPTED --
TO BAN SMOKING AT OUR PARKS IN
OUR BEACHES WE TRY TO PROTECT
OUR OUR NATURAL ENVIRONMENT AS
BEST WE CAN WE ALSO TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO IT BUT
WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO DO.
IT'S POISON IT -- OR OR LETTER
UPON IT AND THIS BILL WILL --
BAND NOT FROM OUR BEACHES IN OUR
PARKS ALLOW PEOPLE TO ENJOY
NATURE WITHOUT.
SECONDHAND SMOKE WITHOUT THE
TOXINS REACHING INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT AND AFFECTING
WILDLIFE AND AND IT'S TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO EVER.
YES.
I YES I SHORT TESTIMONY -- MY
NAME IS ROBERT HANSSEN WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT PRIMARILY AS A
MEANS TO REDUCE -- THE POLLUTION
THAT COMES FROM TOBACCO --
PRODUCTS -- WE HAVE AN
INCREASINGLY SMALLER AND SMALLER
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS WHO SMOKE
TOBACCO PRODUCTS AND YET
EVERYONE OF US STILL HAS TO SEE
AND FEEL THE EFFECTS OF THE
POLLUTION AND GENERATES.
THROUGHOUT BUT SOME FILTERS ARE
MOST COMMONLY FOUND DURING BEACH
AND WATER WAY CLEANUPS COMPANY
RANKING IN THE TOP TEN MOST
POLLUTED ITEMS -- DATA FROM THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN INTERNATIONAL
COASTAL CLEANUP REVEALED THAT
CIGARETTE BUT FOR THE MOST
COMMONLY FOUND ITEM IN
CALIFORNIA BEACH AS THE
CIGARETTE **** DO NOT ONLY POSE
CHOKING HAZARD TO WILDLIFE.
THAT MISTAKE THE LETTER FOR FOOD
THE TOXINS AT LEAST FROM THESE
FILTERS ARE KNOWN TO COLLECT
CARCINOGENS AND PESTICIDES --
THAT CAN ALSO HAVE DETRIMENTAL
WATER QUALITY -- AND HUMAN
HEALTH CONCERNS.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN THE STATE
HAVE STEADILY ADOPTED ORDINANCES
TO PROHIBIT SMOKING IN LOCAL
PARKS AND BEACHES.
AND EARLIER THIS YEAR WE SAW --
THE FIRST LOCAL ORDINANCE WHICH
COMPLETELY BANNED THE SALE OF
CIGARETTES ALTOGETHER THIS IS A
PREVALENT ISSUE FOR CALIFORNIANS
AND THIS MEASURE WOULD BRING THE
ENTIRE STATE UNDER UNIFIED
POLICY -- THAT WOULD -- THAT
WOULD PROTECT OUR PARKS BEACHES
AND WATERS FROM THIS POLLUTION.
OKAY THANK YOU FOLKS ONE ADDED
SUPPORT ELIZABETH HAS BEEN US ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
SUPPORT.
CARE TO SOMEONE BEHALF OF HEAL
THE BAY IN THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOVING COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ON A TOMLINSON NO BUT CENTER
BEACH ISLAND AND SUPPORT.
NOT THE NOT THE WRONG KIND OF
BASS.
OKAY -- ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO
VOICE SUPPORT OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL CONCERNS.
OKAY -- THE MATTERS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS THOUGHTS.
THIS TO MOVE BY A CENTER
CABALLERO -- YOU MAY CLOSE THAT
REALLY PART OF THE THE AMAZING
COALITION OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
BEHIND THIS HAVE BEEN BEHIND
THIS FOR MANY YEARS AND OTHER
PATIENTS OF THIS LEGISLATURE TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON IT.
AS WELL THANK YOU ARE SO CLASS
FOR EITHER.
OKAY CENTERPIECE KALRA MOTIONS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS STERN JONES ALLEN HI
ELLEN AYE FORGES CABALLERO
CARILLO AYE HERTZBERG HUESO
JACKSON MONEY THE BILLS ON CALL
WITH TO VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATORS.
THAT'S WHAT THE DRIVE HOME.
OKAY -- WELL NEXT YEAR FROM A
SIMILAR BLOOM BACK FOR MORE
PUNISHMENT.
I KNOW IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU SO
WHENEVER YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT
THE B. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT I
BELIEVE.
I AM AND YOU MAY PROCEED ONE
RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
I WHICH THANK YOU MEMBERS.
AND TO MR SUBSTITUTE CHAIR.
WHEN INGESTED ANTI COAGULANT
RODENTICIDE BECAUSE ANIMALS TO
BLEED OUT INTERNALLY AND?
THIS DISRUPTS THEIR IMMUNE
SYSTEMS NATURAL ABILITY TO FIGHT
OFF INFECTIONS AND THE FUNCTIONS
SUCH AS MANGE.
AND THEY FREQUENTLY PERSONS A
RESULT.
RECENT STUDIES ON WILDLIFE IN
THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS HAVE
SHOWN THAT TWENTY ONE OUT OF
TWENTY TWO MOUNTAIN LIONS.
TESTED POSITIVE FOR EXPOSURE AND
FOUR HAVE DIED JUST THAT'S AN
UNACCEPTABLE MORTALITY RATE TO
REALLY AND THE MORTALITY RATE
FOR THESE MAGNIFICENT CREATURES
THAT ARE.
IN SHORT SUPPLY CERTAINLY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA -- IS IS TOO
MUCH. NINETY THREE OF A HUNDRED
AND FIVE BOBCATS TESTED POSITIVE
FOR EXPOSURE AND SEVENTY OR MORE
HAVE DIED FROM RELATED SECONDARY
DISEASES FINALLY -- TWENTY THREE
OF TWENTY SEVEN COYOTES TESTED
POSITIVE FOR EXPOSURE AND TWELVE
OF DIED FROM POISONING ANOTHER
STUDY REGARDING THE ENDANGERED
PACIFIC FISHER.
HAS SHOWN THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS
AND THREATS THAT ROAD GENOCIDE
POSE AND ITS CONTRIBUTION TO
THAT SPECIES NEAR EXTINCTION.
JUST LAST MONTH.
IN JUNE A NEW STUDY CAME OUT ON
THE ENDANGERED SAN JOAQUIN KIT
FOX POPULATION.
THE STUDY HAS FOUND THAT ROAD
GENOCIDE EXPOSURE COMBINED WITH
LAND DEVELOPMENT ARE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTING THAT POPULATION.
AND THIS IS IN THE NEW ISSUE AND
FAX SINCE THE LATE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE BEEN WARNING ABOUT
THE IMPACTS THAT RODENTICIDE.
ARE HAVING ON ALL WILDLIFE IN
OUR STATE.
AS A RESULT OF THESE WARNINGS IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN THAT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION ENACTED REGULATIONS
TO RESTRICT THE SECOND THE USE
OF SECOND GENERATION.
ANTI COAGULANT PRESIDENTE SIDES.
IN THE HOPES OF DECREASING THE
NON TARGETED DEATHS.
BUT THESE REGULATIONS HAVE NOT
RESULTED IN A DECREASE IN
SECONDARY WILDLIFE POISONINGS
INSTEAD LEVELS OF STATE CONSTANT
OR INCREASE IN SOME INSTANCES.
IN DPR WANTS US TO WAIT FOR A
SECOND REVIEW -- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NO
TIMELINE OR END DATE FOR THAT
REVIEW.
AND THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
OUR WILDLIFE REALLY CAN'T WAIT
ANY LONGER THERE'S TOO MUCH
PRESSURE ON THESE POPULATIONS IN.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
PROHIBITS THE USE THEREFORE OF
SECOND GENERATION ANTI COAGULANT
RODENTICIDE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND ALSO
PROHIBITS THE USE OF FIRST
GENERATION ANTICOAGULANTS ON
STATE OWNED PROPERTY WITH
EXEMPTIONS FOR AGRICULTURAL AND
FOOD PROCESSING USES.
NEW ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE
AND MORE HUMANE MENS OF
CONTROLLING RODENT POPULATIONS
ARE INCREASINGLY BEING
SUCCESSFULLY USED BY THE PEST
MANAGEMENT INDUSTRY.
INCLUDING ACCORDING TO THE
OPPOSITION A NEW AND TACKLE
COAGULANT RODENTICIDE THAT.
DOESN'T TO PERSIST AND THE
TARGETED AND AFTER THE TARGETED
A MAN ANIMAL HAS INGESTED THEM.
I AM HAPPY TO SAY THAT WE'VE
REACHED AN AGREEMENT ON
AMENDMENTS WITH A FOLKS IN THE
LIFE SCIENCES INDUSTRY AND WILL
BE TAKING THOSE AND
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND WE ARE STILL WORKING WITH
OTHER OPPOSITION.
A TODAY WITH ME OUR LINDSAY
LETTERS WITH THE ANIMAL LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND AND LISA OWENS
VIANI WITH RAPTORS ARE THE
SOLUTION.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AS
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TWO MINUTES
EACH PLEASE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON -- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY.
MY NAME IS TIFFANY HAPPENED I'M
A SCIENTIST AT THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY.
I RECENTLY CO AUTHORED A
PETITION TO LIST SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND CENTRAL COAST
MOUNTAIN LIONS.
AS THREATENED UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA ENDANGERED SPECIES
ACT BECAUSE MANY OF THE THREATS
THAT BECAUSE OF THE MANY.
THREATS THEY FACE INCLUDING
RODENTICIDE POISONING.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION REPORTED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT 92% OF TESTED
MOUNTAIN LIONS.
HAD DETECTABLE LEVELS OF ANTI
COAGULANT RODENTICIDE IN THEIR
BLOOD.
SUCH POISONING CAN LEAD TO
DIRECT DEATH WEAKENED IMMUNE
SYSTEMS OR VULNERABILITY TO
OTHER PREDATORS AND CONSPECIFICS.
EARLIER THIS YEAR A YOUNG MALE
OUTLINED IN THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS WAS FOUND DEAD HE HAD
SIX DIFFERENT ANTI COAGULANT
RHODA DECIDES IN HIS BLOOD.
AND INTERNAL HEMORRHAGING IS HAD
AMONG.
HIS FATHER WAS FROM OUTSIDE OF
THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS AND
HIS EARLY DEATH IS A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE THE
GENETIC DIVERSITY OF THIS
DWINDLING POPULATION.
EXPERTS PREDICT THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS MOUNTAINS MOUNTAIN
LION POPULATION SHOULD COULD GO
EXTINCT WITHIN FIFTY YEARS OR
LESS IF NO IMPROVEMENTS ARE MADE.
TO REDUCE ANTHROPOGENIC
PRESSURES.
WE'VE SEEN SECONDARY POISONING
FROM ANTI COAGULANT RHODA
DECIDES ANOTHER CALIFORNIA
PREDATORS SUCH AS BOBCATS
COYOTES CALIFORNIA FISHER'S SAN
JOAQUIN KIT FOXES AND NUMEROUS
RAPTOR.
LOCAL EXTINCTIONS OF BOBCATS DUE
TO MANGE A PARASITIC SKIN
DISEASE IN CARNIVORES LINKED
WITH RODENTICIDE POISONING HAVE
BEEN DOCUMENTED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
ELIMINATION OF THESE IMPORTANT
PREDATORS COULD HAVE CASCADING
CONSEQUENCES ON THE BIO
DIVERSITY AND HEALTH OF OUR
ECOSYSTEMS.
IMMEDIATE ACTION IS NEEDED AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD BE
A LIFE SAVING MEASURE FROM
OUTLINES AND MANY OTHER
PREDATORS BECAUSE IT TARGETS THE
MOST DANGEROUS RODENTICIDE CIVIL
PROVIDING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY EXEMPTIONS AS NEEDED.
I URGE YOU TO PASS AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S BY A DIVERSITY AND
FACILITATE ARE SAFE CO EXISTENCE
WITH WILDLIFE THANK YOU.
THE VERY MUCH -- SECOND WITNESS
IN SUPPORT.
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON A COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS LYNN DEALERS IN HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE ANIMAL LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND -- ONE OF THE%
BILL'S SPONSORS OF SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT WE HAVE MORE THAN
THIRTY THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA -- AND WE'RE ALL IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AB SEVENTY EIGHT
THE CALIFORNIA ECOSYSTEMS
PROTECTION ACT.
AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM -- TIFFANY
OUT CALIFORNIA'S ECOSYSTEMS
INCLUDING THE STATE'S ICONIC
WILDLIFE HAVE BEEN UNDER SIEGE
FOR YEARS MUSING THESE ANTI
COAGULANT AND DECIDES THERE'S NO
DOUBT THE POISON OF THE WHILE IF
THE PROBLEM IS SUPPORTED BY
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE.
IT'S CLEAR THE ACTIONS TAKEN BY
DPR IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WHILE
WELL INTENTIONED DID NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
ECOSYSTEMS AND WE MUST DO
SOMETHING NOW.
IN ORDER TO PREVENT THE CONTINUE
DEGRADATION OF THE SYSTEMS ARE
THREATS THE STATE'S CHILDREN AND
DOMESTIC ANIMALS.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT IS THE
NEXT LOGICAL STEP.
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE
SCIENCE TODAY -- TO SEE POINTS
OF CLARIFICATION ONE IS THAT
THERE IS AN EXEMPTION AVAILABLE
UNDER AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
FOR USE OF SCARS.
SECOND GENERATION AS I COULD I
GET RID AND DECIDES IN CASES OF
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES.
KERR'S BEEN MADE -- TO ENSURE
THE LEAST PERSON PROCESS FOR
APPROVAL OF THESE PRODUCTS IS IS
THERE IT'S AVAILABLE THE BILL
I'M IT'S PROVIDED FOR UNDER
FEDERAL LAW.
AND IN ADDITION TO THE SCIENCE
THAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT.
I JUST WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT THERE IS THIS
GROUNDSWELL PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL.
AS THE COMMITTEE IS NO DOUBT
SEEN THERE IS OVER FORTY LETTERS
FROM ORGANIZATIONS AND OVER FIVE
HUNDRED INDIVIDUAL SUBMITTED
LETTERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
IN THE PAST SIX YEARS TWENTY
NINE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
ENACTED RESOLUTIONS DISCOURAGING
TO CELEBRATE AND DECIDES BY
LOCAL BUSINESSES AND THE USED BY
RESIDENCES THIS IS ACROSS THE
STATE -- FROM JURISDICTIONS FROM
MALIBU TO HUMBOLDT.
TUMBLE COUNTY TO SANTA CRUZ AND
ALL THESE JURISDICTIONS
CONCERNED CITIZENS AND THE
GOVERNMENT ARE DOING ALL THEY
CAN TO LESSEN THE USE OF THESE
POISONS.
BUT AS YOU KNOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS CANNOT ACT
ANYTHING BEYOND RESOLUTIONS AS
THE STATE'S JOB TO REGULATE
POISONS AND BY THE GROUND SWELL
THIS SUPPORT -- FROM ACTIVISTS
FROM ORGANIZATIONS FROM COUNCIL
MEMBERS AND CITY GOVERNMENTS --
AND ALSO OPEN SPACE DISTRICTS
THE LESS POISONS IN THE
ENVIRONMENT IS THE WILL OF
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE.
CALIFORNIA'S NOW THIS UNIQUE
POSITION TO ENACT THE SORT OF
LEGISLATION THAT THE REST THE
COUNTRY'S GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
AS A MODEL -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THIS COMMITTEE FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELIZABETH HAS
BEEN -- SOME BEHALF OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
THEN KALLINS MOUNTAIN LION
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
SAYS THE MAN NOT LIKE HAS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF WILDER
GUARDIANS IN SUPPORT.
KATIE MAPLE ON BEHALF OF SOCIAL
COMPASSIONATE LEGISLATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THE FEAR OF A CO THE PLANNING
CONSERVATION THEY CAN SUPPORT
BECAUSE THIS BILL WILL PROTECT
MOUNTAIN LINES AND OTHER
WILDLIFE FIRMER THAN SIDE
POISONING.
PERSONAL COULD US HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS AND
SUPPORT.
JEAN TRAP BY WILDLIFE ECOLOGIST.
FOR THIS FIRST SUPPORT.
THIS IS LIKE BLANKET BOMBING.
OUR WILDLIFE AND OUR ECOSYSTEMS
USING THESE PESTICIDES.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
PORTANTINO BEHALF OF MADNESS Là
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
SAMANTHA HARDY ON BEHALF OF THE
HUMANE SOCIETY THE UNITED STATES
AND SUPPORT.
CHRIS WHEN A VOLUNTEER WITH THE
US AT THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE
UNITED STATES IN SUPPORT.
VICTORIA ROME WITHIN OUR DC IN
SUPPORT.
ERIN HOAGIE ON BEHALF OF PROJECT
COMMUNITY CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY AND HUMANE SOCIETY OF
THE UNITED STATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FUNDED TOMLINSON PROJECT
CAPABILITY IN CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
FOR WILDLIFE REHABILITATED ISN'T
STRONG SUPPORT THANKS.
THE MIDDLE FOURTH CAL SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA.
REPRESENTING IN DEFENSE OF
ANIMALS SO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JANET MCCARTY FULL SOME
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEER FOR YOU
MEAN CITING KNIGHTED STATUS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE PAPER ACROSS ALL SENIOR
DISTRICT LEADER HSUS STRONG
SUPPORT.
JENNIFER KENNEDY AGENTS US AND
STRONG SUPPORT FROM EL DORADO
COUNTY THANK YOU.
HI THERE LOW INCOME ROSA WITH
RAPTORS ARE THE SOLUTION AND
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LOVE JANET KAROSA AND I AM HERE
REPRESENTING.
RAPTOR AS A SOLUTION AND PROJECT
COYOTE IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
LISA OWNS THE ANY RAFTERS ARE
THE SOLUTION SUPPORT.
AARON MILLER L. WITH PAST MASTER
SERVICES -- PRIVATE BEST
MANAGEMENT COMPANY IN SUPPORT.
RAINY BI XENON LISTENERS TECH IN
SUPPORT.
DR LORETTA MAYOR BIOLOGY
ENDOCRINOLOGIST.
I AM IN SUPPORT NOT ONLY FOR THE
WILDLIFE BUT FOR THE CHALLENGE
THESE OF SCARS PRESENT TO
ACCELERATING RESISTANCE. TO
RODENTICIDE.
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY AND
PLANET THANK YOU.
DR CHERYL DIRE -- WE'VE INVENTED
AT SEMESTER A CONTRACEPTIVE FOR
RATS SO I'M VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF REDUCING THE USE OF POISONS.
JO ELLAN RYAN FOR THE HOLLOW
AUDUBON SOCIETY IT'S FOR SUPPORT
BY ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
OF BILL ALLEY OF THANK YOU.
DOMINIC INDUSTRY IN SUPPORT OF
THE COME ON MAN COME ON ACTUALLY
THAT'S ISSUE I DO WANT TO SPEAK
WITH.
OKAY HIRING MERION SO DONE WE
WOULD LOVE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING OUR TAILS
OFF TO TRY AND DO IT MY NAME.
IS DOMINIC TOMORROW I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA THE
REST OF THE PASTORAL PROPERTIES
IN CALIFORNIA IT'S BEEN A LONG
DAY I APOLOGIZE -- I'LL BE
DIRECTED TO THE POINT -- WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL WE POSE THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT HAS SEVERAL.
PUBLIC POLICY INTERESTS TO HAVE
NOT BEEN RECONCILED BY US
DESPITE OUR BEST EFFORTS TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
AND SPONSORS.
WE HAVE SUBMITTED AND PROPOSES
TO HIM THAT WE BELIEVE WOULD BE
WAR EFFECTIVE IN TERMS OF
CONTROLLING.
THE AVAILABILITY OF THESE
MATERIALS TO WILDLIFE
POPULATIONS AND IN FACT LOOKING
AT THE BILL WE FEEL THAT THE
BILL WORKS THAT WHAT WE HAVE
PROPOSED WOULD BE BETTER THAN
WHAT'S IN THE BILL NOW.
WHAT'S IN THE BILL NOW IS
BASICALLY.
A PROHIBITION WITH A HUGE
EXEMPTION AND THAT EXEMPTION IS
FOR AGRICULTURAL USE THAT
EXEMPTION IS FOR FOOD PROCESSING
THAT EXCEPTIONS FOR BEER AND
WINE.
THESE ARE MANUFACTURING AND
INDUSTRIAL AREAS IN AGRICULTURAL
AREAS THAT ARE THE MOST
PROXIMATE TO WILDLIFE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHERE YOU WERE BANNING THE USE
OF THESE MATERIALS IS MOSTLY IN
URBAN SETTINGS WHERE YOU DO NOT
FIND WILDLIFE?
AND YOU ARE CREATING A PUBLIC
HEALTH PROBLEM BY DOING SO WHEN
MY CLIENTS USE AS CARS THEY
DON'T.
RUN TO A SECOND GENERATION
COAGULANT SAY -- WE'VE GOT RATS
WE JUST THROUGHOUT THAT SCARS
THERE IS A A PROTOCOL IN A I PM
PROCESS INVOLVED IT STARTS WITH
SANITATION WHAT IS THE
ENVIRONMENT LOOK LIKE IS IT
CONDUCIVE TO RATS IS A CONDUCIVE.
TO HAVING FORAGE FOR RATS TO
FEED ON TO THAT AREA TRACKS THEM
SECOND.
EXCLUSION HOW DO I KEEP RATS OUT
OF A PARTICULAR BUILDING BE AN
APARTMENT BUILDING A WAREHOUSE A
BIOTECH FACILITY WHAT HAVE YOU.
THIRD IF THOSE TWO ISSUES DON'T
WORK WHAT CAN WE DO TO DRAW RATS
AWAY SO WHEN YOU PUT A BAY BOX
OUT YOU'RE NOT JUST SAYING I'M
OF FOR A BIT BOX DOWN BY THE
BUILDING BECAUSE THAT'S WHEN THE
RATS ARE.
YOU WANT THOSE RATS AWAY FROM
THE TARGETBUILDING SO YOU THROW
BAY BOXES.
OUT PASSED THE WARNER THE DEN
WHERE THE RATS ARE IN ORDER TO
DRAW THEM AWAY FROM THE TARGET
PROPERTY THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
S. CARS ARE ONE PIECE OF A
LARGER PROCESS AT A LARGER
PROGRAM.
IN TERMS OF I PM IN TO DO WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD TO ELIMINATE
THEIR USE WITH THESE FAST
EXEMPTIONS.
MOVES AS CARS IN ALLOWS THEIR
USE IN PLACES WHERE THE
VULNERABLE WILDLIFE POPULATION
YOU WANT TO PROTECT.
LIVES AND TAKES IT FROM THE
PLACE WHERE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY IS OUR MOST CRITICAL NEED
IN URBAN AREAS AND SO WILL THE
MOMENT SO WE HAVE SHARED WITH MR
BLOOM AND HIS STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
JUST QUICKLY AND I WILL FINISH
CREATE.
A PROCESS THAT ONE HAS A FUNDING.
ENFORCEMENT AND THAT FUNDING
WOULD COME FROM.
THE INDUSTRY.
IF YOU'RE A PCO IN SIXTY TO
CALIFORNIA AND YOU WANT TO USE
THIS CAR IN A BIG BOX HE WOULD
BUY A STICKER YOU'D PAY A FEE
FOR THAT STICKER THAT FEE WOULD
THEN BE PERMITTED TO DPR IN
ORDER TO HELP THEM FORSMAN.
AND IN THAT STICKER WOULD HAVE
ANA CONDITIONS FOR THE USE AND
THE TYPE OF USE OF THAT ASKAR HE
WITH LIMITED TO FOUR OUNCES FOR
INSTANCE IT WOULD LIMITED. TO
THIRTY DAYS OR TEN DAYS HE WOULD
HAVE CLEAR RESTRICTIONS ON THE
USE OF THOSE MATERIALS.
IN THE APPLICATION AND THE
CONTROL OF COMMENSAL RODENTS.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A OF A
BETTER WAY TO CONTROL THE ACCESS
OF THESE MATERIALS TO WILDLIFE
POPULATIONS.
I THINK WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
THE AUTHORINTO THE PROPONENTS
THAT THE BILL WORKS COUNTER TO
THE INTENT IF YOUR INTENT IS TO
KEEP THESE MATERIALS.
AWAY FROM WILDLIFE POPULATIONS.
THIS BILL IS AN ACCOMPLISHED
THAT YOU HAVE A TON OF ILLEGAL
USE GOING ON IN IT.
MARIJUANA GROWS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE YOU HAVE THE TAIL LEFTOVER
FROM CONSUMER AVAILABILITY AND
YOU CAN STILL BUY THESE
MATERIALS OVER THE INTERNET.
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING FOR
ENFORCEMENT OUR AMENDMENTS WOULD
CREATE FUNDING STREAM AND IN A
FOUR SEN MECHANISM FOR THESE
MATERIALS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AUTHOR
AGAIN AND THE SPONSORS TO
CONSIDER THESE AMENDMENTS TO SIT
DOWN AT THE TABLE WITH US AND
TALK WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH.
IN WORK THROUGH THIS BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT ONE WE WANTTO BE
HELPFUL WE'RE NOT RUNNING AWAY
FROM THE PROBLEM WE'VE NEVER RUN
AWAY FROM THIS PROBLEM.
AND W WOULD LIKE TO BE HELPFUL
BUT WE HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THAT.
YOU HAVE RECENT CONVERSATIONS IN
THE LAST FORTY EIGHT HOURS WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE THAT SEEM
PROMISING.
BUT I'VE HAD THESE CONVERSATIONS
BEFORE SIR WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
PLEASE ALLOW US TO HELP YOU.
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
THESE MATERIALS ARE LESS
AVAILABLE TO WILDLIFE WHILE
MAINTAINING THEIR AVAILABILITY
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY.
AND THE PUBLIC SEE THE HEALTH
EXEMPTION AND THIS DOESN'T WORK
IT'S A FEDERAL LAW THAT DEALS
WITH.
THE USE OF MATERIALS OFF LABEL
FOR INVASIVE SPECIES HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH BEING ABLE TO USE
THESE FOR COMMENSAL RODENTS AND
SO IT'S IT.
BOKI.
AN ARTFUL EXEMPTION FOR A REAL
PROBLEM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR THOSE REASONS AND OTHERS WE
REMAIN OPPOSED AND LIKE I SAID
AT THE BEGINNING WE WOULD LOVE
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
IN UNDER THE RIGHT CIRCUMSTANCES
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES EXIST AND THAT
THOSE AMENDMENTS EXISTING IF WE
WOULD JUST HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO SIT DOWN AND BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT THIS WE'D BE ABLE TO GET A
MAN.
JEFF FISHER THAT -- OTHER FOLKS
ONE AND SPEAKING OPPOSITION.
YOU GO TO THE MICROPHONE.
SORRY SIR RICHARD WOULD
APPRECIATE SOMEONE WHO.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALL OF IRAQ
FOR A CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF REPRESENTING THE
LIFE SCIENCES BIOTECH INDUSTRY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
INCLUDES -- BY PHARMACEUTICAL
MANUFACTURING MEDICAL DEVICE
MANUFACTURERS ACADEMIC AND
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS IN THE
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZE START UPS.
IT'S AN INDUSTRY THAT EMPLOYS
ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS AND CONTRIBUTE TO
SIGNIFICANT -- ECONOMIC BENEFIT
TO THE STATE OUR POSITION IS IN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED WE'VE
ASKED THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
FOR A SIMILAR EXEMPTION -- TO
THE THREE THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE BILL TODAY IT WOULD EXCLUDE
OUR FACILITIES THAT ARE -- BY
NATURE AND DESIGN -- NEED TO BE
STERILE ENVIRONMENTS THE
REGULATED BY THE FDA INSPECTED
BY THE FDA OR THE EUROPEAN
JAPANESE OR ANY OTHER COUNTRY.
EQUIVALENTS OF THE FDA -- I
THINK WE'RE VERY CLOSE. TO
FINDING SOME LANGUAGE -- NEW IN
CONCEPT WE TALKED -- NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE COUPLE WEEKS
AGO -- ABOUT AN EXEMPTION FOR
THOSE FACILITIES -- SO I AM
HOPEFUL THAT BETWEEN NOW AND THE
NEXT COMMITTEE WILL HAVE THAT
LANGUAGE NOT ONLY LETS COUNCIL
FORMAT BUT HOPEFULLY AMENDED
INTO THE BILL -- ONE THING I DO
WANT TO NOTE EVEN THE EPA
BUILDING WHO.
THAT WAS UNFORTUNATELY FESTIVE
IRAQ'S NOT LONG AGO -- IN THEIR
STATEMENT WHEN THEY SAID THAT
THEY LEARNED OF A RAP PROBLEM IN
OUR BUILDINGS EXTERIOR COURTYARD
IN CHILD CARE CENTER PLAY YARD.
WE TOOK ACTION WITH NON TOXIC
PEST MANAGEMENT MEASURES WHEN
THOSE MEASURES DID NOT SOLVE THE
PROBLEM WE CONSULTED EXPERTS TO
DETERMINE THE PROTECTING
CHILDREN FROM RODENT BORNE
DISEASES.
REQUIRED THE ADDITIONAL STEP OF
APPLYING A RODENTICIDE WITH
STRICT SAFETY PROCEDURES WE
WOULD AGREE -- IT THE
MANUFACTURE MEDICINES REQUIRES
THE SAME.
SORT OF PROTECTION -- SO. FOR
THAT REASON WE'RE STILL ASKING
FOR AN EXEMPTION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY OTHER FOLKS ONE
OUT IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON NICOLE CAN YEARS
ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
ALSO OPPOSED.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE LYNCH
REPRESENTING ANIMAL PEST
MANAGEMENT SERVICES SERVING THE
URBAN AREA OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
RAINY PARKING HAVE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON LARA KNOWING HE
CHECK ON BEHALF OF WESTERN PLAN
HEALTH ASSOCIATION AND RISE IN
OPPOSITION.
WITH THE WATER MALLORY SPOKE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA.
AN ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
VALERIE NARROW THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON TOM SHE HERE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU.
AND IF NEW MEMBERS TO ACT ON
BEHALF OF SYNGENTA WERE OPPOSED.
ACTUALLY FRIEDMAN UNIVERSALLY
SHINS I'M A VECTOR BIOLOGIST AND
I DO OPPOSE THIS BILL IN ITS
PRESENT FORM THANK YOU.
DENNIS MICHAEL BELL LABORATORIES
CALL CALIFORNIA OPPOSED.
CAN.
GRAY GRANTEE.
CONCERNED FATHER AND GRANDFATHER
AND AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL AS IS
[inaudible]
WHAT PRODUCTS?
OKAY -- THE ITEM IS NOW BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
DISCUSSION -- YOU CAN JUST
AUTHORED COULD COULD YOU GIVE
VOTE TO GIVE ME A SENSE OF THE
INVOLVING DISCUSSION WITH THE
OPPOSITION I'M I'M I'M TERRY Q.
WE GOT HERE AT THEIR AYE AYE YES
LET ME START WITH A LIFE
SCIENCES -- I THINK -- OR HER --
AMENDMENTS KIND OF CROSSED IN
THE MAIL -- AND TO I HAVE HERE
THE INSTRUCTION TO LET'S COUNSEL
TO MAKE THE AMENDMENTS THAT I
THINK -- RESOLVE ALL OF OUR
ISSUES WITH LIFE SCIENCES --
OKAY SO I SUBJECT -- TO ANOTHER
REVIEW.
I CONSIDER THAT IS SURE TO HAVE
BEEN TAKEN CARE OF NOW WITH
RESPECT TO THE PEST CONTROL
OPERATORS -- THEIR POSITION IS
AND HAS GENERALLY ALWAYS EEN --
WE WANT TO COME TO AGREEMENT
WITH YOU IF YOU'LL JUST TAKE OUR
LANGUAGE -- AND THAT'S KIND OF
WHERE THINGS ARE NOW NOW THE
MOST RECENT VERSION OF OF THEIR
LANGUAGE WHICH IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT BEFORE -- IS THAT
LEDGE COUNCIL MY UNDERSTANDING
IS LET'S COUNCIL HAS A BOATLOAD
OF QUESTIONS ABOUT AND THERE'S
CONCERN THAT -- WILL BE REQUIRED
TWO THIRDS VOTE IN ADDITION TO
THERE BEING.
QUESTIONS RAISED TO AND I CAN'T
BE MORE SPECIFIC ABOUT EXACTLY
WHAT THOSE QUESTIONS ARE BUT
WHAT IS BEING SUGGESTED TO UP BY
THE OPPOSITION.
IS -- A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO A TO THIS ISSUE THE
AND THEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SORT.
OF FRANKLY PRETTY FAR APART BUT
DEPENDING ON WHAT WE HEAR BACK
FROM LEDGE COUNCIL THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT CHANGE OUR OUR POSITION.
AND HAPPY TO HEAR THEM OUT
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT IT BUT
WE'RE PRETTY FAR APART.
MISTER IF I MAY COME. TO THE TO
THE POINT TO THAT MISTER BLOOM
MAKES ABOUT -- US BEING FIGHT AS
YOU IS FOR SIX HOURS OUR
LANGUAGE WE'VE HAD MANY
ITERATIONS.
SUBMITTED TO HIM TO HAVE BEEN
SENSITIVE TO THE CRITIQUES AND
CRITICISMS THAT HEY I'VE HEARD
BACK FROM HIM.
AND THE SPONSORS OF HIS BILL BUT
WE CAN'T GO THIS DIRECTION
BECAUSE WE NEED TO GET
DESTRUCTION SO.
I REJECT THAT.
WHOLE HEARTEDLY WE HAVE COME TO
THE TABLE AND I FEEL A LITTLE
BT LACKEY GETS SLOW RULED FROM
TIME TO TIME SO I JUST.
I HAVE WORKED ASSIDUOUSLY TO GET
LANGUAGE TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF
THAT WE COULD WORK ON AND I GET
A VERY SLOW RESPONSE TIME SO.
I REALLY REALLY AMONG SLIGHTLY
OFFENDED BY THE INSINUATION.
ACTUALLY.
I'M OFFENDED NOT EVEN SLIGHTLY.
YEAH I'M ACTUALLY YES IT HAS
IMAGES AFFECTED YEAH AND HE MAY
JUST BE DISAGREED.
ABOUT WHERE THE BILL IS AND
WE'RE OUT AGO.
AND THAT'S OFTEN WHAT HAPPENS IN
THESE CONSIDERATIONS OKAY CENTER
COVER YOUR SO MY MOM.
OKAY.
READ ALL THE PAPERWORK READ THE
BILL -- I AM.
THIS TODAY I GUESS ON SOME OF
THE SOMETIMES WHAT HAPPENS IS IN --
IN LOOKING AT AN ISSUE IS IS
THAT -- PEOPLE COME UP WITH TWO
DIFFERENT WAYS TO BE ABLE TO GET
TO THE SAME POINT.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
OUR POINT IS THE SAME.
SO -- SOME WILLING TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY IT MIGHT MY CONCERN IS
THAT I AM CONCERNED WITH.
THE URBAN WILDLIFE INTERFACE.
AND ON EIGHT AND AND I'M VERY
CONCERNED WITH THE DATA THAT YOU.
INDICATED ABOUT -- ABOUT
PREDATORS AND THEIR AND THEIR
MORTALITY DUE TO THESE KINDS OF
OF OF CHEMICALS AND SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE WHATEVER
WE'RE DOING IS THAT IT'S NOT.
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
HAPPENS AS LITTLE AS POSSIBLE --
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT IF
THERE IS ANOTHER SOLUTION THAT
WORKS.
AND THAT DOESN'T CREATE ALL THE
EXCEPTIONS IN THE EXCEPTIONS ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT WELL I'LL I'LL
I'LL TELL YOU WHEN YOU START
TALKING ABOUT FACILITIES THAT
HAVE TO HAVE A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
CLEANLINESS YOU JUST.
YOU CAN'T TAKE.
THE RAP FOOD SAFETY ISSUES THAT.
REQUIRE STERILITY IS REALLY WHAT
IT AMOUNTS TO SO I'LL BUY A I
WILL RELY ON THE BILL AS IT'S
WRITTEN TODAY BUT I WOULD URGE
YOU TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS TO
FIND OUT IF THERE'S A BETTER WAY
TO BE ABLE TO GET THERE.
SO THAT WE CAN TAKE CARE OF THE
URBAN PROBLEMS THAT MIGHT EXIST
AND HAVE MAKE SURE IT'S NOT
LEAKING OVER INTO THE INTO THE
INTERFACE AND KILLING OFF
ANIMALS AND WE DON'T WANT TO
KILL.
I AM PREPARED TO MOVE THE BILL
RIGHT NOW AND THEN WE'LL SEE
WITH THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE
WANTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YEAH I MEAN I HI.
I AM.
THIS COMMITTEE Q. I I UNDERSTAND --
YOU KNOW YOU CONTINUE TO WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THESE ISSUES I I
KNOW IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE STILL
FAR AWAY FROM STRIKING A DEAL
WITH -- THE FOLKS AT THE THE
DOMINIC REPRESENTS BY.
TEN YEAH I I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THIS CONTINUES TO BE ALONG A
WINDING ROAD YOU GO TO
PREPARATIONS NEXT TIME I HAVE
I'M SURE THEY'LL BE DISCUSSION
THERE AND ON THE FLOOR IN.
YEAH I THINK THE BROADER GOAL
THE YOU HAVE YEARS OF VITALLY
IMPORTANT I I REPRESENT PART OF
SEMI COMMANDS AS WELL JST AS
YOU.
WE'RE TRYING TO WE'RE TRYING TO
PREVENT MORE.
OF THESE NON LINE THAT'S UP
THERE AND SO I DO ENCOURAGE YOU
TO KEEP YOU TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION I I MEAN I I GUESS I
HI -- THERE SEEMS TO BE JUST A
REAL DISCONNECT IN TERMS OF THE
STATE OF YOUR NEGOTIATION -- YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT JUST BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENT
I YOU KNOW.
THE THOUGHT WHAT'S ALL COME OUT
AND SAY THAT AND THAT'S FINE --
YEAH BUT I'M I'M CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW CAN SUPPORT TODAY TOO AND
THE SUFFERING [inaudible]
I SO.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THOUGHTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE CLOSER SPONSORED ANY THAT.
YES -- WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON ON RESOLVING THIS BUT THE THE
MOST RECENT PROPOSAL IS IS A
VERY FROM THE OPPOSITION IS A
VERY -- MUCH DIFFERENT APPROACH
IT'S COMPLICATED INVOLVES
SETTING UP A FEE STRUCTURE MEAN
YOU HEARD IT FROM MISTER ACT
AMARI WHAT IT IS SO -- THERE'S A
LOT THERE AND THE NOTION THAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO SWITCH A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DEGREES -- ON
ON THIS BILL AT THE LAST MINUTE --
IF WE CAN GET THERE WE WILL I
THINK -- AND WE WE WORK TOGETHER
FOR A LONG TIME IN THIS BUILDING
AND I THINK EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT
I'M SOLUTION ORIENTED -- EVEN
WITH SOME OF THE MORE
CONTROVERSIAL -- BILLS THAT I'VE
THAT I'VE BROUGHT I UNDERSTAND
THE NEED TO NEGOTIATE AND TRY TO
BRING THINGS TO CONCLUSION BUT
THAT'S WHY WE'VE BEEN ABLE -- TO
REACH A POINT WITH THE AG
INDUSTRY WITH FOOD PROCESSORS
WITH BEER AND WINE -- WITH
HOSPITALS THAT THAT WERE
CONCERNED -- AT ONE POINT ABOUT
THE BILL.
WITH THE LIFE SCIENCES.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO ADDRESS ALL
OF THIS ISSUE -- ALL THESE
ISSUES IT'S NOT LIKE WE HAVEN'T
BEEN TRY OR WORKING ON IT WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO YEAH I CAN AND
I COULD ONLY IMAGINE.
THE MISTER TOMORROW WOULD
UNDERSTAND WHY.
HE WOULD ONCE AGAIN A NEW FEE
STRUCTURE AYE AYE.
MAYBE.
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS WHY YOU
WOULD WANT TO DO THAT OKAY SO --
WITH THAT THE THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED -- PICTURE PLEASE KALRA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR STERN
JONES.
JONES NOW ALLEN I ALLEN AYE
FORGES COVER EURO KABIRA AYE
HERTZBERG.
HUESO.
WE ARE ON SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THE LAST BILL.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
THOSE THAT BILLS ON CALL WITH
THREE VOTES.
OKAY WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
OTHER FOLKS TO ADELINE -- AND
OKAY WHEN WE LIVE CALLS ON OCT
WILL MEET ALL HAND MADE A HIM
BACK TO THE VICE CHAIR --
MEMBERS ORANGES ARE GONNA LET
THE CALL ON SOME OF THE BILLS I
DON'T THINK ALL OF THE BILLS --
WE'RE GONNA WAIT TO FOR THE
CHAIR TO GET BACK ON SOME OF
THEM -- WHY DON'T WE DO AS
CONSENT BEEN MOVED IN YES OPEN
SO WHY DON'T WE DO CONSENT FIRST
SO WE GET THAT OUT OF THE WAY --
IF THE SECRETARY CAN CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON CONSENT THIS
IS FOR THE CONSENT FILE.
THE KANSEN FILE CONSISTS OF FILE
ITEM ONE FILE ITEM THREE FILE
ITEM EIGHT IN FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
SIXTEEN SENATORS STERN.
THERE STERN I CAN SAY HI STERN
AYE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE GORGEOUS
HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON THE BILL
THAT'S BACKING CALLS OR PUT THAT
BACK ON CALL.
AND A MISTER CHAIR YOU WANT TO
GO BACK OVER THE ISSUE OKAY SO
MUCH APPRECIATE THE BRIEF MOMENT
I GOT TO BE IN CHARGE -- MORE
OFTEN.
SO WE JUST MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR YES AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE OPEN
ITEMS YES [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
ON WHAT.
OKAY THAT'S MORE THAN JUST YEAH
I UNDERSTAND.
SO WE WILL LIFT THE CLICK TO
CALL ON THE OPEN ITEM SO ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. TWO OH NINE
ALONE IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HANFORD IS TWO
ZERO CHAIR VOTING ICE CENTERS
JONES.
JONES AYE ALLEN AYE AYE ALLEN
AYE BUSH'S HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES BUT
WE'LL PUT IT BACK ON CALL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
VOTERS TO ZERO CHAIR VOTING ICE
SENATORS JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN I HAVE ALLEN I'D
FORGES CABALLERO CAREER AYE
HERTZBERG.
HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE.
THE BILL HAS SIX VOTE SO PUT IT
BACK ON CALL.
THIS ONE NEEDS IN MOTION.
OKAY SO WE NEED WE'RE LOOKING
FOR A MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB TWO NINE TO THE MODE IT WOULD
BE DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
ALL RIGHTS MOTIONS SENATOR
CAFIERO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CENTER STERN HI STERN AYE JONES.
JONES AYE ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE
FORGES CUT BIRO.
CARILLO AYE HERTZBERG WHO HUESO
[inaudible]
HUESO AYE.
JACKSON.
JACKSON I MONEY.
MONNING AYE HERTZBERG.
THIS IS YES AB TWO ARTS FOR HI.
THE BILL IS OUT WITH EIGHT VOTES
[inaudible]
SO.
OKAY OUR ON THE FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB THREE NINETY FOUR
OBERNOLTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
VOTERS FIVE ZERO CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING HIGH CENTERS BARGES
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON I BILLS OUT WITH A VOTE
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT -- NEXT AB
FELL FOR FIFTY FOUR DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN VOTERS -- THREE TO ONE
CHAIR I'D VICE CHAIR NO SENATORS
PORGES KIRBY HERO.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON.
NINE THE BILL IS OUT.
SIX TO ONE WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
OKAY -- WHAT WE ON AB FORTY NINE
NO THAT'S CONSENSUS SB?
SIX THIRTY EIGHT MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED.
VOTERS FOUR ZERO CENTERS STERN.
HI FORGES HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE WHO IS SO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON HI THE BILL IS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO OKAY -- ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB SIX FIFTY EIGHT ARAMBULA
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
VOTERS TO ZERO SENATOR I'D SHARE
IS AN ICE SENATORS JONES.
JONES I ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE FORGES HERTZBERG.
HI HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON I
MONEY.
MONEY ON IT BILLS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO OKAY.
NEXT I PART IS ITEM.
I'VE BEEN AB SEVEN NINETEEN
EIGHTY WE STILL THE AUTHOR HERE
ACTUALLY.
DO WE WANT TO IT -- JUST TAKE A
MOMENT AND ENGAGE I KNOW THERE
WERE SOME DISCUSSIONS OVER --
THE RECESS ABOUT -- POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS DO YOU WANT TO TAKE A
CHANCE TO JUST PRESENT AND WALK
THROUGH THOSE -- ANDERSON AROUND
MAY HAVE A COMMENT HERE -- ABOUT
SOME OF THE PROPOSALS I'M JUST
NOW LOOKING AT WHAT HAS BEEN
ARRIVED AT BUT ONE WAS TAKE A
BRIEF MOMENT.
AND WALKED THAT THROUGH FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO MINE COMING UP
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND YOU CAN WALK
THROUGH THAT WITH THE SOURCE I
DO NOT MIND MEMBERS WERE ON AB
SEVEN NINETEEN THAT'S RUBIO AND
GRAY.
HI THERE THERE IS NO MOTION AT
THIS POINT THERE WERE AMEND
WASN'T MOTION BY A SENATOR.
THERE ISN'T THERE SORRY.
BUT YOU DID NOT TAKE THAT MOTION
HE WANTED TO THAT WAS FOR A YEAR
AND A HALF OKAY EXTENSION IF YOU
STILL WANT TO ACCEPT THAT MOTION
WE CAN MOVE IT THAT WAY.
BASED ON THE CONVERSATION IF I
MAY I AM THERE WAS SOME
DISCUSSION AND WE CAME UP WITH
SOME PROPOSED AMENDMENTS BASED
ON A CONVERSATION WITH US
SENATOR ALLEN AND THE REST OF
THE COMMITTEE.
WE SUBMITTED -- TO THE
CONSULTANT AND SOUL I'M HERE TO
SEE IF THAT'S BECAUSE TAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT YOU WERE
INTERESTED IN THE DO WE HAVE. TO
TALK TO UP FOR THE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE I STILL HAVE NOT SEEN
WHATEVER LANGUAGE THAT IS A
DISSERVICE SCRIBBLE THAT PIECE
OF PAPER SCRIBBLED ON HOW THEY
WERE WHICH WELL THE RESPECTIVE
MY CONSULTANT HERE THIS IS STILL
MORE SCRIBBLE THOUGH -- BUT ALL
TO SEE THAT THE WAY THEY ARE
BECAUSE IT MAYBE YOU CAN WALK IT
THROUGH AN CONCEPT AND THEN WE
CAN SEE.
WHATEVER ACTUAL LANGUAGE.
WOULD BE HERE -- FOR ALL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M SORRY.
BUT I JUST WANT TO SEE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IS THAT WHAT AT
LEAST WE'RE WILLING TO ACCEPT IS
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT THEY PROPOSE.
I OKAY SO WHY DON'T WE GO
THROUGH THAT WHAT WHAT WHAT YOU
OR OTHERS ARE WILLING TO ACCEPT --
IS THAT WOULD SITTING IN MY
HANDS RIGHT NOW THAT'S WITH THE
FOR POSE WITH IN YOUR HANDS.
OKAY THE PROPOSAL FROM THE
AUTHOR FOR AN AMENDMENT IS BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY OR IS THAT ONE'S READING
ALONG.
I DON'T NEEDTO READ THIS
VERBATIM IF YOU CAN SEE IT --
MANUFACTURE PRODUCTS USING THE
HIDES OF ALLIGATORS AFTER
CONSULTATION SHALL SUBMIT TO
RESOURCES TECHNOLOGIES FOR
TRACKING TRACING ESSENTIALLY
DURING THAT PERIOD THE SUNSET
ALLOWING SALES WOULD BE EXTENDED --
ESSENTIALLY TILL TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SO WOULD BE A ONE YEAR
EXTENSION THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING
WHILE TRACK AND TRACE MESSAGE.
METHOD IS DEVELOPED.
GIVING THE SHOT CLOCK SIX MONTHS
TO APPROVE THAT TRACK AND TRACE
METHOD WITH SECRETARY RESOURCES --
AND THEN THAT.
THEIR MANUFACTURES THEN AFTER
TWELVE MONTHS.
AFTER THAT POINT FOR
IMPLEMENTATION -- WHERE THIS
SUNSET ON SALES -- WOULD STILL
BE.
SORRY THAT IT SHOULD BE READ
DURING WHICH TWELVE MONTHS THIS
SUNSET ON THE SALE OF PRODUCTS
WILL BE ALLOWED I THINK IT'S
THAT THE SALE OF PRODUCTS WILL
BE ALLOWED AS WHICH YOU ACTUALLY
MEANT THERE ISN'T THAT WHAT I
UNDERSTAND.
AND IN THE FINAL PIECES THAT THE
CURRENT BAND COULD BE AMENDED TO
ALLOW FOR THE CONTINUED USE.
OF PARKS OF ALLIGATORS FOR
MEDICAL RESEARCH AND
MANUFACTURERS' SPECIALIZE FOOD
PRODUCTS OR ALLIGATOR MEAT FOR
HUMAN CONSUMPTION TO BE
PERMANENTLY ALLOWED -- SO I'LL
JUST SPEAK.
ON ON MY BEHALF HERE MEMBERS ARE
WELCOME I THINK.
OUR COLLOQUY EARLIER CENTERED ON
THE FACT THAT I WASN'T
COMFORTABLE WITH ANY EXTENSION --
EVEN IF IT WAS CONDITION ON A ON
A TRACK ENTRY SYSTEM -- I WANTED
TO SEE THAT SYSTEM UP AND
RUNNING BEFORE LOOKING AT ANY
EXTENSION -- SAID I'M GONNA
STICK WITH THAT POSITION --
BECAUSE I I STILL -- WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO THE SUSTAINABLE
FARMERS OUT THERE AND THE FOLKS
IN THE INDUSTRY -- WHO MAY BE
DOING THE RIGHT THING?
I DON'T THINK WE CAN AFFORD TO
HAVE ANOTHER DAY OF ALLOWING THE
WRONG THING COMING IN AND TO ME
THAT'S THAT DEADLINES ACTUALLY
WHAT'S GOING TO GET IT'S RESULTS
BUT I DO RESPECT -- THE THE WORK
PUT INTO THIS -- BUT MEMBERS ARE
YOU.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO TO WEIGH IN
OTHERWISE -- A DIFFERENT OPINION
WELL AND I I WANT -- TO ASK
MISTER CRAVEN TO SORT OF LAY OUT
WHAT.
HE HAS MARKED UP I'M WE ACTUALLY
WERE ASKING FOR SOMETHING THAT'S
EARLIER THAN DECEMBER AND THE
REASON BEING.
I YOUR YOUR YOUR YOUR POINT IS
WELL TAKEN CENTER STERN.
RIGHT -- THE BECAUSE OF CRAVINGS
GOT ANYTHING MOCKED UP HERE BUT
YOU'RE WELCOME PUT FORWARD AN
AMENDMENT TO THIS AMENDMENT --
BUT I DON'T I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING BEFORE ME THAT SEEMS
LEGIBLE AS AN ALTERATION OF THIS
AMENDMENT WOULD YOU WANT TO
DESCRIBE DISTRICT YOU WANNA
DESCRIBE WHAT WHICH YOU HAVE
WHICH I UNDERSTANDING IS BILL
AND AND AND THEN I CAN KIND OF
TALK ABOUT -- WE TALK ABOUT
ASPECTS OF IT WILL.
BE IF IT'S YOUR AMENDMENT YOU
CAN DESCRIBE IT -- BECAUSE I
DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
THIS MEANS.
THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING HIM TO
DESCRIBE.
OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
WELL -- THIS IS NOT -- YEAH SO
IF YOU'RE DOING WORK FOR YOUR
MISTER OUT OF THREE YEAH BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S BETTER TO TO WORK
WITH PEOPLE NOTED ON YET.
NOBODY SEPTEMBER OF NEXT YEAR
[inaudible]
YEAH.
BY SEPTEMBER OF NEXT YEAR
MANUFACTURERS I'M JUST GONNA
SUMMARIZE THIS WORD -- PROVIDE A
PROPOSAL TO THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION.
THE LAST TRACKING IN TRACING --
OF ALL THE PRODUCTS SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA THE COMPLIES WITH.
INTERNATIONAL FEDERAL AND OTHER
ETHICAL FOR REASONS OF STATE LAW.
THAT ACCOUNTS.
FOR AWAY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
ENFORCE IT.
AND THAT INCLUDES CONSIDERATION
OF HUMANE FARMING AND SLAUGHTER --
THE SECRETARY.
IT MEANS THAT FISHING GAME
COMMISSION HAS SIX MONTHS TO
CONSIDER -- IN IT WOULD BE AT
THE END IF THEY APPROVE IT
WITHIN BE APPROVED BY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE -- THOSE
PROPOSALS OR I THAT WHATEVER
PROPOSAL IS APPROVED WOULD HAVE
TO MEET THE CRITERIA THAT WAS.
IN THE THAT I JUST DESCRIBED --
AND THEN THERE'S THE DIRECTOR
APPROVES -- THERE WOULD BE.
A IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD.
AND THEN THERE.
AFTER THAT IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD
THERE WOULD BE A SUNSET.
OF TWO YEARS. TO SEE HOW IT
WORKS.
SO IF I MAY TRY TO SUMMARIZE.
I MAY TRY TO SUMMARIZE.
YOUR PROPOSED AMENDMENT SENATOR
ALLEN -- BY YOU YOU LOOKING AT A
SEPTEMBER TWENTIETH DEADLINE AS
OPPOSED -- TO A DEADLINE AT THE
END OF THIS YEAR -- FOR AN
EXTENSION THAT WHILE -- IMPOSING
THAT SAME SIX MONTH EXTENSION AS
THE DEADLINE ON TRACK AND TRACE
BEING UP AND RUNNING SO AS
OPPOSED TO THE THE TWO YEAR
ORIGINALLY OFFERED OR THE YEAR
AND A HALF THEN I THINK WHICH
CENTER CABALLERO MADE A MOTION
ON THE SHOULD BE. SIX MONTHS FOR
THAT EXTENSION. FOR BOTH THE
TRACK ENTRY SYSTEM TO BE UP AND
RUNNING.
BUT DURING THE PENDENCY OF THAT.
THAT.
NEW SYSTEM -- TO CONTINUE TO
ALLOW THE IMPORTATION OF OF
ALLIGATORS AND PARKS THERE OF
THAT CORRECT.
YEAH THE IDEA OF DOING SIX
MONTHS AS OPPOSED TO GOING THE%
FULL YEAR OR FURTHER IS THAT USE
REALLY HOLDS.
THAT INDUSTRIES FEET TO THE FIRE --
ANYTHING THAT WOULD GO ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST -- BEYOND
WOULD ALLOW FOR A NEW BILL TO BE
PASSED WITH A MAJORITY VOTE.
ON IN THIS YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
FRUSTRATIONS I THINK YOU
PROPERLY ARTICULATE MISTER CHAIR
WAS AT THIS ISSUES COME BACK
OVER AND OVER AGAIN THE
LEGISLATURE HAS GRANTED
EXTENSIONS.
TO INDUSTRY OVER AND OVER AGAIN --
AND THEY KEEP MAKING PROMISES
ABOUT MEETING ALL OF THESE GREAT
STANDARDS ON THIS IS REALLY
GOING TO MAKE SURE -- AND IT IS
GOING TO IT INSTEAD OF HAVING
INDUSTRY BE THE ULTIMATE
APPROVER -- THE THE END IF PLACE
OF APPROVAL THAT WILL BE DONE BY
BY THE DEPARTMENT -- AND THEY'LL
THEY WILL TAKE A LONG HARD LOOK
AT THE PROPOSALS AND AND MAKE
SURE THAT ANY OF THE DAY --
WE'RE DOING RIGHT BY THE ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED BY YOUR
ANALYSIS ON PAGE.
EIGHT I THINK ANY OF THE DAY
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE COME
OUT OF THIS.
IS I AND I THINK.
PART OF THE BROADER PHILOSOPHY
THAT WE HAVE HERE WITH
AGGRESSIVE ON A POLICY -- IS THE
DATE WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
GIVEN THE SIZE AND SCOPE AND
STRENGTH OF OUR ECONOMY. TO
DRIVE GLOBAL BEHAVIOR ANDIF WE
CAN UP UNTIL NOW IT'S OUR SENSE
THAT THE THE THE THE TRACK AND
TRACE MODEL.
THAT IT IS IS INADEQUATE.
AND IF WE COULD CREATE A MODEL
THAT AT THE IAN THAT COULD
ACTUALLY HELP TO THE TO SHIFT
BEHAVIOR GLOBALLY.
AND THAT OTHER JURISDICTIONS
COULD ADOPT.
WE COULD ACTUALLY REALLY.
HELPED TO ADVANCE.
OUR BROADER SUSTAINABILITY GOALS --
BUT BY BY DOING IT BY BY PUTTING
THE DEADLINE IN SEPTEMBER RATHER
THAN FURTHER OUT -- A REALLY
HOLDS THE FEET TO THE FIRE OF
INDUSTRY IN IN A VERY
SUBSTANTIVE WAY LISTED.
SO JUST TO BE CLEAR MEMBERS AS
TO WHAT.
YOU WOULD BE VOTING ON IT FOR
MOTION IS MADE -- THE IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THIS MOCK UP YOU'RE
SAYING NOTHING IN SECTION FOUR
NOTHING IN SECTION [inaudible]
THREE SO.
YEAH BUT NOT FOR ME.
WITHIN THE SAME SET.
SO -- MENDING.
SECTION FOUR TO NOT SAY
PERMANENTLY ALLOWED BUT STILL
ALLOWING MEDICAL RESEARCH.
AS WELL AS MANUFACTURES
SPECIALIZED FOOD PRODUCTS.
OKAY SO WE'RE STRIKING YOU'D BE
STRIKING OUT AND MANUFACTURE
SPECIALIZE FOOD PRODUCTS.
YOU KNOW.
YEAH IF I CAN SIT HERE AND DO
THE THE MOCKING UP FOR YOU BUT I
NEED A MORE FULLY BIG PRODUCT
BEFORE.
WE WE GO FOR TO IF YOU WANT TO
MARKET UP OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE COMFORTABLE THAT'S FINE I
CAN'T.
I CAN'T DO THIS WORK FOR YOU
HERE SO -- IF YOU ALL WANT TO
SORT OF WORK THROUGH THAT.
OR IF MEMBERS FEEL COMFORTABLE
ENOUGH THAT MOTION THAT'S FINE I
I I I REALLY I I CANNOT SIT HERE
AND WORD SMITH FROM THE DíAS --
IF I DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE A MOCK
UP OF WHAT'S BEFORE ME SO I I'M
TRYING TO STRETCH HERE IN BE
ACCOMMODATING BUT YOU ARE
WELCOME. TO MAKE A MOTION ON
WHATEVER CONCEPT YOU JUST
ARTICULATED I JUST I CAN'T I
CAN'T BE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT AND
THAT AT THIS MOMENT.
BUT YOU ARE WHAT YOUR WELCOME DO
SO CENTER AND IF I CAN JUST
CLICK BUY IT SEEMS TO ME THAT IF
I CAN DIGEST WHAT I JUST HEARD
THEONLY THING SENATOR ALLEN
WANTS TO CHANGE ON THIS PIECE OF
PAPER THAT I READ FOR THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
IS IN THE FIRST LINE TO SAY
INSTEAD OF BY DECEMBER THIRTY
ONE TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY THEY
SAY DESERVE A SEPTEMBER OR NOT
QUITE RIGHT HE'S ALSO SAYING
ELIMINATING AND MANUFACTURES
SPECIALIZED FOOD PRODUCTS FOR
ALLIGATOR MEAT FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION IS PERMANENTLY
ALLOWED IN THESE CONDITIONING.
THE MEDICAL RESEARCH NOT AS A
PERMANENT ALLOWANCE BUT AS A TWO
YEAR EXTENSION NOT A NOT A
PERMANENT ALLOW IT TO CHANGE
YOUR PROPOSING THE CHANGE IN
PARAGRAPH ONE OF SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH.
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY CORRECT
AND THE SECOND IS YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT PUTTING A SUNSET.
ON PARAGRAPH FOUR IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE SUGGESTING.
SUNSET ON PARAGRAPH.
FOUR WHAT'S ON CITY TALKING
ABOUT IN PARAGRAPH [inaudible]
FOUR RESEARCH I KNOW SENSE AND
WHAT DATES ARE.
IF IF I THIS.
IF THE TRACK AND TRACE SYSTEM IS
APPROVED BY THE DEPARTMENT THEN
THAT WOULD EXTEND SO THAT ALL
YOU WANT TO SAY HERE'S THE
CURRENT BAND.
IS AMENDED TO ALLOW FOR
CONTINUOUS DEAL UP INTO SO YOU
WANT TO SAY TWO YEARS UP -- TO
TO JAN TO JANUARY TWENTY A
JANUARY TWENTY TWO INTO.
ONLY IN THE OF IN THE EVENT OF
WHAT.
THE DEPARTMENT APPROVING THE
TRACKING TRADE PLAN OLD AND AND
ALSO -- ETHICAL THERE'S A
THERE'S A THERE'S A PROVISION --
FOR FOR AT THE CALL.
HUMANE STANDARDS.
MAY FARMING AND SLIDE.
THE MAIN FARMING INSIDE.
WOULD GO CRAZY.
BUT EVEN WITH TRACKING TRADE YOU
WANT AND THEN WE GOT OUT OF ICE.
I GOT IT YEAH I KNOW IT'S TIGHT
I'M IT'S REALLY TIGHT AND I
THINK THAT'S YOU KNOW NOBODY'S
GONNA BE HAPPY WHEN W HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION COME UP AND HAVE YOU
ALL SEEN THIS THIS LANGUAGE.
NO I WAS SITTING IN NO YOU WANNA
COME COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
AND WE CAN JUST WE GET YOUR TAKE
ON ON WHAT.
YOUR POSITION WOULD BE JUST SO
WE CAN TO FURTHER CLARIFY --
CENTER ANNUAL WALK THEM THROUGH
YOUR PROPOSED AMENDMENT FOUR
MORE TIMES SO YOU CAN GET A
SENSE FROM.
OPPOSITION ABOUT THEIR TAKE ON
IT.
NO I UNDERSTAND THEY'VE BEEN
SPOKEN THE THEY THEY'VE THEY'VE
ALREADY.
TALKED TO FOLKS IN AYE AYE
ANDERSON THE STILL HAVE CONCERNS
I THINK THAT THE THE PROPONENTS
HAVE CONCERNS BUT THIS IS A THIS
IS REALLY TAKES THE DISCUSSION
THAT YOU HAD.
THE ISSUES LAID OUT ON PAGE.
EIGHT TIMES AND I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET THE FEEDBACK BEFORE YOU
SPEAK FOR THEM I WANT TO GET A
SENSE DIRECTLY FROM THE
OPPOSITION.
AS TO THEIR TAKE ON THIS SO.
WHAT HE'S PROPOSING FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING IS A SIX MONTH
EXTENSION OF THE SUN SAID WELL
TRACKING TREES PROGRAMS PUT IN
PLACE?
AND A TWO YEAR EXTENSION FOR
MEDICAL RESEARCH ONLY BUT NOT
SPECIALIZED FOODS -- WHAT WHAT
WOULD YOUR?
HE RECOGNIZING THAT YOU ACTUALLY
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING BEFORE YOU
HERE -- JUST WANT TO GET A QUICK
REACTION FOR THE FOR THE
RESTAURANT TERRACE OCCASION.
OKAY YEAH PLEASE CLARIFY AT
THREE O'CLOCK THIS AFTERNOON DID
RECEIVE FROM THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
OFFICE THE THE PROPOSAL FROM THE
BILL PROPONENTS I WAS ABLE TO
TRACK DOWN MY CLIENT AND VET
THAT PROPOSAL WITH THEM.
AND IT A NUMBER OF THE ELEMENTS
WERE DEEPLY PROBLEMATIC NOT THE
LEAST OF WHICH IS THAT IT WOULD
ALLOW SALES TO CONTINUE. FOR TWO
AND A HALF YEARS WITH THE LENGTH
OF THAT PROCESS THAT IT RESTED
THE SOUL THIS.
PROCESS FOR DETERMINING THIS
THROUGH A CONSULTATION WITH THE
SECRETARY WHICH DOESN'T FEEL
LIKE AN APPROPRIATE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATORY PROCESS FOR US.
AND LET'S SEE LOOKING FOR THE
REST OF MY COMMENTS -- THAT
EXEMPTING MEDICAL PET FOOD AND
HUMAN FOOD FROM ANY TRACEABILITY
PROGRAM WOULD BE PROBLEMATIC
INTERVIEW.
SO I AM ONLY RECEIVE LIKE A
TAXED VAGUELY DESCRIBING THIS
ALTERNATIVE PROPOSAL TO THIS AND
I JUST I APOLOGIZE BUT I DON'T
THINK THE DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
IS IN A POSITION. TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION BASED ON THAT
CONVERSATION THIS AFTERNOON.
BUT THAT'S JUST IF I THINK YES
YES -- SORRY THROUGH THE CHAIR
CENTER WAY SO IT'S OKAY.
PLEASE JUMP ON IN.
WITH TRACKING TRADE YOU ALSO
SUPPORT THE IF SET TRACKING
TRADE WAS PUT IN PLACE FOR A IN
THE AREA FOR FOOD AND MEDICAL.
USE HE WOULD STILL OPPOSE -- ARE
YOU WOODS ALSO SPORTS SO SO TO
BE CLEAR THE ORGANIZATION I WORK
WITH ARE I WORK ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE I BELIEVE
ALONG WITH OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATIONS
ENERGY SEE SIERRA CLUB DVD AND
OTHERS.
OUR PRIMARY CONCERN IS
ELIMINATING THE POSSIBILITY OF
CALIFORNIA CONTINUING TO BE
ALLOWED ALLOWING A LEGAL.
A LEGAL MARKET TO HAVE AN
ILLEGAL MARKET FLOURISH HERE AND
DURING MY PRIOR TESTIMONY I
IDENTIFIED ALL THE WAYS THAT
THAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
AND SO FOR US WE ARE INTERESTED
IN MY CLIENTS HAVE BEEN IN
DISCUSSION WITH THE PROPONENTS
WHO CHOSE TO CONTACT MY CLIENTS
DIRECTLY A COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND
DISCUSS IT WITH THEM.
IT'S INTERESTING TO THINK ABOUT
A TRACK ENTRY SYSTEM WE WERE THE
ONES THAT BROUGHT THAT
CONVERSATION UP.
BUT THE PROCESS BY WHICH THAT'S
DEVELOPED IT'S SUPER COMPLICATED --
WITH THE LAYERS OF STATE FEDERAL
AND INTERNATIONAL LAW AND I'M
SURE COMPLICATED FOR THE SUPPLY
CHAIN AND CHAIN OF CUSTODY
ISSUES TO IMPLEMENT ON THE
MANUFACTURING SIDE.
BUT IT WOULD MATTER TO US THAT
WE NOT KICKED THE CAN AND ALLOWS
SALES TO CONTINUE WHILE THAT IS
DEVELOPED AND IF THAT MEANS THAT
THIS INDUSTRY.
DOESN'T GET TO SELL FOR A FEW
MONTHS THAT'S THE KIND OF FIRE
THAT WE BELIEVE NEEDS TO BE SET
BECAUSE ALL THE RESPECT I'VE SAT
HERE THROUGH ALL THESE REPEATED
EXTENSIONS.
RAISING THESE ISSUES EVERY
SINGLE TIME AND I KNOW IT FEELS
LIKE AN EMERGENCY TODAY BUT
THAT'S BECAUSE THIS WAS NOT.
FOLLOWED THROUGHOUT ALL THESE
YEARS OUR CONCERNS WERE NEVER
TAKEN SERIOUSLY AND NOW WE ARE
HAVE EVIDENCE OF ILLEGAL
SHIPMENTS COMING.
IT'S A GREAT I'M AND GREAT
AMOUNTS THROUGH THE FROM LATIN
AMERICA INTO CALIFORNIA THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY.
AND THE IF THERE NEEDS TO BE A
HALT TO SALES -- TEMPORARILY TO
MOTIVATE TAKING THIS SERIOUSLY
WE'RE THERE TO WORK ON ON DOING
THAT IT'S IT'S NOT A
PHILOSOPHICAL DISAGREED A
CONCERN FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATIONS
PERSPECTIVE IT'S A PROTECTING
ENDANGERED AND IMPERILED SPECIES
ACROSS THE GLOBE WHICH YOU
CENTER HAVE ACTUALLY.
CHAMPION IN EVERY OTHER INSTANCE
I'VE SAT HERE AND ASK FOR THE
KINDS OF PROTECTIONS SO.
SHE THAT YOU DO KERRY YOU FOR
THE FEEDBACK I JUST TO JUST TO
CLARIFY IN SIMILAR -- OUTLOOK
FROM SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION -- SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT -- WERE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ANIMAL
WELFARE PERSPECTIVE.
AND WE'RE CONCERNED THAT A
TRACKING TRADE.
WOULD NOT DO ANYTHING FOR THAT
ASPECT OF THE DISCUSSION -- AND
SO WE WOULD STILL POSE AT THIS
POINT.
IF ANY OTHER KIND OF PROPOSAL
WOULD COME FORTH WITH UP TO LOOK
INTO IT UNDERSTOOD -- SO LET'S
JUST GET CLEAR CENTER ACCENTORS
ALLEN HERTZBERG YOU WANT TO WALK
THROUGH ONE MORE TIME FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHICH YOU
THINK YOU CAN DO IT OKAY.
THANK YOU CENTER.
NUMBER BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
HAVE THIS DOCUMENT PILED THE
NUMBER ONE THROUGH.
FOUR OKAY.
FOLLOW ME ALONG FILE A IN
PARAGRAPH NUMBER ONE THE DATE
DECEMBER THIRTY ONE TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY EIGHT CHANGES TO
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY THAT'S CHANGE NUMBER.
ONE CHANGE NUMBER TWO IS IN
PARAGRAPH -- FOUR GRAPH FOR SAYS
I'LL JUST READ IT THE CURRENT.
BAND IS AMENDED TO ALLOW RIGHT
IT LISTS WHAT IT'S ALLOWED.
FOR THAT IT'S HIS PERIOD THIS
[inaudible]
CONDITIONAL BUT THIS THIS --
PROVISION IS CONDITIONALLY
SUNSETS CONDITIONALLY SUNSET ON
JANUARY.
ONE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TO DATE
THIS SUNSET PROVISION DOES NOT
APPLY.
OKAY IN THE IF THE DEPARTMENT
APPROVES A TRACK AND TRACE
SYSTEM AS SET FORTH ABOVE.
AND CERTIFIES HUMANE SLAUGHTER
AND FARMING.
IT APPLIES IT'S OVER IF THEY
DON'T CERTIFY IF THEY CERTIFY
YOU MAIN.
OF LAW THERE IS NO SUNSET.
THAT'S THE THAT I THINK CAPTURES
WOULD SENATOR ALAN.
HAS ARTICULATED.
THOSE TWO CHANGES.
AND THEN ON NUMBER THREE IS THAT
ALLOWS A TWELVE MONTH SUNSET.
EXTENSION WHICH SEEMS TO
CONFLICT WITH BY THE DEPARTMENT.
SO THE MANUFACTURERS WILL HAVE
TWELVE MONTHS FROM THE DATE OF
APPROVAL TECHNOLOGIES ARE
PROCESSES BY APPROVED BY THE
SECRETARY FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
DURING WHICH TWELVE MONTHS THE
SUNSET ON THE SALE OF PRODUCTS
WILL BE ALLOWED SO DOES THAT
TWELVE MONTHS EXTEND BEYOND
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY IS THAT ANOTHER YEAR.
OF KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
IS NUMBER TWENTY AT THE MAJOR
SUNSET HAPPENS IN THE MEANTIME --
THIRTIETH RESORT WHICH IS ME
EVERYONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE RIGHT
WE'RE NOW GENUINE.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IN THIS WINDOW
OF TWELVE MONTHS ACTUALLY
HARMONIZES BECAUSE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS MORE TIME TO
DETERMINE.
IF THE DEPARTMENT DETERMINES
IT'S NO HUMANE THAN THAN
EVERYTHING SUNSETS I THINK WE
HAVE TO GET SOME CLARITY BECAUSE
YOU JUST SAID JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUT THE SEPTEMBER.
RENT YOU KNOW THE WORDS THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT UNDER AS IT
RELATES TO PARAGRAPH. FOUR FOR
PURPOSES OF PARAGRAPH FOR BUT
YOU THE STRIKING OUT THE FINAL
LINE IN PARAGRAPH.
ONE DURING THIS PERIOD THE
SUNSET ALLOWING SLES IS
EXTENDED IF NO PROPOSES ARE
SUBMITTED HIS SUNSET AND SALE OF
PRODUCTS.
OKAY [inaudible]
THAT'S FINE.
YEAH THAT'S THAT'S A FAIR
ARTICULATION SO -- THIS THERE IT
IS YES SENATOR MONNING
[inaudible]
OUR SO WITH THAT DESCRIPTION --
WOULD YOU.
YEAH.
ARE YOU WILLING TO ACCEPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS YES AND SO THAT'S A
YES OKAY SO -- I'M NOT SAYING I
WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION BUT IF
ONE IS MADE THAT IS YOUR YOUR
RIGHT TO DO SO SO -- IS THAT A
MOTION.
OKAY SO SO MOVE FROM SENATOR
ALLEN TO IT ADOPTING COMMITTEE
THE AMENDMENTS -- AS DESCRIBED
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG -- SO THEM
THE MOTION WOULDBE.
DO PASS -- TO A AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR STERN NO.
NO JONES.
JONES HI ALAN.
ALLEN AYE BURGESS CABALLERO.
KABIRA AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HI HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON.
MONNING.
MONEY NOW.
THAT HAS -- FIVE WERE JONES AND
THE WE WILL LEAVE THAT MEASURE
ON CALL.
AND AS FAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE DOING ALL THE WORK --
OKAY THANK.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO GIVE THAT TO
THE COMMITTEE TO SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY TRY.
TO WRITE MEMORIALIZE THAT SINCE
THE COMMITTEE WILL BE WRITING IN
FACT -- THANK YOU.
OKAY MOVING.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
THIRTEEN WHICH IS.
A SIMILAR MALL AND WE DO NEED A
MOTION ON AB -- TWENTY FIVE THEM
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SORRY WE'RE ON FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
MULLIN MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CENTERS STERN HI
STERN AYE JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN.
ELLEN HI FORGES CABALLERO
CARILLO AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY
MONEY HI OKAY WE WILL LEAVE THAT
ON CALLS FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS --
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN THIS IS
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY SIX O'DONNELL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTERS TO
ZERO CHAIR VOTING ICE SENATORS
JONES.
O'DONNELL YES -- JONES I ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE FORGES.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY IN MONEY
AND I THE HAS A VERY GOOD WE
WILL LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT UP EIGHTY NINE THIRTY THREE
WHICH IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS KAREN
VOTERS TO ZERO CHAIR VOTING ICE
SENATORS JONES.
JONES NO ALAN.
ALLEN AYE FORGES HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONNING.
MONEY NINE THAT HAS SIX ROOMS WE
SHOULD LEAVE IT OPEN FOR HER
OKAY WE'LL LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON
CALL -- GIPSON IS ON CONSENT
WE'VE ALREADY MOVED THAT CONSENT
CALENDAR CORRECT WELL WE CAN
MOVE IT AGAIN.
OKAY WHEN WE TAKE OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR VERY BRIEFLY -- WE DO
HAVE SOME ABSENT MEMBERS PASSES
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HERE FILE
ITEMS ONE THREE EIGHT AND
SIXTEEN CENTERS PURCHASE
HERTZBERG BOB HERTZBERG I'D
JACKSON.
OKAY WE'LL LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBER ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN MEMBERS AB TEN
FIFTY SEVEN LOW MOAN.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTERS
FORTY ONE CHAIR VOTING NINE VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO FORGES HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG I'D JACKSON MONNING
MONEY HI.
SIR JACKSON WILL LET YOU GET UP
TO SPEED HERE FOR A SECOND WILL
RUN BACK THROUGH IT ALSO WE KNOW
YOU'RE COMPETING CHAIR AWESOME
ALL OF THEM ALL.
YEAH -- WE WILL GET BACK TO WORK.
YEAH WE WILL OKAY SO HE NEEDS AN
OPTION BUT WE ARE NOW ON FILE
ITEM EIGHTEEN IN THE SENATE
JACKSON WILL COME BACK AROUND.
TO WHERE WE STARTED BUT WE DO
NEED A MOTION ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN THAT'S AB TWELVE FIFTY
FOUR COM LONGER DOVE IN THE
MOTION WOULD BE DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THERE'S A MOTION FOR CENTER
HUESO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CENTER STERN HI TONIGHT JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BURGESS CABALLERO.
CABALLERO NO HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON I
MONEY IN.
MONEY AND I THAT HAS OKAY --
FIVE VOTES THAT IS OUT WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT --
NINETEEN SOME MEMBER GIPSON AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE DO WE NEED A
MOTION STILL THERE NOW -- WE WE
DO HAVE A MOTION THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE CHAIRMAN.
CURRENT VOTE THREE ZERO CHAIR
VOTED I SENATORS JONES.
JONES NOW FORGES HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO.
HI SO I'D JACKSON JACKSON AYE
MONNING.
MONNING HI.
IT HAS. THREE FIVE SEVEN OKAY
LIVES OUT HERE WOULD THAT THAT
MEANS THAT MEASURES OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB
FOURTEEN FORTY LEVINE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
VOTERS TO TO ZERO CENTERS STERN
HI STERN HI JONES.
FILE IN TWENTY AB FOURTEEN FORTY
LEVINE.
A JONES SINCE NO FORGES
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO.
QUIZ SO I JACKSON JACKSON AYE
MONEY.
MONEY I IN THE BILLS OUT OKAY
THAT BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB FIFTEEN
ELEVEN BLOOM DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS IS THE MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE UPS MEMBERS
CURRENT VOTERS TO ZERO CHAIR
VOTING I'D SENATORS JONES.
JONES I ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BARGES HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE
MONEY.
MONEY HI THE BILL'S OUT EVEN IF
IT WAS OUT FIVE AND TWENTY TWO
A. B. SIXTEEN EIGHTY LOW MOAN.
THE MAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTERS TO ZERO CHAIR
VOTING ICE SENATORS JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN.
ALLEN I'D PORGES HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO [inaudible]
SENATOR HUESO.
YOU'RE SO CLOSE TO VOTING ON
THIS SOMEONE TO GRAB HIM
[inaudible]
JACKSON.
THIS IS MINE MONEY.
MONEY NINE HUESO HUESO AYE RE SO
WHY THANK YOU -- FILA DE BILLS
OUT FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE A. B.
SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR O'DONNELL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO PROBE
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTERS TO ZERO CHAIR
VOTING ICE SENATORS JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN.
ALLEN HI BRIDGES HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE
MONNING.
MONNING HI THE BILL'S AWESOME
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT I'M SORRY
LOST TRACK HERE ARE WE ON BOARD
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY FOUR AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN LEVINE MOTIONS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS VOTERS TO ZERO
SENATORS STERN HI STERN I'D
JONES.
JONES NO FORGES HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG I TWENTY FOUR FILE IN
TWENTY FOUR AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN LEVINE.
HUESO.
I HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE
MONNING.
MONEY I BILLS OUT OKAY THEIR
BILL IS OUT NOW WE ARE ON THE
PHONE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE BORDER ****
BATH MOTIONS TO PASS. TO THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTERS TO ZEROS -- CHAIR
VOTING HIGH SENATORS JONES JONES
NO FORGES CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MONNING.
MONEY AND I AS FIVE ITSELF SO
[inaudible]
FIVE SO I THAT BILL IS OUT --
OKAY -- FINAL ITEM -- FOR
EVERYONE BUT CENTER JACKSON HERE
IS.
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THAT IS
BLOOM AND THE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
VOTERS -- THREE TO ONE CENTERS
STERN STERN HI.
BRIDGES HERTZBERG HERTZBERG BY
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MONNING MONNING HI
OKAY THAT MEASURE IS OUT --
BEFORE THOUGH THEM YEAH WE ARE
GOING TO ROLL BACK THROUGH THE
FIRST FOR THOSE MEMBERS ABOUT TO
LEAVE THOUGH I DO WANT TO JUST
TAKE A MOMENT IS OUR LAST
REGULAR HEARING.
SO I WANT TO THANK PATTY THE
AMAZING MANY SECRETARY.
TRYING TO KEEP US IN MIND.
MY EFFORTS AND ALSO TO SYDNEY
ARE INCREDIBLE SCIENCE FELLOW
WHO MOVED FROM.
BLACK HOLES IN GRAVITATIONAL
WAVES SOMEHOW INTO A CLIMATE
CHANGE RESILIENCE AND IS DONE A
REMARKABLE JOB SO THANK YOU CITY
FOR ALL YOUR WORK IN THIS --
AMAZING AND CRAZY CAPITAL WILL
WORK AND AND WITH THAT LET'S
LET'S ROLL BACK THROUGH THE TOP
OF THE ORDER ONE MORE TIME HERE --
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR --
SO ONE MORE TIME ON CONSENT --
FILE ITEMS ONE THREE EIGHT AND
SIXTEEN CENTERS.
JACKSON.
THIS IS ON CONSENT NOW OF FILE
ITEM YEAH.
ONE THREE EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN OKAY
SO OKAY THAT CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT NOW WILL RULE FROM THE TOP
HERE SO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO IS
LOW MOAN THAT'S AB TWO OH NINE
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CENTERS HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE MONNING MONEY --
IN THE BILL'S OUT EIGHT OKAY
VERY GOOD THE BILL IS OUT FILE
ITEM NUMBER -- FOUR THAT'S AB
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT MCCARTY THAT
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO A
PROBES SENATORS RIGHT.
IT'S VERY HIGH LEVELS OUT OKAY
THAT MEASURES OUT -- NUMBER AND
IF I DON'T FIVE AB TWO NINE TWO
WERE ALREADY OUT SORRY.
BUT ON FIVE DO WE GET ALL
MEMBERS VOTED.
ON FILE ITEM FIVE YES.
YES OKAY YEAH WE GOT JACKSON
OKAY GOOD SORRY FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX THAN EVERYONE'S VOTED ON
THAT MEASURES HERE.
FILE ITEM SIX NOW AB.
THREE NINETY FOUR IT'S OUR IT'S
ALL OUT YEAH HOW.
HI THIS IS THE IT'S OKAY
[inaudible]
READING OF NOT SURE THAT WE
CLOSE ANYTHING GIVE ME ONE MORE
TIME CENTERS [inaudible] FOR
SEVEN SO OF A FILE ITEM NUMBER --
ELEVEN THAT IS AB SEVEN NINETEEN
RUBIO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED -- TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATE JACKSON.
SO THE CHAIR VOTING NO -- AND
THE CURRENT HOMETOWN IS.
FIVE TO TWO JACKSON.
JACKSON THOUGH.
SO THAT IS FIVE TWO THREE ON
THAT MEASURE IS OUT -- IN
THIRTEEN WAS COULD MOVE FARTHER
THIRTEEN IT AB EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
MULLIN MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
VOTED SIX TO ONE CENTER JACKSON
JACKSON HIGH LEVELS OUT SAYS.
THE ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY SIX O'DONNELL.
VOTERS SEVEN ZERO CENTER JACKSON
JACKSON I WAS A VERY GOOD THE
BILL IS OUT.
NOW ON FILE IN FIFTEEN EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY THREE DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS VOTE
IS SIX TWO ONE CENTER JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE THOSE THAT MEASURE
IS ABOUT.
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB TEN FIFTY
SEVEN LOW MOAN -- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS VOTED
SIX TO ONE SENATOR JACKSON'S
[inaudible]
THANKS. SEVEN OH AND IT'S OKAY
VERY GOOD AND THEN ON EIGHTEEN
WE'RE GOOD IF EVERYBODY EVERYONE
ELSE IS GOOD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION DELIBERATION WITH
THAT WE ARE JR [inaudible]
YOU